ALL RIGHT. WE'LL GET STARTED.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE. WELCOME
BACK. WELCOME BACK, FORTUNATE WE
COULDN'T FINISH LAST THURSDAY,
SO IT'S GOING TO BE A LITTLE
DIFFERENT TODAY. WE'RE GOING TO
FINISH WHERE WE LEFT OFF LAST
THURSDAY. SO IT'S BASICALLY
SOCIAL DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. BUT IN THE MIX OF IT
BRINGING BACK SOME TOPICS WE DID
TALK ABOUT THURSDAY. JUST SOME
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS THAT YOU'LL
SEE ON THE AGENDA. WE'LL GO
THROUGH DSS AND THEN WE'LL SWING
BACK TO HEALTH AND DIVE DEEPER
INTO SOME TOPICS THAT WE WANT
FURTHER INFORMATION ON THAT WE
STARTED TALKING ABOUT ON
THURSDAY. SO THAT'S THE PLAN.
WE'RE HERE UNTIL IF WE NEED IT
UNTIL ONE, AND THAT'S HOW WE'LL,
HOW WE'LL DO IT. WE'LL STICK TO
WHAT I SAID LAST WEEK IN TERMS
OF PUBLIC COMMENT. ONE BIG
TOPIC. WE'LL DO PUBLIC COMMENT
AND MOVE FORWARD LIKE THAT. SO
WE'LL START WITH CHILD CARE.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR, PLEASE JOIN US
UP HERE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
JACKIE, WELCOME BACK
.
AND FOR THIS, YOU KNOW, WE
STARTED TALKING ABOUT, THE
UNSPENT DOLLARS. THE NUMBER WAS
19 MILLION. I'D ALSO LIKE, YOU
KNOW, WE, AS A QUESTION SHOWS
THE 70 MILLION AS WELL. WE FOCUS
ON THOSE TWO POINTS MORE THAN
ANYTHING. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. JENNIFER TROIA,
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
I'M DIVING STRAIGHT INTO THOSE
QUESTIONS ON CHILD CARE TO GO
BACK TO THAT SUBJECT, THE FIRST
QUESTION THAT YOU ASKED WAS
ABOUT THAT 19 MILLION AND
PROJECTED FEDERAL ARPA FUNDS.
I'LL KICK US OFF AND THEN ASK MY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE COLLEAGUES
TO ADD ON IF THEY'D LIKE TO,
ARPA DISCRETIONARY FUNDS WERE
ELIGIBLE FOR USES TO SUPPORT
SUBSIDIES OR SLOTS, BUT ALSO FOR
OTHER PURPOSES LIKE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT RATES, EXPANDING THE
SUPPLY OF CHILD CARE. THAT SAID,
THE FUNDS HAD TO BE OBLIGATED
FOR A SPECIFIC PURPOSE BY
SEPTEMBER 30TH, 2023. WE AS A
STATE DID OBLIGATE ALL OF THE
FUNDING, AND WE DID SO BY THE
DEADLINE. THE $19 MILLION THAT
WE ARE ESTIMATING MAY REVERT TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS
OBLIGATED TO SUPPORT SLOTS AND
THEREFORE CAN ONLY BE USED FOR
THAT PURPOSE. MORE SPECIFICALLY,
THE FUNDS ARE STILL OBLIGATED.
THEY ARE IN CONTRACT ACTIVELY
WITH GENERAL CHILD CARE AND
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAMS.
WHAT WE SHARED WITH YOU ABOUT
THE 19 MILLION IS BASED ON OUR
MOST RECENT ASSESSMENT OF WHAT
WE EXPECT THEM TO EXPEND OUT OF
THOSE CONTRACTS, AND THAT IS A
99% UTILIZATION RATE OF ALL OF
THE FUNDING LEAVING THIS 19
MILLION. IT'S A POINT IN TIME
ESTIMATE IF THE CONTRACTORS ARE
ABLE TO UTILIZE ALL OF THE
FUNDING, WE WOULD NOT REVERT ANY
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. IT'S
OUR BEST ESTIMATE AT THIS POINT
IN TIME OF WHAT THEY'RE NOT
LIKELY TO UTILIZE BECAUSE OF THE
TIME IT'S BEEN TAKING FOR THEM
TO RAMP UP IMPLEMENTATION. BUT
THE MONEY IS ACTIVELY IN
CONTRACT, AND THAT'S WHY WE ARE
UNABLE TO ALTER THE INTENDED
USES. SO I HOPE THAT PROVIDES A
LITTLE BIT MORE CLARITY. I DON'T
KNOW IF OTHERS WANT TO ADD, BUT.
TAMAR WEBER, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, I THINK THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR EXPLAINED IT PRETTY
WELL, BUT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. DEPUTY DIRECTOR.
OKAY, SO THE 90 MILLION WELL,
JUST THE BIGGER NUMBER WAS
ALLOCATED TO CONTRACTS FOR
EXPANSION OF SLOTS. THIS IS AN
ANTICIPATED UNSPENT DOLLARS OF
THE FUNDING THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
PROVIDED TO THE VENDORS,
PROVIDERS THAT POTENTIALLY WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO BE SPENT BY BY
WHAT TIME THE END OF SEPTEMBER
THIS YEAR. BECAUSE OF THE
PROCESS TO GETTING SLOTS OUT TO
THE CONSUMER AND SO FORTH.
CORRECT. IN SOME INSTANCES. SO I
WOULD SAY ON THE VOUCHER SIDE,
THE CONTRACTORS THAT WE HAVE
NEED TO HAVE ENOUGH STAFF TO
PROCESS THE ELIGIBILITY. THE
FAMILIES NEED TO IDENTIFY A
PROVIDER AND GET THAT DONE IN
TIME. ON THE CONTRACT SIDE,
WHERE WE DIRECT CONTRACT WITH
CENTERS, THEY NEED TO HAVE
ENOUGH STAFF AND FACILITIES. AND
SO AS WE HAVE BEEN RAMPING UP,
WE HAVE BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL, AS
WE TALKED ABOUT THURSDAY, IN
EXPANDING, BUT NOT AS QUICKLY AS
WE WOULD HAVE LIKED BECAUSE OF
THOSE LOGISTICAL ISSUES ON THE
GROUND OF ACTUALLY GETTING THE
EXPANSION. WOULD THIS THEN POSE
AN ADDITIONAL NUMBER TO THE
12,000 SLOTS THAT ARE ON THE
TABLE, POTENTIALLY BE CLAWED
BACK IN ADDITIONAL OF THIS
AMOUNT THAT THIS IS, I DON'T
KNOW HOW TO THINK ABOUT THIS IN
TERMS OF THE SLOTS. DO YOU WANT
TO. YEAH. SO THIS IS 19 MILLION
THAT'S IN CONTRACTS FOR CURRENT
SERVICE LEVEL SLOTS. YES. SO
IT'S, COMPLETELY INDEPENDENT OF
ANY NEW SLOTS THAT WOULD BE
ADDED IN 24, 25 ON THE APP SIDE.
SO ON THE VOUCHER SIDE, THEY
HAVE TWO YEARS TO EXPEND THE
FUNDING THAT WE HAVE PROVIDED TO
THEM. IT'S A TWO YEAR CONTRACT.
PART OF THE REASON IT'S
COMPLICATED TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION IS THAT SOME OF WHAT WE
DO IS SHIFT THE FUNDING AROUND.
SO IT'S NOT SO MUCH A SLOT ISSUE
IN THE SENSE THAT IF THEY
ULTIMATELY END UP UTILIZING THE
SLOTS THAT ARE THERE NOW, WE
MIGHT BE USING A DIFFERENT COLOR
OF MONEY. THE QUESTION IS, IF WE
RUN OUT OF TIME BEFORE THIS
COLOR OF MONEY EXPIRES ON THE
GENERAL CHILD CARE SIDE, IT'S A
ONE YEAR CONTRACT, RIGHT? OKAY.
I THINK I UNDERSTAND THAT PART,
BUT I THINK I'M GOING TO GO BACK
TO THE QUESTION I JUST ASKED IF
THE 19 MILLION WAS ALREADY
ALLOCATED, HOWEVER, WAS
ALLOCATED FOR THE DIFFERENT
VENDORS AND THEY CAN'T MEET
THAT. DOESN'T THAT POTENTIALLY
ALSO DECREASE THE NUMBER OF
SLOTS THAT THEY THOUGHT THEY
WERE GOING TO HAVE? WE HAVE
ALREADY ACCOUNTED FOR THE
FUNDING THAT WE EXPECT TO GO
UNEXPENDED IN SLOTS ELSEWHERE.
THIS IS FUNDING THAT WE I THINK
WE'VE ALREADY ACCOUNTED THEN FOR
THAT IN THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
SLOTS AS WELL. IS THAT AS WELL?
YEAH. OKAY SO 12,000 POTENTIALLY
CAN INCLUDE THE UNSPENT 12,000
NOT THE UNSPENT THE 12,000. WE
CAN'T. WE'RE PROPOSING UP
FURTHER PROVIDING RESOURCES. AND
THEN THIS ONE, THE 19 MILLION
THAT IS ONLY ALLOCATED FOR
SLOTS, THE SLOTS THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT IN TERMS OF WHAT WE
ANTICIPATE NOT BEING ABLE TO
FUND THAT WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE
GONE NEWLY INTO CONTRACT. OKAY.
WAS IT'S DIFFERENT FUND SOURCE.
YES IT IS. BUT THEY ALL FUND FOR
SLOTS. THEY ARE ALL FUNDING FOR
SLOTS. THAT IS A DIFFERENT FUND
SOURCE OKAY JACKIE, DO YOU HAVE
ANY ANYTHING ON THIS? JACKIE
BAROCIO LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
OFFICE, WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
TRYING TO SCHEDULE A MEETING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES BEHIND WHY
THESE FUNDS WOULD GO AND
EXPENDED. AS YOUR AGENDA NOTED
LAST YEAR, WE WERE IN A SIMILAR
POSITION WHERE, THROUGH THE OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT, HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS OF FEDERAL FUNDS WERE
PROJECTED TO GO UNSPENT,
POTENTIALLY SOME OF THOSE WERE
ALSO IN CONTRACT. I THINK THE
WAY THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OBLIGATED THOSE DOLLARS, AS THE
DEPARTMENT EXPRESSED, IS RATHER
THAN PAY QUARTERLY PAYMENTS OR
MONTHLY PAYMENTS, HOWEVER, THOSE
PAYMENTS ARE MADE WITH A GENERAL
FUND DOLLAR. MAXIMIZE THOSE
PAYMENTS WITH AN ARPA FEDERAL
DOLLAR. SO MAKE THOSE PAYMENTS
100% UNTIL YOU SPEND ON THE
FEDERAL FUNDS. THEN YOU'LL DIP
INTO THE GENERAL FUND, THE
DEPARTMENT IS ALREADY PROJECTING
WITHIN THE BUDGET THAT THEY WILL
DO SOME FUND SHIFTS WITH $97
MILLION ARPA DISCRETIONARY. I
THINK SOME OF THE QUESTIONS WE
HAVE IS, ARE THOSE DOLLARS IN
CONTRACT AND ARE WE SHIFTING
THOSE DOLLARS, OR WERE THEY
NEVER PUT INTO CONTRACT? WHAT IS
THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN OUR
ABILITY TO SPEND THAT MONEY
BEFORE SEPTEMBER 2024 VERSUS
THIS 19 MILLION, OR IS THE ISSUE
WORKLOAD, ADMINISTRATIVE
CAPACITY? OKAY, I KNOW YOU'RE
LOOKING TO SCHEDULE THAT
MEETING. IS THERE ANYTHING YOU
CAN SHARE REGARDING WHICH KIND
OF FUNDS WE'RE WE'RE
REAPPROPRIATING OR SHIFTING
AROUND ONES THAT HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY ONCE THAT ARE ABOUT
TO END, WE DO PERIODICALLY
ASSESS CONTRACTOR SPENDING
LEVELS AND IDENTIFY ANY
ADJUSTMENTS TO PROJECTED
EXPENDITURES ON THAT SORT OF
FIRST IN, FIRST OUT BASIS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE DOLLARS THAT
EXPIRE THE SOONEST ARE EXPENDED.
FIRST, WE, AS JACKIE NOTED, ARE
PLANNING TO DO THAT SIMILAR KIND
OF REDISTRIBUTION IN AUGUST. BUT
WE'RE PROJECTING THAT EVEN AFTER
WE DO THAT REDISTRIBUTION, THIS
IS THE AMOUNT THAT MAY BE LEFT.
AGAIN, THE CONTRACTORS COULD
EXPEND IT, BUT THIS IS WHAT OUR
PROJECTIONS NOW BASED ON THE
TRENDS NOW SHOW, WOULD BE
REMAINING EVEN AFTER THAT SHIFT
AND DO CONTRACTS. NO THAT THAT
MONEY COULD POTENTIALLY BE
PULLED BACK. THEY KNOW THAT THIS
FUNDING HAS THIS TIMELINE. YES
OKAY. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. LET'S
MOVE ON TO THE SECOND QUESTION,
PLEASE. THE NEXT QUESTION WAS
ABOUT, PREVIOUSLY AWARDED CDF
FUNDS. SO NOT THE ONE TIME
RELIEF FUNDING, BUT THE REGULAR
CDF FUNDS. AND I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY, I THINK THERE MAY HAVE
BEEN CONFUSION. WE ARE NOT
PROJECTING ANY REGULAR CDF FUNDS
WILL GO UNSPENT. OKAY. THAT'S A
THREE YEAR WINDOW FOR UTILIZING
THE FUNDS. WE HAVE PLENTY OF
TIME TO IDENTIFY THE ELIGIBLE
USES AND TO UTILIZE THEM FULLY.
SO OKAY, WHEN ONCE THE DEADLINE
FOR THE UTILIZATION OF THESE
FUNDS, WE HAVE A THREE YEAR PLAN
PERIOD FOR OUR CDF STATE PLAN.
OUR NEW PLAN IS COMING NOW. DO
YOU REMEMBER HOW LONG WE HAVE TO
LIQUIDATE THE EXISTING FUNDS, AT
A HIGH LEVEL. I'M SORRY,
SENATOR, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
AT A HIGH LEVEL, THE REGULAR CDF
AWARD IS ON A THREE YEAR ROLLING
BASIS. DON'T HAVE THE EXACT DATE
, BUT HAPPY TO GET BACK TO YOU.
HOW MUCH? SO WE HAVE AVAILABLE
FUNDS RIGHT THERE. CAN YOU
EXPLAIN TO ME WHY THEN WE CAN'T
USE THIS FOR THE SLOT TO THE
BRIDGE. WHAT IS IT CALLED? THE
EMERGENCY BRIDGE PROGRAM. OUR
CDF PLAN HAPPENS ON A THREE YEAR
PERIOD. WE HAVE ALL OF THE FUNDS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN THE CDF
PLAN ALLOCATED. WE HAVE THEM
IDENTIFIED FOR ELIGIBLE USES,
WHICH DO INCLUDE SLOTS. GOT IT.
OKAY. SO THAT'S. AND WHEN'S THE
THIRD YEAR END. WHEN IS THE
THIRD YEAR? ARE WE IN THE FIRST
YEAR SECOND WE'RE IN THE THIRD
YEAR. BUT I DON'T REMEMBER WHAT
THE TIMELINE IS EXACTLY IN TERMS
OF THE CLOSEOUT OF THE
EXPENDITURES. OUR NEW PLAN IS
DUE JULY 1ST. THIS SUMMER. OKAY
OKAY. AND AS WE ENTER INTO THIS
LAST YEAR OF THIS THREE YEAR
PLAN, THE ENTIRE ALLOCATION
WITHIN THIS FUND HAS IS
ACCOUNTED FOR. WILL ALL BE SPENT
BEFORE WE SUBMIT, NOT BEFORE,
BUT, AND THEN WE'LL SUBMIT THE
NEW PLAN FOR THE THREE YEAR. WE
DON'T EXPECT TO HAVE ANYTHING
LEFT. UNEXPENDED. I THINK WHAT
PERHAPS WAS REFERENCED ON
THURSDAY, WAS THAT PART IN
SIMILAR VEIN TO WHAT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT EARLIER? THERE IS
SOME DEGREE TO WHICH WE CAN SORT
OF SHIFT THINGS, AND WHEN WE
SHIFT THEM, SOMETIMES WE'RE ABLE
TO IDENTIFY SAVINGS. THIS
FUNDING IS INTENDED TO
SUPPLEMENT, NOT SUPPLANT. SO WE
CAN SHIFT IN CERTAIN WAYS, BUT
ALSO HAVE TO BE COGNIZANT OF
THAT. AND THERE I THINK THERE
WAS A QUESTION ABOUT 70 MILLION
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THERE WAS
ANY ADDITIONAL POTENTIAL
OPPORTUNITY TO SHIFT, AND I'LL
DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUES AT
FINANCE IF THEY HAVE ANYTHING TO
ADD TO THAT. GABBY CENTER,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LIKE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR TROYA, SAID, WE
ARE NOT ANTICIPATING ANY OF THAT
70 MILLION BALANCE LIKE WE WERE
WORKING TO MAXIMIZE THAT SO IT
DOESN'T REVERT BACK, JUST FOR
CLARITY, BECAUSE WE ARE STILL
WORKING ON EVALUATING ELIGIBLE
USES FOR THAT, THAT BALANCE, WE
DID NOT SCORE ASSOCIATED GENERAL
FUND SAVINGS AS PART OF THE MAY
REVISION. HOWEVER, WE ARE
CONTINUING TO WORK THAT AND
HAPPY TO FOLD IN THE LEGISLATURE
AND STAFF TO INFORM YOU ON OUR
PROGRESS ABOUT HOW WE MAXIMIZE
THAT $70 MILLION BALANCE. I
GUESS. I THINK I JUST GOT
CONFUSED MYSELF. THERE IS A 70
MILLION BALANCE. SO THE ONLY
DISTINCTION IS JUST THAT WE DID
NOT, IT IS OUR INTENT TO USE
THAT BALANCE AND RECOVER GENERAL
FUND SAVINGS. WE DID NOT SCORE
THOSE SAVINGS AS PART OF THE MAY
REVISION. SO YOU DON'T SEE THAT
YOU HAVE A PLAN OF UTILIZING IT?
YES CORRECT. GOT IT. AND IS
WITHIN THAT DISCUSSION, THE TWO
ITEMS THAT ARE PROPOSED FOR
DELAY OR CUTS, THE SLOTS, THE
EXPANSION OF THE SLOTS AND THE
EMERGENCY BRIDGE PROGRAM. WE ARE
DEFINITELY TAKING A HOLISTIC
LOOK AT LIKE ANY OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT WE'RE
MINIMIZING REVERSION OF FEDERAL
FUNDS, INCLUDING FOR THAT $70
MILLION BALANCE. SO THAT WOULD
THAT, YOU KNOW, LOOKING AT THE
WHOLE PICTURE, THAT COULD BE A
PART OF THE WHAT WOULD BAR US
FROM UTILIZING THAT. FOR THAT, I
JUST, I GUESS, HELP ME
UNDERSTAND IF WE'RE PROPOSING
CUTS AND THERE'S AN OPTION WHAT
BARS US FROM JUST AUTOMATICALLY
DOING THAT INSTEAD OF PROPOSING
CUTS TO THE EXPANSION EXPANSION
AND PROPOSING CUTS TO EMERGENCY
BRIDGE PROGRAM. I THINK PART OF
THIS IS THE ADMINISTRATION IS AS
AS AN AWARDEE OF FEDERAL FUNDS,
IS WORKING WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHATEVER FUNDS OR WHATEVER
PURPOSES WE ARE USING FOR THIS
BALANCE ARE ELIGIBLE. SO THAT'S
PART OF PART OF THE PROCESS. BUT
TO YOUR QUESTION ABOUT HOW DO WE
EVALUATE USES, I THINK THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT ANYTHING, ANY
POSSIBILITY OF SPENDING THOSE
FUNDS SO THAT THEY DON'T REVERT
BACK, YEAH. AND THEN WITH
RESPECT TO THE 70 MILLION, THAT
IS A ONE TIME BALANCE THAT IS
NOT ONGOING FUNDING. AND WHEN WE
INTRODUCE NEW SLOTS, WE MAKE AN
ONGOING COMMITMENT SO THAT THAT
COULD ONLY GET US SO FAR WITH
THE SLOTS AND WE WOULD HAVE TO
COVER THE REST WITH GENERAL
FUND. IS THAT THE SAME THING FOR
EMERGENCY, OR IS THAT ONE TIME
SUPPORT FOR EACH INDIVIDUAL,
SAY, FOR EACH, THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES AN ONGOING REDUCTION OF
THE 35 MILLION FOR RIGHT. BUT
WHEN WE ALLOCATE AN EMERGENCY
SLOT SUPPORT AT THAT TIME, DO WE
ALLOCATE AN ONGOING SUPPORT FOR
EMERGENCY BUT OR IS IT JUST
KEYWORD EMERGENCY? IT'S A ONE
TIME ALLOCATION, AT A, AT A HIGH
LEVEL IN TERMS OF HOW THE
PROGRAM WORKS, WE MAKE A VOUCHER
AVAILABLE FOR A YEAR LONG
PERIOD. THERE WAS A RECENT
AMENDMENT TO, ADD FLEXIBILITY TO
THE EXTENT THAT LIKE A CHILD IN
THE FOSTER FAMILY THAT'S CARING
FOR THEM NEEDS ADDITIONAL TIME.
BUT IN TERMS OF THE FUNDING, WE
MAKE IT AVAILABLE, IT'S NOT LIKE
A ONE FOR ONE. WE JUST HAVE THE
OVERALL FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR,
FOR THOSE VOUCHER SLOTS. SO
WE'RE NOT, YOU KNOW, AND 34.8
MILLION ONGOING. HOW MANY SLOT
EMERGENCY SLOTS ON AVERAGE DOES
THAT COVER I BELIEVE LET ME
JACKIE, MAYBE, YOU KNOW, WE DID
A ROUGH CALCULATION BACK OF THE
ENVELOPE AGAIN, AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
HAS NOTED, CALCULATING A ROUGH
SLOT NUMBER IS DIFFICULT BECAUSE
PROGRAMS ARE FUNDED MAINLY LIKE
FUNDING. BUT IF WE WERE TO LOOK
AT AVERAGE COST PER SLOT, IT'S
ROUGHLY A THOUSAND 700. BUT I
WOULD NOTE THAT THOSE SLOTS
CURRENTLY, ARE NOT BEING USED,
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S REDUCTION IS
THAT THIS IS RIGHTSIZING. BUT AS
WE POINTED OUT LAST WEEK, IT'S
RIGHTSIZING BASED OFF OF CURRENT
TAKE UP TRENDS, TO THE EXTENT
THAT, WE'RE NOT DOING THE SLOT
EXPANSION AND OTHER PROGRAMS,
WHICH IS OUR UNDERSTANDING AS TO
WHY MAYBE BRIDGE SLOTS, HAVE
COME IN LOWER THAN BUDGETED
BECAUSE THERE WAS CAPACITY IN
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT MAY CHANGE
THE TAKE UP TRENDS MOVING
FORWARD. HOW MUCH FUNDING WILL
CONTINUE IN THE SERVICE? THE
EMERGENCY BRIDGE. KRISH
MALHOTRA, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
UNDER THE MAY REVISION PROPOSAL,
THE EMERGENCY CHILD CARE BRIDGE
PROGRAM WILL STILL HAVE $59
MILLION IN TOTAL FUNDING. YES.
THANK YOU. I WROTE THAT DOWN
OKAY. SO SUMMARIZING 19 MILLION
POTENTIALLY WE DON'T KNOW
VENDORS COULD UTILIZE IT. AND
YOU'RE SAYING IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT TO AUTOMATICALLY TAKE
THAT BACK TO ALLOCATE SOMEWHERE
ELSE BECAUSE IT'S ALREADY IN THE
VENDORS? 70 MILLION DOESN'T
REALLY EXIST BECAUSE YOU WILL
HAVE A PLAN WHERE YOU'RE WORKING
ON HAVING A PLAN AND WE'RE
STAYING ENGAGED IN THAT. WE WILL
MEET WITH LAO ON THE QUESTIONS
THAT JACKIE PROPOSED HERE ON
ENSURING NOT A PENNY GETS
UNSPENT AND STAYS WITHIN CHILD
CARE SEEMS TO BE OKAY. AND THEN
THE FINAL QUESTION I'LL DEFER TO
MY COLLEAGUES AT FINANCE FOR
THAT QUESTION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE APPROXIMATELY $60
MILLION IN NEW FEDERAL CHILD
CARE FUNDING ANTICIPATED FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THIS
SUMMER, OF THAT 60 MILLION WE
CURRENTLY HAVE AN ESTIMATE FROM
THE FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES FOR THAT
FUNDING. WE DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO BE
RECEIVING, IT'S NOT STANDARD
PRACTICE FOR US TO BUDGET FUNDS
THAT WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED YET.
AND SO WE DON'T HAVE, YOU KNOW,
A DIRECT ANSWER AS TO WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN WITH THOSE
FUNDING, WITH THAT FUNDING,
UNTIL WE RECEIVE THE AWARD
LETTER FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, COULDN'T WE THEN USE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE FOR CHILD
CARE SLOTS OR ANYTHING ELSE? IF
THERE'S A POTENTIAL FOR FUNDING
COMING IN, TAMAR WEBER,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, WE'RE
WILLING TO ENTERTAIN ANY KIND OF
PROPOSAL THE LEGISLATURE WANTS
TO MAKE ABOUT WHAT TO DO WITH
THE 60 MILLION, IF AND WHEN WE
ACTUALLY GET THE AWARD. OKAY I
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THE AWARD
LETTER, TYPICALLY, THEY
TYPICALLY COME IN JULY AND
AUGUST. ANOTHER OPTION COULD BE,
WHICH WE'VE SEEN IN OTHER AREAS
TO WHEN WE KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
GET A FEDERAL DOLLAR, WE JUST WE
JUST MAY NOT KNOW HOW MUCH IS.
YOU COULD THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER AS A PART OF THE JUNE
PACKAGE, ADOPT A PLACEHOLDER
NUMBER AND THEN POTENTIALLY
THROUGH AUGUST CLEANUP, JUST
CORRECT THAT NUMBER TO REFLECT
ACTUALS. THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES,
ANY QUESTIONS ON THE CHILD CARE
ISSUES? SENATOR, I WOULD I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT I LIKE WHAT YOU'RE
PROPOSING BECAUSE THEN AT LEAST
WE HAVE THAT PLACEHOLDER THAT
WILL REMIND US THAT THAT'S OUT
THERE. JUST SO IT'S LIKE, WHAT
HAPPENED TO THAT MONEY, RIGHT?
OKAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH. MOVING
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR ON THIS ONE, BIG
EMPHASIS ON THE HOME VISITING
PROGRAM MORE THAN ANYTHING ON
THE MENTAL HEALTH. I JUST WANT
TO KNOW IF THERE'S ANYTHING
THAT'S COME OUT OF THE
CONVERSATION ON LAST THURSDAY
ABOUT THE TRANSITION THÀNH OF
PEOPLE IN SERVICES AND WHAT
THAT'S GOING TO LOOK LIKE.
THAT'S REALLY IT. THAT'S WHAT
I'M LOOKING FOR HERE. OKAY.
THANK YOU, JENNIFER TROY, ON
BEHALF OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES, AGAIN, WITH
RESPECT TO REVISITING SOME OF
THE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT CALWORKS
AND WHAT YOU JUST REFERENCED,
STARTING WITH THE HOME VISITING
PROGRAM AND THE QUESTIONS IN THE
AGENDA, THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES A TOTAL FUND OF $58
MILLION FOR THE HOME VISITING
PROGRAM. SO THIS REFLECTS A
REDUCTION OF 47.1 MILLION IN 20
2425 AND ONGOING TO ADJUST
FUNDING TO UTILIZATION AND
ADDRESS THE BUDGET SHORTFALL. AS
I THINK WE TALKED ABOUT ON
THURSDAY, THE HOME VISITING
PROGRAM IS CURRENTLY IMPLEMENTED
BY 41 COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE
AND SERVES AN AVERAGE OF 3400
FAMILIES PER MONTH FOR THE
CALENDAR YEAR, 2023. YOU ASKED
ABOUT THE OUTCOMES OF THE
PROGRAM. WE DID CONDUCT AN
EVALUATION IN 2022 WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA, SAN
FRANCISCO. THEY FOUND THAT
CLIENTS EXPERIENCED THE HOME
VISITING PROGRAM TO HAVE
IMPROVED THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE
AND THAT OF THEIR CHILDREN ON A
NUMBER OF FRONTS. FOR EXAMPLE,
THEY EXPERIENCED IMPROVED PARENT
CHILD BONDS AND GAINED PARENTING
SKILLS. THEY WERE CONNECTED TO
OTHER SERVICES THAT HELPED TO
MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS. THEY
REPORTED INCREASES IN FOOD
SECURITY AND IN MENTAL HEALTH.
PARTICIPANT FAMILIES ALSO OF
THEM, A GREATER PROPORTION OF
CHILDREN RECEIVE DEVELOPMENTAL
SCREENINGS THAN FOR OTHER
MEDI-CAL RECIPIENTS AND OTHER
PREVENTIVE SERVICES. AS WE'RE
STILL IN IMPLEMENTATION AND
UPTAKE FAIRLY EARLY ON FOR THIS
SPECIFIC CALWORKS HOME VISITING
PROGRAM, WE DON'T YET HAVE
INFORMATION ON THE LONGER TERM
IMPROVEMENTS AND THINGS LIKE
FINANCIAL STABILITY THAT SAID,
HOME VISITING PROGRAMS MORE
BROADLY, INCLUDING THE MODELS WE
SPECIFICALLY USE, ARE VERY WELL
RESEARCHED, AND THAT RESEARCH
HAS DOCUMENTED IMPROVEMENTS IN
INFANT AND MATERNAL HEALTH. THE
PREVENTION OF CHILD ABUSE, AND
INFANT MORTALITY. EARLY LEARNING
AND LONG TERM ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENTS, AND THOSE SAME
REFERRALS AND COORDINATION OF
SERVICES YOU ALSO ASKED ABOUT
EXPENDITURES IN 20 2223. WE
ALLOCATED 99.5 MILLION TOTAL TO
THE HOME VISITING PROGRAM. OF
THAT FUNDING, 40.8 MILLION WAS
EXPENDED TO DATE. IN THE CURRENT
YEAR, 39.1 MILLION OUT OF THE
100.3 MILLION THAT WAS ALLOCATED
HAS BEEN EXPENDED. HOWEVER, THE
COUNTIES CAN CLAIM IN ARREARS,
SO WE WILL NOT KNOW FINAL
EXPENDITURES FOR THE CURRENT
YEAR UNTIL WELL INTO THE BUDGET
YEAR OR EVEN BEYOND. SO THAT
39.1 MILLION IS PREMATURE TO
ASSUME IS THE CURRENT YEAR
SPENDING OUR BEST PROJECTION AT
THIS TIME FOR EXPENDITURES FOR
THE. BUT FOR THE CURRENT YEAR IS
64.6 MILLION, SO TO DO THE MATH
FOR YOU, THAT WOULD LEAVE 35.7
MILLION UNSPENT. THE PROPOSED
REDUCTION THAT, PUT FORWARD IN
THE MAY REVISION WAS BASED ON A
POINT IN TIME UTILIZATION RATE.
SO GIVEN THE NUMBERS I JUST
SHARED, I THINK YOU WILL SEE
THAT IT'S BECAUSE IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THE COUNTIES HAVE
DONE SOME INCREASING OF THE
NUMBER OF FAMILIES SERVED IN THE
CURRENT BUDGET YEAR. THE ACTUAL
UTILIZATION COULD BE HIGHER, AND
SOME FAMILIES CURRENTLY
RECEIVING SERVICES WOULD BE
DISCONTINUED FROM THE PROGRAM.
IF THAT WAS INDEED THE CASE,
WE'LL CONTINUE TO ANALYZE THAT
DATA AS IT BECOMES FURTHER
AVAILABLE. DEPUTY DIRECTOR, CAN
YOU REMIND ME? OR MAYBE I GOT
LOST IN THE NUMBERS THERE. SURE.
THE CUTS ARE 47.1 MILLION ON
GOING OUT OF OR WHAT WOULD BE
LEFT ONGOING, IN 20 WE ALLOCATED
100.3 FOR 2425. SORRY, THAT'S
THE CURRENT YEAR IN 2425. DO YOU
HAVE A HANDY GO FOR IT. YEAH. SO
WE HAVE FOR 23, 24, 103 MILLION
ALLOCATED AND EXPENDITURES
AVERAGED 64 MILLION. SO OF THE
47.1 MILLION REDUCTION, WE ARE
CALCULATING THAT 38.7 IS, IS,
REFLECTS A TRUE UP BASED ON
UTILIZATION. AND THE 8.4 MILLION
LEFT OVER IS LIKE KIND OF A
BASELINE BASELINE CUT FOR THIS
REDUCTION. SO WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD WITH 34 ONGOING FOR THE
PROGRAM OR EIGHT POINT SOMETHING
ONGOING FOR THE PROGRAM. SO IT'S
THE 104 MILLION MINUS THE 40,
47.1 MILLION REDUCTION. SO ABOUT
6064. IF MY MATH IS DIFFERENT
NUMBER OVER HERE, BUT IT'S
AROUND THE SAME. YEAH, YEAH.
PLUS OR MINUS. OUR EXPENDITURES
ARE THE 104 MILLION. OKAY. SO
ONGOING THIS PROGRAM WILL STILL
CONTINUE WITH APPROXIMATELY 58
TO $61 MILLION. CORRECT. OKAY.
LET ME DO A QUICK. YOUR NEXT SET
OF QUESTIONS WAS ABOUT THE
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE FUNDING, AS A REMINDER,
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES TO
REDUCE THE FULL AMOUNT OF THAT
FUNDING ON AN ONGOING BASIS TO
ASSIST IN CLOSING THE BUDGET
PROJECTED BUDGET SHORTFALL. YOU
ASKED ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS SERVED IN THE AGENDA
IN 20 2223. A MONTHLY AVERAGE OF
5628 INDIVIDUALS WERE RECEIVING
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE SERVICES THROUGH CALWORKS.
5098 OF THAT WAS MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES, AND 530 WERE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE SERVICES. IN 20 2223, WE
ALLOCATED $126.6 MILLION FOR
THESE SERVICES, AND 89.4 MILLION
OF THAT FUNDING WAS EXPENDED SO
FAR IN 23, 24, 85.1 MILLION OF
THE 126.6 MILLION HAS ALLOCATED
THAT WAS ALLOCATED HAS BEEN
EXPENDED THAT WE KNOW OF. THOUGH
THIS IS THE SAME ISSUE IN THE
SENSE THAT IT'S THE CURRENT YEAR
IS NOT YET CLOSED OUT, AND THE
COUNTIES HAVE TIME TO CLAIM,
EVEN AFTER THE CURRENT YEAR
ENDS. OUR BEST PROJECTION AT
THIS TIME IS EXPENDITURES IN THE
CURRENT YEAR OF $72.1 MILLION,
SO THE REMAINING BALANCE WOULD
BE $54.5 MILLION IN THE CURRENT
YEAR. COUNTIES HAVE FLEXIBILITY
DESIGNING AND IMPLEMENTING THESE
PROGRAMS. AS WE DISCUSSED ON
THURSDAY, THE FOCUS IS TO REMOVE
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT AND
SUPPORT SELF-SUFFICIENCY SO WE
DON'T TRACK THE UTILIZATION OR
OUTCOMES IN A MORE DETAILED
FASHION, YOU ASKED IN PARTICULAR
ABOUT, TRANSITION INS, AND I
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD TO
WHAT WE SHARED ON THURSDAY IN
TERMS OF THE WORK THAT WE WOULD
NEED TO DO WITH THE COUNTIES TO
MAKE SURE THAT AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE, THERE ARE WARM
HANDOFFS ON THE MEDICAL SIDE IN
PARTICULAR, AND THEN ALSO
BECAUSE WE CAN ASSUME MOST
LIKELY THESE PEOPLE WON'T CUT
OFF SERVICES RIGHT AT JULY
FIRST, IS WILL THERE BE SOME
FUNDING TO CONTINUE THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN SERVICES THROUGHOUT
AUGUST, SEPTEMBER? THE PROPOSAL
IS TO REDUCE THE FULL AMOUNT OF
FUNDING FOR THE BUDGET YEAR. SO
HOW HOW THEN IF WE DO THAT, THEN
EVERYBODY WHO'S IN DAY TWO OF
THEIR TEN DAY INPATIENT
TREATMENT WILL BE KICKED OUT
IMMEDIATELY. HOPEFULLY ANYONE
WHO'S IN INPATIENT TREATMENT IS
GETTING SERVED ON THE MEDICAL
SIDE ALREADY BECAUSE THAT'S A
PRETTY MEDICAL SERVICE. BUT I
REALIZE YOUR YOUR LARGER
QUESTION, YOUR LARGER QUESTION
WAS ABOUT PEOPLE RECEIVING THOSE
SERVICES, THE ONLY THING I CAN
POINT TO, WHICH, OF COURSE, IS
DIFFICULT GIVEN THE OTHER
PROPOSALS WITHIN THE MAY
REVISION, IS THAT THE COUNTIES
HAVE FLEXIBILITY WITHIN THE
SINGLE ALLOCATION TO PROVIDE
SERVICES RELATED TO EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
THEY FEEL THAT THESE ARE ARE
WE'RE CUTTING THAT DRASTICALLY?
YES, DRASTICALLY. SO I MEAN, I,
I REALLY DO WORRY THAT, YOU
KNOW, IT TAKES A WHILE EVEN TO
TRANSITION OVER TO MEDI-CAL.
THEY'RE GOING TO GET KICKED OUT
OF THE SERVICE, FIGURE OUT THEIR
INSURANCE AND THEN MAYBE THEY'LL
COME BACK TO THIS SERVICE. I
THIS SEEMS LIKE IT'S A COLD
TURKEY CUT OFF. DOES IT MATTER
WHAT SERVICE YOU'RE IN? YOU'RE
GOING TO LOSE EVERYTHING. JULY
1ST WITHOUT HAVING A RAMP UP.
SOME KIND OF ALLOCATION JUST TO
WEED PEOPLE OFF? YEAH, I'M
REALLY, REALLY WORRIED ABOUT
THAT PART. REALLY WORRIED ABOUT
THAT PART. ANYBODY THEY'RE ALSO
WORRIED YOU CAN SEE IT ON THEIR
FACES. THEY'RE WORRIED, OKAY, WE
CAN SKIP NUMBER THREE. THE THIRD
QUESTION. OKAY. I'M GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE.
OH, I'M JUST KIDDING. ALEJO ANY
COMMENTS ON THAT? SONIA CARUSO
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE I WOULD ECHO SOME OF YOUR
QUESTIONS THAT YOU'VE RAISED
AROUND THE OPERATIONAL ASPECTS
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL, IT MAY PUT
COUNTIES IN A, IN A DIFFICULT
SPOT WHEN THEY'RE FACING BOTH
SINGLE ALLOCATION REDUCTIONS AND
ALSO THESE PROPOSALS TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO FUND THE FOLKS WHO
ARE TRANSITIONING OFF,
ADDITIONALLY, WE HOPE TO ENGAGE
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO GET A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR
CURRENT YEAR PROJECTIONS WHEN IT
COMES TO EXPENDITURES, SO WE CAN
REPORT BACK ON THAT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT. NOW WE CAN
MOVE FORWARD
.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR. SORRY. DO YOU
HAVE ANY NUMBERS ON UTILIZATION
FOR THE FAMILY STABILIZATION
PROGRAM? IN TERMS OF THE NUMBERS
OF PEOPLE SERVED, IT MIGHT TAKE
ME A SECOND TO TRACK THAT DOWN.
IN TERMS OF UTILIZATION, IT IS
FULLY UTILIZED, ACTUALLY. OVER
UTILIZED. OKAY. ALL OF THE
FUNDING. OKAY? OKAY OKAY. PLEASE
BEGIN. WE ARE NOW MOVING INTO
NEW INFORMATION THAT WE DIDN'T
GO OVER IN THURSDAY. GREAT THE
THIRD ITEM ON YOUR AGENDA
RELATES TO CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES AND THE MAY REVISION
SOLUTIONS THAT YOU ASKED US
FIRST TO SHARE AN OVERVIEW OF
THOSE SOLUTIONS, THE FIRST ONE
IS RELATED TO CAREGIVER
APPROVALS. THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES A REDUCTION OF $50
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
CAREGIVER APPROVALS, WORKLOAD IN
2425, AND ONGOING. THIS FUNDING
HAS BEEN PROVIDED ANNUALLY SINCE
2022. IT HAS BEEN FULLY UTILIZED
BY THE COUNTY'S. AS OF MARCH
THIS YEAR, 1923 FAMILIES WITH
PLACEMENTS WERE GOING THROUGH
THE APPROVAL PROCESS. THESE ARE
TYPICALLY RELATIVE AND 2716
PENDING FAMILIES WERE SEEKING
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVALS, SO
THEY DID NOT YET HAVE A CHILD
PLACED IN THEIR HOME, BUT WERE
SEEKING TO BECOME RESOURCE
FAMILIES IN TERMS OF THE
OUTCOMES OF THIS REDUCTION, WE
DO EXPECT THAT THE REDUCTION
COULD RESULT IN HIGHER CASELOADS
FOR COUNTY STAFF WHO APPROVE
CAREGIVERS AND THEREFORE THERE
COULD BE DELAYS IN THE APPROVAL
OF CAREGIVERS AND THE PERMANENCY
FOR CHILDREN. THE SECOND
PROPOSAL RELATES TO THE
PERMANENT FOSTER CARE RATES
STRUCTURE, WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
DETAILED CHANGES TO THE TRAILER
BILL RELATED TO THAT PROPOSAL. I
WILL SAVE THOSE FOR THE LATER
ITEM ON THE AGENDA. THE SPECIFIC
ONE THAT RELATES TO THE
SOLUTIONS IS A TRIGGER, THE
TRIGGER MECHANISM IS INTENDED TO
IDENTIFY WHETHER THERE ARE
AVAILABLE REVENUES IN THE SPRING
OF 2026, IN ORDER TO TRIGGER ON
THE PERMANENT RATE STRUCTURE, I
WILL TURN TO OUR CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR RAMSEY FOR THE BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM. CLARE
RAMSEY, CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO
SPEAK TO BRINGING FAMILIES HOME
AGAIN OR HOLD OFF ON THAT? WE'LL
HOLD OFF. I REALIZED THAT WE
DIDN'T DO THE PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
THAT TOPIC LAST THURSDAY, BUT
LET'S DEPUTY DIRECTOR, LET'S GO
BACK TO THE RATE STRUCTURE AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. LET ME
HELP ME, TELL ME IF I'M WRONG
HERE. AND I WAS SEARCHING AND
DIDN'T DO I DON'T THINK I DID A
GOOD JOB OF SEARCHING THE ENTIRE
BUDGET ON THIS, BUT IS THERE
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE BUDGET THAT
HAS TRIGGER LANGUAGE FOR A
MANDATED INFRASTRUCTURE STATUE?
QUÊ DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WE
COULD TAKE THAT BACK. I'M NOT
SURE IF THERE'S ANOTHER AREAS OF
THERE'S TRIGGER LANGUAGE BEING
PROPOSED. I DON'T I DON'T I
DON'T THINK THERE IS. AND I'M
WONDERING IF WE CAN WALK THROUGH
THIS AGAIN. THIS IS A STATUTORY
MANDATE. WE'RE SOLVING. I GET IT
FOR BUDGET PLUS ONE. THIS BRINGS
NO SAVINGS WHATSOEVER. AND
PUTTING THE WORD TRIGGER. BUT IT
REALLY SENDS A MESSAGE THAT EVEN
THOUGH THIS IS A STATUTORY
MANDATE, WE'RE GOING TO PUT
TRIGGER LANGUAGE ON THIS AND
JUST THIS. THE DEPARTMENT ALWAYS
COMES BACK TO BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEES. HEY, WE NEED TO
DELAY THIS. WE NEED TO DELAY
THAT. WE'RE DOING IT FROM ALMOST
EVERYTHING. SO I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR THE WORD
TRIGGER HERE. QUÊ DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SO I THINK THE INTENT
WILK WE DON'T WANT IT TO DELAY
THIS EFFORT, THE INTENT IS THAT
LIKE THE AUTOMATION TBL, AND THE
WORK TO DEVELOP GUIDANCE AND
OTHER NECESSARY ACTIVITIES. I'M
SORRY I SAID IT WRONG. YOU'RE
RIGHT. I DON'T WANT TO DELAY, I
APOLOGIZE, I'M GOING TO CUT YOU
OFF SO I CAN FIX WHAT I SAID.
WHY THE NEED TO PUT ANYTHING? WE
DON'T HAVE TO PUT DELAY. JUST
SAY, HEY, THIS IS GOING TO BE
IMPLEMENTED IN 2026. AND FOR
SOME REASON SOMETHING HAPPENS.
WE COME BACK. YES. SO THE
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
SUPPORT FOSTER CARE RATE REFORM.
I THINK GIVEN THE VOLATILITY OF
GENERAL FUND REVENUES AND JUST
THE SIGNIFICANT SIZE OF THIS
INVESTMENT, WE WANT TO BE ABLE
TO MONITOR AND EVALUATE THAT
GENERAL FUND IN THE OUT YEARS
CAN SUPPORT THIS INVESTMENT. WE
CAN STILL DO THAT WITHOUT A
TRIGGER, BECAUSE THIS IS
SUPPOSED TO BE GOING INTO PLAY
TWO YEARS FROM NOW. WE STILL
HAVE TIME NEXT YEAR TO COME BACK
AND REEVALUATE. BUT THE TRIGGER
LANGUAGE REALLY LOCKS US IN AND
GIVES, WITH ALL DUE RESPECT, A
LOT MORE POWER TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO JUST SAY NO. WE PUT
TRIGGER LANGUAGE IN THIS VERSUS
HAVING THE DIALOG TO COME BACK
NEXT YEAR AND SAY, HEY, LET'S
REEVALUATE WITH HOW THIS PROGRAM
IS GOING IN THE PROCESS. I AM
NOT A FAN OF THE WORD TRIGGER IN
HERE. I THINK IF WE'RE WE'LL
STICK TO THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ON THE PROCESS AND SO
FORTH. BUT NO TRIGGER LANGUAGE
TO THIS PROGRAM. UNDERSTAND BUT
I WOULD JUST ALSO, NOTE THAT
WHETHER OR NOT LIKE THE WHATEVER
THE OUTCOME OF THE
DETERMINATION, WE ARE GOING TO
BE HAVING THAT CONVERSATION FOR
SURE IN SUBCOMMITTEE. SO 100%
IT'S NOT SOLELY A FINANCE
DEPARTMENT DECISION. RIGHT?
RIGHT. AND I WANT TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION. BUT PUTTING THE
TRIGGER KIND OF LIMITS IT A
LITTLE BIT. IT REALLY SAYS IF WE
HAVE FUNDS, WE'RE GOING TO DO
THIS. WE'RE GOING TO PUT IT ON
THE TRIGGER. BUT JUST LEAVING IT
AS IS, THE DEPARTMENT CAN STILL
COME BACK NEXT YEAR AND SAY,
HEY, WE NEED TO DELAY THIS. AND
THAT CONVERSATION STILL HAPPENS,
AND I THINK IT ALLOWS FOR MORE
TRANSPARENT CONVERSATION. THÀNH,
BEFORE INSTEAD OF PUTTING THE
WORD TRIGGER, LIKE MOST PROGRAMS
THAT ARE COMING TO THE TABLE
TODAY ARE FROM DEALS THAT WERE
MADE A COUPLE YEARS AGO THAT ARE
BEING PROPOSED FOR DELAY, THAT'S
STILL THE OPPORTUNITY OF THE
DEPARTMENT TO DO THAT. I STILL
THINK THE TRIGGER LANGUAGE
REALLY LOCKS US IN. BEFORE
HAVING THAT CONVERSATION.
SENATOR, ANYTHING TO ADD ON
THAT? I WOULD JUST CONCUR, MADAM
CHAIR. I THINK THIS IS A I MEAN,
I'M LIKE A BROKEN RECORD, BUT IN
MY FINAL YEAR, BUT IT'S ALWAYS A
DEPARTMENT. IT'S ALWAYS A HUMAN
SERVICES DEPARTMENT, SOCIAL
SERVICES THAT GET THE TRIGGER
LANGUAGE, AND IT, IT RARELY THEN
COMES BACK TO US. THE TRIGGER IS
TRIGGERED AND THAT'S TWO YEARS
DOWN THE ROAD. YOU GUYS THINK IT
GIVES A TIME FOR THE PUBLIC TO
GIVE INPUT? AGAIN, I IT CAN BE
PAINFUL, BUT THAT'S PART OF
TRANSPARENCY AND OVERSIGHT. AND
US ACTUALLY THE LEGISLATURE
ACTUALLY TAKING OUR ROLE VERY
SERIOUSLY AND BEING DELIBERATE
ABOUT ABOUT ITS IMPACT ON
FAMILIES. SO ONCE YOU PUT, I
MEAN TRIGGER IN THERE JUST FROM
A MENTAL HEALTH PERSPECTIVE,
RIGHT? YOU'RE TRIGGERING
SOMEBODY. YOU'RE TELLING IT'S
COMING. IT'S COMING, IT'S
COMING, SO I WOULD CONCUR WITH
YOU THAT WE CAN LET IT GO AS IS.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION COME BACK
TO US IF THEY NEED TO MAKE
CHANGES LATER. LIKE EVERYTHING
ELSE. YEAH. BECAUSE I THINK YOU
JUST REMINDED ME THE CONTINUOUS
COVERAGE FOR ZERO FIVE IS ON
TRIGGER LANGUAGE. TRIGGER
LANGUAGE. AND THAT KEEPS JUST. I
MEAN, OF COURSE WE CAN BRING UP
ANYTHING TO TALK ABOUT IT ON ON
SUB THREE, BUT THOSE ARE JUST
SOME EXAMPLES THAT GET TRIGGERED
AND GET DOWN AT THE BOTTOM OF
THE LIST FOR PRIORITIES. SO, IT
DOESN'T TAKE AWAY YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING IT BACK. I
JUST LEAVE IT WHERE WE STAND,
LEAVE AS IS. AND I KNOW WE'LL
CONTINUE HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION WITH THE THREE
PARTIES FOR THE BUDGET AT THE
END, BUT THAT'S WHERE I'M
STANDING ON. OKAY I THINK THOSE
WERE. AND ON THAT, I THINK I
WE'RE GOING TO DO PUBLIC COMMENT
NOW FOR ALL CHILD WELFARE
ISSUES, CALWORKS AND CHILD
WELFARE AND THEN MOVE ON TO IHSS
AFTER LAO I KEEP FORGETTING
Y'ALL, THANK YOU, ANGELA SHORT
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE, I'LL START WITH THE
TRIGGER, SINCE THAT'S WHAT WE
WERE JUST FOCUSED ON, I THINK
PERHAPS SIMILARLY TO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS MADE BY BY THE CHAIR
AND SENATOR EGGMAN, WE ALSO
WOULD AGREE THAT IT DOES NOT
SEEM TO MAKE SENSE NECESSARILY
TO SUBJECT IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
NEW RATES STRUCTURE TO A
TRIGGER, MORE SPECIFICALLY, WE
THIS IS A QUITE SIGNIFICANT
REVAMPING OF THE FOSTER CARE
RATE STRUCTURE THAT HAS BEEN
PROPOSED, AND WE ALREADY KNOW
THAT THE DEPARTMENT,
STAKEHOLDERS, COUNTIES, SERVICE
PROVIDERS WILL BE SPENDING QUITE
A LOT OF TIME OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS, CONTINUE TO
WORK OUT THE IMPLEMENTATION
DETAILS OF THE PROPOSAL AND, AND
PREPARING TO TRANSITION TO THE
TO THE NEW RATE STRUCTURE. SO
WE'RE NOT SURE IF, HAVING
EVERYONE DO ALL OF THAT
PREPARATION, ALL OF THAT WORK
WOULD MAKE SENSE IF ULTIMATELY
THE DECISION IS DEFERRED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
IMPLEMENTATION MAY NOT HAPPEN AT
ALL, SINCE WE ALREADY KNOW AGAIN
THAT THIS IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT
PROPOSAL THAT'S GOING TO TAKE
TIME, WE WOULD AGREE A PRUDENT
APPROACH WOULD SEEM TO BE TO,
PASS, LANGUAGE. THIS BUDGET YEAR
THAT IS NECESSARY TO ALLOW THAT
IMPLEMENTATION, PREPARATIONS TO
BEGIN. AND THEN IN THE NEXT YEAR
OR SO, ONCE THE LEGISLATURE HAS
A BETTER FISCAL PICTURE OF THE
STATE'S FUTURE REVENUES, MAKE A
DETERMINATION IF A DELAY NEEDS
TO OCCUR. BUT ULTIMATELY, THE
TRIGGER LANGUAGE DOESN'T SEEM TO
MAKE SENSE FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
FOR THIS PROPOSAL, AND THEN
BRIEFLY, I'LL JUST GO BACK TO
THE PROPOSED 50 MILLION
REDUCTION FOR THE RESOURCE
FAMILY CAREGIVER APPROVALS, WE
WOULD JUST ADD TO WHAT CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR TROYA MENTIONED,
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
CURRENTLY THE MEDIAN APPROVAL
TIMES REMAIN OVER 100 DAYS, BOTH
FOR RELATIVE CAREGIVERS AS WELL
AS, NON-RELATIVE RESOURCE
FAMILIES. THIS IS ABOVE THE
TARGET 90 DAY APPROVAL TIMELINE.
SO REDUCING THOSE FUNDS THAT
COUNTIES USE TO HELP ADDRESS THE
BACKLOG AND GET THOSE PROCESSING
TIMES DOWN, WE WOULD ANTICIPATE
WE'LL JUST, YOU KNOW, RESULT IN
LONGER TIMES AND LONGER DELAYS
FOR THOSE FAMILIES, AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NO QUESTIONS. TURNING
OVER TO PUBLIC COMMENT. SO WE
HAVE THE BRING FAMILIES HOME
PROGRAM. WE HAVE THE FAMILY CARE
APPROVALS, FOSTER CARE TRIGGER
LANGUAGE AND THEN THE CALWORKS
PROGRAMS. WE OPPOSE THE TRIGGER
AND ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE. MEDI-CAL IS NOT
THE SOLUTION TO THE ISSUE
BECAUSE MEDI-CAL HAS A LIMITED
SIX VISITS FOR A YEAR. SO OFTEN
PEOPLE NEED MORE THAN SIX
VISITS. SO IF THAT'S GOING TO BE
THE SOLUTION, THEN THE THOSE
PREPAID HEALTH PLANS HAVE TO BE
AMENDED TO, TO, TO, TO MAKE THIS
POSSIBLE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. EILEEN KUBINSKI
WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION, CUT ME
OFF WHEN YOU NEED TO. THERE'S A
LOT JUST THE SINGLE ALLOCATION.
I'LL JUST SAY, IT IS A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION TO THE
SINGLE ALLOCATION WITH THE
ELIGIBILITY SHORTFALL THAT WE
HAVE ABOUT $400 MILLION. WE'RE
LOOKING AT WHAT IS EFFECTIVELY
THE ENTIRETY OF THIS CUT COMING
OUT OF THE EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
COMPONENT OF THE SINGLE, THAT'S
ABOUT A 50% REDUCTION TO
SERVICES. THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT,
WE ARE GOING TO BE CUTTING
PEOPLE OFF OF THE EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES THAT WE HAVE AND WILL
NOT HAVE ANY ROOM TO TRANSITION
ON THE MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE
ABUSE SIDE EITHER, AND THAT'S ON
TOP OF THE EAS CUTS AND THE
FAMILY STABILIZATION CUTS AS
WELL. SO, AND NOW THE HOME
VISITING PROGRAM CUTS TOO. SO
WE'LL BE LOOKING POTENTIALLY AT
CUTTING SOME FAMILIES OFF OF
THAT. SO IT IS IT IS SIGNIFICANT
AND IT IS DEEP AND IT IS DEEPLY
CONCERNING TO US WHAT THAT MEANS
FOR THE CALWORKS PROGRAM.
MINIMALLY, WE'RE GOING TO NEED
SOME TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
ABSORB EVEN A PORTION OF THESE
CUTS THAT'S GOING TO EXEMPT US
FROM WORK PARTICIPATION
REQUIREMENTS AND SO FORTH, ON
THE ONE LAST THING, BECAUSE YOU
WENT OVER YOUR TIME ALREADY. OH,
I'M SORRY, ON THE CAREGIVER
SUPPORTS ON THE APPROVALS, WE
FUND ABOUT 200 SOCIAL WORKERS
STATEWIDE WITH THAT MONEY. WE
SPEND AT LEAST TWICE THAT ON
THOSE. WITHOUT THAT FUNDING, WE
ARE UNDERMINING CORE PROGRAMS.
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
REMAINING ABOUT THE FOSTER CARE
PROPOSAL. NONE OF OUR CONCERNS
WERE ADDRESSED IN THE TRAILER.
BILL. THANKS KELLY BROOKS, ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA,
WE HAVE DEEP CONCERNS WITH THE
CALWORKS, REDUCTIONS, WHICH IS
759,000,487 MILLION OF THAT IS
ONGOING. WE'RE LOOKING AT CUTS
TO INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE
PROGRAM, THINGS THAT HELP, IN
FAMILY CRISIS SUPPORTS ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
SERVICES, JOB READINESS TRAINING
AND EMPLOYMENT SUPPORTS, AND
COUNTY CASEWORKERS. IF COUNTIES
DECIDED TO IMPLEMENT THE SINGLE
ALLOCATION CUT JUST WITH
LAYOFFS, WE'D BE LAYING OFF 1730
CALWORKS STAFF STATEWIDE, JUST
UNDERSCORE WHAT MISS KUBINSKI
SAID ABOUT WE WILL NEED SOME
TRAILER BILL TO IMPLEMENT THIS
LEVEL OF CUTS ON THE CAREGIVER
APPROVALS, THIS IS THE
FOUNDATION OF OUR CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM TO MAINTAIN FAMILY
CAREGIVERS FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH WHO HAVE BEEN REMOVED FROM
THEIR PARENTS. THIS WILL DELETE
LEAD TO DELAYS AND MANDATED
APPROVALS, INCLUDING OF RELATIVE
CAREGIVERS AND DELAYS IN THEIR
ABILITY TO BE PROVIDED A FULL
FOSTER CARE RATE PAYMENT,
INCLUDING INCLUSIVE OF
SUPPLEMENTAL RATES. THE $50
MILLION CUT IS EQUAL TO ABOUT
200 AND THREE SOCIAL WORKERS
STATEWIDE, THANKS. GOOD MORNING.
KIM LEWIS REPRESENTING ESPERANZA
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY IN 35
COUNTIES IN THE STATE. AND I
JUST WANT TO ECHO YOUR COMMENTS
AROUND THE TRIGGER INTO THE
PERMANENT RATE STRUCTURE. I
THINK THIS CAUSES GRAVE CONCERN
TO THE FIELD ABOUT WHAT THE
STABILITY OF OUR PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES ARE SUPPORTING OUR
FOSTER YOUTH. AND IN ADDITION TO
THE 240 MILLION IN CUTS THAT ARE
BEING PROPOSED IN THIS BUDGET TO
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM IN
GENERAL, LET ALONE THE LOSS OF
THE FFA BRIDGE FUNDING THAT'S
GOING TO GO AWAY. AND SO HOW DO
WE EXPECT TO HAVE OUR FOSTER
CARE PROVIDERS BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE VISION OF THIS NEW
RATE STRUCTURE IF THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO BE HERE IN TWO YEARS?
SO I URGE YOU TO REJECT ALL THE
CUTS TO CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM AND
HAVE AN ENGAGING CONVERSATION
WITH US AROUND HOW WE'RE GOING
TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. KRISTIN BAUER WITH
THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS. I WANT TO ECHO YOUR
COMMENTS ABOUT THE TRIGGER
LANGUAGE AND SUPPORT THE
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE LA
OFFICE. WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT
WE ARE SUPPORTING THIS
INVESTMENT AND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS OVERSIGHT INTO
THIS PROCESS AND THAT THE
OVERALL PROCESS IS SUPPORTED AND
RESULTS IN WHAT WE ANTICIPATE IS
AN INCREASE. AT THE SAME TIME,
WE WANT TO URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO REJECT THE CUTS TO ALL OF THE
CHILD WELFARE PROGRAMS AND SEE
WHERE THIS BALANCE ENDS US AT
THE END OF THE DAY. THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CHRIS STONER
MERTZ WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES. WE SIMILARLY, WE AGREE
THAT WE NEED TO REMOVE THAT
TRIGGER LANGUAGE AND BRING BACK
THE PROPOSAL TO THE LEGISLATURE
FOR REVIEW IN JANUARY 2025 SO
THAT WE'RE ALL WORKING TOGETHER
TO MAKE SURE IT'S THE RIGHT
PROPOSAL. AND WE WANT TO FOCUS
YOUR ATTENTION ON THOSE CUTS TO
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES, WHICH
ARE A CRITICAL PART OF THIS
PROPOSAL. WE MUST GET THAT 8.8%
COLA IN PLACE FOR THIS JULY. AND
THEN FINALLY, WE ALSO REJECT THE
CUTS TO THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
IN GENERAL. WE CAN'T BE BUILDING
ON ONE SIDE AND CUTTING ON THE
OTHER. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. JUSTIN GARRETT, THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES, WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THE CUTS TO THE
CALWORKS ALLOCATION, THE VARIOUS
SERVICES CUTS, THE BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM CUT AND
THE CAREGIVER APPROVAL CUT, YOU
KNOW, TAKEN TOGETHER, THESE CUTS
WILL SIGNIFICANTLY IMPEDE
COUNTIES ABILITIES TO PERFORM
CORE ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS
FOR THESE PROGRAMS, AS WELL AS
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE WORKFORCE
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL. ON THE
SERVICES SIDE, THEY WILL TAKE
AWAY KEY HOUSING SUPPORTS, JOB
TRAINING AND OTHER SKILLS AND
SERVICES THAT FAMILIES NEED, AND
IT'S CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS OF
THESE PROGRAMS, SO WE URGE YOU
TO REJECT THEM. THANK YOU.
SUSANNA KNIFFEN WITH CHILDREN
NOW, THE STATE HAS BOTH A MORAL
AND LEGAL RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROTECT CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN
OUR FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. TODAY
THEY NEED YOUR YOU TO PROTECT
THEM FROM THIS ADMINISTRATION.
PLEASE REJECT ALL CUTS TO OUR
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM, PARTICULARLY
THE ELIMINATION OF THE FAMILY OR
TERM RESPONSE SYSTEM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS.
KATHY MCDONALD FOR ALAMEDA
COUNTY, WE URGE REJECTION OF THE
FIRS ELIMINATION, THE BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME ELIMINATION, THE
ELIMINATION OF THE SOCIAL
HOUSING SUPPLEMENT AND THE $50
MILLION CUT TO RFA APPROVAL.
THESE CUTS WOULD DELAY
REUNIFICATION FOR FAMILIES WHO
ARE DOING EVERYTHING WE ASK OF
THEM, WOULD DELAY APPROVAL FOR
RELATIVES WHO WANT ONLY TO CARE
FOR THE CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES. IT DELAYS STABILITY
FOR THOSE CHILDREN AND YOUTH. IT
WOULD FURTHER TRAUMATIZE AND
REDUCE SERVICES TO CHILDREN AND
YOUTH WHO'VE ALREADY SUFFERED
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS. AND
FINALLY, IT WOULD FURTHER REDUCE
AND THREATEN AN ALREADY
OVERBURDENED WORKFORCE. THANK
YOU. THANKS, KATHY. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MARTHA GUERRERO,
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS,
ALSO URGE YOUR REJECTION OF THE
CALWORKS ALLOCATION BECAUSE IT
WOULD AFFECT 117,000 FAMILIES,
217,000 CHILDREN AND 70,000
ADULTS IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WOULD BE IMPACTED. WE ALSO
OPPOSE THE ADDITIONAL CUTS TO
CHILD, THE CUTS TO CHILD WELFARE
FROM THE JANUARY WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION.
IT WILL END THE SERIOUS IMPACT
IT WILL HAVE TO LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL IMPACT INFORMATION.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. KELLY
LONGO FLORES WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS, WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A VERY
CHALLENGING BUDGET YEAR, BUT WE
ASK THAT THE COMMITTEE REJECTS
OUT CUTS THAT WILL IMPACT
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS, SPECIFICALLY, WE
ASK THAT YOU REJECT THE DOUBLE
CUTS OF CALWORKS AND SAFETY NET
WITHDRAWAL AND ANY PULLBACK IN
CHILD CARE FUNDING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, JEFF NEILL,
REPRESENTING THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO. WE REMAIN CONCERNED WITH
THE PROPOSED CUTS TO THE SINGLE
ALLOCATION TO THE WORK,
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. ESPECIALLY,
YOU KNOW, THE PROPOSED CUTS TO
THE STATUTORILY REQUIRED
ELIGIBILITY AND EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES PROGRAM WOULD BE ALMOST
$30 MILLION JUST IN SAN DIEGO
WOULD MAKE IT UNSUSTAINABLE TO,
TO CONTINUE TO OPERATE THAT
PROGRAM INTO THE FUTURE, GIVEN
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE CUTS,
THE COUNTY WOULD REQUEST THAT
YOU CONSIDER REDUCING SOME OF
THE ADMINISTRATIVE AND
REGULATORY BURDEN, BOTH ON
COUNTIES AND ON CLIENTS. SOME OF
THE COVID ERA EXECUTIVE ORDERS,
YOU KNOW, MADE CHANGES TO
SUSPENDING INTAKE INTERVIEWS,
ANNUAL RENEWAL INTERVIEWS,
SEMIANNUAL REPORTING AND GOOD
CAUSE LATITUDE FOR COUNTIES THAT
DON'T PARTICIPATE IN IN
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES. LIFTING
SOME OF THOSE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS WOULD WOULD AT LEAST
GIVE US SOME FLEXIBILITY TO
OPERATE THE PROGRAMS UNDER THESE
DEVASTATING CUTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR.
I'M EMERALD EVANS WITH GRACE AND
CHILD POVERTY CALIFORNIA. WE
WOULD LIKE TO DEEPLY OPPOSE AND
REJECT CUTS TO PROGRAMS SERVING
FOSTER YOUTH, BOTH INCLUDED IN
THE MAY REVISE AND THE JANUARY
BUDGET PROPOSAL. AND THEN ALSO
REGARDING THE FOSTER CARE RATE
STRUCTURE, WE WANT TO ECHO
CONCERNS BY COUNTIES AND
ADVOCATES ABOUT THE UNKNOWNS, IN
THE METHODOLOGY BEHIND THE
TURING SYSTEM, WE URGE ONLY
MINIMALLY NECESSARY ACTION THIS
YEAR FOR STAKEHOLDERS TO GET IT
RIGHT, GIVEN THE PERMANENT
REFORMS BEING MADE. WE SHARE
YOUR CONCERN ABOUT THE STRUCTURE
OF THE TRIGGER. AND THEN
REGARDING CALWORKS, I WANT TO
ECHO OUR COMMENTS FROM ANDREW ON
THURSDAY, TO UNDERSCORE YOUR
COMMENTS, CHAIR, THAT THESE ARE
DEEP CUTS TO CORE PROGRAMS. AND
THEN REGARDING CHILD CARE,
LASTLY, WE WANT TO REJECT THE
CUTS TO CHILD CARE BRIDGE THAT
WOULD ENSURE CHILDREN ARE PLACED
INTO FOSTER CARE AND CRISIS,
THAT ARE IN CRISIS, HAVE CHILD
CARE. AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
HARD WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
MAXIMIZE ALL FEDERAL FUNDING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. VANESSA KAHINA, ON
BEHALF OF THE NURSE FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP, ONE OF THE CAL
WORKS HOME VISITING PROGRAMS,
DEEPLY CONCERNED WITH ALL OF THE
PROPOSED CUTS TO CAL WORKS.
TAKEN TOGETHER, THESE WOULD HAVE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS ON THOUSANDS
OF FAMILIES AROUND THE STATE AS
WE'VE DONE AN ASSESSMENT OF OUR
NETWORK PARTNERS IN DIFFERENT
COUNTIES, WE CAN TELL YOU THAT
WE BELIEVE THAT THERE WOULD BE
100 FAMILIES IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
WHO WOULD BE CUT OFF FROM HOME
VISITING SERVICES IF THIS CUT
WERE TO GO INTO EFFECT. WE URGE
YOU TO REJECT THESE CUTS. AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
ATTENTION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. HEIDI KAISER
REPRESENTING CHILD ACTION. WE'D
LIKE TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
THE COALITION. PLEASE REJECT THE
CUTS TO THE CHILD CARE BRIDGE
PROGRAM. CUTTING THESE FUNDS
WILL HURT SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN.
ADDITIONALLY, PAUSING ANY NEW
CHILD CARE SLOTS WILL RESULT IN
MISSED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STRUGGLING FAMILIES TO STABILIZE
AND HURT THEIR CHILDREN. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, NINA BOOTH, THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF EVERY
CHILD CALIFORNIA. WE'RE VERY
OPPOSED TO THE CUTS TO THE CHILD
CARE BRIDGE PROGRAM, AND ALSO
SPECIFICALLY TO THE GENERAL
CHILD CARE SLOT REDUCTION,
CENTERS HAVE ALREADY STARTED
TRANSFORMING CLASSROOMS ON THE
PROMISE OF THESE FUNDS. ONE OF
MY MEMBERS IN LA SAID THE
EXPANSION OF FUNDING APPLICATION
WAS A VERY LONG AND ARDUOUS
PROCESS. SHE WENT THROUGH IT,
GOT BOARD APPROVAL, STARTED
SHIFTING CLASSROOMS, GOT
LICENSED, WHICH TAKES A VERY,
VERY LONG TIME. OF ALL OF THE
AGE GROUPS SHE SERVES, THE
LONGEST WAITING LIST IS FOR
INFANTS AND TODDLERS. WITHOUT
THIS EXPANSION FUNDING, SHE WILL
HAVE THREE EMPTY CLASSROOMS,
UNABLE TO SERVE THESE CHILDREN.
LET'S NOT LET CLASSROOMS JUST
SIT OPEN BECAUSE WE'RE CUTTING
THIS FUNDING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, VALERIE DE
NIRO WITH EVERY CHILD CALIFORNIA
. AND WE ALSO ALIGN OURSELVES
WITH THE EAC COALITION. I ECHO
THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN MADE. THE èC COALITION. WE
ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
TO ADOPT OTHER BUDGET SOLUTIONS.
IN PARTICULAR, WE REALLY URGE
YOU TO ADOPT THE TIMELINE FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE ALTERNATIVE
RATE METHODOLOGY. ADOPTION OF
THE EAC REVERSION ACCOUNT AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY, THE RELEASE OF
THE 27,000 CTR SPACES THAT WERE
ALREADY PROMISED TO PROVIDERS
THAT HAVE ALREADY GONE EXTREMELY
OUT OF POCKET TO BE READY TO GO
TO ENROLL FAMILIES JULY 1ST.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO
THIS MATTER. GOOD MORNING,
REBECCA GONZALES WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY. WE
CONTINUE TO OPPOSE THE DEEP CUTS
TO CALWORKS, ESPECIALLY THE
FAMILY STABILIZATION PROGRAM,
SUBSIDIZE EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM,
THE DRAINING OF THE SAFETY NET
AND THEN IN MAY, THE CAL WORKS
HOME VISITING PROGRAM AND THE
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE PROGRAM. WE DO BELIEVE
THIS RUNS COUNTER TO THE STATE
BECOMING PART OF THE FEDERAL
PILOT PROGRAM, BUT WE WERE HAPPY
TO SEE IN THE BUDGET THAT THERE
WAS SOME LANGUAGE PUT IN BY THE
DEPARTMENT REQUESTING LANGUAGE
TO BE A PART OF THIS PILOT.
THANK YOU. AND WE'RE ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CUTS TO THE
CHILD WELFARE, INCLUDING THE
CHILD CARE SLOTS AND THE BRING
FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR MEMBERS JANICE O'MALLEY
WITH AFSCME CALIFORNIA VÀ.
YOU'VE HEARD, FROM THE FOLKS
PRIOR TO ME THAT THE CUTS TO
CHILD WELFARE VÀ TO CALWORKS
WILL REALLY SEVERELY IMPACT THE
WORKFORCE. BUT I ALSO WANT TO
SHARE WITH YOU WHAT THAT
ACTUALLY MEANS ONE PERSON, EVEN
ONE PERSON WHO, IS FIRED FROM
THESE POSITIONS COULD REALLY
AFFECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CHILDREN. AND FAMILIES,
ESPECIALLY IN SMALL RURAL AREAS.
WE REPRESENT FOLKS IN HUMBOLDT
COUNTY, AND THEY HAD TO PUT OUT
AN ALL POINTS BULLETIN, MESSAGE
TO THEIR WORKERS TO EVEN IF THEY
DIDN'T WORK IN THE
CLASSIFICATION OF CHILD WELFARE,
THEY NEEDED TO ALL WORK TOGETHER
TO ADDRESS THE BACKLOGS. AND SO
THAT MEANS THAT THE WORKFORCE IS
OVERBURDENED. THEY'RE UNABLE TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE HEALTH AND
SAFETY ISSUES THAT ARE MANDATED
BY THE STATE. SO WE'RE REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THESE CUTS AND
HOPE THAT I KNOW THIS IS A BAD
BUDGET YEAR. YOU HAVE TO MAKE
REALLY DIFFICULT DECISIONS. I
DON'T ENVY YOU WHEN YOU MAKE
THESE DECISIONS. BUT LET'S THINK
ABOUT LIKE THE REAL IMPACT OF
HOW THIS WILL AFFECT FAMILIES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MARIO
CHILD CARE LAW CENTER WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO REJECT ANY
CUTS TO THE CALWORKS PROGRAM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. CHAIRMAN. MY NAME IS
JULIETTE TERRY. I'M WITH THE,
CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER, AND
WE'RE PROUD PARTNERS OF THE SEIU
COALITION AND ALIGN OURSELVES
WITH ALL OF THEIR SENTIMENTS.
TODAY. I JUST WANT TO START OFF
BY SAYING THAT DURING THE MAY
REVISION, DROP THE GOVERNOR'S
SENTIMENTS AROUND A CHOICE
HAVING TO BE MADE BETWEEN
FUNDING CHILD CARE RATES AND
FUNDING CHILD CARE SLOTS IS
QUITE A FALSE CHOICE NARRATIVE,
AND IT'S VERY HARMFUL TO OUR
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN WHO ARE
DEPENDING ON THESE PROGRAMS, WE
KNOW WE HAVE OTHER CHOICES, SO
PLEASE CONSIDER REJECTING THE
CUTS TO CALWORKS, REJECTING THE
CUTS TO THE FOSTER CARE BRIDGE
PROGRAM, FULLY FUNDING THE CHILD
CARE SLOTS THAT WERE ALLOTTED. I
KNOW IN OUR DISTRICT ALONE THAT
WE SERVE. WE ALREADY HAVE 18,000
FAMILIES WAITING FOR CHILD CARE,
AND AS WELL WE DO ASK THE
RESTORATION OF THE GENERAL CHILD
CARE SLOTS AS WELL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MOVING INTO
IHSS, MADAM CHAIR, BEFORE YOU
DO, IF I MAY, JUST FOR YOUR
RECORD, ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
RELATED TO FAMILY STABILIZATION,
IT WAS 44,000 CALWORKS FAMILIES
THAT RECEIVED THOSE SERVICES IN
20 2223. THANK YOU SO MUCH. I
APPRECIATE THAT. OKAY GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. CLAIRE
RAMSEY FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
SPEAKING ON YOUR IHSS QUESTIONS,
I WILL BEGIN WITH THE RESCISSION
OF THE IN-HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES BENEFIT BASED ON
IMMIGRATION STATUS. THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES THE
ELIMINATION OF IHSS FOR ALL
UNDOCUMENTED RECIPIENTS AFFECTED
BY THE FULL SCOPE. MEDI-CAL
EXPANSIONS, THE ELIMINATION OF
IHSS FOR ALL RECIPIENTS,
UNDOCUMENTED RECIPIENTS WOULD
AFFECT ESTIMATES FOR THE
CASELOAD. IMPACT OF SB 75, WHICH
IS THE CHILDREN 18 AND UNDER,
AND THOSE 19 TO 25, 26 TO 49,
AND 50 AND OLDER. THIS
ELIMINATION WOULD RESULT IN A
REDUCTION OF $94.7 MILLION AND A
WORKLOAD ADJUSTMENT OF
3,000,400. $304.8 MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN FISCAL YEAR
2425, AND ONGOING TO ASSIST IN
CLOSING THE PROJECTED SHORTFALL,
BASED ON OUR CASE MANAGEMENT
INFORMATION AND PAYROLLING
SYSTEM DATA IT WOULD SUPPORT,
WHICH SUPPORTS BOTH THE IHSS AND
THE WAIVER PERSONAL CARE
SERVICES PROGRAM. THIS POLICY
WILL IMPACT APPROXIMATELY 2968
INDIVIDUALS, WE ARE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES ON THIS
CHANGE BECAUSE THEY RUN THE
MEDI-CAL PROGRAM AND WE RUN THE
IHSS PROGRAM. SO WE'RE WORKING
TO MITIGATE ANY NEGATIVE IMPACTS
TO CURRENTLY ASSISTED
INDIVIDUALS, INCLUDING LOOKING
AT OTHER BENEFITS THEY MAY BE
ABLE TO RECEIVE UNDER THE
MEDI-CAL PROGRAM. THESE COULD
INCLUDE THINGS LIKE THE CAL AIM
ENHANCED CARE MANAGEMENT, THE
CAL AIM COMMUNITY SUPPORTS, AND
OTHER MEDI-CAL WAIVERS,
INCLUDING. THE COMMUNITY BASED
ADULT SERVICES PROGRAM AND THE
MULTI-SERVICE SENIOR PROGRAM. SO
CBAS AND MSSP. IN ADDITION TO
ALL OTHER MEDI-CAL BENEFITS THAT
THEY WILL REMAIN ELIGIBLE FOR
UNDER THE EXPANSIONS. THERE ARE,
HOWEVER, NO ALTERNATIVES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES AT
THIS TIME. FOR THIS POPULATION,
WE WERE ALSO ASKED TO SPEAK IN
QUESTION TWO TO OUR
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN, THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD NEED TO TAKE A
NUMBER OF STEPS TO IMPLEMENT
THIS CHANGE, INCLUDING THE
NORMAL ADMINISTRATIVE STEPS WE
TAKE TO ISSUE AN ALL COUNTY
LETTER DRAFT, A NOTICE OF ACTION
MESSAGES FOR RECIPIENTS, WORK
WITH. DHS TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
ACCURATE DATA TO ENSURE NO OTHER
QUALIFIED POPULATIONS WERE
INCLUDED IN THIS TERMINATION. WE
WOULDN'T NEED TO MAKE SOME
SYSTEMS CHANGES AS WELL, BUT
THOSE ARE ABSORBABLE BY THE
DEPARTMENT. WE WOULD THEN HAVE
TO ISSUE NOTICES WITH, AT LEAST
TEN DAYS IN ADVANCE TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD BE LOSING,
MEDI-CAL. EXCUSE ME, LOSING IHSS
UNDER THIS PROPOSAL, I'LL MOVE
NEXT TO THE ELIMINATION OF THE
IHSS PERMANENT BACKUP SYSTEM.
THE PERMANENT BACKUP SYSTEM WAS
ESTABLISHED ON OCTOBER 1ST, 2022
TO ASSIST IHSS RECIPIENTS WITH
FINDING A PROVIDER WHEN AN
URGENT OR IMMEDIATE NEED FOR
IHSS SERVICES ARISES AND THE
REGULAR PROVIDER IS NOT
AVAILABLE, OR WHEN AN IHSS
RECIPIENT IS TRANSITIONING FROM
OUT OF HOME CARE TO HOME BASED
CARE, AND THEY DO NOT YET HAVE A
PROVIDER. ELIGIBLE PROVIDERS ARE
CURRENTLY ALLOWED TO RECEIVE UP
TO 80 HOURS A YEAR, AND IN
CERTAIN INSTANCES, UP TO 160
HOURS A YEAR. AND THERE IS A
DIFFERENTIAL WAGE PAGE PAID OF
$2, FOR BACKUP PROVIDER SYSTEMS,
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES THE
ELIMINATION OF THE PROGRAM. SO
BOTH THE FUNDING GOING FORWARD
AND THE PROGRAM ITSELF, THE
REDUCTION WOULD RESULT IN $11.6
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND SAVINGS
STARTING IN 2425 AND ONGOING IN
REGARD TO IMPACT, THERE ARE NO
ALTERNATIVE. AT THE STATE LEVEL
TO THE CURRENT BACKUP SYSTEM.
SOME COUNTIES HAVE OPERATED
INDEPENDENTLY. BACKUP SYSTEMS,
BEFORE THESE SYSTEMS WERE MADE
PERMANENT THROUGH THE STATE, WE
ANTICIPATE SOME COUNTIES WOULD
CONTINUE TO DO THAT, ALTHOUGH,
WE DON'T KNOW HOW MANY AND TO
WHAT EXTENT THEY WOULD BE ABLE
TO, OFFER BACKUP SERVICES
ONGOING, HOWEVER, WE DO PLAN TO
WORK WITH OUR COUNTIES AND
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES TO DETERMINE,
HOW BEST TO SUPPORT THEM AND ANY
RECIPIENTS TO MAKE SURE THEIR
URGENT NEEDS ARE MET, REGARDING
UTILIZATION, UTILIZATION
CURRENTLY HAS BEEN LOW IN THE
PROGRAM. WE ARE AVERAGING ABOUT
110 PROVIDERS PROVIDING BACKUP
SERVICES PER MONTH FOR THE FIRST
FOUR MONTHS OF 2024.
SPECIFICALLY, IN JANUARY, 105
FEBRUARY, 117 MARCH, 114, AND
APRIL 105, AND WE DO ANTICIPATE
THAT THERE. ARE A LOT OF IHSS
RECIPIENTS WHO ARE ABLE TO
UTILIZE FAMILY, FRIEND AND
PERSONAL NETWORKS TO PROVIDE
BACKUP SERVICES, WHICH IS WHY
THE CURRENT BACKUP SYSTEM IS NOT
BEING MORE HEAVILY USED AT THIS
TIME. LASTLY, I'LL SPEAK TO THE
REDUCTION IN THE IHSS CAREER
PATHWAYS PROGRAM, THE CAREER
PATHWAYS PROGRAM IS THE TRAINING
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE TALKED
ABOUT SEVERAL TIMES THAT IS
MEANT TO INCREASE QUALITY OF
CARE AND ASSIST IN RECRUITING
AND RETAINING PROVIDERS, INTO
THE IHSS PROGRAM, YOUR YOUR
AGENDA CORRECTLY INDICATES THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
CURRENTLY BEEN SERVED THROUGH
THE CAREER PATHWAYS. PROGRAM AND
THE NUMBER OF INCENTIVE PAYMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN PAID OUT TO DATE,
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSAL
PROPOSES A ONE TIME REVERSION OF
$60 MILLION IN THE HCBS FUNDING
FOR IHSS CAREER PATHWAYS TO HELP
CLOSE THE PROJECTED SHORTFALL.
THE 60 MILLION WOULD BE DIVIDED
BETWEEN 40 MILLION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AND 20 MILLION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO FUND ASSISTED LIVING
WAIVER SLOTS. AND ON THE DDS
SIDE, IT WOULD HELP FUND RATES,
CAN YOU SAY THAT BREAKDOWN
AGAIN? SURE. AND I LOOK TO MY,
FINANCE COLLEAGUES IF I'VE
STATED ANYTHING WRONG, BUT IT'S
40 MILLION TO DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES FOR RATES
AND 20 MILLION OF THE 60 MILLION
TO DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FOR THE ASSISTED LIVING
WAIVER. AND THEN REGARD TO
IMPACTS, WE WILL CONTINUE
OFFERING ALL THE CLASSES WE ARE
CURRENTLY OFFERING THROUGH THE
END OF SEPTEMBER AS PLANNED.
THERE ARE NO CHANGES THERE. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO
, SUBMIT FOR PAYMENT AND
INCENTIVES THROUGH, THE MIDDLE
OF NOVEMBER AND THEY WILL BE
ABLE TO EARN ON INCENTIVES
THROUGH THE END OF OCTOBER. SO
THAT WILL ALL STAY THE SAME. AS
WE DISCUSSED AT THE HEARING
EARLIER THIS YEAR, WE DO
ANTICIPATE THAT WE CAN SPEND
DOWN THE ENTIRE $235 MILLION
REMAINING, AS WE HAVE ALREADY
SPENT AS OF MARCH 31ST OF THIS
YEAR, $91.6 MILLION IN THE
PROGRAM. SO WE DO NOT ANTICIPATE
A NEGATIVE IMPACT TO ANYONE
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM.
AND BELIEVE THERE WAS MONEY TO
BE ABLE TO USE FOR OTHER
PURPOSES, I WILL STOP THERE AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. A
YEAR AGO, YOU ALL SAID THE SAME
EXACT THING. A COUPLE OF MONTHS
AGO, YOU ALL SAID THE SAME EXACT
THING. AND NOW AGAIN, YOU'RE
SAYING WE HAVE CONFIDENCE WE'RE
GOING TO SPEND IT. THAT'S THREE
TIMES I'VE HEARD IT IN MY TIME
HERE AND WE'RE NOT. SO I DON'T
HAVE THAT MUCH CONFIDENCE IN
THIS AREA THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SPEND IT ALL, DO WE HAVE I KNOW
THESE ARE NUMBERS FOR MARCH.
MIGHT BE TOO EARLY TO GET APRIL
NUMBERS. DO WE HAVE ANY APRIL
NUMBERS JUST TO SEE A TREND WE
DON'T HAVE? OH EXCUSE ME, WE
DON'T HAVE APRIL NUMBERS YET,
BUT WE ANTICIPATE WE WILL LIKELY
HAVE THEM, IN THE COMING WEEKS.
WE ARE ALWAYS A MONTH IN ARREARS
ON PAYMENTS, AND WE UNDERSTAND
THE CONCERN BY THE CHAIR ABOUT,
SPENDING FULLY IN THIS PROGRAM.
THIS HAS BEEN A HARD PROGRAM TO
PREDICT SPENDING, AND WE ARE
DOING IT IN SMALL INCREMENTS. SO
IT REQUIRES A LOT OF PROVIDERS
TO TAKE CLASSES TO BUILD UP THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT. BUT WE DID HAVE
OUR HIGHEST SPENDING TO DATE, IN
MARCH OF 2024 AFTER THE DOUBLING
OF CLASSES. AND WE DO ANTICIPATE
THE TRENDS TO CONTINUE UPWARD.
ARE WE STILL DOUBLING CLASSES?
WE'RE NOT DOUBLING ANYMORE, BUT
WE NOW HAVE A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF CLASSES BEING OFFERED ONGOING
, AND WE DO EXPECT TO CONTINUE
TO SEE HIGH RATES OF SPENDING
GOING FORWARD. QUESTION FOR BOTH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND LEO,
BECAUSE THIS WILL BE AFTER THE
BUDGET PROCESS. WHAT
RECOMMENDATIONS CAN WE PUT IN
HERE OR WHAT WHAT WOULD THE
PROCESS LOOK LIKE COME AUGUST
FIRST, WHERE WE DON'T SEEM TO BE
ON TRACK TO UTILIZING ALL THIS
FUND? AND HOW QUICKLY CAN WE
REALLOCATE SOME OF THOSE FUNDS
FOR SOMETHING ELSE OUTSIDE OF
THIS PROCESS? DEPARTMENT FINANCE
I THINK THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING
WE'D HAVE TO, WORK WITH OUR DCS
COLLEAGUES AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES, SINCE THEY
ARE THE LEAD AGENCY ON THE HCBS
SPENDING PLAN. WOULD THE
DEPARTMENTS JUST DETERMINE ON
THEIR OWN? I MEAN, I DON'T THINK
THEY'RE CALLING ALL OF US TO
COME BACK AND DECIDE. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. JINNEY BELLA, WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE, I THINK YOU'RE RAISING
REALLY GREAT QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
HOW WILL WE KNOW AND HOW HOW CAN
WE KEEP MORE LIVE TIME TRACK OF
THIS SPENDING? I THINK HEARING
THIS, THIS APRIL INFORMATION
WILL BE VERY HELPFUL IN KIND OF
DETERMINING HOW MUCH IS LEFT
OVER AND WHAT WE CAN DO, BECAUSE
TO YOUR POINT, IF YOU ARE GOING
TO REDIRECT MORE OF THIS MONEY,
YOU WOULD WANT TO KNOW THAT NOW
SO THAT YOU CAN OFFSET OTHER
REDUCTIONS THAT YOU MAY BE
CONSIDERING. SO, SOMETHING THAT
WILL BE ON TOP OF Tê IN TERMS OF
APRIL. AND SO WE CAN GET BACK TO
YOU ONCE WE SEE THOSE NUMBERS,
DO WE ANTICIPATE THOSE ON JUNE
1ST? THAT'S ABOUT RIGHT. I DON'T
WANT TO PROMISE THE DATE, BUT
THAT SHOULD BE ABOUT ACCURATE.
WE SHOULD HAVE THEM EARLY JUNE
AT THE LATEST. OKAY. PLEASE DO
SEND THAT OVER TO US AS SOON AS
WE GET THAT, WE DEFINITELY WANT
TO TRACK THIS LITERALLY DAY BY
DAY. JUST BECAUSE, AGAIN. AND
IT'S NO PERSONAL NOTHING. I JUST
THE TREND THAT WE'VE SEEN, WE'RE
NOT ON TRACK. AND I DO WORRY
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO UTILIZE
ALL THIS FEDERAL FUNDING, AND IF
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE WE'RE
LOOKING TO EXPAND IT, I STILL
WANT TO ENTERTAIN THE IDEA OF
JUST DOUBLING DOWN THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY WE GIVE OUT. IF THAT'S OR
UTILIZING FOR OTHER THINGS. BUT
I DEFINITELY DON'T WANT ANY
FUNDING TO BE LEFT OVER FOR IN
THIS AREA. THANK YOU. CHAIR. WE
HAVE THE SAME COMMITMENT TO
SPENDING ALL THE MONEY. OKAY AND
THEN FOR THE IMMIGRATION BENEFIT
BENEFITS FOR THE IMMIGRATION,
REGARDLESS, BECAUSE OF YOUR
IMMIGRATION STATUS, HOW WE I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE BEEN
TALKING WITH ADVOCATES, BUT THIS
ISN'T A PUBLIC CHARGE. AND FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE COMPLEX NEEDS,
THEY CAN'T GO TO SEE BASIS,
RIGHT? IT REQUIRES YOU TO BE
AMBULATORY AND SO FORTH. IF THIS
IS CARE FOR SOMEONE WHO IS
NON-AMBULATORY, AND THEIR NEXT
OPTION IS A SNIFF, A CARE
NURSING FACILITY, THAT'S A
PUBLIC CHARGE. SO I'M WONDERING
WHAT WE'RE DOING TO FOCUS ON
THAT SPECIFIC AREA BECAUSE I
AGREE WITH YOU. C¢M Â KI¾M CAN
HELP WITH CERTAIN AREAS, BUT THE
MOST DIRE, DIRE NEED OF THIS
CARE COULD POTENTIALLY BE LOCKED
OUT OF OTHER SERVICES,
ESPECIALLY ON PUBLIC CHARGE
AREAS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION, UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS WOULD HAVE A RIGHT TO
SKILLED NURSING CARE IF THEY
NEEDED IT. SO I JUST WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO
THEM AT A SNIFF, AT A SNIFF.
WOULD IT BE A PUBLIC CHARGE? I'M
NOT AN IMMIGRATION EXPERT, BUT,
I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN ABOUT
ADVOCATES HAVE SHARED WITH ME
THAT THAT WOULD BE, IN FACT, A
PUBLIC CHARGE. SO THAT WOULDN'T
BE AN OPTION FOR THEM. I CAN
TAKE THAT QUESTION BACK, MADAM
CHAIR, WE ARE COGNIZANT THAT
PEOPLE MAY NEED TO MAKE HARD
CHOICES, IF THIS PROPOSAL GOES
FORWARD AND IHSS IS TERMINATED,
AGAIN, WE WOULD BE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO MAKE
SURE NO ONE IS, CAUGHT OUT OR
WITHOUT SERVICES THAT THEY NEED
TO LIVE SAFELY IN THEIR OWN
HOME. AND WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT
THAT MAY BE, NOT POSSIBLE TO
STAY AT HOME, GIVEN THE CHANGE
IN IHSS ELIGIBILITY THIS HAS
ATTAINED TEN DAY TIME FRAME. YOU
MENTIONED A NOTICE GOES OUT. YOU
HAVE TEN DAYS. THIS SERVICE IS
OVER. SO THAT'S SOMETHING WE
COULD CERTAINLY WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON TEN DAYS IS OUR
MINIMUM REQUIREMENT OF NOTICE TO
GIVE TO AN INDIVIDUAL. I MEAN, I
APPRECIATE SOME KIND OF NOTICE.
RIGHT. OTHER PROGRAMS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER TODAY, IT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THERE IS A
NOTICE APPROACH. IT'S JUST A CUT
OFF WITH THE TEN DAY TIME FRAME.
DOES THAT MEAN THAT THERE IS
GOING TO HAVE TO BE SOME
SPENDING IN THIS AREA IN THE IN
THE UPCOMING FISCAL YEAR? I
THINK THAT, IS SOMETHING WE WILL
TAKE BACK AS A QUESTION, BUT IS
GOING TO BE A CHALLENGE GIVEN
THAT THERE ARE MULTIPLE
REQUIREMENTS THAT HAVE TO BE MET
BEFORE THE ACTION CAN ACTUALLY
BE TAKEN FOR ANY INDIVIDUAL
RECIPIENT. AND YOU MENTIONED
IT'S ABOUT LIKE 300 SOMETHING
MILLION FOR THE ADMIN. OH LET
ME, LET ME, CORRECT. IT'S, THERE
WAS A CASELOAD ADJUSTMENT OF
$304 MILLION. AND I DON'T KNOW
IF OUR MY COLLEAGUES AT FINANCE
WANT TO SPEAK ANY MORE TO THE
CASELOAD ADJUSTMENT. NO, NO NO
NO. OKAY, OKAY. NO, NO. I JUST
WANTED TO SEE IF THERE WAS ANY
FUNDING LEFT FOR THOSE PEOPLE
THAT ARE GOING TO BE USING THOSE
TEN DAYS LEEWAY TO COME OFF THE
SERVICE INTO THE FISCAL YEAR IN
THE FISCAL YEAR, WE HAVE NOT
BUDGETED FOR ANY, FUNDING FOR
THIS POPULATION INTO THE BUDGET
YEAR, HOWEVER, WE MAY, WANT TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE LEGISLATIVE
DISCUSSIONS AROUND, HOW TO HOW
TO WORK THAT TIMING AND THE
FUNDING ON THAT TIMING. IF WE
HAVEN'T DEPARTMENT FINANCE, WHAT
IS THE PLAN THEN? IF WE'RE
GIVING THEM TEN DAYS, THAT MEANS
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
SERVICE ALL THE WAY UP TO THE
10TH DAY UNTIL THEY FIND SOMEONE
ELSE. SO HOW DO WE, ITALY'S
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, YEAH. IN
REGARDS TO THIS, WE'RE
CONTINUING TO ENGAGE STILL WITH
DSS ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
SOLUTION. SHOULD IT MAKE IT INTO
THE FINAL BUDGET? OKAY I FEEL
LIKE WE WAIT TILL THE LAST
MINUTE TO DISCUSS EVERYTHING.
OKAY, ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ON
IHSS COLLEAGUES? ELIO, I WAS
GOING TO FORGET. NO. DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. DID YOU HAVE SOMETHING
ELSE TO ADD, YES, MADAM CHAIR,
PLEASE, OKAY, SO WE ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO NOTE THAT IN REGARDS TO
THE IHSS FOR UNDOCUMENTED
EXPANSION SERVICES, PRIOR TO THE
VARIOUS COVERAGE EXPANSION FOR
INDIVIDUALS, REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS, THIS
POPULATION QUALIFIED ONLY FOR
EMERGENCY AND PREGNANCY RELATED
SERVICES. THEY WERE NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR IHSS. THE MAY REVISION
MAINTAINS EXPANDED MEDI-CAL
COVERAGE FOR INDIVIDUALS OF ALL
AGES, INCLUDING THE ADULTS THAT
BECAME ELIGIBLE FOR THE FULL
SCOPE. MEDI-CAL. EFFECTIVE
JANUARY 1ST, 2024. THE BENEFIT
THE BENEFITS FOR THIS POPULATION
CONTINUES TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
INCLUDE ESSENTIAL SERVICES SUCH
AS PREVENTATIVE CARE, DENTAL
COVERAGE, OPTICAL SERVICES,
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS, PHYSICAL
THERAPY, REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH,
AND DOULA COVERAGE, AND MENTAL
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES.
IT CONTINUES TO BE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PRIORITY TO
MAINTAIN HEALTH COVERAGE FOR ALL
MEDI-CAL MEMBERS AND IN LIEU OF
REDUCING ELIGIBILITY, THE MAY
REVISION IS RECOMMENDING THE
SOLUTION, NOW TO ADDRESS THE
SECOND PART OF THE QUESTION, OF
HOW OR YEAH, AS IF THE
ADMINISTRATION CONSIDERED THE
POTENTIAL HIGHER COSTS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO LOSE ACCESS TO
IHSS AND IF THEY MAY RELY ON
INSTITUTIONAL CARE, AT THIS
TIME, WE DON'T HAVE ANY
ESTIMATES, BUT WE'LL WORK TO
MAKE SURE WE PUT FORTH A
BALANCED BUDGET TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN SUBSEQUENT YEARS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. XUAN XUAN.
YES. JOANNE DREIER, LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OFFICE, SO FOR US, JUST
OVERALL, WE'RE ALWAYS MONITORING
UTILIZATION RATES AND CASELOADS
AND ALWAYS MAKING SURE THAT WHAT
IS BUDGETED IS IN LINE WITH
UTILIZATION RATES FOR THIS
ELIMINATION OF THE IHSS UNDER
POPULATION FOR ALL AGES, FIRST,
WE WILL NOTE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCED THE ESTIMATE OF WHAT
WOULD COST FOR THE IHS
UNDOCUMENT POPULATION, REDUCING
IT FROM HUNDREDS OF MILLION
DOLLARS IN JANUARY TO LESS THAN
$100 MILLION, AS AS OF THE MAY
REVISE. SO WE'RE CURRENTLY
TRACKING, AND TAKING A CLOSER
LOOK AT THESE ESTIMATES. OTHER
PRIMARY QUESTIONS KIND OF
REVOLVE AROUND WHAT'S ALREADY
BEEN DISCUSSED, REGARDING THE
ARPA, ARPA, ADDITIONALLY, HOW
IT'S GOING TO BE OPERATIONALIZED
, GOING FORWARD, AS WELL AS THE
OTHER RESOURCES AND BENEFITS
THAT THESE, POPULATIONS ARE
GOING TO BE, ELIGIBLE FOR AND AT
A HIGHER LEVEL. WE DO HAVE
QUESTIONS AROUND THE
IMPLICATIONS OF ELIMINATING
MEDI-CAL BENEFITS FOR A SPECIFIC
GROUP OF RECIPIENTS. FOR
EXAMPLE, HAS THIS BEEN DONE
ANYWHERE ELSE IN MEDI-CAL, AND
HOW WAS IT DECIDED FOR IHSS
BENEFIT TO BE THE COMPONENT OF
THE PROGRAM ELIMINATED, FOR THE
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION? IF THE
IF THERE WERE OTHER BENEFITS
CONSIDERED, AS FAR AS THE CAREER
PATHWAYS, WE'LL WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ON, MONITORING THE
APRIL NUMBERS AND WORK WITH THE,
AND GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT. AND
THEN JUST TOUCHING ON THE
ELIMINATION OF THE PERMANENT
BACK-UP PROVIDER SYSTEM, WE DID
NOTE DURING OUR EVALUATION OF
THE JANUARY PROPOSAL THAT, THE
UTILIZATION RATES WERE LOWER
THAN EXPECTED, AND THERE WAS
ROOM TO CREATE SAVINGS. THE
DEPARTMENT DID, REDUCE THEIR
ESTIMATE BEFORE PROPOSING TO
ELIMINATE THE PROGRAM OVERALL.
BUT WE ARE LOOKING AT THESE
UPDATED ESTIMATES TO SEE IF WE
COULD, REDUCE OR RIGHTSIZE THE
PROGRAM FURTHER TO CREATE
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS WITHOUT,
LIKE, COMPLETELY ELIMINATING THE
PROGRAM, AND SO WE'LL GET BACK
TO YOU ON THAT AS WELL. OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. PUBLIC
COMMENT ON IHSS. FIND THE MIC.
YOU. YOU WILL HAVE 45 SECONDS AS
SOON AS I GET TO EACH. PERFECT.
ALL RIGHT. WHERE ARE WE? ALL
RIGHT HERE. THERE YOU GO. HELLO,
SENATORS, MY NAME IS WARREN
CUSHMAN. COMMUNITY RESOURCES FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING IN HAYWARD. I
TOOK A WHILE, TOOK A BIT OF A
JOURNEY TO GET UP HERE. I FROM
HAYWARD, I WANT TO SAY THAT THE
IHSS DISCUSSION TODAY AROUND THE
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION IS JUST
SHOCKING. THE FACT THAT WE WOULD
IN OUR STATE CONSIDER THAT
CONSIDER CUTTING OFF AN ENTIRE
GROUP OF FOLKS FROM IHSS WOULD
JUST BE UNCONSCIONABLE. IT WOULD
BE, SOMETHING I CAN'T EVEN
FATHOM. AND I ABSOLUTELY HOPE
THAT WE WILL NOT GO DOWN THAT
ROAD. IT IS A SERIOUS BREACH OF
TRUST FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES, AND I HOPE WE
DON'T GO THERE. THANK YOU SIR.
YEAH. KEVIN ESTÁN COALITION,
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION. THE TEN DAY NOTICE
IS A MINIMUM REQUIRED BY FEDERAL
LAW. THE STATE LEGISLATURE COULD
DECIDE TO DO 30 DAYS. AND
THERE'S NOT NOTHING THAT
PREVENTS YOU FROM DOING THAT.
AND FOR THE RECORD, I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO SAY THAT WE OPPOSE ALL
THE CALWORKS CUTS. I FORGOT THAT
LAST TIME. THANK YOU. SORRY.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, MY NAME IS
MOHAMMED RASHID. I'M A
SELF-ADVOCATE IN STANISLAUS
COUNTY. I JUST ASKED IS A
PROGRAM THAT SUPPORTS ALL PEOPLE
DOCUMENTED AND UNDOCUMENTED,
WITH DISABILITIES TO LIVE
INTERDEPENDENTLY IN THE
COMMUNITY. K¾T IT ALLOWS THOSE
WITH FAMILY MEMBERS TO STILL
HAVE INCOME IN AS THEY PROVIDE
CARE FOR THEIR FAMILIES, WHILE
HELPING TO CLOSE THE GAP FIRST.
THE GAP OF THE SHORTAGE FOR
PROVIDERS, PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES THAT DO NOT HAVE
FAMILY TO PROVIDE CARE BACK.
THAT DO NOT PROVIDE CARE BACK,
REGISTRY RELIEVES THE ANXIETY
AND REMOVES THE BURDEN OF
PROVIDERS. IT ENSURES THE VITAL
CARE AND CARE CAN TO BE PROVIDED
THERE BY KEEPING INDIVIDUALS IN
THEIR HOMES AND COMMUNITY, AND
OUT OF MORE EXPENSIVE CARE
FACILITIES THAT HAVE LIMITED
SPACE AND RESTRICTIVE PLACEMENT
OPTIONS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU SIR. GOOD
MORNING, KIM ROTHSCHILD,
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES FOR IHSS, AND WE'RE
HERE, TO ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM
THE LÀ, WE'D LIKE TO WORK WITH
CDSS, AS WELL AS THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ON RIGHTSIZING THE
BACKUP PROVIDER PROGRAM SO THAT
FOLKS ARE NOT COMPLETELY,
WITHOUT CARE OR CUT OFF. THIS
COULD RESULT IN MORE COSTLY
SERVICES AS WELL AS FEAR AND
ANXIETY AROUND NOT HAVING CARE
AND ENDING UP IN URGENT CARE OR
ERS, SO WITH THAT, WE'D LIKE
CONSIDERATION OF MAINTAINING
SOME LEVEL OF FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, DAN
OCKENFELS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS. JUST A FEW WORDS
ABOUT WHAT IHSS MEANS FOR OUR
COMMUNITY, THE INDEPENDENT
LIVING MOVEMENT AND IHSS THE
KIND OF SHARE THE SAME DNA. IT'S
ALL ABOUT, CRITICAL NEEDS FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES TO STAY
OUT OF, MORE EXPENSIVE, NURSING
FACILITIES AND REMAIN PRODUCTIVE
IN THEIR HOMES AND COMMUNITIES,
WE'RE ALREADY DESPERATE FOR
QUALITY CARE, GIVERS, WHICH
WHICH ARE HARD TO RECRUIT FOR
THESE POSITIONS, LOW WAGES AND
HIGH TURNOVER AND INSUFFICIENT,
YOU KNOW, HOURS FOR THE
CONSUMERS THAT RELY ON THESE
IHSS SERVICES, THE CONSUMERS,
SOME OF THEM ARE OFTEN THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN OUR SOCIETY,
SUFFER WHEN THESE CUTS HAPPEN
AND LIVE IN FEAR OF LOSING THEIR
PROVIDERS AND NOT BEING ABLE TO
FIND THEIR REPLACEMENTS. AND
FINALLY, I BELIEVE THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR MENTIONED THAT ON THE
IHSS, BENEFITS BASED ON
PROCREATION. SHE SAID 3000
INDIVIDUALS AFFECTED. THAT'S,
TEN TIMES THE CAPACITY OF THIS
ROOM. THANK YOU. Ó. HELLO.
RAYLAN AGUADO WITH THE FILIPINO
WORKER CENTER AND COURAGE HOME
CARE COOPERATIVE. WE ARE DEEPLY
ALARMED THAT THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION INCLUDES THE
ELIMINATION OF IHSS BENEFIT
BENEFIT FOR UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS IN MEDI-CAL. THIS
ELIMINATION ALSO PUTS A
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC BURDEN ON
FAMILY CAREGIVERS, WHO MAY NOW
HAVE TO LEAVE THE WORKFORCE TO
PROVIDE THAT CARE AND
UNCOMPENSATED FAMILY CAREGIVERS
ARE OFTEN LOW INCOME WOMEN OF
COLOR, AND IF THEY MUST LEAVE
THE PAID WORKFORCE TO PROVIDE
CARE TO THEIR AGING AND DISABLED
FAMILY MEMBERS. THIS PROPOSAL
WILL EXACERBATE ECONOMIC
DISPARITIES. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. REBECCA SALAS WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. I WANT TO ECHO SOME OF
THE COMMENTS ABOUT, THE CUTS TO
THE IHSS PROGRAM BEING A PUBLIC
CHARGE ISSUE ABOUT IT, RESULTING
IN MORE INSTITUTIONAL CARE,
WHICH IS MORE EXPENSIVE. AND
ALSO IT WOULD HARM WORKERS WHO
ARE PREDOMINANTLY WOMEN OF
COLOR. WE BELIEVE CALIFORNIA
SHOULD NOT TURN ITS BACK ON THE
HISTORIC MEDI-CAL COVERAGE
EXPANSION AND TREAT PEOPLE
DIFFERENTLY BASED ON THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS. GIVEN THE
PROPOSED CUTS TARGET IMMIGRANT
AND DISABILITY COMMUNITIES, WE
BELIEVE THESE CUTS VIOLATE THE
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT
AND THE SUPREME COURT'S DECISION
IN OLMSTEAD, THE EQUAL
PROTECTION CLAUSE OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION AND
CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNMENT CODE,
SECTION 11135, WE ARE EXPLORING
LITIGATION OPTIONS AT THIS
MOMENT. THANK YOU. THANKS,
REBECCA. OH, JESUS, I WAS GOING
TO I WAS GOING TO DO THE POWER.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. MALIK
BYNUM WITH US ASKED ME LOCAL
3930, REPRESENTING IHSS
PROVIDERS IN 21 COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. ALSO
COMMENTING ON BEHALF OF MY SEIU
COUNTERPART, TIFFANY WHITTON,
WHO REPRESENTS HOME CARE
PROVIDERS IN THE OTHER 37
COUNTIES, IT TRULY IS
DISAPPOINTING TO SEE THE
EXPANSION OF IHSS TO
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS CLAWED
BACK, AS WELL AS THE REDUCED
FUNDING FOR THE CAREER PATHWAYS
PROGRAM. BUT EVEN FURTHER, THE
PROPOSED ELIMINATION OF THE
BACKUP PROVIDER SYSTEM IN ITS
ENTIRETY. THESE CUTS AREN'T JUST
GOING TO BE HARMFUL TO OUR
WORKERS. THIS IS GOING TO BE
DEVASTATING FOR CONSUMERS OF
EXCESS AND THEIR FAMILIES ACROSS
THE STATE. AND, YOU KNOW, WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE BUDGET
ISN'T IN GOOD SHAPE FOR ANYBODY
THIS YEAR. BUT IT IS UNFAIR AND
UNJUST FOR US TO KEEP BALANCING
THE BUDGET ON THE BACKS OF OUR
PROVIDERS, CARING FOR THOSE WHO
NEED IT MOST. YOU KNOW, OUR
AGING DISABILITY OR AGING
POPULATION AND THOSE LIVING WITH
DISABILITIES. SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE COMMITTEE
AND THE LEGISLATURE TO REJECT
THESE PROPOSALS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THE DOT. HELLO AGAIN.
CHAIR MEMBERS. JANICE O'MALLEY
ASKED ME. CALIFORNIA. I JUST
WANT TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH
OUR AFSCME AFFILIATE, UW LOCAL
3930, BECAUSE OF THE DEVASTATING
IMPACT TO PROVIDERS AND
CONSUMERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CHRISTINE SMITH WITH HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA ALSO URGING
THE LEGISLATURE TO PUSH BACK ON
THESE PROPOSED CUTS THAT
UNFAIRLY TARGET IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES, INCLUDING THIS
PROPOSAL FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED. AND THE PROPOSAL
UNDERMINES THE HEALTH FOR ALL
PROGRAM BY SPECIFICALLY ROLLING
BACK EXISTING SERVICES FOR THIS
POPULATION, IT IS ESSENTIAL
CARE, AS HAS BEEN NOTED, AND
ALSO COULD REVOLT. REYES REMOVAL
OF THIS FUNDING COULD RESULT IN
FURTHER IMPOVERISHMENT AND
INCREASE STATE SPENDING ON
EXPENSIVE NURSING HOME CARE. AND
ALSO, AS NOTED, EXPOSES PEOPLE
WHO ARE UNDOCUMENTED TO PUBLIC
CHARGE IF THEY WERE TO RESULT IN
A NURSING HOME. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS. KATHY
MCDONNELL FOR ALAMEDA COUNTY,
ECHOING THE COMMENTS OF THE
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES REGARDING THE
BACKUP PROVIDER SYSTEM AND
URGING CONSIDERATION THAT THIS
PROGRAM BE MAINTAINED DUE TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF IT, AS WELL AS
EXPRESSING CONCERNS ABOUT THE
EFFECTS OF ELIMINATING THE
SERVICES FOR UNDOCUMENTED
RECIPIENTS OF IHSS. AND ALSO
THINKING ABOUT PROVIDING FULL
SCOPE COVERAGE TO THIS GROUP.
BUT YET CARVING OUT THIS ONE SET
OF SERVICES DOESN'T ACTUALLY
MAKE A LOT OF SENSE IN THE
PROVISION OF A ROBUST HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM, WHICH IS REALLY THE
POINT OF HEALTH CARE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, RONALD COLEMAN HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK, KHN, WE
IMPLORE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S
DISCRIMINATORY PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE IHSS SERVICES FOR THE
UNDOCUMENTED. IT IS INDEFENSIBLE
THAT GOVERNOR NEWSOM TO
ELIMINATE THESE SERVICES FOR A
POPULATION FOR NO REASON BUT FOR
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS,
SEGREGATING WHICH CALIFORNIANS
ARE ELIGIBLE AND WHO ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE IS UNCONSCIONABLE. IT
IS 2024. IT'S CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR'S SO-CALLED CALIFORNIA
FOR ALL, AND THIS HAS VILE
UNDERTONES OF PROP 187. AND IT'S
RIGHT OUT OF DONALD TRUMP'S
PLAYBOOK. WITHOUT IHSS, THESE
INDIVIDUALS WILL NEED COSTLY AND
PREVENTABLE HOSPITAL AND NURSING
HOME CARE AND FAMILY CAREGIVERS
WILL GO WITHOUT PAY. THIS WILL
PERPETUATE A GENERATIONAL CYCLE
OF POVERTY. WE UNDERSTAND THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO MAKE VERY
DIFFICULT DECISIONS RIGHT NOW,
BUT WE ASK YOU TO REJECT THIS
CUT AND STAND UP AND DO NOT PUT
DISCRIMINATORY PROPOSALS IN
STATUTE AND STAND UP FOR EQUITY.
THANK YOU. LOOK, I STOOD UP.
GOOD MORNING, JACKIE GONZALEZ,
POLICY DIRECTOR OF IMMIGRANT
DEFENSE ADVOCATES. I HUMBLY
OFFER MY OPINION ALSO AS AN
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY, THAT THIS
WOULD RESULT IN A PUBLIC CHARGE.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS ALSO
TAKEN A POSITION ON WHAT
CONSTITUTES A PUBLIC CHARGE ON
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES WEBSITE, WHERE I
READ, PUBLIC CHARGE IS DEFINED
AS A NON-CITIZEN WHO IS LIKELY
TO BECOME PRIMARILY DEPENDENT ON
THE GOVERNMENT FOR SUPPORT BY
RECEIVING EITHER CASH ASSISTANCE
OR BEING INSTITUTED ANALYZED FOR
LONG TERM CARE AT A GOVERNMENT
EXPENSE. SO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS AWARE THAT THIS
WOULD RESULT IN A PUBLIC CHARGE,
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO CLARIFY
WHAT PUBLIC CHARGE MEANS,
BECAUSE WE'RE THROWING IT
AROUND. PUBLIC CHARGE COULD LEAD
TO THE INADMISSIBILITY OF
SOMEONE, WHICH WOULD PREVENT
THEM FROM BECOMING A LAWFUL
PERMANENT RESIDENT, MAKING THEM
ELIGIBLE FOR OTHER SERVICES THAT
THEY NEED IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES WITHIN FIVE YEARS
OF ADMISSION. IT CAN ALSO RESULT
IN DEPORTATION. AND I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT HAS NO ISSUE
DEPORTING PEOPLE WHO ARE
DISABLED OR IN A WHEELCHAIR OR
SUFFER OTHER DISABILITIES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
VANESSA CAJINA ON BEHALF OF
COMPROMISO, THE STATEWIDE
NETWORK OF PROMOTORAS AND
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE HHS CUTS TO
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS. THANK
YOU, EMERALD EVANS HERE WITHIN
CHILD POVERTY CALIFORNIA, WE
ALIGN WITH SEIU AND WKOP AGAINST
THE PROPOSED CUTS AND DELAYS TO
IHSS, REGARDING THE BENEFIT FOR
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS, WE
UNDERSCORE THE DEEP INEQUITIES
THAT THIS WILL CREATE AND THAT
MANY OF THESE MANY IMPACT, MANY
OF THESE PEOPLE WHO WILL BE
IMPACTED WILL BE ALSO CHILDREN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. CHAIR MEMBERS ANDREA
VISCO, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER, I WANT TO FIRST ECHO
SOME OF THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE
FILIPINO WORKER CENTER AND
OTHERS REGARDING WHO TENDS TO
SERVE AS CAREGIVERS AND THE
IMPACTS THAT THIS WOULD HAVE ON
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES. THE
PROPOSED PERMANENT ELIMINATION
OF IHSS FOR UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS UNFAIRLY TARGETS
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES AND
UNDERMINES THE AIM OF THE HEALTH
FOR ALL PROGRAM. THIS IS NOT A
DELAY OR SCALING BACK. THIS IS A
FULL REMOVAL OF BENEFITS THAT
PEOPLE ARE RECEIVING RIGHT NOW.
IHSS PROVIDES ESSENTIAL CARE
THAT ALLOWS THOUSANDS OF SENIORS
AND PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES TO
REMAIN SAFELY IN THEIR HOMES AS
AN ALTERNATIVE TO OUT-OF-HOME
CARE. REMOVAL OF THIS FUNDING
COULD RESULT IN FURTHER
IMPOVERISHMENT AMONG OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITY MEMBERS. AS
WELL AS INCREASED STATE FUNDING.
OUR STATE SPENDING ON EXPENSIVE
NURSING CARE. WE RESPECTFULLY
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO REJECT
THE PROPOSED CUTS TO THIS
CRITICAL INVESTMENT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR, AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS RUSSELL
DAWSON RAWLINGS AND I AM THE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING MANAGER AT
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS. AND
AS MY COLLEAGUE AND OTHERS HAVE
TESTIFIED, THESE CUTS HAVE DEEP
IMPACT. I WANT YOU TO SEE THE
FACE OF SOMEONE WHO HAS
BENEFITED FROM HAVING ACCESS TO
PROGRAMS SUCH AS IN-HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. I MYSELF
CAME TO CALIFORNIA IN 2001, AND
I CAN ALSO TELL YOU THAT WHAT
THESE HARD DECISIONS LOOK LIKE,
WAITING FOR ACCESS TO PROGRAMS
SUCH AS IHSS OR BEING DENIED
ACCESS TO THE PROGRAM MEANS
THOSE HARD DECISIONS INCLUDE
GOING TO OUR ERS, I MYSELF HAD A
PERIOD WHERE I WAS INELIGIBLE
BECAUSE MY BENEFITS HAD NOT YET
STARTED IN CALIFORNIA, AND THOSE
WERE THE DECISIONS I HAD TO MAKE
WAS GOING INTO THE ER JUST TO
SIMPLY GET WASHED UP AND TO MAKE
IT OUT OF BED IN THE MORNING. SO
THIS IS THESE ARE THE REAL
IMPACTS THAT YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
FOR UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS, IF
THEY LOSE ACCESS TO THIS PROGRAM
. I ALSO REALLY WONDER ABOUT A
TEN DAY NOTICE PERIOD, ALSO,
BECAUSE THE IN-HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAM OPERATES ON A
MONTHLY PAY SCHEDULE OR, TWICE
MONTHLY. SO I'M WONDERING ABOUT
UNPAID WAGES TO PEOPLE
POTENTIALLY UNFAIRLY, IF THE
PROGRAM WERE CHANGED. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, YEAH. THANKS. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE, MY NAME IS
KHALID RASHID. I'M FROM
STANISLAUS COUNTY. AS A IHSS
BACKUP PROVIDER FOR MY BROTHER,
I KNOW WHAT IT IS TO HAVE
SECURITY, TO KNOW THAT MY
BROTHER WILL BE CARED FOR WHEN
MY MOM NEEDS A BREAK, TO KNOW
THAT OTHERS DON'T HAVE THAT
SECURITY WORRIES ME. IT ALSO
GIVES ME ANXIETY IF I OR MY MOM
ARE NOT AROUND TO PROVIDE CARE
FOR MY BROTHER. AS A PERSON WITH
A DISABILITY, MYSELF, TO KNOW
THAT WHEN I NEED CARE THAT I
WILL NOT HAVE A BACKUP REGISTRY
TO BACK ME UP SCARES ME. PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDERS ARE ALREADY
LIMITED TO NARROW. TO NARROW
THAT DOWN, EVEN MORE. MAKES NO
SENSE. DISABILITY DOES NOT
DISCRIMINATE. WE NEED TO HAVE A
SYSTEM THAT WILL BE READY TO
CARE FOR ALL DOCUMENTED AND
UNDOCUMENTED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
MICHAELA DUPONT. I'M ALSO A
RESIDENT OF STANISLAUS COUNTY.
IHSS PROVIDES ESSENTIAL,
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TO
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES TO
ALLOW ALL TO REMAIN IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. CAREGIVERS ARE
ALREADY IN SHORTAGE IN THIS
PROGRAM, AND ELIMINATING THE
BACKUP SYSTEM PUTS ELDERLY AND
DEPENDENT ADULTS AT RISK FOR
MORE COSTLY INSTITUTIONAL OR
HOSPITAL PLACEMENT. CONTINUOUS
CARE IS CRITICAL TO ENSURE
INDIVIDUALS REMAIN IN THEIR
HOMES DESPITE POTENTIAL GAPS IN
PRIMARY CARE, WHICH ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS TO ALSO CONTINUE
ACCESSING THEIR COMMUNITIES, AND
EVEN BEING ABLE TO TAKE AN
ACTIVE ROLE IN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES AND
EMPLOYMENT. I URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PLEASE REJECT
THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. THANKS
MY NAME IS ELLA ROBERTS. I'M A
RETIRED STATE WORKER. I RETIRED
DISABILITY, RETIRED IN 1999. MY
HUSBAND BECAME VERY DISABLED
WITH PARKINSON'S. I HAD TO TAKE
CARE OF HIM EVEN THOUGH I'M
DISABLED MYSELF. WE DON'T NEED
CUTS. ANY CUTS TO DISABLED
SERVICES OR IHSS. WE WERE NOT
ELIGIBLE. I'M A RETIRED CLERK.
HE'S A RETIRED GROUNDSKEEPER. HE
JUST DIED IN JANUARY, WE MADE
TOO MUCH. WE WERE NOT ELIGIBLE.
I'M HAVING TO HIRE PEOPLE OUT OF
MY POCKET, AND I GET PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT TRAINED. IT'S BEEN A
NIGHTMARE. I DID MANAGE TO KEEP
THEM HOME UNTIL HE DIED. HE
DIDN'T WANT TO DIE IN A NURSING
HOME. NO CUTS. INSTEAD, CLOSE 15
OF THE PRISONS AND DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THE OIL SUBSIDIES. THANK
YOU. HI, I'M MIN CHANG, I'M CEO
FOR HOMEBRIDGE. HOMEBRIDGE IS
THE MAIN PROVIDER FOR CAREER
PATHWAYS, AND TO DATE WE'VE
TRAINED ACTUALLY OVER 28,000
CARE CAREGIVERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ACROSS ALL 58
COUNTIES. SO WE'RE VERY PROUD OF
IT. AS YOU KNOW, TRAINING IS
SUCH AN IMPORTANT PART OF
ACTUALLY PROVIDING QUALITY CARE
TO THE CLIENTS AND THE CUSTOMERS
THAT YOU'VE HEARD FROM. AND SO
WE URGE YOU TO CONTINUE THE
FUNDING NOT ONLY THROUGH THIS
CALENDAR YEAR, BUT THROUGH THE
FISCAL YEAR AS WELL. THE DEMAND
HAS ONLY BEEN INCREASING. JUST
AS AN EXAMPLE, IN THE MONTH OF
APRIL, WE'VE HAD 30,000 PEOPLE
REGISTER. SO THE NEED IS
ABSOLUTELY THERE. SO I ENCOURAGE
YOU TO RETHINK THAT AS WELL. IF
THERE ARE QUESTIONS THAT WE CAN
ANSWER. I AM VERY HAPPY TO SET
UP SOME SEPARATE TIME AND ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. ALSO PROVIDE SOME
CONTEXT. WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH CDSS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO DO THAT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AARON SABERI
ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF
HOMEBRIDGE, I WANT TO THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. AND, THIS COMMITTEE
, FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF IHSS AND
FOR ALL SERVING OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CITIZENS. I ALSO
WANTED TO JUST WEIGH IN ON
BEHALF OF CAREER PATHWAYS AND
THE INCREASING DEMAND THAT WE'RE
SEEING EVEN IN THE LAST FEW
WEEKS. AND SO WE HAVE NO DOUBT
THAT THE MONEY THAT, DIRECTOR
RAMSEY SAID COULD BE SPENT,
WOULD BE SPENT. AND WE'RE ALSO,
HOPING, EVEN THOUGH IT'S A TOUGH
YEAR TO EXTEND THIS PROGRAM,
WHICH IS AFFECTING HAS CAPACITY
TO AFFECT OVER MORE THAN HALF A
MILLION CALIFORNIANS. AND AS THE
WOMAN BEFORE, CEO CHANG SPOKE,
TRAINING IS SO CRITICAL, FOLKS
ARE ON THE FRONT LINES OF OUR
COGNITIVE AND, AND, ALZHEIMER'S
ISSUES AND REALLY NEED THIS
TRAINING AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. KELLY LONGO FLORES WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THE ELIMINATION OF IHSS
BENEFITS BASED ON IMMIGRATION
STATUS. ALL CALIFORNIANS DESERVE
TO LIVE IN THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT POSSIBLE. THANK YOU.
THANKS THANK YOU. HELLO. JESSICA
LEHMANN, DISABILITY AND AGING
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER. I AM AN
EMPLOYER OF HOME ATTENDANTS
MYSELF AND IT HAS GOTTEN HARDER
AND HARDER TO HIRE ATTENDANTS.
HAVING DECENT RATES, HAVING
PROVIDER BACKUP, HAVING CAREER
PATHWAYS ARE ALL ABOUT HAVING
THE STRONG WORKFORCE WE NEED TO
KEEP US IN THE COMMUNITY WHERE
WE CAN COME AND BE PART OF
THINGS, AND NOT IN NURSING
HOMES. THIS IS ACTUALLY A LIFE
OR DEATH MATTER. I DO KNOW
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
GET THE ATTENDANCE THEY NEED,
WHO HAVE CYCLED IN AND OUT OF
NURSING FACILITIES AND HAVE
KILLED THEMSELVES BECAUSE IT IS
SO MISERABLE. I AM NOT
EXAGGERATING. WE CANNOT MAKE
CUTS TO IHSS WHEN SOMEONE ASKED
ME WHY ARE THEY PROPOSING CUTS
TO UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE, ALL I
COULD THINK WAS THAT IT IS, OF
COURSE, ONE OF THE GROUPS THAT
IS PROBABLY THE LEAST ABLE TO
SAFELY FIGHT FOR THEIR RIGHTS.
IBRAM KENDI SAYS THAT EVERY
ACTION IS EITHER RACIST OR
ANTI-RACIST, AND IT'S PRETTY
CLEAR WHICH WAY THIS PROPOSAL
GOES. PLEASE REJECT ALL THE
PROPOSED CUTS TO IHSS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO, MADAM
CHAIR AND TO THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS MONICA KIRKLAND. I AM
THE STATE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
SENIOR SERVICES COALITION OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY. WE OFFER A IT'S
ABOUT 39 NONPROFIT AND,
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS THAT
OFFER HEALTH AND DIFFERENT
SOCIAL SUPPORTS TO ABOUT 89
OLDER ADULTS WITHIN THE COUNTY.
AND WE STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
REJECT THE CUTS TO THE IHSS,
CAREER PATHWAY PROGRAM. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. YASMIN PELLETT, ON
BEHALF OF JUSTICE AND AGING, WE
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE
PROPOSED CUT OF IHSS FOR
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS, AND
REALLY, WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, WHEN
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE COMMITTED TO
EXPANDING MEDI-CAL TO ALL IN
CALIFORNIA, REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS, THAT MEANT
EXPANDING ALL OF MEDI-CAL, WHICH
INCLUDES IN-HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES. SO TO SUGGEST THAT
JUST BECAUSE THEY CAN HAVE THE
REST OF THE RANGE OF MEDI-CAL
SERVICES, THAT THIS IS NOT A
DETRIMENTAL CUT IS REALLY
DISINGENUOUS, ALSO ALARMED THAT
THERE DIDN'T SEEM TO BE AN
ACKNOWLEDGMENT OR AN
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PUBLIC
CHARGE CONSIDERATION WHEN THESE
FOLKS POTENTIALLY MAY HAVE TO,
END UP IN NURSING FACILITIES,
WHICH IS, LIKE EVERYONE HAS SAID
BEFORE ME, A MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE
PLACE TO END UP. SO WE ARE ALSO
OPPOSED TO THE CUT TO THE IHSS
BACKUP PROVIDER SYSTEM. THANK
YOU.
MOVING INTO CALFRESH AND FOOD
PROGRAMS
.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. JENNIFER
TROIA FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES, YOU'VE ASKED US
TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF MAY
REVISION SOLUTIONS RELATED TO
CALFRESH AND FOOD PROGRAMS. SO I
WILL BEGIN BY DOING THAT, THERE
ARE THREE, THREE PROPOSALS THAT
I WILL HIGHLIGHT. THE FIRST IS
THE EXPANSION OF THE CFAP, OR
THE DELAY OF THE CFAP EXPANSION
OR THE CALIFORNIA FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM, AS YOU WILL
PROBABLY RECALL, THE LEGISLATURE
AND GOVERNOR RECENTLY AGREED TO
EXPAND THE CFAP PROGRAM TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS AGED 55 AND OLDER,
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
. THIS PROPOSAL EXTENDS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT PROGRAM
BY TWO YEARS, SO IT WOULD MOVE
FROM OCTOBER 1ST, 2025.
IMPLEMENTATION TO OCTOBER 1ST,
2027, AND CORRESPONDINGLY RESULT
IN GENERAL FUND SAVINGS. THERE
ARE NO IMMEDIATE IMPACTS IN
TERMS OF LOSSES OF BENEFITS FOR
PEOPLE ELIGIBLE FOR CFAP WHO ARE
CURRENTLY RECEIVING THEM,
BECAUSE, AGAIN, THE PROGRAM HAS
NOT YET THE EXPANSION HAS NOT
YET BEEN IMPLEMENTED. HOWEVER OF
COURSE, WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD OTHERWISE
HAVE BEEN SERVED BEGINNING IN
2025 WOULD BE WAITING TO BE
SERVED UNTIL 2027. PRIOR
ESTIMATES INDICATED THAT AROUND
75,000 PEOPLE WOULD RECEIVE CFAP
DURING THE FIRST YEAR OF THE
EXPANSION. THOSE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE FOR THE CFAP
PROGRAM, APPROXIMATELY 45,000
INDIVIDUALS WOULD CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE CFAP WITH NO CHANGES.
THE SECOND PROPOSAL TO HIGHLIGHT
IS THE MINIMUM NUTRITION BENEFIT
PILOT. THIS PROGRAM WAS ENACTED
AS A PART OF THE 2023 BUDGET TO
ASSIST IN CLOSING THE PROJECTED
BUDGET SHORTFALL. THE PROPOSAL
IS TO ELIMINATE THE PILOT
PROGRAM, WHICH WOULD HAVE ISSUED
SUPPLEMENTAL STATE FUNDED
CALFRESH BENEFITS TO RAISE THE
MINIMUM BENEFIT FROM 23 TO $50.
THE PILOT PROGRAM HAS NOT YET
BEEN IMPLEMENTED, SO THERE ARE
NO IMMEDIATE LOSSES OF BENEFITS
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
OTHERWISE RECEIVING THEM. THE
FINAL PROPOSAL TO HIGHLIGHT IS
THE WORK INCENTIVE NUTRITION
SUPPLEMENT PROGRAM THAT THIS
PROPOSAL RESULTS IN AN
ANTICIPATED REDUCTION OF $25
MILLION IN BEGINNING IN 2025,
AND ONGOING. THE WINS PROGRAM OR
WORK INCENTIVE, NUTRITIONAL
SUPPLEMENT PROVIDES A
SUPPLEMENTAL $10 PER MONTH FOOD
BENEFIT IDENTIFIED AS A FORM OF
TANF ASSISTANCE TO CALFRESH
HOUSEHOLDS WHO ARE NOT RECEIVING
CALWORKS. IN THE PAST, THIS HAS
ALLOWED US TO MEET OUR TANF WORK
PARTICIPATION RATE BY BEING ABLE
TO COUNT THOSE INDIVIDUALS IN
THE CALCULATION FOR THE WORKER,
BECAUSE THE RECENT FEDERAL
FISCAL RESPONSIBILITY ACT
PROVIDES ENOUGH CASELOAD
REDUCTION CREDIT FOR THE STATE
TO MEET THE ALL FAMILIES WPPR,
WE NO LONGER NEED THE WINDS
PROGRAM TO SERVE THAT PURPOSE.
HAVING SAID THAT, THE
ELIMINATION OF THE WINDS WILL
RESULT IN THE LOSS OF FOOD
BENEFITS OF $10 PER MONTH PER
HOUSEHOLD FOR JUST OVER 100,000
CALIFORNIANS. WE'RE COMING AFTER
EVERYTHING. THAT'S $1,010 EACH.
THE SECOND ONE WAS MY BABY. THIS
WAS MY INITIATIVE LAST YEAR,
WE'VE CUT MOST OF THE ONES I
MADE DURING MY TIME, SO I SHOULD
GET USED TO THIS. OH, NO. NO, I
DON'T WANT TO. DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. WHAT IS THE. I GOTTA
SEE IF I CAN SEE IF I CAN SAVE
THIS. DELAYING IT TWO YEARS.
YES. SO YOU WANT TO KNOW THE
FISCAL FOR DELAYING TWO YEARS?
YEAH. WELL, I MEAN, IT WON'T
IMPACT US RIGHT NOW, RIGHT? WE
CAN STILL COME BACK AND WE'LL
REEVALUATE IN TWO YEARS. AND
THAT'S THE PLAN. SO
IMPLEMENTATION WILL BEGIN
OCTOBER 1ST, 2027 INSTEAD OF
OCTOBER 1ST, 2025. SO THIS WAS
PLANNED TO BEGIN IMPLEMENTATION
IN 2526. I'M SO SORRY. I'M SO
SORRY. I'M TALKING ABOUT THE
CALFRESH MINIMUM Ó MINIMUM
NUTRITION PROGRAM, THAT THIS IS
JUST A CUT OF THE MILLION ONE
TIME FUNDING. NO, NO, I KNOW, SO
WHAT COULD WE POTENTIALLY JUST
DELAY IT TWO YEARS? WE'RE HAPPY
TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS ON
ALTERNATIVES TO A COMPLETE CUT.
BUT FOR NOW THE BUDGET PROPOSES
THE MAYOR VISION PROPOSALS. IT
WON'T IMPACT US RIGHT. THERE'S
NOT YOU'RE NOT GOING TO SAY OH
NO, THAT'S WE STILL HAVE TO
ALLOCATE SOME MONEY FOR X, Y, Z.
JUST WANT TO KNOW IF DELAYING IT
FOR TWO YEARS IS A NET ZERO OR
NOT. SURE IF I'M LOOKING. IS IT
GOING TO COST US ANYTHING. YEAH.
SO, AND I'M KHN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, IF WE DID DELAY IT FOR
TWO YEARS AND WE WOULD HAVE TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE 15 MILLION IN
BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE, SO IT
WOULD HAVE COST IN BUDGET YEAR
PLUS ONE. NO, I'M TWO YEARS, SO.
RIGHT BUDGET YEAR PLUS TWO PLUS
TWO WHICH WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT
RIGHT NOW. RIGHT. WE'RE JUST
SOLVING FOR INCOMING PLUS ONE.
CORRECT. THE ADMINISTRATION
LOOKED AT BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE
RIGHT. JUST BUDGET SOLUTIONS.
YEAH. SO IF WE'RE LOOKING AT
BUDGET PLUS TWO IT HAS NO
IMPLICATIONS AS WELL. IT HAS
IMPLICATIONS IN THE OUT YEARS.
RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT. SO I'M
GOING TO TAKE THAT AS A NO.
THERE'S NO IMPACT FOR WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING TO SOLVE OF FISCAL YEAR.
LUDUS MORALES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WHILE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FOCUS WAS ON
PRODUCING A BALANCED BUDGET FOR
BUDGET YEAR PLUS BUDGET YEAR
PLUS ONE, WE DO KNOW THAT THERE
ARE STRUCTURAL DEFICITS IN SORT
OF THE OUT YEARS. AND SO AS WE
SORT OF LOOK TO MAKE ONGOING
REDUCTIONS TO THE BUDGET, IT IS
TO PROVIDE US A SOLID FOOTING
FOR THOSE OUT YEARS AS WELL. SO
AS AS THOUGH WE ARE NOT FULLY
SOLVING IT HELPS ADDRESS SORT OF
MULTIYEAR DEFICITS THAT WE KNOW
ARE WOULD PERSIST SHOULD WE NOT
TAKE THESE CORRECTIVE ACTIONS.
NOW, CAN YOU SHARE WITH ME, IF
WE'RE IF WE'RE SOLVING FOR TWO
YEARS, DOES NOT DOES THAT NOT
SOLVE THE STRUCTURAL PROBLEMS?
NO. SO WE UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
THE REVENUES AND EXPENDITURES
SORT OF DO NOT PUT US ON, ON
SOLID FOOTING, SORT OF UNDER
CURRENT EXPENDITURES THROUGH THE
MULTI YEAR PERIOD. SO THAT IS
THREE YEARS OUT BEYOND BUDGET
YEAR OKAY. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ALEJO. ANY
COMMENT ON THESE ISSUES. YES.
THANK YOU SONIA RUSSO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE, AS
IT RELATES TO THE FIRST TWO
PROPOSALS OF THE DELAY TO CFAP
EXPANSION AND THE REDUCTION IN
THE MINIMUM BENEFIT PILOT
PROGRAM, THESE DO IN GENERAL
ALIGN WITH OUR OVERALL
RECOMMENDATIONS AS AN OFFICE FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER,
DELAYS IN PROGRAMS THAT HAVE NOT
YET BEEN IMPLEMENTED OR
REDUCTIONS AGAIN IN PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE NOT YET BEEN
IMPLEMENTED, GIVEN, AS WAS
MENTIONED BY THE DEPARTMENT,
THAT THIS WILL NOT IMPACT THE
BENEFITS OF INDIVIDUALS
CURRENTLY RECEIVING BENEFITS.
HOWEVER, OF COURSE THERE ARE
TRADE OFFS TO THESE DECISIONS,
AND GIVEN THE BUDGET SITUATION,
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER THOSE TRADE OFFS AND
THE POTENTIAL FUTURE RECIPIENTS
IN ITS MANY PRIORITIES ACROSS
HUMAN SERVICES AND SOCIAL
SERVICES. SIMILARLY, AS IT
RELATES TO THE WINDS PROGRAM
ELIMINATION, WHILE AS THE
DEPARTMENT HAS MENTIONED, THE
WINDS PROGRAM IS UNLIKELY TO BE
NEEDED IN THE NEXT FEW YEARS TO
MEET THE STATE REQUIREMENTS, WE
DO HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT
MIGHT OCCUR IF LONGER TERM, WE
DID NEED A PROGRAM LIKE WINDS TO
MEET THE WPA REQUIREMENT. AGAIN,
AS WE SEEK INCREASING IN THE
COMING YEARS. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MOVING ON TO THE NEXT
ISSUE, ISSUE NUMBER SIX. APS
PANEL I JUST HAVE SPINAL
EVERYTHING.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR CLAIRE
RAMSEY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. I'M HERE TO
SPEAK ON ISSUE SIX. THE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES AND CS
HOUSING PROGRAMS. I WILL START
WITH THE CUTS TO THE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES EXPANSION.
THE BUDGET ACT OF 2021 MADE
STATUTORY CHANGES TO THE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM TO
LOWER THE APS ELIGIBILITY AGE
FOR OLDER ADULTS FROM 60 TO 6,
EXCUSE ME, 65 TO 60, AND
ADJUSTED THE ELIGIBILITY AGE FOR
DEPENDENT ADULTS TO AGE 18 TO
59. IT ALSO EXPANDED THE
DEFINITION OF SELF-NEGLECT TO
INCLUDE FINANCIAL MISMANAGEMENT
AND HOUSING INSECURITY. IT ALSO
ALLOWED FOR ADDITIONAL CASE
MANAGEMENT. THE CURRENT MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL PROPOSES A
DECREASE IN FUNDING FOR THE APS
EXPANSION OF $40 MILLION.
ONGOING THIS WOULD HELP TO
ASSIST WITH THE PROJECTED BUDGET
SHORTFALL. THE PROPOSAL LARGELY
IMPACTS COUNTIES, AND THEIR
ABILITY TO SERVE THE EXPANDED
POPULATION. SO IT IS NOT A
DIRECT, BENEFIT CUT TO ANY
INDIVIDUAL. BUT WE HAVE, HEARD
INDICATIONS FROM COUNTIES THAT
THERE MAY BE LAYOFFS ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS REDUCTION, WE WOULD
FLAG THERE ARE NO ALTERNATIVES
FOR APS FOR THIS POPULATION AND
APS IS REQUIRED TO TAKE ALL
CALLS ON A 24 HOUR HOTLINE AND
TO PERFORM AN IN-PERSON VISIT TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE CALLED FOR
ASSISTANCE, THE GROWTH IN APS
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS,
BETWEEN JANUARY 1ST, 2029 AND
JANUARY 1ST, 2023, HAS SEEN
APPROXIMATELY 20% INCREASE
OVERALL IN SERVICES PER MONTH
AND HAS HAD AN INCREASE IN
SERVICES TO INDIVIDUALS 60 TO
64, WE WERE ALSO ASKED ABOUT
EXPENDITURES AS COUNTIES DO
FULLY EXPEND, THESE FUNDS, WHICH
ARE CURRENTLY AT $70 MILLION. IF
THE PROPOSAL MOVES FORWARD, IT
CAN BECOME EFFECTIVE JULY 1ST,
2024. SINCE IT IS A REDUCTION IN
FUNDING AND NOT A CHANGE TO THE
AB 135 REQUIREMENTS, AND WE WILL
WORK WITH COUNTIES TO DETERMINE
ANY TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THEY
NEED TO MAKE THIS SHIFT AND TO
ADJUST THEIR STAFFING LEVELS.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS,
I'LL MOVE ON TO THE STATEWIDE
TRAINING PROGRAM. OR WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO. YEAH. ONE SECOND.
SURE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, I
THINK WE'VE I'VE, WE'VE HAD SOME
SIMILAR QUESTIONS ABOUT LIKE
WHAT UNFORESEEN INCREASES WE'RE
GOING TO SEE ACROSS A COUPLE OF
PROGRAMS THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
WHERE THERE'S A POTENTIAL FOR A
LOT OF LAYOFFS, THE FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH POTENTIALLY LAYING
OFF. I THINK IT WAS LIKE A
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS ACROSS
STATEWIDE LAYOFFS HERE, LAYOFFS
ELSEWHERE. THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY REQUEST
OR SEEK GOVERNMENTAL ASSISTANCE
IN OTHER PROGRAMS. INCREASING
OUR COSTS HAVE WE LOOKED INTO
THIS AND SEEN COMING NEXT YEAR
THAT ARE MEDI-CAL CASES WILL
INCREASE AND SO FORTH, WHERE OUR
COSTS WILL BE MUCH MORE THAN
WHAT THE CUTS WERE DOING.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, I THINK
WHAT YOU MENTIONED IS A POSSIBLE
POSSIBILITY, BUT AT THIS TIME WE
DON'T HAVE ANY ESTIMATES, AND I
THINK AS MY, COLLEAGUE MENTIONED
EARLIER, WE WILL MAKE WORK TO
MAKE SURE WE PUT FORTH A
BALANCED BUDGET IN FUTURE YEARS
TO THE LEGISLATURE. WHEN WE DO
THESE CUTS, IS THAT A VARIABLE
THAT WE LOOK AT? I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE STILL,
LOOKING AT AND WE CAN CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE IN PAST YEARS.
IS THAT A VARIABLE THAT WE'VE
LOOKED AT WHEN WE ARE PROPOSED
CUTS TO PROGRAMS? IS THAT A
VARIABLE THAT WE INCLUDE IN OUR
CALCULATION. NOT WHERE THEY WILL
DO IT. BUT IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN PART OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE APPROACH
FOR VARIOUS THINGS? OR HAVE WE
EVER GONE BACK TO THE TABLE
AFTER YEARS? AFTER YEARS SAYING,
HEY, WE CUT THIS. THIS IS A
DIRECT CORRELATION TO NOW WE'RE
SEEING AN INCREASE IN X, Y, Z. I
THINK I CAN TAKE THAT QUESTION
BACK AND GET BACK TO YOUR STAFF.
OKAY. I JUST YEAH, I GUESS,
MADAM CHAIR, IF I COULD ALSO
THIS I MEAN I'M WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT CUTTING SERVICES IHSS AND
FAMILY SUPPORT AND AT THE SAME
TIME, WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
CUTTING SERVICES TO APS AND CPS.
RIGHT. SO THOSE TWO THINGS HAVE
A DEFINITE RELATION, RIGHT? I
MEAN, THE AMOUNT OF STRESS AND
POVERTY ON A FAMILY AND THE LACK
OF HELP INCREASES ABUSE. I MEAN,
THAT'S THE NUMBERS DON'T LIE ON
THAT AT ALL. SO THAT'S ANOTHER
DIRECT CORRELATION. I WONDER IF
WE COULD, WE COULD LOOK AT AS
FAMILIES BECOME MORE STRESSED,
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE MORE ABUSE
AND INJURIES OCCUR, TO ALSO BE
ABLE TO THINK ABOUT HOW DO WE
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT INCURRING OTHER REALLY BIG
COSTS BOTH TO, TO, TO OUR
POCKETBOOKS AND, AND TO, OUR
MOST VULNERABLE? THESE ARE
PREVENTATIVE IN NATURE. MOST OF
THESE PROGRAMS. RIGHT THESE ARE
JUST TO HELP ASSIST, GET PEOPLE
BACK OFF THEIR FEET SO THEY NO
LONGER UTILIZE THESE SERVICES.
THE LONGER WE CUT ASSISTANCE,
THE LONGER THEY'LL BE ON THESE
PROGRAMS. SO I'M JUST WONDERING
IF WE'VE EVER DONE THIS KIND OF
CORRELATION THAT IF WE THE MORE
WE ASSIST IN THE BEGINNING, THE
LESS THEY'LL NEED SUPPORT ONCE
THEY GET OLDER OR DOWN THE LINE.
SO WHATEVER CAN BE BROUGHT BACK
ON ON THAT, FOR, FOR APS OR FOR
LIKE IN GENERAL, A LOT OF
PROGRAMS, YOU KNOW, I'VE HEARD
WELL, THESE ARE PROGRAMS THAT
JUST STARTED. AND SO FORTH, I
FEEL LIKE WE NEVER GIVE WE'RE
NOT, NOT NEVER. I FEEL LIKE
WE'RE NOT GIVING PROGRAMS ENOUGH
TIME OR WE PROVIDE THEM FOR A
COUPLE YEARS AND THEY'RE LIKE,
WELL, WE ONLY DID IT FOR TWO
YEARS. SO IT'S NOT REALLY A CORE
SERVICE. PEOPLE AREN'T REALLY
USED TO IT, BUT THE IMPACTS IN
THOSE SHORT YEARS ARE SO ARE
FANTASTIC THAT I CAN ONLY
IMAGINE HOW MUCH MORE WE CAN
REALLY HELP PEOPLE IF WE LET
THESE PROGRAMS GROW, AND WE'RE
NOT CUTTING THEM AT THE ROOT.
AND THE APS. YOU CAN IMAGINE
WITH THE INFLUX OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE GOING TO BE COMING OF
AGE INTO THIS THIRD PART OF
THEIR LIFE, WE NEED ALL THE
TYPES OF SERVICES AROUND THIS,
AROUND THIS DEMOGRAPHIC, THE
EXPANSION WAS FOR GOOD FOR A
GOOD REASON. I MEAN, WE DO THESE
THINGS AFTER EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES, AFTER STAKEHOLDER
DISCUSSIONS, AFTER XYZ. WE PUT
SO MUCH EFFORT INTO EXPANDING
THESE PROGRAMS BECAUSE WE KNOW
THERE'S A NEED AND THEN WE CUT
THEM OFF. AND, YOU KNOW,
ESSENTIALLY, I FEEL LIKE NEGATES
ALL THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE
LEADING UP TO THESE KIND OF
EXPANSIONS, NOTHING ELSE TO SAY
ON THAT. LÀ ANY COMMENTS ON
THESE ISSUES? JOANNE, OUR
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE. SO
FIRST WE WOULD JUST HIGHLIGHT,
WHAT WAS SAID ABOUT HOW THE
COUNTIES HAVE HISTORICALLY FULLY
SPENT THEIR ANNUAL APS
ALLOCATION AND THUS ANY CUTS
WILL LIKELY RESULT IN REAL
REDUCTIONS IN SERVICES, ALSO, WE
WOULD NOTE THAT ALTHOUGH THE APS
EXPANSION DID LOWER ELIGIBILITY
AGE FOR APS FROM 65 TO 60 IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING. THE REDUCTIONS IN
FUNDING WILL, POTENTIALLY IMPACT
THE AVAILABILITY OF SERVICES FOR
ALL AGE GROUPS, NOT JUST THOSE
EXPANDED BECAUSE IT'S THE SAME
POT, RIGHT? SO WE DON'T KNOW WHO
IT'S GOING TO IMPACT, CAN IMPACT
ANYBODY. WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADD
ANYTHING ELSE? YOU DON'T HAVE
TO. I JUST, NO FURTHER COMMENT.
OKAY. THANK YOU. I'M GOING TO
HOLD THE ITEM OPEN AND MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN, EXCUSE
ME, I JUST WANTED TO CHECK IF
YOU WANTED ME TO SPEAK TO THE.
OH, NO. THIS EDITION, YES.
SECOND ITEM. YES. THANK YOU.
QUICKLY, JUST ADD THAT THE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES TRAINING
PROGRAM, IS A STATE FUNCTION
THAT IS MANDATED TO SELECT AN
AWARD GRANTS TO PRIVATE,
NONPROFIT OR PUBLIC ENTITIES FOR
THE PURPOSE OF ESTABLISHING A
STATEWIDE APS WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND TRAINING
PROGRAM, AS WELL AS PROVIDING
TRAINING TO OTHER INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE SERVING APS CLIENTS,
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
PUBLIC ADMINISTRATORS, PUBLIC
GUARDIANS, AND PUBLIC
CONSERVATORS. THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES THE ELIMINATION OF THE
APS CONTRACT FOR TRAINING
CURRICULUM, THE ELIMINATION OF
THE CONTRACT WOULD RESULT IN A
REDUCTION OF $4.9 MILLION
GENERAL FUND BEGINNING IN 2024
AND CONTINUING ONGOING TO ASSIST
IN CLOSING THE PROJECTED
SHORTFALL. THE APS TRAINING
BUDGET WOULD REVERT TO $176,000
PER YEAR, WHICH WAS ITS AMOUNT
BEFORE THE, EXPANDED MONEY WAS
PROVIDED, AND WE DO ANTICIPATE
AS IMPACTS, THERE WILL BE
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS TRAINING
PROVIDED AND CLASSES OFFERING
AND AVAILABILITY IN THE NUMBER
OF CLASSES AVAILABLE TO APS
SOCIAL WORKERS, AND THE STATE
WILL HAVE TO AMEND OR END
CONTRACTS WITH CURRENT APS
TRAINING PROVIDERS. THE
CONTRACTS ALREADY STARTED,
CORRECT. THERE ARE YEARLY
CONTRACTS, SO WE ARE CURRENTLY
IN CONTRACT WITH, CSU SAN DIEGO.
AND IN THE PROCESS OF EXECUTING
CONTRACTS WITH CSU SACRAMENTO
AND CSU FRESNO FOR THESE
TRAINING DOLLARS. ALTHOUGH THEY
ARE ALREADY PROVIDING THE
SERVICES. SO OKAY, IS THERE LIKE
A FEE TO GET OUT OF THESE
CONTRACTS? WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO PAY? NO, WE DON'T ANTICIPATE
THAT. BUT THERE WILL BE TIME TO
AMEND, CONTRACTS. OKAY. JOIN
YOU. GOOD. ARE WE OKAY? OKAY NOW
WE'RE GOING TO GO ON TO ISSUE
SEVEN. THANK YOU
.
IS IT NOT? THERE WE GO. GOOD
MORNING. MADAM CHAIR. ELIANA
CAME HERE FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. I WILL BE
SPEAKING ON ITEM NUMBER SEVEN.
THE RAPID RESPONSE IMMIGRATION
ITEM. AS WE ALL KNOW, THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR IMMIGRATION
POLICY AND MIGRANT PROCESSING.
HOWEVER, IT LARGELY FALLS TO
LOCAL AND STATE GOVERNMENT TO
ADDRESS THE POST PROCESSING
NEEDS OF NEW ARRIVALS. THE CDSS
FUNDED NONPROFIT PARTNERS
WELCOME, PROVIDE SHELTER AND
ADMINISTER SERVICES TO HUNDREDS
OF VULNERABLE MIGRANTS WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE BE RELEASED BY FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES DIRECTLY INTO BORDER
COMMUNITIES. JUST LAST MONTH, ON
APRIL 15TH, THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
A SIGNED ASSEMBLY BILL 106,
WHICH REAPPROPRIATED 79.4
MILLION GENERAL FUND FROM THE
2021 AND 2022 BUDGET, ACTS TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER HUMANITARIAN EFFORT. THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSES TO REDUCE
THE RAPID RESPONSE
REAPPROPRIATION AUTHORITY
INCLUDED IN THIS LEGISLATION BY
29 MILLION. GENERAL FUND TO
ASSIST IN CLOSING THE BUDGET
SHORTFALL. THE REDUCTION WON'T
IMPACT THE SERVICES CURRENTLY
BEING SUPPORTED IN SAN DIEGO AND
OTHER PARTS OF THE BORDER. AS
EARLY ACTION FUNDING WOULD
SUPPORT SERVICES IN THE BUDGET
YEAR. FY 2425, WE EXPECT THERE
WILL BE SUFFICIENT CURRENT YEAR
SAVINGS IN BORDER OPERATIONS TO
RESTORE THE 29 MILLION, AND THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL CONTINUE TO
ASSESS THE DETAILS OF THESE
POTENTIAL SAVINGS BASED ON
CURRENT PROJECTIONS AND
OPERATIONAL NEEDS. I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. SO YOU
EXPECT CURRENT FUNDING SHOULD BE
ENOUGH FOR THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR?
OKAY LEÓN ANY COMMENT ON THIS
ONE? ALLEGEDLY LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE, I GUESS THE
ONLY INITIAL QUESTION WOULD BE,
IF THERE'S ANY NEW FUNDS
PROVIDED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND IF SO, HOW MUCH?
SINCE JANUARY, THERE WERE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS PROVIDED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND THIS
FEDERAL FISCAL YEAR, OUR
ORGANIZATIONS IN SAN DIEGO AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTY RECEIVED A
LITTLE BIT OVER $45 MILLION IN
SHELTER SERVICE PROGRAM FEMA
FEDERAL FUNDS, FOR A TOTAL OF 93
MILLION OVER THE LAST TWO FISCAL
YEARS. AND IT COULD BE USED FOR
THIS KIND OF PROGRAM. YES IS
THIS THE ONLY KIND OF PROGRAM
THAT CAN BE USED FOR. YES IT'S
FOR SHELTERING SERVICES ACROSS
THE BORDER. OKAY. BECAUSE IF I
REMEMBER CORRECTLY, THERE WAS
THERE WEREN'T ANY OTHER KIND OF
FUNDING TO HELP OFFSET THE OTHER
TWO PROGRAMS WE TALKED ABOUT.
RIGHT. THE OTHER TWO PROGRAMS,
TEMPORARY AND THE TPS. THAT'S
CORRECT. CSU IMMIGRATION, THOSE
ARE SEPARATE BECAUSE THOSE ARE
LEGAL SERVICES. AND THIS IS
SHELTERING FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
SHELTERING. OKAY OKAY. YOU KNOW,
SHARING WITH MY COLLEAGUES I WAS
LIKE, THIS HEARING IS GOING LONG
IS BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS BEING
PROPOSED FOR CUTS. THAT'S WHY
IT'S THAT'S WHY THAT'S WHY
THAT'S OKAY. IT'S A LOT. IT'S A
LOT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE
GOING TO GO ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT. THANK YOU.
WE CAN GO FAIRLY QUICKLY ON THIS
ONE. GO AHEAD. PLAN. YANG LEE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. SO FOR THE FIRST
COUPLE OF ISSUES ARE JUST
CASELOAD ADJUSTMENTS AND CHANGES
THAT ARE HAPPENING TO OUR MAJOR
PROGRAMS. I DON'T I MEAN, THE
AGENDA DOES A PRETTY GOOD JOB OF
OUTLINING SOME OF THOSE CASELOAD
ADJUSTMENTS. SO I'M NOT GOING TO
GO INTO TOO MUCH DETAILS OF THAT
UNLESS THE CHAIR WANTS ME TO DO
SO. OTHERWISE, I'LL JUST GIVE A
HAND AND START TALKING ABOUT THE
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS INSTEAD.
IF YOU COULD JUST A LITTLE BIT
ON THE PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE FOR
THE FEDERAL CALWORKS PILOT
PROGRAM. SURE. AGAIN,
REITERATING, WE DON'T ANTICIPATE
ALL THESE CUTS HURTING OUR
ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PILOT PROGRAM, AT THE MOMENT, WE
DON'T ANTICIPATE THAT BECAUSE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS GOING
TO BE MAKING THE DETERMINATION.
I DON'T THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
BE LOOKING AT WHAT THE WHAT THE
STATE'S GOING TO DO ON THAT SIDE
, BUT I DON'T KNOW, BECAUSE I'M
NOT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE LOOKING AT.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, NO.
OKAY BUT ON THAT ONE, REALLY
SIMPLE. JUST THE EXTENT THAT WE
ARE ACCEPTED TO BE PART OF THE
PILOT, WE'RE JUST GOING TO NEED
SOME RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT
THAT. AND THAT GIVES US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THOSE
ADJUSTMENTS DURING THE CURRENT
YEAR WHEN THE LEGISLATURE IS NOT
AVAILABLE. CAN YOU REMIND US OF
THE TIMELINE FOR THIS WHOLE
THING? SURE SO, THE SPRING AND
EARLY SUMMER, THE
ADMINISTRATION, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL RELEASE THE
GUIDANCE APPLICATION FOR THE
PILOT AROUND THE SUMMER, THE
STATE WILL WILL BE SELECTED AND
STATES WILL BE SELECTED TO
PARTICIPATE. AND THEN OCTOBER
FIRST IS WHEN WE ANTICIPATE THAT
THE PILOT WILL LAUNCH AND DATA
WILL BE COLLECTED TO START THE
PROCESS. DO WE I THINK I ASKED
THIS OR ANTICIPATE ANY OTHER
FUNDING SOURCES NECESSARY. I'M
NOT TRACKING ANY, BUT THERE
COULD ALWAYS BE THAT WHEN WE
START DOING THE ASSESSMENTS,
ONCE WE GET THE MORE INFORMATION
FROM THE FEDS. OKAY, THE 2.4
MILLION. THIS IS ADMINISTRATIVE.
THOSE THAT'S, AUTOMATION COSTS
THAT WE'RE ANTICIPATING THAT
WOULD BE NEEDED TO DO SOME OF
THE AUTOMATION WORK. THERE'S
GOING TO BE SOME RESOURCES FOR
STAFF TO DO SOME OF THE WORK AND
ALSO SOME RESOURCES FOR THE
COUNTIES TO ALSO. OKAY. THANK
YOU, SO I'LL START WITH SOME OF
THE BEEPS THAT WE HAVE INCLUDED
IN THE MAY REVISION, AND I'LL
JUST COVER SOME OF THOSE AND
THEN SOME OF THE OTHER DETAIL
STUFF. OKAY. SO THE FIRST ONE IS
JUST THE MAINTENANCE OF THE
SECRET SYSTEM. WE'RE REQUESTING
TO MAKE PERMANENT POSITION FOR
PERMANENT MAKE PERMANENT FOR
TERM POSITIONS TO CONTINUE TO
MAINTAIN AND OPERATE THE SYSTEM.
THESE RESOURCES WERE PROVIDED
TWO YEARS AGO AND THIS IS IT
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL FOR US TO
ALLOW TO ENSURE THAT THE COUNTY
IS REIMBURSED TIMELY, SO LIKE I
SAID, WITHIN THE SYSTEM, YOU
NEED PEOPLE TO MAINTAIN AND
OPERATE IT. THE SECOND ONE IS
JUST THE SUMMER ELECTRONIC
BENEFIT. WELL, WHICH IS NOW
REFERRED TO AS THÀNH BUCK,
THAT'S A PROGRAM THAT WE'RE
REFERRING TO NOW. THAT'S THE
FEDERAL CHANGE IN THAT NAME.
WE'RE REQUESTING, $2.5 MILLION
IN THE BUDGET YEAR, FOR SIX
PERMANENT AND TWO LIMITED
RESOURCES, PERSON POSITION TO
COVER THE, THE END SUB FUNDING
TO COVER SOME CONSULTING, CON,
WORK WITH RELATED TO THE IT
COMPONENT. SO THIS, THE
RESOURCES WILL PROVIDE STABLE
STATE LEVEL ADMINISTRATIVE, YOU
KNOW, TECHNICAL EXPERTS AND TO
DO SOME OF THE POLICY WORK
AROUND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
SON PROGRAM PROGRAM, THE NEXT
ONE IS THE CHILD WELFARE
TRAINING FUNDS, THIS IS MORE OF
JUST A SHIFT BETWEEN FUNDING
BETWEEN TWO DIFFERENT BUDGET
ITEM. WE'RE TAKING MONEY THAT'S
RIGHT NOW BEING ALLOCATED AND
PAID FOR THROUGH SOME CONSULTANT
SERVICES WITH A VENDOR. WE'RE
GOING TO BRING SOME OF THAT
IN-HOUSE INSTEAD WE'RE GOING TO
HIRE TWO, TWO POSITION TO DO
SOME OF THOSE, TRAINING. AND
THEN THE LAST, NO, SORRY, THE
SECOND TO THE LAST PCP. IT'S A
GUARDIAN BACKGROUND CHECKS,
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS. THIS
IS THE CURRENT SYSTEM THAT THE
STATE IS. THE DEPARTMENT IS
USING FOR BACKGROUND CHECK,
CURRENTLY THE COST HAS COME A
LITTLE BIT HIGHER AS ANYTHING
ELSE THAT WE'VE SEEN. COSTS ARE
GOING UP, SO WE'RE ASKING FOR
$312,000 FOR THE NEXT TWO FISCAL
YEARS AND THEN $612 AND STARTING
26, 27 TO COVER THE COST OF THE
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATION FOR
THE CURRENT GUARDIAN BACKGROUND
SYSTEM. THE LAST CCP IS, THE
PRESCHOOL DEVELOPMENT GRANT
PROGRAM. THIS IS JUST FEDERAL
DOLLARS THAT WE'RE ASKING AND
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY FOR
SOCIAL SERVICES. SO 328
REIMBURSEMENT FOR SOCIAL
SERVICES, $1.3 MILLION. FEDERAL
FUNDS FOR, AGENCY FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO EXPAND AND IMPLEMENT
THE PRESCHOOL DEVELOPMENT GRANT
PLANNING PROGRAM, THE FRA, WE
COVERED THAT ALREADY. THAT IS
JUST BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE. THE
NEXT ONE IS THE ABOD, THE BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE. WE'RE ALSO ASKING
FOR LANGUAGE TO BE INCLUDED IN
THE BUDGET BILL. THAT WOULD
ALLOW DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
INCREASE OUR DEPARTMENT'S
AUTHORITY TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
ARE DETERMINED TO, NO LONGER BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE WAIVER. SO ABOD
CURRENTLY CURRENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA IS UNDER THE
STATEWIDE WAIVER, THE ABOVE TIME
LIMIT. PENDING RELEASE OF
RELEVANT UNEMPLOYMENT DATA.
CALIFORNIA WILL BE CONDUCTING AN
ANALYSIS TO DETERMINE IF THE
STATE WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR
ANOTHER WAIVER BEGINNING IN
NOVEMBER. FIRST, TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE'RE NOT, BECAUSE THE
EMPLOYMENT DATA ARE COMING IN,
THAT WOULD SHOW THAT WE'RE NOT
LONGER IN MEETING THE WAIVER WE
HAVE. WE'LL HAVE TO IMPLEMENT
THE TIME LIMIT. AND THAT
REQUIRES RESOURCES TO DO SO. SO
WE'RE PUTTING LANGUAGE INTO
CONSENT THAT THAT HAPPENS. AND
STARTING NEXT FISCAL YEAR,
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
GET RESOURCES TO DO THAT. AB 85
CALPERS GRANT INCREASES. PRETTY
SIMPLE. EVERY YEAR WE DO AN
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT THE LOCAL
REALIGNMENT DOLLARS ARE RIGHT
NOW, WE'RE PROJECTING THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE A 0.3%
INCREASE IN THE CAL WORKS, MAP.
AND THAT WOULD IN ITSELF BRING,
THAT'S ESTIMATED TO COST AROUND
$10.5 MILLION. AND THIS IS ALL
PAID FOR BY REALIGNMENT. THE
CHILD POVERTY AND FAMILY. FAMILY
SUPPLEMENTAL SUPPORT ACCOUNT
THAT WOULD BRING OUR NON EXEMPT
MET LEVEL UP TO $1,171. OH
SORRY. SORRY FROM 1171 TO 1175
PER MONTH FOR A FAMILY OF THREE.
THE NEXT ONE IS THE OF
COMPARABLE QUALIFICATION. HERE
WE HAVE A PROPOSAL WHICH
INCLUDES CHIRLA BILL. TO
ELIMINATE THE COMPARABLE
DISQUALIFICATION FOR THE C FAT
PROGRAM AND TO MAKE IT ALIGN
WITH THE CALFRESH PROGRAM.
COMPARABLE DISQUALIFICATION
REFERS TO THE POLICY WHEREBY A
STATE MAY CHOOSE TO QUALIFY, TO
CHOOSE TO DISQUALIFY CALFRESH
HOUSEHOLD MEMBER. IF THE
HOUSEHOLD MEMBER IS DISQUALIFIED
FROM ANOTHER MEANS TEST PROGRAM
SUCH AS CALWORKS AND SO, WE
CALFRESH RECEIVES APPROVAL FROM
FANS TO ELIMINATE THE COMPARABLE
DISQUALIFICATION BEGINNING APRIL
1ST, 2024, AS PART OF ITS OUR
ANNUAL STATE OPTIONS REPORT
PROCESS. BECAUSE OF THAT, WE
WANT TO ALIGN THAT WITH CAL C
42. SO WE'RE JUST MAKING THAT
SHIFT. THEY'RE MAKING THAT
CHANGE WITH THIS PROPOSAL. THE
NEXT PROPOSAL IS THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR MISSING AND EXPLOITED
CHILDREN REPORTING REQUIREMENT,
OR THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES 1.2
MILLION 432 GENERAL FUND,
ONGOING FOR NEW FEDERAL
REPORTING AND COMMUNICATION
REQUIREMENTS, THIS IS SIGNED
INTO LAW IN FEDERAL LAW THIS
PAST JANUARY. UNDER CURRENT LAW,
FEDERAL AGENCIES. FEDERAL TITLE
40 AGENCIES ARE REQUIRED TO
MAINTAIN REGULAR COMMUNICATIONS
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
AND OFFER IN. IN AN EFFORT TO
PROVIDE SAFETY RECOVERY OF
MISSING YOUTH. THIS FUNDING WILL
GO TO THE COUNTY SO THAT THEY
CAN IMPLEMENT THAT PROCESS. AND
THEN OF COURSE, WE HAVE THE LA
COUNTY WOHLFORD SOLUTION
STABILIZATION FUNDING. THIS IS
MORE OF A TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT
THAT WE'RE JUST MAKING, BECAUSE
WE'RE NO LONGER PROPOSING THAT
AS PART OF THE SOLUTION. RIGHT.
FOSTER RATE REFORM, I THINK FOR
THE MOST PART, WE TALKED ABOUT
THAT ALREADY. SO I'M NOT GOING
TO BELABOR THAT AND GET INTO
THOSE DETAILS. WE ALSO HAVE
ANOTHER PROPOSAL FOR
REAPPROPRIATION. THIS HAS TO DO
WITH CONNECT. WE GOT $2.6
MILLION THAT WE WANT TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL YEAR TO SPEND, SO
THAT WE COULD CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE INVITATION OF THE
CHILD FAMILY TEAMS FOR FAMILIES,
MAINTENANCE CASES ASSOCIATED
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF PH
CONNECT. AND THEN FFA, FFP,
ESTÁ, REAPPROPRIATION. THIS IS
VERY TECHNICAL FOR THE MOST
PART. WE JUST WANT TO MAKE A
CORRECTION TO A BUDGET ITEM
THAT'S IN THE BUDGET BILL. THE
LAST COUPLE OF THINGS ARE JUST
CHAPTER LEGISLATION. THESE ARE
JUST FUNDING THAT ARE PROVIDED
TO, IMPLEMENT VARIOUS CHAPTER
LEGISLATIONS AND IMPACTS. THE
DEPARTMENT. WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY, THERE'S QUITE A
FEW, BUT OVERALL THE DEPARTMENT
IS REQUESTING $46.4 MILLION.
24.7 GENERAL FUND TO IMPLEMENT
VARIOUS CHAPTERS, LEGISLATE.
SOME BIG ONES ARE. I'M NOT GOING
TO GO INTO ALL OF THE DETAILS,
BUT SOME OF THE BIG ONES ARE,
IMPLEMENTING, PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL PAY SICK LEAVE FOR
IHS PROVIDERS GOING FROM 24
HOURS A YEAR TO 40 HOURS A YEAR.
IMPLEMENTING SOME BOOKS. SOME
BOOKS, PROGRAM THINGS OF THAT
NATURE. THERE'S A LOT IN THERE,
BUT THESE ARE JUST CHAPTERS,
LEGISLATION THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR AGREED TO AS
PART OF THE 23, LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. SO THAT'S, PRETTY MUCH
THE INFORMATION THERE. I'M HAPPY
TO TALK MORE ABOUT THE DETAILS
OF SOME OF THESE LEGISLATION, IF
THAT'S DESIRED. NO WE'RE OKAY,
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. I JUST HAVE
KIND OF LIKE THE SAME QUESTION I
HAD LAST WEEK REGARDING. WELL,
THE GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING ABOUT
AN 8% CUT ACROSS DEPARTMENTS FOR
STAFF, BUT WE CONTINUE CONTINUE
TO SEE STAFF REQUESTS THAT IS
ESSENTIALLY COULD POTENTIALLY
OFFSET THE 8. SO I'M NOT SEEING
HOW WE'RE GOING TO SAVE ALL
THESE SAVINGS IF WE'RE ASKING
FOR MORE STAFF. AND I'M GOING TO
PERMANENT FINANCE. SO ARE YOU
REFERRING TO THE VACANT POSITION
SAVINGS? NO, THAT'S A 10,000
VACANT POSITIONS. THE STATEWIDE
REDUCTIONS. YES. YEAH. SO THE
MAY REVISION IS ASSUMING ACROSS
THE BOARD REDUCTION TO STATE
OPERATIONS BY 7.9% FOR ALL
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS, THE
PLAN REDUCTION INVOLVES ALL
CATEGORIES. SO IT'S INCLUDING
PERSONNEL, OPERATING COSTS AND
CONTRACTING, WE'RE PLANNING TO
WORK WITH AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS IN THE FALL TO ON
THE APPROPRIATE BUDGET
REDUCTIONS, AND THIS IS JUST FOR
TO ADDRESS THE STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT FACING THE STATE, THE
PROPOSED CUTS, WE THINK ARE
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS THE BUDGET
DEFICIT, AND ENCOURAGING THE
DEPARTMENT TO OPERATE MORE,
EFFICIENTLY IN A WAY THAT WILL
MAINTAIN CORE OPERATIONS AND
AFFECTED LEVELS OF SERVICE, AND
THEN, AS THE GOVERNOR MENTIONED,
IN THE MAY REVISION PRESS
CONFERENCE, WE'RE TARGETING, 3
BILLION IN GOVERNMENT
EFFICIENCIES. BUT HOW CAN WE DO
THAT IF WE'RE REQUESTING FOR
MORE STAFF? HOW ARE WE GOING TO
BE WORKING MORE EFFICIENTLY? IF
I'M SEEING ALL THESE DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS ASKING FOR MORE
STAFF, IT WILL OFFSET THE 8%
CUT, RIGHT? SO I THINK WE TOOK
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION WHEN
DETERMINING THE STATEWIDE CUTS.
I THOUGHT YOU TURNED IT OFF
BECAUSE I'M TURNING IT OFF. OKAY
OKAY. YOU'RE LIKE, DON'T TURN TO
ME OKAY. SO THAT CONSIDERATION
THE 8% IS STILL GOING TO BE
SEEN, EVEN THOUGH WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING, WHAT I'M HEARING IS THAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR MORE STAFF.
CORRECT. OKAY LÀ ANY COMMENT ON
THIS? ANGELA SHORT WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE,
WE'RE STILL REVIEWING THE
DETAILS OF THESE VARIOUS
PROPOSALS, BUT VERY MUCH IN LINE
WITH THE CHAIR'S COMMENTS.
SOMETHING THAT WE WILL BE
LOOKING INTO IS, GIVEN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED 7.95%
KIND OF GLOBAL ACROSS THE BOARD
STATE OPERATIONS REDUCTION
PROPOSAL. HOW HOW DOES HOW DO
THESE NEW FUNDING REQUESTS
INTERACT WITH THAT OVERALL FALL,
REDUCTION GOAL IS SOMETHING THAT
WILL BE WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND IN THE COMING DAYS.
THANK YOU. AND THEN I'D ALSO
LIKE TO KNOW, AND THIS IS NOT
SPECIFICALLY ON THIS TOPIC, BUT
THE 10,000, I THINK I BROUGHT IT
UP WHERE THEY LIE AMONGST HHS
DEPARTMENTS, IF THEY IMPEDE ANY
CHAPTER LEGISLATION, THEN ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS OUR COLLEAGUES HAD
WAS LIKE, ARE ANY OF THE 10,000
VACANT POSITIONS? SO WERE THEY
SUPPOSED TO HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
SOME CHAPTER LEGISLATION? WOULD
THAT FURTHER IMPEDE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SAID CHAPTER
LEGISLATION? THÀNH. SO OKAY. ANY
ANY QUESTIONS? OKAY. MOVING ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER NINE. LET'S TALK
ABOUT SOME TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGES
.
THIS IS THE. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. JENNIFER
TROY, ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES,
THE FIRST ITEM OF TRAILER BILL
IS THE ONE THAT I WILL ACTUALLY
SPEND A LITTLE BIT OF TIME GOING
THROUGH THE DETAIL OF, IF THAT
IS ALL RIGHT, AND THEN ON THE
OTHERS, I THINK WE CAN MOVE
FAIRLY QUICKLY. THAT FIRST ITEM
OF TRAILER BILL IS ADJUSTMENTS
TO OUR PROPOSED PERMANENT RATE
REFORM STRUCTURE FOR THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM, AS YOU MAY RECALL,
WE ALREADY TALKED ABOUT THE
TRAILER, THE TRIGGER LANGUAGE
WITH RESPECT TO THIS PROPOSAL,
BUT THE OVERALL PROPOSAL IS A
LARGE SET OF CHANGES TO THE
OVERALL STRUCTURE OF THE FOSTER
CARE RATE REFORMS SUBSEQUENT TO
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET AND THE HEARINGS
THAT WE PREVIOUSLY HAD ON THIS
TOPIC, WE HELD MORE THAN 15
PUBLIC MEETINGS WITH MORE THAN
500 INDIVIDUALS. WE RECEIVED
EXTENSIVE PUBLIC COMMENTS IN
WRITING AND IN VERBALLY. IN
THOSE MEETINGS, WE ARE
SUBMITTING RESPONSIVE REVISIONS
TO THE TRAILER. BILL, IN LIGHT
OF ALL OF THOSE COMMENTS THAT WE
RECEIVED IN THOSE EXTENSIVE
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENTS, I WILL
HIGHLIGHT THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
OF THOSE CHANGES, FOR YOU, AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE ADDITIONAL
DETAILS, THERE WERE THREE
COMPONENTS OF THE OR THREE MAIN
COMPONENTS OF THE PROPOSAL
STRENGTH, BUILDING PROGRAM,
IMMEDIATE NEEDS, AND THEN A SORT
OF CATCH ALL BUCKET OF
EVERYTHING ELSE. SO WITH RESPECT
TO THE STRENGTHS BUILDING
PROGRAM, WE PREVIOUSLY HAD A LOT
OF CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
SUPERVISED INDEPENDENT LIVING
PROGRAMS AND HOW THOSE RATES
WERE STRUCTURED. OUR PROPOSAL IN
THE MAY REVISION IS TO MAKE AN
ADJUSTMENT TO THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE, SO THAT THE STRENGTHS
BUILDING FUNDING WILL BE GIVEN
DIRECTLY TO THE YOUTH WHO RESIDE
IN SUPERVISED, INDEPENDENT
LIVING PLACEMENTS. THEY WILL NOT
GO THROUGH THE THIRD PARTY
FINANCIAL MANAGER FOR THE
RECEIPT OF THOSE FUNDS. IT WILL
BE BUILT INTO THE SLP RATE AS A
RESULT, THE TOTAL OF THE SLP
RATE WOULD BECOME $2,288 AND IT
WOULD GO DIRECTLY TO THE
NON-MINOR DEPENDENT NON MINOR
DEPENDENTS WOULD ALSO BE
EMPOWERED. SO OUTSIDE OF SOAPS,
BUT IN OTHER PLACEMENTS TO
DEVELOP THEIR OWN STRENGTH
BUILDING PLAN AND TO MAKE
DECISIONS TO EXPAND THE STRENGTH
BUILDING FUNDS IN A MANNER THAT
SUPPORTS THEIR TRANSITION TO A
SUCCESSFUL ADULTHOOD. WE ALSO,
IN RESPONSE TO FEEDBACK THAT WE
RECEIVED FROM STAKEHOLDERS, MADE
AN ADJUSTMENT SO THAT ANY
UNSPENT FUNDS IN A CHILD OR
NON-MINOR DEPENDENT STRENGTH
BUILDING ACCOUNT WILL REMAIN
AVAILABLE TO THEM FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE FISCAL YEAR IF
THEY HAVE TRANSITIONED TO
PERMANENCY. SO IF THEY REUNIFY
WITH THEIR PARENT OR ARE ADOPTED
OR ENTER INTO GUARDIANSHIP, THEY
WILL STILL CONTINUE TO BE ABLE
TO EXPEND THOSE STRENGTHS.
BUILDING FUNDS. WE REMOVED
BACKGROUND CHECK LANGUAGE THAT
WAS CAUSING SOME CONFUSION. OUR
INTENT WAS SIMPLY TO REFERENCE
THE EXISTING LAW, AND OUR
REFERENCE TO THAT CREATED SOME
CONFUSION ABOUT WHETHER WE WERE
CREATING A NEW STANDARD. WE WERE
NOT. AND SO WE'VE JUST DELETED
THAT. TO MAKE IT CLEARER, WE
ALSO CLARIFIED THAT STRENGTH
BUILDING FUNDS ARE NOT TO BE
CONSIDERED INCOME OR RESOURCES
FOR THE PURPOSES OF ELIGIBILITY
FOR ANY OTHER LOCAL, STATE, OR
FEDERAL BENEFIT OR ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM TO THE EXTENT ALLOWABLE
UNDER FEDERAL LAW WITH RESPECT
TO THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS PROGRAM.
THE BIGGEST CHANGE WAS TO SET
ESSENTIALLY A DEFAULT SO THAT
THOSE FUNDS, IF THE CHILD OR
YOUTH IS PLACED IN A TRAP, THEY
WOULD RECEIVE, THE STRAP WOULD
BE THE DEFAULT. DEFAULT PROVIDER
OF THOSE IMMEDIATE NEEDS
SERVICES. UNLESS THE COUNTY
AFFIRMATIVELY DETERMINED THAT IT
WAS NOT IN THE CHILD'S BEST
INTEREST FOR THE STRAP TO STRAP
TO RECEIVE THOSE IMMEDIATE NEEDS
FUNDS. SO THAT WOULD CREATE SOME
GREATER CERTAINTY FOR THOSE
STRAP PROVIDERS OF THE
AVAILABILITY OF THOSE IMMEDIATE
NEEDS. FUNDS AND THE FINAL THING
THAT I'LL HIGHLIGHT IS THAT THE
IMMEDIATE NEEDS PROGRAM PLAN
WILL BE REQUIRED TO BE JOINTLY
SUBMITTED TO CDSS BY THE LOCAL
CHILD WELFARE AGENCY, AS WELL AS
THE LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH PLAN TO
INCREASE THE COLLABORATION AND
COORDINATION REQUIRED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. SO I'LL PAUSE THERE
ON THE RATE REFORM AND SEE IF
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS ON THAT. AND
YOU KNOW, I STILL AM VERY
EXCITED TO FOR WHAT THIS REFORM
IS GOING TO BRING. AND WE'RE
HEARING THE EXCITEMENT FROM
YOUTH AND CAREGIVERS. I KNOW NOT
EVERYONE ELSE IS SUPER HAPPY,
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, IF
THE YOUTH WHO ARE IN THESE
PROGRAMS ARE HAPPY ABOUT THIS,
THE CAREGIVERS ARE HAPPY ABOUT
THIS. THIS IS A REALLY BIG START
AND I KNOW WE HAVE TWO YEARS TO
CONTINUE TO HASH OUT THE TRAILER
, CONTINUE TO HASH OUT THE
PROGRAM AND SO FORTH. MY ASK,
AND I DON'T DO THIS TO THE
ADVOCATES, IS THAT WE NEED TO
COME TOGETHER, AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE SUPPORTING THE
DEPARTMENT AND PUSHING THIS
FORWARD. BECAUSE WHAT I DON'T
WANT IS FOR THERE TO BE SOME
SETTLEMENT, SOME BARRIERS AND
PIECES FROM CONTINUING TO PUSH
FORWARD THIS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ON THIS PROGRAM THAT IS
GOING TO BE HISTORIC FOR OUR
YOUTH, AND I THINK, AGAIN, WE'LL
HAVE TIME TO COME BACK AND SEE
WHAT ELSE WE CAN DO. BUT FOR
RIGHT NOW, THIS IS A BIG FIRST
STEP, AND WE'LL CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE COUNTIES AND PROVIDERS.
BUT WE NEED TO BE UNITED FOR NOW
AND PUSHING THIS FIRST STEP
FORWARD BEFORE WE DON'T HAVE A
FIRST STEP THAT WE CAN PUSH
FORWARD. SO THAT WOULD BE MY ASK
TO THE ADVOCATES ON THAT, AND
THEN GOING BACK TO THE TRIGGER
LANGUAGE, I JUST WANT TO ASK
ANOTHER QUESTION ON THIS. BY
PUTTING A TRIGGER, ARE WE
SCORING A SAFE BECAUSE WE'RE
DOING AN INFRASTRUCTURE RIGHT.
ARE WE ANTICIPATE ARE WE DOING
THIS TO SCORE A SAFE OR. YEAH,
SCORE SAFE SAVINGS. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. SO YES, IN THE OUT
YEARS WE ARE WE ARE NOT
CAPTURING THOSE COSTS IN THE OUT
YEARS UNTIL THE TRIGGERS
DETERMINATION IS MADE. OKAY. SO
THAT'S WHAT I'M WORRIED ABOUT.
WE'RE SCORING A SAVE ON
SOMETHING THAT'S A STATUTORY
MANDATE. AND I'M THINKING ABOUT
THE DDS RATE REFORMS. SO I'M
THINKING ABOUT WHERE WE'RE GOING
THROUGH RIGHT NOW. AND LIKE
THAT'S I THINK THAT'S VERY
UNFAIR. BUT I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU ANSWERING THE QUESTION.
THANK YOU. I JUST THINK IT'S
VERY UNFAIR FOR US TO DO THIS,
TO THIS, TO THIS POPULATION,
SCORING TO SAVE ON SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE TO DO, OKAY. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS ON THE TRAILER,
BILL? LANGUAGE FOR THE RATE
REFORM, FOSTER CARE RATE REFORM.
I JUST WANT TO CONFIRM THAT, THE
TRAILER, THE TRIGGER LANGUAGE
FOR 2026 DOESN'T AUTOMATICALLY
LET US ROLL THIS PROGRAM OUT.
IT'S BASED ON FUNDS AVAILABLE
FOR 2026. IS THAT TRUE OR NOT?
YES SO IN THE SPRING OF 2026,
THE INTENT IS FOR FINANCE TO
MAKE A DETERMINATION TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S, SUFFICIENT
GENERAL FUND REVENUES TO SUPPORT
IN THE MULTI YEAR OVER THE MULTI
YEAR. LEÓN COMMENT ON. YES.
THANK YOU, REGARDING THE AMENDED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE, BASED ON
OUR INITIAL READ, WE DID WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IT DOES SEEM THAT
MANY AMENDMENTS ARE MADE
DIRECTLY IN RESPONSE TO THE
SIGNIFICANT STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK
THAT HAS BEEN PROVIDED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OVER THE PAST COUPLE
OF MONTHS, AND WE DO ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE DEPARTMENT
WILL BE CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS SOME,
SOME ISSUES THAT DO REMAIN
OUTSTANDING. FOR EXAMPLE, WE
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE STILL SOME
QUESTIONS RELATED TO THE CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT NEEDS AND
STRENGTHS. KANS ASSESSMENT,
USAGE, THE LATENT CLASS
ANALYSIS, OR THE METHODOLOGY TO
ESTABLISH THE TIERS AND SOME
OTHER ISSUES. SO WHILE THERE DO
REMAIN OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS,
THE AMENDMENTS DO AGAIN SEEK TO
DIRECTLY ADDRESS MANY, MANY
ELEMENTS OF STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK
THAT HAS BEEN PROVIDED. SO WE'LL
BE CONTINUING TO TRACK THE
EVOLUTION OF THE LANGUAGE IN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS. THANK
YOU. AND THEN CAN YOU SHARE
ANYTHING REGARDING, THE ADMIN
COST FOR PROVIDERS AND WHAT
WE'RE SEEING AND HOW
CONVERSATIONS ARE GOING IN THAT
REALM WHERE PROVIDERS FEEL IT'S
JUST NOT ENOUGH? WE HAVE NOT
PROPOSED ANY CHANGES TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FROM JANUARY
WITH RESPECT TO THE ADMIN COSTS,
CONVERSATIONS ARE STILL
HAPPENING. WE ABSOLUTELY ARE
HEARING FROM PROVIDERS AND DO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR CONCERNS
ARE. I THINK THEY ARE BOTH
CONCERNED WITH THE TOTAL OF THE
ADMIN FUNDING AND ALSO WITH THE
DESIRE FOR A COLA TO BE APPLIED
TO THOSE FUNDS. WE HAVE NOT
PROVIDED EITHER OF THOSE IN THE
PROPOSAL AT THIS TIME, BUT DO
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS THAT ARE
BEING RAISED. THIS DEPARTMENT,
DOES THE DEPARTMENT SEE IT IN A
DIFFERENT LIGHT, WHERE WE FEEL
WE'RE DEPARTMENT FEELS LIKE THIS
IS THIS WILL GET PROVIDERS
THROUGH. THIS IS ENOUGH, OUR
PROPOSAL REPRESENTS WHAT WE
BELIEVE IS NECESSARY TO
IMPLEMENT THE RATES. OKAY, OKAY.
CLARE RAMSEY FOR THE DEPARTMENT
ON, THE SECOND TRAILER, BILL
LANGUAGE FOR INFORMATION SHARING
FOR SMALL FAMILY CHILD CARE
HOMES. THIS IS A NON FISCAL TBL
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD ALLOW SMALL
FAMILY CHILD CARE HOME NAMES,
LICENSE NUMBERS, ZIP CODES AND
TELEPHONE NUMBERS TO BE SHARED
ON CALIFORNIA'S CONSUMER
EDUCATION WEBSITE FOR CHILD
CARE. CURRENTLY, MY CHILD CARE
PLAN.ORG CURRENT LAW, LIMITS
THAT SHARING AND CALIFORNIA IS
LOOKING TO BRING ITSELF INTO
ALIGNMENT WITH FEDERAL LAW THAT
REQUIRES THIS INFORMATION TO BE
MADE AVAILABLE. WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS IF WE DON'T COME INTO
COMPLIANCE, WE MAY HAVE
PENALTIES ASSESSED IN OUT YEARS,
NEXT I WILL SPEAK TO THE
FACILITY INCLUSION FOR COMMUNITY
CARE EXPANSION PRESERVATION
PROGRAM, THIS IS A ALSO A NON
FISCAL TBL TO ALLOW CDSS TO
ACCEPT A LEGALLY ENFORCEABLE
AGREEMENT IN LIEU OF A DEED
RESTRICTION FOR FACILITIES
AWARDING. EXCUSE ME, FACILITIES
AWARDED FUNDING FOR OPERATING
OPERATING SUBSIDY PAYMENTS IN
THE COMMUNITY. CARE EXPANSION
PRESERVATION PROGRAM, THE
REQUIREMENT FOR DEED
RESTRICTIONS HAS POSED A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER FOR
PARTICIPATION IN THE OPERATING
SUBSIDY PAYMENTS FOR CCE,
BECAUSE WE'RE FINDING THAT
PEOPLE OFTEN LEASE THE
PROPERTIES THEY USE TO RUN THE
FACILITIES AND THEIR LANDLORDS
ARE NOT LOOKING TO MAKE DEED
RESTRICTIONS, JUST TO CONFIRM
THAT THE TERM OF ANY LEGALLY
ENFORCEABLE AGREEMENT WOULD
COVER THE FULL TERM OF ANY
OPERATING SUBSIDY PROPOSALS
PROVIDED TO THAT FACILITY. THE
NEXT ITEM IS WITH RESPECT TO
FEDERAL REPORTING AND
COMMUNICATION REQUIREMENTS. WHEN
THERE ARE MISSING OR EXPLOITED
CHILDREN, THE TBL PROPOSAL
RELATES TO FEDERAL REPORTING AND
COMMUNICATION REQUIREMENTS,
WHICH WERE SIGNED INTO LAW IN
JANUARY 2023. THE FEDERAL LAW
REQUIRES US AS A TITLE FOR Â
AGENCY TO MAINTAIN REGULAR
COMMUNICATION WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN EFFORTS
TO PROVIDE SAFE RECOVERY OF
MISSING YOUTH. THESE ARE
ADDITIONAL RECORDING
REQUIREMENTS THAT WILL BRING US
INTO FEDERAL COMPLIANCE AND ALSO
ENHANCE THE OVERALL PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN COUNTY CHILD WELFARE
AGENCIES AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE NEXT ITEM IS RELATED TO
SPECIAL CARE INCREMENTS.
SPECIALIZED CARE INCREMENTS
PROVIDE A SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT
TO FAMILY HOME PROVIDERS WHEN
THEY NEED TO PAY FOR THE
ADDITIONAL CARE AND SUPERVISION
OF WHEN THERE ARE BEHAVIORAL OR
EMOTIONAL OR PHYSICAL
REQUIREMENTS, OF THE NEEDS OF A
FOSTER CHILD. THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD ALLOW TRIBES WHO HAVE A
TITLE FOUR AGREEMENT WITH THE
STATE TO CREATE THEIR OWN SSI
RATE SETTING SYSTEM. IT WOULD
ALSO EXPLICITLY CLARIFY THAT
CHILDREN UNDER COUNTY
JURISDICTION WHO ARE PLACED IN A
TRIBALLY APPROVED HOME MAY
RECEIVE THE COUNTY'S SSI WHERE
APPLICABLE, SO OVERALL IT IS
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL SPECIALIZED
CARE INCREMENT RESOURCES TO
TRIBAL CHILDREN. THE NEXT
PROPOSAL RELATES TO THE RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL PROGRAM AND THE
EMERGENCY CAREGIVER FUNDING,
WHICH WE'VE PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED
FOR OTHER PURPOSES, THE RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL PROGRAM WAS
IMPLEMENTED TO CREATE A
STREAMLINED APPROVAL PROCESS FOR
RELATIVE AND NON RELATIVE
CAREGIVERS UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF COUNTY CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEMS AND TO INCREASE
THE USE OF HOME BASED AND FAMILY
CENTERED PLACEMENT OPTIONS.
THERE'S CURRENTLY A DISCONNECT
IN THE STATUTE IN THE SENSE THAT
THE RFA STATUTE REQUIRES THE
APPROVING AGENCY TO COMPLETE THE
PROCESS WITHIN 90 DAYS, WHERE
EMERGENCY CAREGIVER FUNDING CAN
BE PROVIDED FOR UP TO 120 DAYS.
THE RFA TIMEFRAMES HAVE
CONTINUED TO DECREASE, BUT NOT
EVER HIT THE 90 DAY MARK. SO
THIS TRAILER BILL IS BRINGING
THOSE TWO STATUTES INTO
ALIGNMENT AT THE 120 DAY TIME
FRAME. THE NEXT TRAILER BILL IS
RELATED TO THE STATE AND FEDERAL
KINSHIP GUARDIANSHIP ASSISTANCE
PAYMENT PROGRAM. THIS IS AN
ALIGNMENT TO BRING THE STATE
INTO A PLACE WHERE WE CAN ALLOW
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE AGING OUT
OF THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM TO
HAVE A BETTER TRANSITION INTO
ADULTHOOD BY NOT REQUIRING THEM
TO SPEND DOWN RESOURCES. SO THE
CURRENT LAW PROVIDES THAT
CHILDREN AND NON MINORS
RECEIVING KIN GAP CAN ONLY
RETAIN CASH SAVINGS, INCLUDING
INTEREST UP TO $10,000 AND
SPECIFIED PERSONAL PROPERTY
LIMITS. THIS IS A HOLDOVER FROM
PRIOR FEDERAL LAW. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NO LONGER REQUIRES
IT, AND SO THERE IS NO REASON
FOR THE STATE TO CREATE SUCH A
RESTRICTION. AND THERE'S NO
FISCAL IMPACT TO US OF ALLOWING
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE TO RETAIN
THOSE RESOURCES AND TRANSITION
BETTER INTO ADULTHOOD. THE NEXT
ONE IS RELATED TO THE EXCELLENCE
OF FAMILY FINDING, ENGAGEMENT
AND SUPPORT PROGRAM, ONE OF THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS PROGRAM IS
THAT COUNTIES THAT OPT INTO THE
PROGRAM NEED TO HAVE FULL TIME
STAFF FULLY DEDICATED TO THIS
RESOURCE. WHAT WE HAVE FOUND IN
IMPLEMENTATION IS THAT FOR THE
20 SMALL COUNTIES AND FOR SOME
TRIBES, THERE IS NOT A
SUFFICIENT CASELOAD TO JUSTIFY A
FULL TIME STAFF PERSON. AND SO
IN THOSE EXCEPTIONAL
CIRCUMSTANCES, WE WANT TO HAVE
THE FLEXIBILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE STILL MEETING THE
INTENT OF THE PROGRAM, BUT ARE
ABLE TO DO SO PERHAPS WITH
SOMEONE ON A PART TIME BASIS.
THE NEXT TRAILER BILL IS RELATED
TO SNAP OR CALFRESH
REIMBURSEMENT WHEN THERE ARE
INSTANCES OF STOLEN BENEFITS. SO
THE MAY REVISION IS CODIFIED, IS
PROPOSING TO CODIFY HOW WE
REIMBURSE ELECTRONICALLY STOLEN
CALFRESH BENEFITS, AND TO BRING
US INTO ALIGNMENT IN TERMS OF
WHEN THE STATE VERSUS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS FOOTING
THE BILL FOR THAT REPLACEMENT OF
BENEFITS, THE PROPOSAL WOULD
HALT THE STATE FUNDED
REPLACEMENTS IF FEDERAL FUNDING
IS AVAILABLE, AND WOULD ALSO
CREATE BETTER ALIGNMENT BETWEEN
THE STATE AND FEDERAL POLICIES
THAT ULTIMATELY ARE MORE
GENEROUS TO HOW MUCH IS REPLACED
FOR THE RECIPIENT. WE ORIGINALLY
IMPLEMENTED OUR STATE,
REPLACEMENT PRIOR TO ANY
AVAILABILITY OF FEDERAL FUNDING.
SO THESE PROGRAMS SORT OF CAME
INTO BEING AT DIFFERENT TIMES.
AND WE ARE BRINGING THEM INTO
ALIGNMENT THROUGH THIS. I KNOW A
LOT OF THE ADVOCATES HAS HAVE
PUSHED FOR STREAMLINING THE
PROCESS OF GETTING THE FUNDS
BACK, YOU KNOW, TEN DAYS. I KNOW
WE WORK TO GET TO TEN DAYS, TEN
BUSINESS DAYS AND WE'RE STILL
ADVOCATES. THINK THAT'S STILL A
LONG TIME. I'M INTERESTED IN
SEEING IF WE COULD PUT SOME
STRONGER LANGUAGE IN THIS TABLE
REGARDING, YOU KNOW, AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE OR JUST I THINK TEN
DAYS, JUST WE'RE GOING TO WAIT
TILL THE TEN DAYS. SO INTERESTED
IN SEEING SOME LANGUAGE
REGARDING CODIFYING A FASTER
APPROACH TO GETTING THE FUNDS
OUT. I BELIEVE THE WAY THAT THE
STATUTE FRAMES IT RIGHT NOW IS
THAT IT'S A PROMPT REPLACEMENT,
AND WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED THAT TO
BE THE TEN DAY STANDARD. DOES IT
SAY PROMPT? OKAY IT DOES,
APPRECIATE YOUR POINT THOUGH,
AND HAPPY TO TALK WITH YOU
FURTHER AND TO WORK WITH YOUR
STAFF ON ANY PROPOSALS THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE. OKAY. THANK YOU. THE
NEXT PIECE OF TRAILER BILL IS
RELATED TO THE TRIBAL NUTRITION
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. THE TRAILER
BILL WOULD REMOVE REFERENCES TO
THE FEDERAL DISTRIBUTION PROGRAM
ON INDIAN RESERVATIONS FROM THE
STATUTE THAT AUTHORIZED TÊ NH█P
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE TÊ NH█P
PROGRAM COULD BE MORE AVAILABLE
WITHOUT REQUIRING TRIBAL MEMBERS
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN FDPIR OR
CALFRESH IN ORDER TO BENEFIT
FROM NAP. THE NEXT ONE IS
RELATED TO THE CALWORKS
INTENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT.
HOURLY INCREASE PAUSE. THIS WAS
A JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL. THIS
IS THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD EFFECTUATE THE
PROPOSAL. THE NEXT TRAILER BILL
IS THE CALIFORNIA FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM, OR CFAP
ELIMINATION OF COMPARABLE
DISQUALIFICATION, MY COLLEAGUE
MR. LEE ALREADY REFERENCED SOME
OF THIS. WE HAVE CURRENTLY A
POLICY OF DISQUALIFYING OR
SANCTIONING INDIVIDUALS IN
CALFRESH IF THEY RECEIVED A
SANCTION IN CALWORKS. WE ARE NOT
REQUIRED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO IMPOSE SUCH A
SANCTION, AND WE'VE RECEIVED
APPROVAL IN THE CALFRESH PROGRAM
TO NO LONGER DO SO. BUT THE CFAP
STATUTE REMAINS ON THE BOOKS,
AND SO WE NEED TO ADJUST THE
CFAP STATUTE TO ALIGN WITH
CALFRESH IN ORDER TO NOT
SANCTION THE CALFRESH
RECIPIENTS. MADAM CHAIR, YEAH.
ONE QUESTION IS THIS. REMIND ME.
I KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
EARLIER IN THE YEAR REGARDING
SOME ADDITIONAL STATE SANCTIONS
THAT THE FEDERAL DOESN'T FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T HAVE. IS THIS
WHAT YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT,
REMOVING THAT? NO I BELIEVE WHAT
YOU WERE REFERENCING IN THE
EARLIER HEARINGS WAS WITH
RESPECT TO THE PILOT AND THE
ADVOCATES ADVOCACY FOR SAYING
THAT THE STATE SHOULD NOT, IN
THE CALWORKS PROGRAM, SANCTION
ANY MORE THAN IS MINIMALLY
FEDERALLY REQUIRED. THIS IS
ABOUT CARRYING A CALWORKS
SANCTION OVER INTO CALFRESH.
OKAY, SENATOR GROVE, I HAVE A
QUESTION ON THE CALWORKS
INTENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT.
HOURLY INCREASE. PAUSE. HOW MANY
PEOPLE OR HAVE YOU GUYS
DETERMINED HOW MANY PEOPLE WOULD
BE AFFECTED BY THAT FOR DELAYING
THAT? I DON'T HAVE THAT NUMBER
IN FRONT OF ME. I DO KNOW THAT
THE CASE MANAGEMENT, OUR YEARS
ARE REDUCED, BUT THERE IS STILL
INTENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT. IT'S
JUST GOING TO BE INSTEAD OF
INCREASING FROM 8.7 5 HOURS TO
10 HOURS, IT WILL REMAIN AT 8.75
HOURS. SO WE WILL STILL BE
SERVING ALL OF THE SAME PEOPLE.
I DON'T I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
TOTAL CASELOAD IS OFF THE TOP OF
MY HEAD, BUT WE WILL STILL SERVE
ALL OF THEM. CAN YOU FIND OUT
HOW MUCH A NUMBER OF HOURS LOAD
IS NOT BEING SERVED? BECAUSE MY
OFFICE RECEIVES CALLS ALL THE
TIME FOR HELP TO DEVELOP TO GET
A CASE MANAGER BECAUSE THEY'RE
WAITING MONTHS FOR ONE. AND SO
I'D LIKE TO KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE
AREN'T BEING SERVED. THAT'S WHY
WE ASKED TO HAVE THE INCREASE IN
THE FIRST PLACE, SO THAT PEOPLE
THAT WERE STRUGGLING WITH THOSE
BENEFITS, WORKING WITH A
BUREAUCRATIC AGENCY, WOULD BE
ABLE TO HAVE THEIR BENEFITS
ASSESSED, YOU KNOW, BROUGHT
FORWARD ON THE CASE MANAGEMENT
PROBLEMS THAT THEY HAD. AND
THAT'S WHY WE ASKED FOR IT TO BE
INCREASED. AND IF YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO INCREASE IT, I WANT TO
KNOW HOW HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
STILL GOING TO BE WAITING IN
LINE AND FOR HOW LONG AND WHAT
GIVE ME A DASHBOARD. WE WILL WE
WILL PROVIDE YOU THE INFORMATION
ON THE CASELOAD FOR THAT PROGRAM
THAT ARE SERVED BY THAT. THE
NEXT PIECE OF TRAILER BILL
RELATES TO THE FAMILY
REUNIFICATION CASH ASSISTANCE
FOR FAMILIES WHO WERE RECEIVING
CALWORKS WHEN THEIR CHILDREN
WERE REMOVED. ON THE CHILD
WELFARE SIDE. THIS IS
RECOGNIZING AN IMPLEMENTATION
DELAY. TYPICALLY, WE INCLUDE IN
CHANGES TO THE CALWORKS PROGRAM
LANGUAGE THAT INDICATES IT WILL
TAKE EFFECT AT A CERTAIN TIME OR
WHEN AUTOMATION IS COMPLETE,
WHICHEVER IS LATER. WE DID NOT
INCLUDE THAT LANGUAGE IN THIS
STATUTE AND DO NEED TO DO SO AND
SO THIS IS MAKING THAT
ADJUSTMENT, PART OF THAT IS ALSO
BECAUSE THE, ALL COUNTY LETTER
TO IMPLEMENT THE POLICY WAS
RELEASED IN NOVEMBER OF 2023.
AND WHAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM CAL
SOS IS THAT THE IMPLEMENTATION
FOR THE CHANGE WILL NOT BE
COMPLETED UNTIL JANUARY 2025,
AND THE COUNTIES ARE NOT ABLE TO
DO A MANUAL WORKAROUND GIVEN THE
COMPLEXITY INVOLVED. PRIOR TO
THAT TIME. SO THIS IS CHANGING
THE TIMELINE JUST TO MATCH WHAT
IS ACTUALLY FEASIBLE IN
IMPLEMENTATION. IN NEXT, WE HAVE
THE DATA SHARING TO QUANTIFY THE
IMPACTS OF THE SAFETY NET. ON
THE WHOLE CALIFORNIAN. THIS IS
ANOTHER NON FISCAL TBL PROPOSAL
THAT WOULD ALLOW CDSS TO RECEIVE
DATA AND REPORT ON OUTCOMES
RELATED TO HOUSING STABILITY FOR
PARTICIPANTS IN VARIOUS HUMAN
SERVICES PROGRAM, INCLUDING OUR
CDSS HOUSING PROGRAMS.
SPECIFICALLY, THIS WOULD GIVE US
ACCESS TO PERSON LEVEL DATA FROM
THE HOUSING DATA INTEGRATION
SYSTEM HDIS THAT THE, BCS AGENCY
RUNS, WE BELIEVE THE STATUTORY
AUTHORITY WILL PROVIDE
EVERYTHING THE DEPARTMENT NEEDS
IN ORDER TO ACCESS THAT DATA AND
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH ADDITIONAL,
ABILITY TO ANALYZE OUTCOMES. THE
NEXT PROPOSAL RELATES TO THE
CFAP PROGRAM AND TO THE OVER
ISSUANCE COLLECTION RETENTION
RATES. THIS WAS ACTUALLY A
JANUARY PROPOSAL, WHICH YOU HAVE
ALREADY HEARD. WE ARE LITERALLY
JUST CHANGING A CODE SECTION
REFERENCE WITHIN THAT TRAILER
BILL, BECAUSE WE IDENTIFIED AN
ERROR. THE NEXT IS THE IHSS
PERMANENT BACKUP PROVIDER
SYSTEM. THIS IS THE TBL TO
EFFECTUATE THE ELIMINATION OF
THE IHSS BACKUP PROVIDER SYSTEM.
THE FOLLOWING ITEM. SIMILARLY,
Ó FAP AND THE WINDS AND THE
UNDOCUMENTED. DO WE HAVE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE YET LIKE THAT? SO,
REGARDING CFAP, YEAH, THAT
TRAILER LANGUAGE, THE TECHNICAL
CORRECTION IS FORTHCOMING, FOR
THE WINDS THAT'S ALSO HAS NOT
BEEN POSTED YET. SO AND THE
UNDOCUMENTED IHS, THE
UNDOCUMENTED IHSS IS STILL
PENDING. SO WE'RE WORKING ON
THAT. AND THAT WILL BE POSTED AS
SOON AS WE HAVE IT READY. OKAY.
SO JUST A FOLLOW UP QUESTION. SO
WE'RE GOING TO BE VOTING ON THIS
TUESDAY AND WEDNESDAY, RIGHT. IS
THAT CORRECT? TBD, BECAUSE I
STILL HAVE A LOT OF HEALTH TO GO
OVER AND TBD. SO MY
UNDERSTANDING IS, IS WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE UP THE VOTES ON THIS
NEXT TUESDAY AND WEDNESDAY, AND
WE DON'T HAVE TREE MAYBE AND WE
DON'T HAVE LANGUAGE FOR THOSE
THREE LIKE IT'S JUST PENDING OUT
THERE WHEN IS SOMEBODY GOING TO
PROVIDE US THE LANGUAGE SO WE
KNOW WHAT WE'RE VOTING ON? OR IS
THAT THE I DON'T KNOW, MODUS
OPERANDI? I GUESS THAT'S WHAT I
FEEL LIKE. I FEEL LIKE THAT
EVERY YEAR A BUDGET IS
SUBMITTED. SOMEBODY PUTS A
LITTLE STICKY NOTE ON A WHITE
PAPER THAT SAYS, YOU'RE GOING TO
CUT ALL THESE PEOPLE'S BENEFITS
IN THE MOST POOREST OR MOST
VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF OUR
SOCIETY. AND THEN YOU MEET WITH
THEM AND YOU CAN SAY, OH, WE MET
WITH ALL THESE PROVIDERS. WE HAD
15 MEETINGS AND MET WITH OVER
500 PROVIDERS AND INSTEAD OF
CUTTING THEIR BENEFITS AT THIS
LEVEL, YOU ONLY CUT THEM AT THIS
LEVEL AND THEY'RE VERY GRATEFUL,
AND THANKING YOU GUYS FOR DOING
SO. BUT THEY STILL HAVE A CUT
AND THEN WE DON'T EVEN GET THE
LANGUAGE. SO SOMEBODY TELL ME
WHEN WE'RE GOING TO GET THE
LANGUAGE. RESPECTFULLY. SORRY GO
AHEAD. ANYBODY? YEAH. SO IN
REGARDS TO THE CFAP AND WINDS
PROGRAM, WE'RE WORKING ON THE
LANGUAGE AS WE SPEAK. SO HOPING
TO GET TO YOU AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
DOES THAT MEAN THIS WEEK OR NEXT
WEEK OR. YES, I WOULD I WOULD
HOPE BY THIS WEEK. OKAY AND THEN
FOR THE. YES MA'AM. SORRY. GO
AHEAD. I WAS JUST GOING TO ADD
FOR THE IHSS UNDOCUMENTED
SOLUTION, WE'RE ALSO EXPECTING
TO GET THAT, HOPEFULLY WRAPPED
UP THIS WEEK FOR YOU GUYS AS
WELL. HOW MANY PAGES DO YOU
THINK IS IN THERE? LIKE, ARE WE
GOING TO HAVE TIME TO READ IT?
IS THAT 100 LESS FIVE IN REGARDS
TO THE CFAP AND THE WINDS, THE
CFAP IS A TECHNICAL CORRECTION,
SO IT WON'T BE MORE THAN ONE
LINE, THE WINDS WE, WE HAVEN'T
SEEN YET. SO THAT SHOULD BE
PENDING, BUT IT SHOULDN'T BE
HUNDREDS. YOU HAVEN'T SEEN IT
YET. SO WE'RE WE'RE WORKING ON
THAT CURRENTLY. WHO'S WORKING ON
IT, THE ADMINISTRATION. SO THE
DEPARTMENT, ALONG WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND HAVE
YOU SEEN IT? I HAVE NOT AT THIS
TIME. OKAY NO, I I'M, I'M THERE
WITH YOU. I'M THERE WITH YOU.
I'M THERE WITH YOU, OKAY, WE CAN
ADD PROCEED. I BELIEVE WE ARE
DONE BECAUSE THERE'S NOTHING TO
SHARE. RIGHT? YOU NEED TO ADD,
LAST THING I WANTED TO JUST FLAG
FOR THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON THE
IHSS UNDOCUMENTED. THERE IS CDSS
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT WILL
BE POSTED, WHICH IS VERY BRIEF
BECAUSE IT'S A SINGLE CODE
SECTION BEING AMENDED. HOWEVER,
THERE IS AMENDMENTS NEEDED FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AS WELL. AND THOSE ARE
IN PROCESS AS WELL. SO WE'LL
HAVE ALL THAT TOGETHER. OKAY.
THANK YOU. WE'RE NOW BACK TO
DEPARTMENT OF AGING. Þ LÀ Ó. IS
THERE ANYTHING YOU WANTED TO
SHARE WITH THAT? NO. OKAY.
SORRY, ANGELA, WHAT'S GOING ON?
I DON'T KNOW, YOU KNOW WHAT I
DON'T KNOW? I FEEL LIKE YOU'RE
USUALLY ON THIS SIDE. MY, MY.
YES, I'M ALWAYS THIS WAY. OKAY.
GO AHEAD. PLEASE. ALL RIGHT.
GOOD MORNING. CHAIR. MEMBERS,
MARK BECKLEY, CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING, THERE ARE
TWO QUESTIONS ON THE AGENDA FOR
US, I'LL TAKE THE FIRST
QUESTION, AND I'D LIKE TO TAKE
THE SECOND QUESTION EMBEDDED
WITHIN THE FIRST ITEM, WHICH IS,
HOW MANY HOW DID THE DEMAND FOR
MEALS, COST OF MEALS, INCLUDING
CONGREGATE OPTIONS LIKE MEALS ON
WHEELS, CHANGE DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND DURING THE PANDEMIC
, WE SAW A COUPLE OF SIGNIFICANT
EVENTS OCCUR, ONE IS AND THIS
ACTUALLY KIND OF JUST FOLLOWED
ALONG WITH A TREND THAT HAD BEEN
EXISTING IN THE PROGRAM FOR. SO
LONG, IS A SWITCH FROM
CONGREGATE MEALS TO HOME
DELIVERED MEALS, HOME DELIVERED,
OBVIOUSLY, BECAUSE OUR
CONGREGATE SITES HAD CLOSED DOWN
AND PEOPLE WERE INTERESTED IN
RECEIVING, MEALS AT HOME, THE
TRIPLE A'S ALSO PROVIDED GRAB
AND GO MEALS, BUT THIS DOES SEEM
TO BE A CHANGE THAT, OUR
CUSTOMERS ARE INTERESTED IN. AND
UNDER THE NEW FEDERAL FINAL
RULE, THERE IS MORE FLEXIBILITY
TO SWITCH FUNDING FROM
CONGREGATE TO HOME DELIVERED
MEALS, THE SECOND THING THAT
OCCURRED DURING THE PANDEMIC IS,
YOU KNOW, AND WE'RE VERY PROUD
OF THIS AND PROUD OF OUR TRIPLE
A PARTNERS IS WE'VE SERVED MORE
PEOPLE. THROUGH OUR MEAL
PROGRAMS THAN WE EVER HAVE
BEFORE. AS I TESTIFIED
PREVIOUSLY, OVER THE PAST FIVE
YEARS, WE'VE SERVED 100,000
MORE, MEAL PARTICIPANTS AND
PROVIDED 3 MILLION MORE MEALS,
SO THIS IS, JUST TREMENDOUS
PROGRESS, AND WE DEFINITELY HOPE
TO BUILD UPON THAT PROGRESS IN
THE FUTURE, REGARDING, THE
QUESTION REGARDING IMPACTS. SO
I'D LIKE TO KIND OF BREAK DOWN
THE IMPACTS BASED ON DIFFERENT
FUNDING SOURCES. SO CURRENTLY
THE TRIPLE A'S RECEIVE TWO
ADDITIONAL, ONE TIME FUNDING
SOURCES, ARPA FUNDS, WHICH, IS
AT 77 MILLION IF YOU DIVIDE THAT
OVER THE THREE YEARS OF ARPA,
THAT COMES OUT TO BE $25.6
MILLION A YEAR. AND THEN, HCBS
RELIEF FUNDS, WHICH IS $20
MILLION OVER TWO YEARS COMBINED.
THAT'S 36 MILLION. THAT'S
ROUGHLY THE FIGURE THAT THE
TRIPLE A'S HAD REQUESTED, THE 37
MILLION ON ANNUAL BASIS. SO
THAT'S THE GAP THAT WAS REALLY
INTENDED TO BE CLOSED WITH THIS
FUNDING. THERE WAS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING RECEIVED IN THE CURRENT
YEAR, UNEXPECTED BUT VERY
WELCOME FUNDING IN THE AMOUNT OF
$15 MILLION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION OF COMMUNITY
LIVING TO PROVIDE A BASELINE
AUGMENTATION TO NUTRITION
FUNDING. SO IF YOU TAKE THAT 20
MILLION AND SUBTRACT IT FROM THE
36, THAT GIVES YOU A PROBLEM OF
21 MILLION THAT WERE, THAT THE
TRIPLE A'S WERE SEEKING TO SOLVE
WITH THE OLDER CALIFORNIANS, ACT
FUNDING, THAT THAT ROUGHLY
EQUATES TO ABOUT 9.5% REDUCTION
IN, SPENDING CAPACITY, BY THE
TRIPLE A'S ON NUTRITION SERVICES
. THERE ARE SOME IMPORTANT
CAVEATS THERE, THE FIRST IS WE
HAVE NOT CLOSED THE BOOKS ON
ARPA OR HCBS YET BECAUSE THOSE
FUNDING SOURCES STILL HAVE
ADDITIONAL TIME TO RUN, SO WE
WON'T KNOW UNTIL PROBABLY LATE
NEXT YEAR. IN TERMS OF HOW MUCH
MONEY THEY ACTUALLY SPENT AND
HOW MANY PEOPLE THEY SERVED WITH
THAT FUNDING, AND THEN THEY ALSO
HAVE FLEXIBILITY IN TERMS OF,
THE NUMBER OF MEALS THAT THEY
SERVE TO PARTICIPANTS. SO THEY
ALL OPERATE A COMBINATION OF
BOTH HOME DELIVERED AND
CONGREGATE MEAL SERVICES. SO
DEPENDING ON THAT MIXTURE, IT
COULD RESULT IN A DIFFERENT
NUMBER OF POPULATIONS BEING
SERVED, WITH THEIR FUNDING. SO I
THINK, YOU KNOW, TO REALLY
QUANTIFY THE IMPACT WE'VE BEEN
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE TRIPLE A'S, FULLY UNDERSTAND
LOCAL IMPACTS, AS I MENTIONED IN
LAST THURSDAY'S HEARING, WE DO
HAVE $53 MILLION IN WHAT WE CALL
OLDER CALIFORNIANS ACT
MODERNIZATION FUNDING THAT IS
CURRENTLY DEDICATED TO PROVIDE,
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES SUCH AS
LEGAL CARE GIVING, CARE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES. WE'RE GOING
TO PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY TO THE
TRIPLE A'S TO USE THAT, FUNDING
FOR NUTRITION PROGRAMS SO THEY
CAN MAKE THE DECISION LOCALLY,
IF THEY, USE THAT FUNDING ON
NUTRITION SERVICES, THAT COULD
BRIDGE THE GAP FOR THE NEXT FEW
YEARS, BECAUSE LIKE I SAY, THE
PROBLEM IS 21,000,053 DIVIDED
OVER THE TWO YEARS IS ABOUT 25
AND $26 MILLION A YEAR, SO THAT
WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO THEM. IN
ADDITION, THEY DID RECEIVE THE
FIRST COMPLIMENT OF OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT MODERNIZATION,
NUTRITION FUNDING OF 15 MILLION
IN THE CURRENT YEAR. THAT
FUNDING WILL ALSO STILL BE
AVAILABLE TO THEM TO SPEND UNTIL
MARCH OF 2026. SO TO THE EXTENT
THAT THEY HAVEN'T FULLY SPENT
THEIR ALLOCATION IN THE CURRENT
YEAR, THEY COULD CONTINUE TO
SPEND DOWN THAT FUNDING SOURCE,
SO IN IN A NUTSHELL, THAT'S
REALLY THE DEFINITION OF THE
PROBLEM. WILL WE SEE A DIFFERENT
IMPACT AND DIFFERENT TRIPLE A'S
DEPENDING ON GEOGRAPHICS IN
TERMS OF GEOGRAPHICS YOU MAY
LIKE I SAY IT, I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S SO MUCH GEOGRAPHICS AS MUCH
AS IT IS BASED ON THEIR LOCAL
ASSESSMENTS OF NEEDS, WHETHER
YOU HAVE, YOU KNOW, GREATER
POPULATION, ONES WHO NEED HOME
DELIVERED MEALS VERSUS
CONGREGATE MEALS, BUT I WOULD
IMAGINE THAT THE IMPACTS WOULD
VARY ACCORDING TO TRIPLE A'S.
OKAY BUT AT THE BOTTOM LINE,
IT'S THE 9.5% REDUCTION OVERALL,
RIGHT? THAT'S ACROSS ALL TRIPLE
A'S OR IS JUST THAT'S TOP LINE.
SO IF YOU LOOK AT THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT'S BEEN APPROPRIATED
IN THE CURRENT YEAR FOR TRIPLE
A'S, AND YOU TAKE OUT THE 21
MILLION, IT'S ABOUT A 99. 5%
REDUCTION, OKAY. CAN WE MOVE
INTO THEN WE CAN MOVE INTO THE
SECOND POINT. OKAY. SO I THINK
OKAY, SO THE SECOND ISSUE, OLDER
ADULT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH, SO IN
THE CURRENT YEAR WE HAVE SPENT
325,000 TO DATE. AND JUST KIND
OF EXPLAIN HOW THE FUNDING IS
BEING USED, OLDER ADULT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ETHNIC MEDIA
CAMPAIGN REALLY HAD TWO
COMPONENTS TO IT. THE FIRST IS
CONDUCTING RESEARCH SURVEYS,
FOCUS GROUPS FOR 11 DIFFERENT
ETHNIC COMMUNITIES. AND THE
POINT OF THESE, OF THIS RESEARCH
IS TO IDENTIFY THE NEEDS OF
THESE POPULATIONS AND THEN TO,
TO UNDERSTAND GOOD MESSAGING. SO
WHAT IS IT THAT THEY WOULD NEED
TO KNOW OR HEAR ABOUT TO MAKE
THEM MORE AWARE OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN THEIR AREAS AND BE
WILLING TO ACCEPT THOSE
SERVICES. SO THAT WAS THE FIRST
STAGE, IS RESEARCH. AND THEN THE
OTHER COMPONENT TO IT IS
TRANSLATING OUR AGING PROGRAM
RESOURCE GUIDE IN 17 DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES, SO THAT WAS REALLY
THE WORK ENVISIONED. AND WE
BELIEVE THAT IF WE COULD
ACCOMPLISH THIS FIRST PHASE OF
WORK, THAT'S REALLY GOING TO
MAKE THE SECOND PHASE OF WORK
VERY EFFECTIVE, WHICH IS A PAID
MEDIA CAMPAIGN TO REALLY CONDUCT
ACTIVE OUTREACH TO THESE
POPULATIONS, AGAIN, INCREASING
AWARENESS OF THE SERVICES, BUT
ALSO REDUCING STIGMAS SO THAT
THEY'RE NOT, YOU KNOW, UNWILLING
TO RECEIVE SERVICES ONCE THEY
ARE AWARE OF THEM, SO THAT
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE WORK THAT
WE CURRENTLY HAVE UNDERWAY WITH
OUR CONTRACTOR, AND THAT WE'D
LIKE TO CONTINUE. 312,000 OUT OF
THE 10.5 MILLION, I'M SORRY,
25,000 325,000. CORRECT. OUT OF
THE $10.5 MILLION. CORRECT. SO
LET'S LET'S GET LET'S GET A
LITTLE REAL HERE I UNDERSTAND
THIS. YES. BRING AWARENESS TO
SERVICES. BUT WE'RE SLASHING A
LOT OF SERVICES. YES SO WHAT DO
WE BRING IN AWARENESS TO IN A
YEAR WHERE WE'RE REALLY, REALLY
LOOKING TO SCRAPE DOLLARS TO
FUND CORE SERVICES? THIS IS NOT
ONE OF THEM. AND I KNOW WE'RE
POTENTIALLY IN A CONTRACT WITH
SAID VENDORS, BUT I THINK WE
JUST HEARD UNDER APS, WE'RE
LOOKING TO CUT AND END CONTRACTS
FOR APS, SOCIAL SERVICES, SOCIAL
WORKER TRAINING. SO DEPARTMENT
OR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, IF
WE'RE CUTTING CONTRACTS IN OTHER
AREAS, THIS IS ANOTHER CONTRACT
WE SHOULD CUT BECAUSE THIS IS $9
MILLION MORE, $9.5 MILLION. WE
CAN SAVE TO. AND IF WE'RE
LOOKING AT OLDER ADULTS, SAY FOR
APS, EXPANSION, SAY FOR APS
TRAINING SOCIAL WORKERS, I DON'T
SEE HOW THIS IS A PRIORITY. A
MEDIA CAMPAIGN OVER ACTUAL CORE
SERVICES OR ACTUALLY SERVICES TO
THE COMMUNITY. THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING I WILL BE, INCLINED TO
SUPPORT IN LOOKING AT HOW WE
TRIAGE THINGS, I ECHO THE
CHAIR'S COMMENTS. I THINK IT'S
ABOUT PRIORITIES. AGAIN, THE
SAME THING I SAID TO THE LAST
PANEL. YOU GUYS ALWAYS START
WITH CUTTING SENIOR SERVICES,
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED HEALTH
CARE SERVICE TO THE MOST
VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. AND THEN YOU OFFER
SOMETHING UP. THAT'S 50% OR LESS
OF WHAT THEY'RE, YOU KNOW,
GETTING AND BUT NOT AS MUCH AS
YOU INTENDED OR THAT YOU PUT
FORWARD ON THE CUT, I STILL WANT
TO UNDERSTAND THE METHODOLOGY OF
HOW THAT HAPPENS. LIKE, WHY DO
YOU START THERE? WHY DON'T YOU
START IT? I DON'T KNOW, $30
MILLION FOR THE HEALTH CARE.
BOARD THAT DOES PRICING. WHY
DON'T YOU START? I MEAN, I
REALIZE IT'S FEDERAL AND BOND
DOLLARS, BUT WE'RE SPENDING
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON THE HIGH SPEED RAIL. WHY NOT?
YOU KNOW, DELAY THAT FOR, YOU
KNOW, 60, 90, 100 DAYS OR
WHATEVER. AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN OUR
SOCIETY HAVE FOOD, FOOD IS SORT
OF A NECESSITY WAITING FOR THE
NEXT 50 YEARS FOR THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL IS JUST SHOULDN'T BE TOP
PRIORITY. AND I REALIZE THERE'S
SEPARATE DOLLARS, BUT AGAIN,
THERE'S A LOT OF MONEY, LIKE THE
ADVERTISING CAMPAIGN, LIKE THE
CHAIR JUST SAID, WHY ARE WE
SPENDING MONEY TO GET PEOPLE TO
SIGN UP FOR SERVICES THAT YOU
ARE CUTTING? YOU CAN RESPOND.
WHY ARE WHY ARE WE SPENDING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS? WHY ARE WE
DOING THAT? T I. ALREADY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT FOR THE
10.5 MILLION UNSPENT, FOR THESE
FOR THIS PROGRAM, FOR THE OLDER
ADULT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THAT,
THESE DOLLARS ARE ENCUMBERED AND
THEY'RE PROMISED IN CONTRACTS TO
LOCALS ON THE GROUND. SO WE FELT
IT WAS IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN
THOSE CONTRACTS. RIGHT. SO
THOSE. I'M SORRY. THOSE SORRY,
MADAM CHAIR, THOSE CONTRACTS
EXCUSE I MEAN, WE'RE WE'RE
CLAWING BACK $12,000. 12,000
SLOTS OF CHILD CARE, OF AWARDED
LETTERS. BUT WE CAN DO THAT.
THOSE ARE ENCUMBERED, SO I'VE
ASKED IF WE'RE GOING TO DO SOME
APPROACH. FOR ONE, WE'RE GOING
TO DO IT FOR ALL. I WANT TO SEE
A COPY OF THE CONTRACTS, TOO.
THERE'S GOT TO BE AN OUT CLAUSE.
YOU DON'T HAVE A 30 DAY
CANCELLATION NOTICE OR A, FEE
BUYOUT THING THAT MAYBE WE PAY,
YOU KNOW, 1% OR WHATEVER IT IS.
WHAT ARE THE CONTRACTS? SAY IS
THERE A CANCELLATION NOTICE?
DOES THE EITHER PARTY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO CANCEL? AND IF SO, WHAT
ARE THE TERMS, I'M UNAWARE AT
THE MOMENT OF THE SPECIFICS OF
THE TERMS OF THE CONTRACTS, BUT
WE'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE THAT BACK
FOR YOU BECAUSE AGAIN, THE WHAT
WE WENT OVER ON APS, ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES, THERE'S
ALREADY CONTRACTS OUT FOR THE
TRAINING FOR SOCIAL WORKERS AND
THE DEPARTMENT SAID THAT THEY'RE
GETTING OUT OF THEM. THEY'RE
GOING TO BE ENDING THE CONTRACTS
AMENDING. SO I KNOW WE CAN DO
THAT FOR OTHER AREAS. IT JUST
SEEMS LIKE WE'RE PICKING AND
CHOOSING WHICH ONES WE'RE GOING
TO GET OUT OF VERSUS OTHERS.
THIS IS SO MUCH MONEY THAT WE
CAN USE FOR ACTUAL SERVICES THAT
IF THERE IS A CLOT, THERE'S
ALWAYS MOST LIKELY A CLAUSE
RIGHT, TO GET OUT A PENALTY. WE
PAY FOR THAT OFFSETS THE SAVINGS
THAT WE CAN GET FROM THIS. A
MEDIAN CAMPAIGN, WE'RE TELLING
CALIFORNIANS WE'RE CUTTING
ACTUAL CASEWORKERS FOR ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES, BUT WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE YOU ADS ON
INSTAGRAM THAT'S NOWHERE NEAR
HOW WE SHOULD TRIAGE, TRIAGE
WHAT SHOULD BE CUT AND SAVED IN
THIS YEAR. AND TO FOLLOW UP ON
THAT, THERE WAS A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION PASSED LAST YEAR
THAT SIGNED INTO LAW, WENT
THROUGH BOTH HOUSES, SIGNED INTO
LAW TO INCREASE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS TO, I DON'T KNOW, $20 AN
HOUR, $25 AN HOUR, WHATEVER IT
WAS. AND THE STATE IS RENEGING
ON THAT, NOT RENEGING. BUT
THEY'RE THEY REALIZE THEY CAN'T
AFFORD IT, SO THEY'RE NOT DOING
IT. SO THEY'RE JUST
AUTOMATICALLY ARBITRARILY
SWEEPING AND SAYING, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO THAT FOR STATE
WORKERS, SO EVEN IF THERE ISN'T
A CLAUSE IN THE CONTRACT, WHICH
THERE SHOULD BE, IN THE PRIVATE
WORLD, I HAVE STATE CONTRACTS. I
KNOW THERE'S A CLAUSE IN THERE
FOR TERMINATION, AND THE RIGHT
TO TERMINATE. I WANT A COPY OF
THE CONTRACTS, AND I ALSO WANT
TO KNOW IF THE ADMINISTRATION IS
WILLING TO JUST NULL AND VOID
THOSE CONTRACTS, JUST LIKE THEY
DID WITH THE INCREASE IN THE
WAGES WHICH THEY WERE ABLE TO DO
FOR WHATEVER REASON, WITH NOT
HAVING OAN. I MEAN, WHERE'S A
PARGA ATTORNEY WHEN YOU NEED
ONE? BUT IT'S NOT HAPPENING. SO
WHAT'S THE WAY OUT? BECAUSE I
SIDE WITH THE CHAIR ON THIS
THAT, YOU KNOW, IF YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO DELIVER FOOD TO PEOPLE
WHO NEED IT AND CAN'T AFFORD TO
BUY FOOD, ESPECIALLY WITH THE
COST OF FOOD, LIKE SHE SAID, WHY
ARE YOU POSTING ADS ON INSTAGRAM
AND PAYING THAT? I DON'T WANT TO
UNDERVALUE. I KNOW IT'S PROBABLY
NOT ADS ON INSTAGRAM, BUT IT IS
AT THE END OF DAY. SO SOCIAL
MEDIA CAMPAIGN, I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE ANY. IT IS.
I MEAN, AND I THINK THE ONLY
THING I WOULD ADD WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT PROVIDING SERVICES TO
CUSTOMERS, WHAT WE'RE REALLY
SEEING THIS AT LEAST FIRST PHASE
OF WORK DOING IS SETTING THE
STAGE FOR LEVERAGING THE
PROPOSITION ONE MONEY TO REALLY
IMPLEMENT A ROBUST CAMPAIGN FOR
THESE COMMUNITIES. SO IT WAS
REALLY MORE OF A STEPWISE
PROCESS, IF YOU WILL. SO WE DO
THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY,
THIS WILL, YOU KNOW, DELIVER
VALUABLE SERVICES THAT ARE
FUNDED, THIS IS REALLY JUST THE
FIRST PART OF THE PROCESS. I
KNOW I HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION,
MADAM CHAIR. HOW MANY SENIORS
ARE ON INSTAGRAM? I JUST MADE
THAT UP. I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S ON
INSTAGRAM. I WAS JUST HOW MANY
YOU DON'T WANT US ON SOCIAL
MEDIA? 65 AND OLDER THAT WE
PROVIDE FOOD? I THINK IT'S JUST
MEDIA. MEDIA RIGHT? COULD BE TV,
TV, ANYTHING, RIGHT, YEAH. PRINT
MEDIA I WAS JUST AND WHEN WE DO
CONDUCT MEDIA CAMPAIGNS, WE MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO IT IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT MODALITIES. YEAH,
DEFINITELY NOT JUST THE
INTERNET, BUT ALSO THROUGH, YOU
KNOW, TV, RADIO ADS, PRINT ADS.
I'D LIKE A LOT OF THAT AS WELL.
LIKE, WHAT DO WE SPEND ON PRINT
ADS, MEDIA ADS, TELEVISION ADS,
RADIO ADS AND SOCIAL MEDIA FOR
THE OLDER ADULT POPULATION? THE
OLDER ADULT POPULATION? OKAY, I
CAN SEE AND WE'RE NOT THE ONLY
DEPARTMENT, OF COURSE, WHO RUNS
THOSE KIND OF PROGRAMS. BUT
OKAY, I UNDER I UNDERSTAND LIKE,
YOU KNOW, THE FIRST STEP
LEVERAGE. HOW ARE WE GOING TO
EXPAND OUR PROP ONE. BUT AGAIN
WHEN WE'RE LOOKING TO TRIAGE
THIS, THIS SHOULDN'T BE ONE THAT
WE'RE GIVING A LIFELINE TO AT
ALL. Ã LEÓN COMMENTS ON OUR
LEGISLATIVE OFFICE. SO WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO, LOOK
THROUGH THESE NUMBERS THAT WE'VE
BEEN GIVEN THROUGHOUT THIS TIME,
BUT ALSO TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT
THE MEDIA CAMPAIGN CONTRACTS
MOVING FORWARD. OKAY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. LÀ. DO YOU HAVE THAT
LANGUAGE? DO YOU HAVE ALL THAT
LANGUAGE? OKAY. I'M SORRY,
LANGUAGE FOR DO YOU HAVE THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE OR DO YOU
HAVE ALL THIS LANGUAGE ON THE
CONTRACTS AND STUFF? DO YOU HAVE
THAT IN YOUR POSSESSION NOW? NOT
AT THIS TIME, OKAY. BUT YOU'RE
GOING TO GET IT AND LOOK THROUGH
IT. BUT WE'LL ASK FOR IT. YOU'LL
ASK FOR IT. WILL YOU GET WILL WE
ASK FOR WILL? WE'LL BE HAPPY TO
SHARE THE INFORMATION. AND THEN
THERE ARE TERMINATION CLAUSES IN
ALL OF OUR CONTRACTS. JUST SO
YOU KNOW, THE CONTRACTS ARE
ALWAYS SUBJECT TO BUDGET ACT
APPROPRIATION. SO OKAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ABSOLUTELY
MOVING ON TO, DDS OR MOVING BACK
TO DDS.
WE NEVER DO ANYTHING ELSE.
SO WE'RE BRINGING THESE BACK UP
JUST TO CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION THAT WE HAD. I'M
MOSTLY INTERESTED. WE DON'T HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THE WHOLE THING.
MOSTLY INTERESTED ON ANY
POTENTIAL UPDATES. WE HAVE FROM
OUR LAST CONVERSATION. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. KARLA
CASTANEDA WITH DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. AND WE
DO HAVE A HANDFUL OF UPDATES,
NOT ALL OF THEM. RIGHT THE FIRST
ISSUE, ONE THAT YOU HAD ASKED
FOR ON THE MAY REVISION WAS ON
THE COMPLEX NEEDS HOMES AND IF
ANY OF THAT COULD BE RETRIEVED
OR, ANY OF THE APPROPRIATION WAS
BEEN SPENT TO DATE. SO WITH THE
EXECUTION OF THE CONTRACT, WE
DID PAY THE FAIRVIEW MANAGEMENT
COMPANY THE 10 MILLION TO THEN
ADDRESS THE DEVELOPMENT AT
FAIRVIEW, SO WE DON'T WE'RE
STILL LOOKING AT THE TECHNICAL
FEASIBILITY OF ANY RETURN, AND
WE'LL CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE
500,000 THAT WAS ATTRIBUTABLE
FOR STAFFING AND BRINGING THOSE
ON BOARD. SO WE PAID FAIRVIEW
THE 10.5 MILLION ALREADY 10
MILLION FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE HOME. SO THAT WOULD INCLUDE
THE DEVELOPMENT ANY OF THE
DEMOLITION BECAUSE STATUE
DOESN'T WANT ANY OF THE EXISTING
STRUCTURES. AND WE ARE LOOKING
TO INCORPORATE THOSE AT NEAR TO
ADJACENT TO HARBOR VILLAGE TO
MINIMIZE ANY ISSUES WITH
UTILITIES AND OTHER. OKAY. CHECK
HAS GONE OUT. AND THEN ON THE
500,000 THAT THAT WE WILL LIKELY
STILL HAVE A REMAINING FUNDS,
WE'RE JUST STILL RECONCILING ON
THAT BECAUSE IT DOES DEPEND ON
RAMPING UP OUR STAFF. AND THAT'S
THE POTENTIAL UNSPENT. BUT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR 2324. CORRECT
. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. AND THEN
LET'S MOVE ON. OH SO NO WORK HAS
BEEN COMPLETED YET, WE'VE WE'VE
IDENTIFIED TWO POTENTIAL
LOCATIONS. SO A LOT OF THE WORK
WAS ASSESSING SOME OF WHAT'S
AVAILABLE IN PRIOR, ASSESSMENTS
OF THE SITES, THE ANY POLLUTION
OR, THE BUILDINGS ON THE
LOCATIONS. SO THE 10 MILLION
THAT WAS GIVEN TO FAIRVIEW, WAS
GIVEN AS A LUMP SUM? YES.
CORRECT. WITHOUT CONSTRUCTION OR
ANYTHING DONE. CORRECT. AND WHEN
WE'RE DOING HOUSING DEVELOPMENT,
WE TYPICALLY PUT THAT FULL
AMOUNT ASIDE SO THAT IT'S
AVAILABLE AS THE PROJECTS
CONTINUE. OKAY. I DID THAT WITH
MY CONTRACTOR AS A BAD NEWS.
DIDN'T FINISH A PROJECT AND THEN
I NEVER GOT MY MONEY BACK. BUT
THAT'S NEITHER HERE NOR THERE.
BATHROOM UPGRADE. OKAY. SO 20,
23, 24. WE GOT NOTHING.
POTENTIALLY $500,000 THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO ROLL OVER INTO THIS
YEAR. THERE IS NO ADDITIONAL
AUTHORITY FOR THOSE DOLLARS. SO
THEY WOULD ONLY BE AVAILABLE
THROUGH THIS FISCAL YEAR. AND IF
NOT ENCUMBERED THEN THOSE WOULD
BE LOST, REVERTED TO THE GENERAL
FUND. CORRECT. SO THEY CAN
POTENTIALLY BE REVERTED TO THE
GENERAL FUND. A PORTION OF THAT
COULD BE. SO WE HAVE A MONTH AND
A HALF TO SPEND IT. WE STILL
HAVE TO RECONCILE. NOT THAT IT
WOULD BE SPENT BECAUSE THESE
WERE FOR THE STAFF RESOURCES. SO
WHETHER THAT IS HIRING IN
PROGRESS OR, PREPARING FOR THEM
TO DO MUCH OF THAT RIGHT NOW.
RIGHT. CORRECT OKAY. SO
POTENTIALLY WE COULD HAVE THE
FULL $500,000 UNSPENT. I DON'T
HAVE MORE DETAILS ON THAT. DOES
THIS INCLUDE THE 8, VACANCY? Kò.
NO, IT DOES NOT. NO, NO, IT SAYS
NO. OKAY. GO AHEAD. NO. SORRY.
RIGHT. THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO.
CHRIS O'NEILL, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THAT'S CORRECT. MADAM
CHAIR. OKAY WHEN ARE WE LOOKING
AT. LOOK, I KNOW 500,000 IS
NOTHING, RIGHT? POCKET CHANGE
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, BUT
I'M. YOU KNOW WHAT I'M DOING?
I'M LOOKING AT EVERYTHING. COUCH
CUSHIONS. WHEN ARE WE GONNA
ADMIT TO OURSELVES, LIKE, HEY,
THIS IS REALLY GOING TO GO
UNSPENT? ARE WE? DO WE HAVE AN
INTERNAL TIMELINE? CHRIS
O'NEILL, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
I DON'T THINK THERE'S AN
INTERNAL TIMELINE FOR THAT. I
THINK WHEN IT CAME TO THIS
PROGRAM AND DEVELOPING THE MAY
REVISION OR ASSUMPTIONS HAD
LINED UP AT THE TIME, YOU KNOW,
CERTAINLY, YOU KNOW, IF THERE
WERE AN ACTION TAKEN BY THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THAT 500, YOU
KNOW, WE OBVIOUSLY WE'LL TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT AT NUMBER TWO. BUT
YEAH. OKAY. OKAY. LET'S MOVE ON
TO PORTERVILLE. DURING THE THIS
WAS MORE ABOUT THE POPULATION
AND THE HISTORICAL TREND OF THAT
POPULATION. SO THE FIRST QUARTER
OF 2024, WE'VE HAD AN AVERAGE
CENSUS AND AVERAGE MONTHLY
CENSUS OF 176 INDIVIDUALS, OVER
THE LAST FIVE YEARS, THAT ANNUAL
AN ANNUAL AVERAGE HAS RANGED
FROM A HIGH OF 208. IN 2019 TO A
LOW OF 187 IN 2023, 177, 187,
208 AND 2019. CORRECT AND 187
AND 280. IN 2023. SO GOING BY
CALENDAR YEAR, DO WE WHAT'S HOW
MANY DO WE HAVE RIGHT NOW?
CURRENTLY IT IS A I BELIEVE IT'S
ONE 7676. OKAY WE DO SEE A TREND
DOWN. IT DOES GO UP AND DOWN
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. SO THESE
THESE ANNUAL AVERAGES DO HAVE
THAT APPEARANCE, WE DO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT DURING ANY
GIVEN MONTH YOU MIGHT HAVE
HIGHER CLOSER TO THE CAP. SO OF
COURSE THE BUDGET ALLOWS THAT
CAPACITY FLEXIBILITY FOR WHEN
THERE ARE REFERRALS FROM THE
COURTS TO PORTERVILLE. OKAY AND
MADAM CHAIR CHRIS O'NEIL,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, JUST TO
CLARIFY, TO JUST PORTERVILLE IS
UNIQUE IN THAT, A LARGE SEGMENT
OF THE POPULATION SERVED THERE
ARE INDIVIDUALS DEEMED
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL, JUST
LIKE WHO THE STATE HOSPITALS
SERVE. AND SO THE SERVICES THERE
ARE HIGHLY DEPENDENT UPON KIND
OF VARIABILITIES WITH THE COURT
SYSTEM AS WELL. AND SO I THINK
IT'S INSTRUCTIVE TO, LOOK AT
THOSE AVERAGES AND KIND OF SEE
THE UPS AND DOWNS AND THE POINTS
AND TIMES DO FLUCTUATE. BUT AT
THIS POINT, THAT'S THE 211 CAP.
THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD, WOULD
SEE THAT AS A REASONABLE LANDING
SPOT, I MEAN, TO MAINTAIN THAT,
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT'S CURRENTLY
ALLOWED IN STATUTE. AND THAT'S
WHERE WE THINK MAINTAINING THAT,
THAT NUMBER IS, IS IMPORTANT. SO
AND HOW MANY EMPLOYEES DO WE
HAVE WORKING THERE? I WILL
DOUBLE CHECK FOR YOU. I BELIEVE
IT'S CLOSE TO 1400 FOR THE FULL
POPULATION FACILITY. THAT
INCLUDES LEVEL OF CARE AND
OPERATIONS. THE 20 MILLION WOULD
BE FOR HOW MANY POSITIONS? I
DON'T HAVE THAT WITH ME, I, WE
WOULD NEED TO CALL. I THINK WE
WOULD NEED TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION. I'M NOT AND I'M
NOT. I'M NOT SURE OF FEASIBILITY
JUST BECAUSE I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY
POSITIONS ARE DIFFERENT SALARY
RANGES AND THINGS LIKE THAT,
BUT, WE COULD TAKE THAT BACK AND
TRY TO UNPACK THAT MORE. MADAM
CHAIR, IT'S CHRIS. IT IS? YES
CHRIS. YEAH. SO, CHRIS, WE'RE
ASKING FOR $20 MILLION FOR OUR
STAFF, RIGHT? MIKE. BUT WE DON'T
KNOW. STAFF. NO, ACTUALLY, WHAT
WE WERE DOING WAS CAPTURING
SAVINGS IN THE CURRENT YEAR. SO
BASED ON VACANCY. SO AS MY
COLLEAGUE WAS SO WE'RE REVERTING
THAT IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
CORRECT. JUST ACKNOWLEDGING
HIRING CHALLENGES AT PORTERVILLE
WHEN WE DEVELOPED THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, WE, THE ADMINISTRATION
DETERMINED IT WAS A REASONABLE
ASSUMPTION TO SCORE 20 MILLION
IN SAVINGS, IT WAS, YOU KNOW, IT
WAS A LOOK, WE WERE GOING WE
WERE PARTWAY THROUGH THE CURRENT
YEAR, MADE THAT KIND OF
ASSESSMENT. AND SO WE BROUGHT
DOWN WHAT WE THOUGHT WOULD BE
PROJECTED EXPENDITURES AT
PORTERVILLE, FOR STAFFING, YOU
KNOW, I THINK WE WOULD MAINTAIN
THAT FULLY BUDGETING PORTERVILLE
IN BUT BUDGETING PORTERVILLE FOR
FULL STAFFING IN BUDGET YEAR IS
THE IS STILL THE APPROPRIATE WAY
FORWARD. AND THEN, YOU KNOW, I
WOULD SAY I DON'T KNOW IF WE
WOULD GO THROUGH THE SAME
EXERCISE AGAIN FOR PORTERVILLE
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S SOME OTHER GLOBAL THINGS
HAPPENING IN THE BUDGET AS WELL
WITH THE REDUCTIONS IN AND
ASSESSING VACANCIES, MORE
GLOBALLY, ACROSS STATE
GOVERNMENT AS WELL. SO I THINK
IT KIND OF COMPLICATES THE
PICTURE GOING FORWARD. SO GOING
WITH, YES, HIRING DIFFICULTIES,
CHALLENGES PROBABLY ARE GOING TO
PERSIST, RIGHT. WE FEEL
CONFIDENT YOU WERE GOING TO USE
THE FULL 20 MILLION TO BRING IN
THE PEOPLE THAT WE NEED TO
SUPPORT THE POPULATION AT ANY
GIVEN TIME, WE WOULD BE LOOKING
AT THE PERMANENT STAFF THAT ARE
HIRED, VOLUNTARY OVERTIME OR
MANDATORY OVERTIME. IN ADDITION
TO CONTRACTED SUPPORT, SO WE'RE
KIND OF MORE LOOKING FOR THE
SUPPORTING, WHAT WE'VE HAD AS AN
AVERAGE PLUS THAT ROOM FOR
ADMISSIONS AS OUR REFERRALS
HAPPEN, I THINK THE OTHER
CLARIFICATION I WANTED TO ADD,
SORT OF FOR CONTEXT, FOR
PLANNING FOR THE UNKNOWN
ADMISSION REFERRALS IS, BEING
ABLE TO ADDRESS THE ACUITY OF
INDIVIDUALS WHEN THEY COME INTO
OUR FACILITY SO THEY MAY NOT
FALL INTO Ã, THEY MAY NEED MORE
INDIVIDUAL SUPPORT, WHICH COULD
RESULT IN LIKE ONE ON ONE
SUPERVISION OR ADDITIONAL STAFF.
I MEAN, WE HAVE A LOT OF
DIVERSION PROGRAMS, AND EVEN
THIS YEAR THE LEGISLATURE IS HAS
INTRODUCED A NUMBER OF BILLS TO
DIVERT FROM GOING INTO STATE
HOSPITALS OR KIND OF OTHER
ESTABLISHMENTS LIKE THIS. I DO
SEE OUR NUMBERS TO DECREASE AS
WE CONTINUE, AND WE'LL SEE THAT
TREND TEAM HERE. I'M STILL I
DON'T KNOW IF THE FULL 20
MILLION AND I RECOGNIZE WE NEED
TO HAVE A GOOD RATIO. WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS LAST YEAR, BUT WHAT
IF WE'RE NOT USING THE FULL 20
MILLION, I'M NOT SAYING THAT YOU
DON'T NEED THE FULL, BUT GIVEN
THE TREND OF DECREASING AMOUNT
OF CLIENTS HERE, ALSO THE
DIFFICULTY ON ONBOARDING, THE
DIFFICULTY IN FINDING PEOPLE TO
WORK IN THIS SPACE, AND LOOKING
AT HOW WE CAN APPROACH THESE
AREAS, PERHAPS A LOWER AMOUNT OF
DOLLARS HERE SEEMS MORE
APPROPRIATE, SO JUST THROWING
THAT BACK OUT AS WE CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION ON THIS TOPIC.
QUESTIONS ON PORTERVILLE. YES.
GO AHEAD. SENATOR. SO A FOLLOW
UP ON THE 20 MILLION. FIRST,
THERE'S 1400 EMPLOYEES AND AT A
MAX CAPACITY, IT'S 211 PEOPLE
THAT ARE SERVED. I REALIZE
THEY'RE BEHIND THE FENCE PEOPLE
I REALIZE THEY'RE NOT YOU KNOW,
THEY'RE A DIFFERENT TYPE OF
PERSON OTHER THAN IN A REGULAR
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER, BUT THAT'S
LIKE ALMOST SEVEN EMPLOYEES PER
INDIVIDUAL. SO IF YOU HAD TO
TELL ME WHAT THOSE SEVEN
EMPLOYEES DID PER INDIVIDUAL,
WHAT WOULD THEY DO? I THINK A
LARGE PART OF IT IS THE MULTIPLE
SHIFTS, BECAUSE IT IS A 24 HOUR
FACILITY. SO THE LEVEL OF CARE
STAFF WOULD BE COVERING ALL
SHIFTS, THE THREE SHIFTS DURING
THE DAY, THAT INCLUDES OFFICE OF
PROTECTIVE SERVICES WOULD BE
SUPPORTING THREE SHIFTS FOR
INDIVIDUALS ON THE
ADMINISTRATIVE SIDE, IT'S MORE
LIKE THE TRADITIONAL OPERATIONS
OF A DEPARTMENT, WITH THE STAFF
WHO ARE DOING THE PROCUREMENT,
DOING THE HUMAN RESOURCE WORK.
SO ON THE 20 MILLION TO FOLLOW
UP ON THE CHAIR'S QUESTION, AND
YOU DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
POSITIONS THAT IS, $20 MILLION.
HOW MANY POSITIONS DOES THAT GET
US FOR $20 MILLION, SENATOR
GROVE, WE WHEN WE SCORED THOSE
SAVINGS WE WEREN'T WE WEREN'T
TYING IT NECESSARILY TO THE
NUMBER OF AUTHORIZED POSITIONS.
JUST ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THERE
WAS PROBABLY SOME SAVINGS,
RELATED TO, TO HIRING
CHALLENGES. AND SO, SO DO YOU
HAVE THE FORMULA, HOW YOU SCORED
THAT SAVINGS $20 MILLION OR IS
THAT JUST LIKE A NUMBER YOU
LIKE? I DON'T KNOW WE'RE THE $20
MILLION COME FROM LIKE WHO
DETERMINED WHAT THAT WAS LIKE.
WE'RE GOING TO SAVE $20 MILLION
ON PORTERVILLE OR WE'RE GOING TO
SPEND $20 MILLION ON PORTERVILLE
NOT SAVE. WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE
GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO SPEND
$20 MILLION ON PORTERVILLE TO
HIRE NEW PEOPLE WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT SAYS HE'S
TAKING 8% OF VACANT POSITIONS TO
REDUCE EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION
COSTS. SO WE'RE TAKING 8% ACROSS
THE BOARD FOR PEOPLE THAT WE
EMPLOY NOW. BUT WE'RE GOING TO
SPEND $20 MILLION TO HIRE. WE
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE FOR
WHAT POSITIONS. IT'S JUST $20
MILLION. LIKE HOW DID YOU COME
UP WITH THE $20 MILLION. AND HOW
MANY POSITIONS IS THAT SENATOR.
WE I, I COULDN'T DESCRIBE A
NUMBER OF POSITIONS TO THAT
NUMBER, I THINK LOOKING AT WHAT
PORTERVILLE HAS BUDGET AND
TOTALITY WHICH I CAN PULL THAT
NUMBER FOR YOU, BUT, JUST
KNOWING THE HIRING CHALLENGES
AND THE, THE VACANCY RATES THAT
ARE DEALT WITH, IT WAS, IT WAS A
, A REASONABLE, WE DETERMINED,
WAS A REASONABLE ESTIMATE OF
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO, TO PUT
FORWARD WHAT, WHAT BASIS LIKE
IT'S JUST I MEAN, I HAVE A
HOUSEHOLD INCOME OF I KNOW WHAT
MY BUDGET IS AND I CAN'T GO I'M
GOING TO SAVE $5,000 THIS MONTH.
HOW? I DON'T KNOW, JUST $5,000
OR I'M GOING TO SPEND AN
ADDITIONAL $5,000. WHERE WHERE
AM I GOING TO GET THE MONEY? SO
HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH $20
MILLION? AND YOU'RE SAYING IT'S
BASED ON THEIR TOTAL BUDGET?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN? AND BEFORE
YOU ANSWER, I THINK TO THAT
POINT, I THINK THAT'S WHY THE 20
MILLION SEEMS A LITTLE
ARBITRARY. THAT'S WHY I'M LIKE,
I KNOW YOU NEED TO HIRE SOME
PEOPLE. LET'S BRING THAT DOLLAR
AMOUNT LOWER, BECAUSE WE'RE
POTENTIALLY GOING TO STILL IN,
COME ACROSS THE SAME BARRIERS
THAT WE CAME ACROSS A YEAR AGO
AND HAVING MORE WILL STILL HELP
IN PORTERVILLE. AND YOU CAN COME
BACK AGAIN. I JUST THE FULL 20
MILLION UP FRONT WHERE
POTENTIALLY YOU'LL SAY, HEY, WE
DIDN'T USE IT. AND THEN I'M
LIKE, WELL, WE CUT THESE OTHER
SERVICES AND WE COULD HAVE USED
IT FOR THAT IS WHAT WE'RE HOPING
TO ACCOMPLISH. WE HAVE 45
MINUTES LEFT, SO I AND I HAVE TO
GET THROUGH PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
HUMAN SERVICES. SO WE'RE GOING
TO OKAY, I'M SORRY, BUT MY LAST
FOLLOW UP COMMENT IS, IS THAT
YOUR CUTTING 6% OR 8% IN VACANT
POSITIONS, BUT YOU'RE ASKING FOR
20 MILLION FOR POSITIONS. AND
IT'S PORTERVILLE IS IN MY
DISTRICT. I'M NOT TRYING TO STOP
JOBS IN MY DISTRICT. I'M JUST
TRYING TO SAY, YOU HAVE TO COME
UP WITH A NUMBER THAT'S GOING TO
BE ADEQUATE FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO HIRE, AND NOT
JUST THROW $20 MILLION AT THE
PROGRAM AT THE VERY BEGINNING,
WHEN OTHER SERVICES ARE BEING
CUT. OKAY. UNDERSTOOD, SENATOR.
THANK YOU. OKAY. THE LAST, ISSUE
ON NUMBER THREE REALLY QUICK,
ANY, ARE WE LOOKED AT JUST
HAVING A NUMBER, A LOW NUMBER? I
KNOW 10 MILLION, APPROXIMATELY.
IF WE'RE THINKING WE'RE GOING TO
SPEND A LITTLE BIT MORE THAN
THAT, THEN WE SHOULD HAVE, LIKE,
A VERY CONSERVATIVE NUMBER THAT
WE SHOULD SAY FROM THIS
AUTOMATICALLY INCLUDED IN THE
JUNE REVISED OR WHATEVER, AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. ANYTHING ELSE ON
THAT? CHRIS SENATOR MANAGER, I,
WE DON'T HAVE UPDATES TO THE
NUMBERS THAT ARE CITED IN THE
AGENDA OR THAT HAVE BEEN
PREVIOUSLY PROVIDED TO STAFF.
OKAY. SO I'M SORRY, IS
PORTERVILLE UNDERSTAFFED NOW?
AND THAT'S WHY YOU NEED THESE
POSITIONS. I DON'T THINK I THINK
WE'RE I THINK I GOT CONFUSED
WITH THE ISSUES CROSSING. DO WE
MOVED ON TO THE WORKFORCE?
SENATOR I HAD A QUESTION. OKAY,
SO, FOR STAFFING FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE THERE, WE
WILL USE WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
PERMANENT STAFF. BUT WHAT WE DO
IS THERE'S VOLUNTARY OVERTIME,
MANDATORY OVERTIME, AND
SUPPLEMENTED WITH REGISTRY
CONTRACTS TO SUPPORT THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE ADMITTED
AND THE BUDGET WE HAVE FOR THEM
RIGHT NOW DOES NOT COVER THAT.
THE PROPOSED GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
WOULD PLEASE. RIGHT? YES. THE
PROPOSED GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OR
THE PROPOSED BUDGET YEAR DOES
SUPPORT THE 211 CAPACITY. AND
WE'RE NOT AT 211, THOUGH. NO,
WE'RE AT 176. CORRECT. BUT THE
CAPACITY ALSO SORRY ALSO ALLOWS
FOR THE WHETHER YOU HAVE THE ONE
ON ONE SUPERVISION OR AS YOU
ADMIT, INDIVIDUALS TO ADDRESS
THAT. SO WE'RE AT 176 CAPACITY.
YOUR FUNDING. YOU WANT FUNDING
FOR 211. BUT WE'RE ON 176.
WHAT'S THE SAVINGS DIFFERENCE
FROM THE 176 TO THE TWO? THE
211? I DON'T HAVE THAT WITH ME.
BUT GET BACK TO YOU ON DSP, BUT
THEY WANT ON THE TUITION. SO
MOVING ON TO THE THIRD ONE ON
THE TUITION AND THE STIPEND
PROGRAM. COULD YOU JUST ASK
ANSWER THE MIDDLE OF THE, OF THE
QUESTION, COULD THE PROGRAM, THE
TUITION BE LIMITED IN A SIMILAR
WAY TO THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSED LIMITATION OF THE
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM? JUST GIVING
OUT THE WANT TO THE ONES THAT
ALREADY ARE IN THE PROGRAM AND
TAKING BACK THE TAKING OUT THE
REMAINING FUNDING? I THINK ON A
TECHNICAL ASPECT, THAT'S AN
ACTION THE LEGISLATURE COULD
OKAY, COULD TAKE. YEAH AND THEN
ON THE STIPENDS, WE STILL DON'T
HAVE A NUMBER, I THINK AS A
DEPARTMENT PREVIOUSLY. SURE,
THERE'S A 90 DAY LAG AND
UNDERSTANDING. SO THE FIGURE,
THE $10 MILLION FIGURE THAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY PROVIDED TO STAFF IS
WE DON'T HAVE AN UPDATE OKAY. AN
UPDATE NUMBER. BUT THAT NUMBER
WE'RE STILL LOOKING AT THIS
BECAUSE WE COULD POTENTIALLY SEE
A SAVINGS ON THAT AS WELL.
WHETHER IT'S AS LOW AS 3
MILLION, 2 MILLION OUT OF THE 10
MILLION. YEAH. THE TEN IS THE
BEST FIGURE THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
STAFF AT THIS. WE CAN PROVIDE
THE LEGISLATURE AT THIS POINT.
YEAH. ALL RIGHT. KEEP IN MIND
WE'RE VOTING ON THIS NEXT WEEK.
UNDERSTOOD. SENATOR LEÓN
COMMENTS ON THIS. KARINA HENDREN
LEÓN NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS
TIME. OKAY? WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON. SENATOR. SENATOR HARVICK
SORRY, JUST WE WANTED TO MAKE
ONE CLARIFICATION, IN THE
AGENDA, JUST, THE AGENDA NOTED
STOPPING NEW ENROLLMENTS IN THE
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM. AND WE JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE WE WERE
CLEAR THAT THERE'S A NUANCE HERE
OF WE'RE HONORING THE EXISTING
COMMITMENTS. BUT WE, YOU KNOW,
WE DON'T HAVE TOTAL VISIBILITY
INTO PLACEMENTS THAT MAY BE
PENDING OUT THERE. AND SO THAT
WAS THE THAT WAS THE ASSUMPTION,
THAT THAT'S WHAT THE 2.5
REFLECTS IS THAT IS THAT KIND OF
ASSUMPTION. SO I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE SURE WE WERE CLEAR WE DON'T
KNOW IF SOME ARE ONBOARDING
RIGHT NOW IN CURRENT YEAR.
CORRECT. YEAH. SO THAT'S SO THEY
COULD POTENTIALLY BE CUT OFF
WITHOUT EVEN STARTING OR KNOW
THE INTENT OF SCORING THE 20
MILLION SAVINGS WAS TO, MAKE
SURE WE COULD CAPTURE THOSE,
THOSE AS WELL. YES EXACTLY. SO
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU
WEREN'T SEEING THIS AS A HARD
CUT OFF OF THE, OF THE NUMBER
THAT WE PROVIDED LAST WEEK. JUST
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF NUANCE
THERE. SO WE JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY THAT FOR THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU CAN MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR, FOR AN UPDATE ON THE
TERM'S IN YOUTH MODERNIZATION
PROJECTS, IN JANUARY, WE
SUBMITTED THE STAGE TWO
ALTERNATIVE ANALYSIS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY FOR
REVIEW, DURING THAT MARKET
RESEARCH, THIS LAST YEAR, WE DID
IDENTIFY THAT THERE ARE
POTENTIAL SYSTEMS IN THE IN
AVAILABLE THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO
COMBINE COMBINE THE TWO
PROJECTS. SO WE HAVE DONE THAT
AND WE ARE WORKING ON,
IDENTIFYING THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL. THAT
WOULD BE, SOME, PUBLISHED NEXT
YEAR, PART OF THAT WILL DEPEND
ON IF THERE ARE ANY CHANGES
DURING THE REVIEW OF K¾T FOR
THAT STAGE TWO REPORTING
DOCUMENTATION AND THEN, WE DO
HAVE A QUARTERLY UPDATE
REQUIREMENT FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
SO THAT IS IN PROGRESS. THAT
WILL GIVE YOU MORE DETAILS. FOR
THE NEXT QUESTION, YOU WERE
ASKING ABOUT THE FUNDING LEVEL.
AND SO THIS IS ANOTHER ONE WHERE
WE CAN GET BACK TO YOU, BECAUSE
WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
EXPENDITURES IN THE CURRENT YEAR
STILL, ON THE POSITIONS. YES AS
I UNDERSTAND IT, THE QUESTION IS
SPECIFICALLY OF THE CURRENT
BUDGET, FUNDING FOR THE PROJECT.
IS THERE ANY REMAINING FUNDS
THAT MIGHT BE REAPPROPRIATED OR
USED IN SUBSEQUENT YEAR? YES WE
DON'T KNOW YET. RIGHT. CORRECT
REGARDING THE FEDERAL FUNDING,
THOUGH, WE HAVE MET WITH CMS
REPRESENTATIVES AND WITH
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. SO THOSE CONVERSATIONS
CONTINUE. WE HAVE A CONSULTANT
TO HELP US WHO'S FAMILIAR WITH
THE PROCESS FOR GETTING THE
FEDERAL APPROVAL, THOSE
DOCUMENTS ARE STILL IN THE
PLANNING PHASE. AND THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. SO WE DON'T HAVE
A GOOD TIMING OF, YET WHAT THAT
APPROVAL MIGHT LOOK LIKE, THE
TIME FRAME FOR THAT TO, IF WE
PROVIDE IF WE DO PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE, CAN WE SCORE ANY
SAVINGS IN THE UPCOMING FISCAL
YEAR? BECAUSE WE HAVE A GOOD
HOPEFULLY CMS WILL FUND A GOOD
PORTION OF THIS, RIGHT. SO WHAT
HAPPENS THEN TO THOSE THOSE
DOLLARS AND THEN TO CAN WE IF WE
DO PROVISIONAL CAN WE SAVE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE. CAN WE
SAVE. GOODBYE. OKAY. THANK YOU.
SORRY ABOUT THAT, SO YES, THEY
WILL WHEN THEY ARE APPROVED. IF
APPROVED, IT WOULD PROVIDE UP TO
90% MATCHING FUNDS FOR THE
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT, WHICH
IS THE STAGE WE'RE IN, FOR THE
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATION WOULD
BE 75% MATCH GOING FORWARD. WE
JUST DON'T HAVE A SENSE OF WHEN
THEY WOULD APPROVE THAT. AND I
THINK, SENATOR, WE JUST WE WOULD
NOTE THAT. I MEAN, THE, YOU
KNOW, FEDERAL FUNDING
CONVERSATIONS ARE OCCURRING AND
SO IT'S, YOU KNOW, NOT 100%
GIVEN, BUT WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
OPTIMISTIC. AND I, AND SO, IT
JUST WOULD JUST MAKE THAT POINT.
AND IF WE DO PROVISIONAL, THAT'S
STILL PROTECTS US TO USE UP TO
ALL WHAT IS NEEDED, BUT NOT ALL.
IF WE HAVE THE FUNDING COME IN.
AND IN THAT SCENARIO, WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THE FUNDING THAT WE
DON'T NEED TO END? WE DON'T END
UP USING. SO IF THE PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE WERE TO SAY YOU CAN USE
UP TO THIS, WHATEVER YOUR
GENERAL OF GENERAL FUND, IF
FEDERAL FUNDING WERE TO BECOME
AVAILABLE DURING BUDGET YEAR AND
FEDERAL FUNDING WOULD OFFSET
THAT, IS THAT THE QUESTION, WE
COULD LOOK AT PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE AND MAY REVISION
DOESN'T INCLUDE THAT LANGUAGE,
BUT, YOU KNOW, I THINK IT'S
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE PROPOSED IN
THE OTHER BCP FOR THE
REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM PROJECT,
WHERE WE ARE APPROPRIATE. I
GUESS I'M POINTING TO THAT AS AN
EXAMPLE WHERE WE'RE WAITING ON A
PENDING CDC REPORT TO COME IN.
SO WE HAVE THE REQUEST IS FOR UP
TO THIS AMOUNT OF GENERAL FUND.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
REPORT FROM K¾T DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY COMES BACK AND SAYS
IT'S LOWER THAN THAT, THEN WE
WOULD LOWER DSE'S GENERAL FUND
AUTHORITY FOR THAT PROJECT
ACCORDINGLY. OKAY. AND THEN AT
THAT POINT THERE WOULD BE THERE
WOULD BE GENERAL FUND SAVINGS,
BUT WE WOULDN'T BE. BUT IT WOULD
HAPPEN. IT WOULD HAPPEN DURING
THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR. CORRECT.
OKAY. THANK YOU. CAN MOVE ON TO
THE Ó LÀ Þ. ANY COMMENTS ON
THIS? OKAY MOVING ON TO OUR LAST
ISSUE ON OIC. ARE.
WELCOME BACK. SO I'LL GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN. THANK YOU. SENATOR
MENGIBAR AND YOUR SUBCOMMITTEE
AND STAFF FOR THE THOROUGH
REVIEW OF THE TRAILER. BILL,
LANGUAGE AND MY OPPORTUNITY TO
COME SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY. MY
NAME IS CATHERINE LUCERO, AND I
AM THE DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION.
I'M JOINED BY JOSEPH DONALDSON
FROM HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
TEAM, AS WELL AS ALLISON HEWITT
FROM THE DOFF CAUTION TEAM. I
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE KATIE
HOWARD IS HERE FROM BSC AND IS
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS, AND I DO WANT TO
THANK HER TEAM FOR BEING
AVAILABLE THROUGHOUT THIS
TRANSITION PROCESS. BEFORE I
WALK THROUGH Ã, I'D LIKE TO
BEFORE I PROVIDE A WALKTHROUGH
OF THE PROPOSED LANGUAGE, I'LL
TACKLE THE SECOND PART OF
QUESTION ONE FIRST TO DESCRIBE
EACH GRANT THAT IS PROPOSED TO
BE SHIFTED TO Þ COR. IT IS
CONFUSING AT TIMES, SO I WOULD
LIKE TO LAY THAT OUT VERY
CLEARLY. CHAPTER 337 STATUTES OF
2020 SB 823 REQUIRES JUVENILE
JUSTICE GRANT ADMINISTRATION
FUNCTIONS AT THE BSC TO BE MOVED
TO Þ ACRE BY JANUARY 1ST, 2025.
THE 2024 25TH MAY REVISION
PROVIDES FOR THE TRANSFER OF ALL
THE REMAINING JUVENILE GRANTS
FROM BSC TO WEISER, AS OF
JANUARY 1ST, 2025, IT IS
PROPOSED THAT OIC WILL OVERSEE
FIVE DIFFERENT JUVENILE JUSTICE
GRANTS. NUMBER ONE, THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE REALIGNMENT BLOCK GRANTS
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED THROUGH
823. IT'S A NONCOMPETITIVE,
COMPETITIVE FUNDING THAT'S
ALWAYS BEEN HOUSED WITH US.
HOWEVER, WE ARE PROPOSING TO
CHANGE THE FUNDING FORMULA GRANT
REVISION, TO JANUARY 10TH, 2025.
SO IT WAS PREVIOUSLY Dð 2024,
NUMBER TWO, THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
CRIME PREVENTION ACT. THAT GRANT
IS CURRENTLY HOUSED WITH THE
BSC, WITH THE PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL THAT WE'RE REVIEWING TODAY,
IT WOULD BE MOVED TO US BY
JANUARY 1ST, 2025. THIS IS A NON
COMPETITIVE GRANT THAT PROVIDES
STATE FUNDING FOR COUNTIES TO
IMPLEMENT PROGRAMS AIMED AT
REDUCING YOUTH CRIME AND
DELINQUENCY. THIS IS A SEPARATE
GRANT FROM THE YOUTHFUL OFFENDER
BLOCK GRANT THAT I WILL DISCUSS
IN A MINUTE. BUT AS OF 2016,
COUNTIES COMBINE THE REPORTING
OF THE JCPA AND THE IABG
EXPENDITURE AND DATA REPORTS ARE
SUBMITTED YEARLY. NUMBER THREE,
THE YOUTHFUL OFFENDER BLOCK
GRANT. THIS GRANT IS CURRENTLY
HOUSED WITH THE BSC AND WITH THE
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL WOULD BE
MOVED TO US BY JANUARY 1ST,
2025. THIS IS A NON COMPETITIVE
GRANT THAT ENHANCES COUNTY
PROBATION, MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DEPARTMENTS TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO YOUTHFUL
OFFENDERS. THIS IS A SEPARATE
GRANT THAN THE JJ, CPA, BUT AS
OF 2016, COUNTIES COMBINE THE
REPORTING EXPENDITURE AND DATA
REPORTS ARE SUBMITTED YEARLY.
NUMBER FOUR IS THE JUVENILE
REENTRY GRANT. THIS GRANT IS
CURRENTLY HOUSED WITH THE BSC
AND WILL BE MOVED PURSUANT TO
THIS TRAILER TRAILER BILL BY
JANUARY 1ST, 2025. THIS GRANT
ADDRESSES LOCAL PROGRAMS NEEDS
FOR PERSONS DISCHARGED FROM
CUSTODY TO OF JJ IT. IT WAS AS
YOU KNOW, PROPOSED TO SUNSET.
BUT THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WE ARE REVIEWING TODAY
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSES THE FACT
THAT NOW WE HAVE SECURE YOUTH
TREATMENT FACILITIES, A TERM
THAT DID NOT EXIST PREVIOUSLY.
THIS NEW LANGUAGE ALLOWS FOR THE
ELIGIBILITY OF THE YOUTH FROM
THE CITF UPON REENTRY, AND AFTER
JJ CLOSED. AND THEN YOU'RE
ALREADY FAMILIAR WITH THE TITLE
TWO GRANT. WE'VE DISCUSSED THAT
MANY TIMES. THAT IS A
COMPETITIVE GRANT FOR COUNTIES,
CBOS, CITY GOVERNMENTS, COUNTY
GOVERNMENTS, AND THAT IS A THREE
YEAR CYCLE OF GRANTS, WITH WITH
REGARD TO THE TRAILER BILL, WALK
THROUGH, I WOULD LIKE TO, NOTE
THAT THE BULK OF THE TRAILER
BILL REPLACES THE BOARD OF STATE
AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS WITH
OIC FOR, AS YOU WILL HEAR,
PERHAPS AT SOME POINT THE INTENT
WAS JUST REALLY AND I MEAN FROM
DOFF, THE INTENT REALLY WAS JUST
TO LITERALLY MOVE THE GRANTS
FROM COPY AND PASTE. YES
EXACTLY. SO THAT WAS DONE. AND
IN ADDITION TO THE BSC, OIC, OUR
LANGUAGE SWAP OUT, THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF PLACES WHERE WE DO
INTRODUCE SECURE YOUTH TREATMENT
FACILITY INTO THE LANGUAGE. THE
FIRST IS THE AMENDMENT TO WICK
1981 ON PAGE NINE OF THE 16 PAGE
TBL. THIS ALLOWS THE
ELIGIBILITY, AS INDICATED
EARLIER, OF THE JUVENILE REENTRY
GRANT, TO GO TO THOSE KIDS. NOW,
ON PAGE TEN, THE AMENDMENT TO WD
CODE 1982 INCLUDES EDITS TO THE
AUDITING FUNCTIONS AND EDITS TO
THE ABILITY TO WITHHOLD FUNDING
IF DATA IS NOT SUBMITTED.
HOWEVER, THE ADMINISTRATION DOES
NOTE THAT THE REMOVAL OF THESE
PROVISIONS WAS NOT INTENTIONAL,
AND WE WILL WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCORPORATE THE
PROVISIONS WITHIN THE OTHER
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED TO THIS CODE
. SECTION. EDITS IN WICK 1984
ARE. TECHNICAL CLEANUP. NOW I'LL
ADDRESS THE EDITS TO WICK 2200
AND H. THIS LANGUAGE ADDED I
QUOTE AND THE METHODOLOGY OF
GRANT ALLOCATIONS SHALL BE
CONSISTENT WITH THOSE
INCORPORATED INTO THE 2011
PUBLIC SAFETY REALIGNMENT.
FISCAL STRUCTURE, UNQUOTE. OIC
RECOGNIZES THAT THE SHIFT OF
THESE GRANT RESPONSES ABILITIES
IS SIGNIFICANT TO OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS. BY THIS LANGUAGE, WE
REAFFIRM TO COUNTIES THAT OCR
WILL FOLLOW THE ORIGINAL INTENT,
FORMULAS AND STATUTES ASSOCIATED
WITH THESE GRANT ALLOCATIONS.
ONLY THE STATE AGENCY WILL
CHANGE. IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN THE
INTENT AND THE LANGUAGE ALLOWS
FOR A MEETING OF THE MINDS ON
THIS CONCEPT IN BLACK AND WHITE.
IT I BELIEVE I'VE ADDRESSED THE
FOUR QUESTIONS, BUT I AM
CERTAINLY AVAILABLE AND MY TEAM
IS AVAILABLE TO ANSWER. ANY
OTHER FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS ON
THE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE,
REGARDING THE POINT THAT THE
WHOLE POINT WAS TO TRANSFER
OVER, YOU'RE GOING TO BE MAKING
SOME TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THAT
TO ENSURE THAT OCR IS STILL
COLLECTING DATA ON FROM THE
COUNTIES, WHICH IS REALLY GREAT
ON THE 2200 AGE LANGUAGE. I KNOW
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE, YOU KNOW, THE NEED
DOWN THE LINE AS WE MOVE FORWARD
TO LOOK AT THIS METHODOLOGY AND
GIVES US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CHANGE IT. WE'RE NOT ASKING
RIGHT NOW TO CHANGE IT, I GET
THAT, BUT THIS ALSO LOCKS OUR
OUR ARMS OR HANDS AND TO NEVER,
EVER CHANGING IT. SO I'M
WONDERING IN EXCLUDING THAT,
THAT GIVES US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COME DOWN THE LINE TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS GATHER WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND LOOKING AT
CHANGING THE METHODOLOGY,
BECAUSE THIS REALLY LOCKS US IN,
DO YOU SEE THIS AS LOCKING US IN
FOREVER, THIS METHODOLOGY AND
NEVER ALLOWING TO READJUST IT?
WELL, I DON'T SEE IT SAY SAYING
YOU'RE NEVER ALLOWED TO
READJUST, WHICH I THINK IS THE
PLAIN LANGUAGE OF THE LAW. AND
THIS REALLY AFFIRMS WHAT THE LAW
ALREADY IS. THERE WAS NEVER AN
INTENT FOR US TO DO ANYTHING
THAN APPLY BY THE LAW, AS
PREVIOUSLY, PROMULGATED. AND SO
I DON'T SEE IT AS TYING HANDS. I
WOULD CERTAINLY OFFER MY
COLLEAGUES TO COMMENT. BUT EVERY
YEAR, YOU KNOW, DIFFERENT
GOVERNORS, DIFFERENT
LEGISLATORS, THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE CHANGES AS
NEEDED. BUT I'M HAPPY TO HEAR
FROM OTHERS ON THIS. ALISON
HEWITT. ALLISON HEWITT
DEPARTMENT HÌ VOIGTS GOING TO BE
THAT. ALLISON HEWITT, DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD TO DIRECTOR
LUCERO'S COMMENTS. THERE'S NO
PROPOSAL FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
TO CHANGE ANY OF THE REALIGNMENT
FORMULAS THAT HAVE EXISTED IN
STATUTE, OTHER THAN A TECHNICAL
UPDATE TO THE JUVENILE REENTRY
GRANT. THIS TIME, I WOULDN'T SEE
THAT THE, NOT A LAWYER OR A
JUDGE AS DIRECTOR LUCERO HAS
BEEN. I WOULDN'T SEE THAT THAT
ADDING THAT LANGUAGE WOULD
PREVENT ANY FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS. TO THAT END. THEN
WHY ADD THE LANGUAGE? BECAUSE
THERE'S A BIG TRANSITION
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW, AND BSC HAS
BEEN ADMINISTERING THESE
PROGRAMS FOR WELL OVER A DECADE.
SO I THINK THIS GIVES THE COUNTY
SOME CERTAINTY THAT THE FORMULA
IS, AT LEAST AS THEY ARE IN
STATUTE NOW, REMAIN THE SAME,
WHILE THIS TRANSITION OCCURS TO
THE EXTENT THERE WERE FUTURE
PROPOSALS TO AMEND THE
REALIGNMENT STATUTES, I THINK
YOU'D BE POTENTIALLY AMENDING
THE SAME CODE SECTIONS. BUT IN
EITHER CASE, I THINK THIS IS
THIS PROVIDES SOME CERTAINTY FOR
RIGHT NOW THAT RIGHT, WHILE WE
EVER COME BACK TO THE TABLE AND
TRY TO CHANGE THAT, THERE, THE
DEPARTMENT'S GOING TO POINT AND
SAY, HEY, IN THIS TBO IT SAYS
THE METHODOLOGY WON'T CHANGE. SO
MAKING IT EVEN HARDER FOR US TO
COME BACK. I THINK IT WOULD BE
HARD. I THINK, MY, MY $0.02 IS
IT'S GOING TO BE HARD TO REWRITE
ANY OF THE FORMULAS THAT WERE
WRITTEN INTO 2011 REALIGNMENT
FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS,
INCLUDING PROPOSITION 30. THAT
SAID, WE THIS CODE SECTION COULD
EASILY BE MODIFIED IN IN ANY
FUTURE VEHICLE. PROP ONE IS
REALIGNING A WHOLE DIFFERENT
THINGS, AND WE'RE ALLOCATING
FUNDING TO GO DOWN TO COUNTIES
TO ADJUST TO OUR PROP 30. SO
IT'S DOABLE BECAUSE PROP ONE IS
A WHOLE NEW, DIFFERENT MANDATE
AND WE'RE ALLOCATING FUNDING FOR
THAT. SO I DON'T THINK THAT'S AN
ENOUGH REASON TO NOT DO IT. I
JUST I DO THINK HAVING IT
STRICTLY IN THE TBL WILL PREVENT
US YEARS FROM NOW TO EVEN HAVE
IT WILL MAKE IT HARDER FOR US TO
MOVE AROUND. METHODOLOGY.
BECAUSE THE HAVING SOMETHING
FROM 2011 STAY THE SAME AND
STAGNANT TO 2040, 2035 MEANS
THAT WE'RE NOT GROWING AS WE SEE
THINGS GROWING AND CHANGING AND
SO FORTH. I'M NOT SAYING AGAIN
THAT WE WANT TO CHANGE THE
METHODOLOGY RIGHT NOW. I WANT TO
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION. I DO THINK THIS
LOCKS US INTO PREVENTING THAT
CONVERSATION FROM HAPPENING,
BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT WILL COME
BACK AND SAY, WELL, IT'S IN THAT
TÊ BLEW PAST THREE YEARS AGO,
FOUR YEARS AGO. SO JUST THERE'S
NO NEED TO BE A RESPONSE TO
THAT. BUT THAT'S WHERE THAT'S
HOW I'M LOOKING AT IT. ALLOW OUR
COMMENTS REFLECT THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE AS HEARD, AS YOU
HEARD THE WE RAISED THESE
INADVERTENT DELETIONS TO BOTH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND YOUR
STAFF AND, THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS COMMUNICATED THAT THEY'RE
WILLING TO CHANGE THAT AND
UPDATE THOSE, BUT THOSE PERTAIN
TO THE JUVENILE REENTRY GRANT.
AND THAT THERE'S CERTAIN DATA
THAT THESE GRANTS REQUIRE THAT
ARE REPORTED TO THE STATE THAT
THAT WAS DELETED. AND THERE'S
ALSO SOME PROVISIONS THAT THAT
WOULD ALLOW THE OCR TO AUDIT THE
THIS DATA THAT THE STATE
RECEIVES. AND AGAIN, THAT THAT
WASN'T INCLUDED. BUT WE'VE
RAISED THOSE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION NOTES THAT, THERE
ARE WILLING TO, TO MODIFY THAT
LANGUAGE. THE SECOND ISSUE I
WANT TO RAISE IS THE GRANTS. WE
JUST HEARD, NOW IS, IS MISSING
LIKE ONE NOTABLE BSC GRANT THAT
IS ADMINISTERED, THIS IS THE
JUVENILE PROBATION CAMP FUNDING.
THIS IS FOR CAMPS AND RANCHES.
THERE'S SOME DATA THAT THE BSC
CURRENTLY COLLECTS ON THE ON THE
POPULATION AND THEN THIS THEN IS
GIVEN TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WHO THEN DECIDES HOW
COUNTIES GET ALLOCATED THIS
FUNDING, THE GRANTS THAT WERE
JUST GONE THROUGH DID NOT
MENTION THAT ONE. SO I JUST WANT
TO RAISE THAT FOR THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU. AND ORLANDO SANCHEZ
WITH THE LÀ. SORRY ABOUT THAT,
DIRECTOR. WAS THAT ON PURPOSE?
WAS THAT ON? YES. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE BSC IS
GOING TO MAINTAIN PURVIEW OVER
THE ACTUAL FACILITY, THE TITLE
15 INSPECTIONS, THAT KIND OF
THING. SO IT'S, DIRECTLY, IN
THERE, PURVIEW. GO AHEAD. DREW
SODERBERG LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
OFFICE YEAH, THE ONLY, CONTEXT I
JUST WANTED TO ADD REAL QUICK
IS, IS THAT THAT GRANT IS REALLY
DRIVEN BY DATA THAT'S COLLECTED
BY BSC, AND THAT DATA COLLECTION
FUNCTION HAS ALWAYS BEEN
INTENDED TO STAY WITH BSC. THERE
HASN'T BEEN A PROPOSAL TO
TRANSFER IT TO ECR. AND SO SINCE
IT'S PRETTY MUCH JUST COLLECTING
THAT DATA AND PLUGGING IT INTO A
FORMULA, THAT'S WHY, THAT CHANGE
HASN'T BEEN PROPOSED YET, IS MY
UNDERSTANDING. ALLISON HEWITT,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I THINK
UNLIKE THE OTHER THREE GRANTS
THAT THE CAMPS AND RANCH AND
FUNDING IS DISTINCTLY NOT A
GRANT PROGRAM. SO THERE'S BSC,
BSC ADMINISTRATION, BUT IT'S NOT
A GRANT. IT'S A DIRECT
ALLOCATION BASED ON THE NUMBER
OF FACILITIES THAT COUNTIES
OPERATE, NUMBER OF CAMPS AND
RANCHES AND THAT, DATA IS
ALREADY COLLECTED BY BSC ON THE
NATURAL IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THEIR TITLE 15 RESPONSIBILITIES.
SO THERE'S NOTHING FUNCTIONALLY
TO TRANSFER AT THIS POINT,
SENATOR GROVE, DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION? I DO, IS THE IS THE
PURPOSE OF THIS TRANSFER UNDER
YOUR DEPARTMENT DIRECTOR? IS IT
IS IT, BECAUSE BSC IS MORE
PUBLIC SAFETY FOCUSED ON
JUVENILE JUSTICE ISSUES THAT
WE'RE, YOU KNOW, THEY'RE
HARDENED CRIMINALS BASED ON, YOU
KNOW, THE CRIME THAT THEY
COMMITTED AND WHY THEY'RE THERE,
AND OCR IS MORE OF A MENTAL
HEALTH, APPROACH. WHAT'S THE
REASON FOR THE TRANSFER? WELL AS
YOU KNOW, SENATOR, IT WAS
CONTAINED WITHIN SB 823 WHEN IT
WAS ORIGINALLY, PROMULGATED. AND
MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE REASON
IS BECAUSE OCR IS SPECIALIZING
IN JUVENILE JUSTICE DATA,
POLICY, BEST PRACTICES, EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES, AND HAVING ALL
OF THIS INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO
US. AND, AND WE ARE, OVERSEEING
THE PLANS THAT WILL BE DELIVERED
UNDER JJC, CPA, WHY OBG WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO REALLY MINE
THIS INFORMATION AND GIVE THE
LEGISLATURE BACK SOME REALLY
GOOD, INFORMATION ABOUT THE
REALIGNMENT ITSELF AND HOW YOUTH
ARE DOING IN THE 58 COUNTIES. SO
THIS REALLY HAS BECOME OUR OUR
SPECIALTY IS THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE POPULATION. NOT TO SAY
THAT BSC DOESN'T STILL HAVE
OVERSIGHT OVER THE ACTUAL
FACILITIES. AND MAKING SURE THAT
THE KIDS ARE SAFE IN THOSE
FACILITIES WERE MUCH MORE
INVOLVED IN PROGRAMS, MENTAL
HEALTH, SUBSTANCE USE, AND WANT
TO KNOW HOW THOSE OUTCOMES ARE
GOING. AND SO NOW ALL OF THIS
WILL BE IN ONE PLACE WITH US.
AND DOES BSC NOT PROVIDE YOU
THAT INFORMATION? THEY THEY
COULD THEY COULD ABSOLUTELY. BUT
WE WILL BE THE ONES NOW THAT THE
COUNTIES WILL PROVIDE IT TO
DIRECTLY. WE COULD GO BACK AND
WE COULD LOOK AT THE PLANS THAT
ARE POSTED. WE COULD LOOK AT THE
DATA THAT'S COLLECTED. BUT WE
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE THIS UNIFORM
UNDERNEATH OCR. OKAY GREAT. NØ
FOR THE QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY. THANK YOU.
OPENING IT UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
FOR THE REMAINING ITEMS THAT WE
HAVE NOT HAD. PUBLIC COMMENT ON.
HOLD ON. GIVE ME ONE SECOND
BEFORE YOU BEGIN. LET ME KNOW
WHEN THEY'RE READY. ARE YOU
READY? OKAY. PLEASE PROCEED.
OKAY. WARREN CUSHMAN FOR
COMMUNITY RESOURCES FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING IN HAYWARD.
THREE QUICK THINGS. FIRST OF
ALL, JUST TO, Ã POINTING OUT
THAT WHEN YOU, LOOK AT OLDER
ADULT PROGRAMS, YOU'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. ALSO WE ARE WE ARE
INTERESTED IN FOOD SECURITY. SO
THAT'S ANOTHER PIECE, INCLUDING
CALFRESH. AND THEN THE ONLY
OTHER THING I'LL SAY IS, IT'S
NICE TO HEAR DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS AT LEAST EXPOUNDING
ON EACH OTHER'S POSITIONS ONCE
IN A WHILE. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. THAT'S S. GOTCHA. THERE YOU
GO. THAT'S GOOD. IT'S GOING TO
HIT YOU. THANKS AND GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
RUSSELL DAWSON RAWLINGS,
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING MANAGER AT
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS. AND
I REITERATE, WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
JUST MENTIONED, MANY OF THE APS
CUTS DO DIRECTLY AFFECT PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES OF ALL AGES.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER
THAT WHEN LOOKING AT THESE.
ALSO, IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT ALL OF THESE
CUTS THREATEN OUR STATE'S
COMPLIANCE WITH THE SPIRIT OF
THE OLMSTEAD DECISION, ALLOWING
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES THE
ACCESS TO THE COMMUNITY LIVING
OPTIONS AND EVERY CUT THAT YOU
MAKE THAT TAKES AWAY THOSE
COMMUNITY BASED OPTIONS COSTS
THE STATE EXTRA MONEY IN MONEY
SPENT IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND OTHER
INSTITUTIONALIZED SETTINGS. SO
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT
THESE AS COST SAVINGS BY KEEPING
THESE CUTS OR KEEPING THE
BUDGETS WHOLE. THANK YOU. YOU
ALL HAVE 45 SECONDS, IF YOU GO
OVER, WE'RE CUTTING IT OFF AT
ONE, SO YOU MIGHT NOT LET THE
OTHER ONE SPEAK. HOLA. BUENAS
TARDES. MY NAME IS JESSENIA
ORTIZ DEL CONDADO DE MARIN.
MIEMBRO DE PARA. INVOICES POR
FAVOR. NECESITAMOS QUÊ LU█N POR
EL PRESUPUESTO O FINAL INCLUIA
FINANCIAMENTO PARA NUESTROS DIAS
DE CUIDADO INFANTIL Y LAS
PROMESAS PARA LAS PROVEEDORES
TAMBIÉN QUÊ RECHAZAN EL CORTE
PARA CALWORKS A AUMENTO DE
INGRESOS ESTATALES YA TOMAMOS
COMENTARIO PUBLICO EN ESTOS
TEMAS. OKAY? GRACIAS. OKAY HI.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. I
APOLOGIZE THAT WE HAVE
REPRESSED, YOU KNOW, WE ARE
DRIVING FROM MARIN COUNTY WAS
TRAFFIC AND THERE ARE LIKE
TAKING THEIR DAY OFF JUST TO BE
HERE. SO I WILL REALLY
APPRECIATE IF YOU CAN HEAR THEIR
WORDS. THEY ALREADY TAKE THEIR
DAY TO BE HERE. AND YOU KNOW, WE
ARE HERE TO REJECT THE CUTS TO
CALWORKS. WE ARE HERE TO ASK FOR
THE 20 000 SLOTS FOR CHILD CARE.
BUT ALSO LIKE WE KNOW THAT THE
GOVERNOR PUT LIKE ALMOST
20,000,000,000IN THE RAINY DAY
FUND, BUT IT IS RAINING FOR OUR
FAMILIES ALREADY. THEY ARE
STRUGGLING AND IT IS HARD FOR
THEM TO BE HERE. I BROUGHT A
PICTURE OF 100 MEMBERS THAT WE
HAVE JUST IN MARIN COUNTY. TWO
WEEKS AGO. WE BROUGHT LIKE 500
FAMILIES OVER HERE WITH THEIR
CHILDREN TO ADVOCATE FOR WHAT IT
IS NEEDED. YOU SAID OUR
FAMILIES, THEY NEED TO HAVE
THOSE SERVICES. WE CANNOT SPEND
THE MONEY ON OTHER THINGS THAT
LIKE MEDIA OR LIKE
ADMINISTRATIVE, LIKE SALARIES
WHEN THEY ARE STRUGGLING. YOU
KNOW WHAT IT IS TO POST YOUR
DREAMS. JUST BECAUSE SOMEBODY
SAYS THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE
FUNDS TO DO THAT, OR FAMILIES
ARE WAITING. THAT'S WHY WE ARE
HERE. AND I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE IF YOU CAN LISTEN TO
OUR PARENTS THAT THEY ARE TAKING
THE DAY OFF. THANK YOU. NEXT
HOLA. BUENAS TARDES. MY NAME IS
MARITZA DELEON. TAMBIÉN I UNA
LINEA AÉREA POR ESO DEL CONDADO
DE MARIN. ESTOY AQUI PARA EL
GOBERNADOR A SU PROMESA PARA EL
CUIDADO INFANTIL, PORQUE LAS
FAMILIAS NO PUEDEN ESPERAR A
MUCHAS NECESIDADES EN LA
COMUNIDAD. EL CUAL NECESITAMOS
DE SU AYUDA PARA C¯ PUEDEN SALIR
ADELANTE COMO YO ESTUVE EN LA
LISTA DE ESPERA POR TRES ANOS. Y
ES BIEN TRISTE PONER TUS SUENOS
EN PAUSA. POR ESO, NECESITAMOS
QUÊ MAS FAMILIAS TENGAN EL
CUIDADO INFANTIL. GRACIAS AL
CUIDADO UNTIL Â PODIDO SACAR A
MI FAMILIA ADELANTE Â PODIDO
TRABAJAR PORQUE NECESITAMOS QUÊ
LU█N POR UN PRESUPUESTO FINAL
FINANCIAMIENTO PARA LOS USUARIOS
DEL CUIDADO INFANTIL PROMETIDA
PARA LAS FAMILIAS COMPROMETER EL
COSTO DE REAL DE LAS NECESIDADES
PARA LOS PROVEEDORES RECHAZAN EL
CORTE DEL CALDERON GRACIAS,
GRACIAS. GOOD AFTERNOON, REBECCA
GONZALEZ WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY. I'M HERE TO
TALK ABOUT A FEW ISSUES. WE
OPPOSE CUTS TO NUTRITION
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE CALIFORNIA
FOOD ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. THIS IS
A PROGRAM IS IMPORTANT FOR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES COMBINED
WITH IHSS CUTS. IT IS
DEVASTATING BLOW. I'M ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ELIMINATION
OF THE CALFRESH MINIMUM BENEFIT
PILOT PROGRAM, AND ALSO THE WINS
PROGRAM. AS YOU KNOW, FOOD COSTS
ARE GOING UP AND THESE CUTS WILL
ONLY RESULT IN MORE HUNGER. ALSO
OPPOSE REDUCTIONS TO CDSS
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS. WHEN A TIME OUR
HOUSELESSNESS CRISIS IS AT
RISING LEVELS AND IT REALLY
CONCERNS EVERYONE, THAT INCLUDES
THE BRINGING FAMILIES HOME
PROGRAM, WHICH TARGETS FAMILIES
IN THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM,
HOME SAFE PROGRAM FOR THOSE IN
APS HOUSING AND DISABILITY
ADVOCACY PROGRAM. THANK YOU
REBECCA. THANK YOU. EMERALD
EVANS WITHIN CHILD POVERTY
CALIFORNIA ON THE CALFRESH
MINIMUM PILOT. WE ARE A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR OF YOUR BABY CHAIR
AND WE ARE APPRECIATING YOUR
LEADERSHIP. THE NEW DATA FROM
THE URBAN INSTITUTE RELEASED
TODAY HIGHLIGHTS THAT CALFRESH
BENEFITS ARE INADEQUATE TO COVER
THE COST OF EVERY ONE OF THE 58
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE. AND
THIS CANNOT BE PERMANENTLY CUT
AS WE ARE READY TO SUPPORT ANY
NEXT STEPS NECESSARY ON WINS.
THANK YOU FOR UNDERSCORING THAT
THIS WILL CREATE A NEW HUNGER
CLIFF. WE SHOULD BE INCREASING
THE WINDS TO PROVIDE MORE THAN
$10 A MONTH. WE STRENUOUSLY
OPPOSE REMOVING WINDS FROM THE
STATUTE AND AGREE WITH LÀ Ó TO
GUARD AGAINST CHANGES TO THE
WPA, WHICH WE KNOW THE US HOUSE
WANTS TO DO, AND WE ALIGN WITH
THE FOOD FOR ALL COALITION
AGAINST THE CFP DELAY FOR ISSUE
EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION, AND WE WILL
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH THE
DSS THAT THE CUTS DO UNDERMINE
THE FRA PILOTS. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, DIANE OCKENFELS. ONCE
AGAIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS. WE OPPOSE THE
CUTS TO THE 65 MILLION FROM THE
HOME SAFE PROGRAM AND THE 50
MILLION FROM THE HOUSING AND
DISABILITY ADVOCACY PROGRAM.
HONESTLY, WITHOUT THIS PROGRAM,
THOUSANDS OF AT RISKS CURRENTLY
HOUSED OLDER AND DEPENDENT
ADULTS WILL NOW BECOME NEWLY
HOMELESS. WE ALREADY KNOW THAT
THE ADULTS ARE THE STATE'S
FASTEST GROWING GROUP OF FIRST
TIME HOMELESS, WHO WILL BE
ADDING TO THE NUMBER OF UNHOUSED
AND INSTITUTIONALIZED OLDER
ADULTS WITHOUT HOME SAFE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. YASMIN PELE, ON
BEHALF OF JUSTICE AND AGING, ON
ISSUE SIX OF CDSS HOUSING
PROGRAMS WERE OPPOSED TO THE
PROPOSED CUT. OLDER ADULTS ARE
THE FASTEST GROWING POPULATION
OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. NEARLY HALF OF
HOMELESS CALIFORNIANS ARE OVER
THE AGE OF 50. THIS IS A
TRAVESTY, AND THE STATE DOES NOT
HAVE AN ADEQUATE PLAN TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE BY ELIMINATING HOME
SAFE AND REDUCING FUNDING FOR
ADAP, THE ONLY TWO STATE
PROGRAMS THAT SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESS OLDER ADULT
HOMELESSNESS. HOW CAN WE SAY
THIS IS A PRIORITY FOR THE STATE
WHEN THERE IS NO PROGRAMMATIC
INVESTMENT? ADDITIONALLY, WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THE CFAP DELAY AND
THE MINIMUM NUTRITION NUTRITION
BENEFIT PILOT CUT WERE OPPOSED
TO THE OTHER APS FUNDING CUTS.
AND FINALLY, UNDER CDA, WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THE REDUCTION OF
FUNDING FOR THE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT SENIOR
NUTRITION PROGRAMS. THERE IS NOT
AN ADEQUATE BACKFILL FOR THESE
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CAN ONLY HAVE 30S OR ELSE NOT
EVERYONE'S GOING TO BE ABLE TO
SPEAK 30S EILEEN KUBACKI WITH
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO THE
APS CUTS. IT IS ABOUT 200
WORKERS STATEWIDE AND THE
TRAINING IN PARTICULAR. ONCE
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE IS GONE,
IT'S GONE. AND REGARDING THE
FOSTER CARE RATES, COMPLETELY
AGREE. WE WANT TO KEEP THE
MOMENTUM GOING AND THINK THERE
IS A MIDDLE GROUND WHERE WE CAN
KEEP IT GOING AND ADDRESS ALL OF
THE CONCERNS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TIFFANY
WHITTON WITH SEIU CALIFORNIA
OPPOSE THE APS CUTS AS WELL AS
THE CALFRESH CUTS. AND WE ALSO
REJECT THE PROPOSED CUTS TO THE
DSS ADMINISTERED IMMIGRANT LEGAL
SERVICES. AND THEN WITH RESPECT
TO THE FOSTER CARE RATES,
DEFINITELY HAVE CONCERNS AROUND
ADMIN FUNDING AND HAVING ENOUGH
WORKFORCE. THERE ARE SO MANY
CUTS ALL OVER THE PLACE. WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE AN
ADEQUATE WORKFORCE TO ATTEND TO
ALL THE NEEDS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MÀ NÓ CHILDCARE LAWCENTER.
CHILDCARE IS ESSENTIAL FOR
THRIVING FAMILIES AND JUSTICE
AND COMMUNITIES. THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES CONTINUE TO LANGUISH ON
WAITING LISTS AND THEY NEED
AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE NOW. WE
URGE THE BUDGET COMMITTEE TO
REJECT THE CUTS AND PAUSES TO
81,000 SPACES AND CUTS TO SPACES
OF EMERGENCY BRIDGE PROGRAMS. WE
URGE LEGISLATORS TO IDENTIFY
OTHER SOURCES OF REVENUE AND
RESERVES INSTEAD OF TAKING AWAY
CRITICAL SERVICES FROM FAMILIES
WITH THE LEAST RESOURCES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. JUSTIN AT
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
APS CUTS, WE HAVE STRONG
CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT THIS MEANS
FOR BOTH THE COUNTY WORKFORCE
AND SERVICES THAT OLDER ADULTS
NEED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CHRIS STONER MERTZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES ON THE TABLE FOR
FOSTER CARE RATES. WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT HOW THIS IS
GOING TO IMPACT THE PROVIDER
COMMUNITY. WE ARE NOT JUST
TALKING ABOUT ADMINISTRATION.
THESE ARE CORE SERVICES, SOCIAL
WORKERS, OTHER SUPPORTS,
TRANSPORTATION TO FAMILY, ETC.
VÀ, WE ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT THE
STRENGTHS BUILDING FOR YOUTH. WE
SUPPORT THE CAREGIVER SUPPORTS
AS WELL, BUT WE CANNOT HAVE A
SAFETY NET IF WE'RE GOING TO
DECIMATE THE PROGRAMS THAT
SUPPORT THEM. THANK YOU. HI, I'M
SHAWNA MORRIS WITH CASA PACIFICA
CENTERS FOR FAMILY AND CHILDREN.
WE TAKE CARE OF FOSTER KIDS
TODAY. WE LOST $1 MILLION LAST
YEAR DOING IT. WE WILL LOSE
ANOTHER MILLION DOLLARS THIS
YEAR. IF YOU CUT OUR RATES. WE
WILL CLOSE THOSE PROGRAMS. WE
HAD 237 REFERRALS IN THE LAST
SIX MONTHS. WE WERE ABLE TO
TREAT FOUR OF THEM IN OUR
PROGRAM. PLEASE DO NOT CUT THESE
PROGRAMS. YOUR CHILDREN ARE
CHILDREN'S LIVES DEPEND ON IT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. KELLY
LONGO FLORES FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS, WE
ASK YOU TO REJECT THE
ELIMINATION OF THE CALFRESH
MINIMUM BENEFITS PILOT, WHICH
WOULD HAVE RAISED THE MINIMUM
BENEFIT FROM JUST $23 TO $50 A
MONTH, REJECT THE CFAP DELAYS
AND REJECT THE CUTS TO THE WINS
PROGRAM. WE KNOW $10 DOESN'T
SOUND LIKE A LOT, BUT TO MANY
CALIFORNIANS, EVERY LITTLE BIT
HELPS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
JAMIE, I'M DOCTOR MARK LEBOW,
CEO OF CALIFORNIA RURAL INDIAN
HEALTH BOARD, ON BEHALF OF THE
68 FULLER RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN
THE CRIB MEMBERSHIP, URGE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT TRAILER
BILLS SPECIALIZED CARE INCREMENT
ELIGIBILITY EXCELLENCE AND
FAMILY FINDING ENGAGEMENT AND
SUPPORT PROGRAM. AND FINALLY,
THE TRIBAL NUTRITION ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, KATHY
MOSSBERG, ON BEHALF OF THE AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING, AS WELL AS
MEALS ON WHEELS, CALIFORNIA,
BOTH IN STRONG AND STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE CUT TO SENIOR
NUTRITION. WE ALREADY KNOW THIS
WILL LEAVE US SERVING 60% LESS
MEALS THAN WHAT WE SERVED IN THE
PANDEMIC. WE ALREADY KNOW WE
HAVE AN UNMET NEED OF
APPROXIMATELY 370 MEALS PER YEAR
THAT WE'RE NOT GETTING AT
SENIORS WHO NEED FOOD, SO THIS
WOULD BE A TREMENDOUS CUT WE
URGE YOU TO REJECT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. SO I ASSUME ON BEHALF
OF DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA,
WE ARE OPPOSED TO, AS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED, CUTS TO IHSS
SPECIFICALLY TO THE IMMIGRANT
POPULATION. THE ELIMINATION OF
THE BACKUP PROVIDER SYSTEM TOOK
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR IHSS AND ALSO
FOR THE IMMIGRATION AND EQUITY
PROGRAMS. APS AND HTAP. WE JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A CONSTANT
THEME THAT WE'RE SEEING, THAT
THE BUDGET IS BEING BALANCED ON
THE BACKS OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
AND IN THIS CASE, THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY, WHICH IS WHY WE
WANTED TO MENTION THAT THE CUTS
TO IHSS ONCE AGAIN, WE WANT TO
JUST RAISE THE LEGAL
LIABILITIES. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS JARED KAUL WITH NOURISH
CALIFORNIA, URGING YOU TO REJECT
THE CALFRESH CUTS, PARTICULARLY
THE PROPOSED DELAY TO CFAP,
THESE ARE OLDER ADULTS WHO'VE
LITERALLY WAITED FOREVER FOR
FOOD ASSISTANCE IMPLEMENTATION.
I KNOW WE'RE SAYING IT WILL BE
PAUSED FOR TWO YEARS. WE KNOW
PLANNING AND AUTOMATION IS
HAPPENING NOW AND HAS BEEN
HAPPENING. WE KNOW IF WE PAUSE
IT, IT'LL BE THAT MUCH HARDER TO
GET IT STARTED. WE ALL KNOW THAT
IT WILL FALL FURTHER DOWN THE
QUEUE. SO URGING YOU TO PLEASE
WORK WITH US TO FIND A WAY TO
KEEP IT GOING. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
GERM OF RISK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER, I ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE
BY MY COLLEAGUE AT NOURISH
CALIFORNIA REGARDING THE
PROPOSED DELAY TO THE CFAP
EXPANSION. ADDITIONALLY, WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED CUTS TO THE
TPS IMMIGRATION SERVICES
PROGRAM, THE CSU IMMIGRATION
LEGAL SERVICES PROJECT, AS WELL
AS A DISCONTINUATION OF FUNDING
FOR THE CHILDREN'S HOLISTIC
IMMIGRATION REPRESENTATION
PROJECT. THESE SERVICES ARE A
LIFELINE FOR IMMIGRANT FAMILIES
ACROSS OUR STATE, AND CAN MEAN
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A YOUNG
PERSON LOSING A PARENT OR FAMILY
MEMBER TO DEPORTATION OR
ATTAINING HIGHER EDUCATION AND
ECONOMIC MOBILITY, CALL ON THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE TO
FULLY FUND THESE PROGRAMS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. YEAH THANK YOU
SO MUCH TO CHAIRMAN JABBAR AND
SENATOR EGGMAN FOR YOUR REALLY
INSIGHTFUL COMMENTS. THAT CUTS
TO SERVICES ACTUALLY LEAD TO AN
INCREASE IN THE NEED FOR
SERVICES, WHETHER OR NOT THE
GOVERNOR WANTS TO ACKNOWLEDGE
IT, PLEASE REJECT ALL CUTS TO
FOOD PROGRAMS, APS, THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
OLDER ADULTS. INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AND ESPECIALLY REJECT
ALL CUTS TO HOUSING PROGRAMS.
WE'VE BEEN CRIMINALIZING
UNHOUSED PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
HEALTH DISABILITIES. WE NEED ALL
HOUSING SUPPORT POSSIBLE. PLEASE
SHOW THAT OLDER ADULTS AND
DISABLED PEOPLE ARE VALUED
MEMBERS OF OUR SOCIETY. THANK
YOU FOR FIGHTING FOR US. THANK
YOU. JACKIE GONZALEZ, POLICY
DIRECTOR AT IMMIGRANT DEFENSE
ADVOCATES HERE TO OPPOSE THE
GOVERNOR'S CUTS TO TPS. CHIRP
AND THE CSU'S. SINCE I LAST
TESTIFIED BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE,
OUR FUTURE PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE HAS THREATENED THE
DEPORTATION OF IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES, A MILITARIZED
DEPORTATION. HOW WE TURN THE TAP
OFF TODAY. I DON'T KNOW, I DON'T
KNOW, BUT IF IN SIX MONTHS I
HOPE THAT WE FIND A WAY TO TURN
IT BACK ON, IT SHOULDN'T BE CUT
OFF. THE ZERO TOLERANCE POLICY
OF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
SEPARATED 5000 CHILDREN, 2000 OF
THEM HAVE NOT BEEN REUNITED WITH
THEIR PARENTS. STILL TO THIS
DAY. THANK YOU. HI, MY NAME IS
NIKA MAZLOOM AND I'M HERE WITH
THE MESA VERDE GROUP ON BEHALF
OF THE CENTRAL AMERICAN RESOURCE
CENTER, IMMIGRANT LEGAL DEFENSE
CARESIN, WE'RE URGING THE
COMMITTEE TO REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED CUT TO
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES AND
REQUEST THAT THE COMMITTEE FULLY
FUND IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS KHALID
RASHID. I'M FROM STANISLAUS
COUNTY, CALIFORNIA. FOOD
ASSISTANCE CALFRESH AND APS
PROGRAM SUPPORT ALL AND ARE
NEEDED. WE NEED TO PRIORITIZE,
PRIORITIZE SERVICES THAT WILL
KEEP OUR COMMUNITIES HEALTHY,
SLASHING FUNDING IMPACTS ON
LOCAL LEVEL. ON A LOCAL LEVEL,
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE BIG AND ARE
GROWING. WE NEED TO HELP THE
AGENCIES THAT SUPPORT ON A LOCAL
LEVEL WITH THE FUNDS THAT ARE
NEEDED. THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
PASSION AND SUPPORT. I CAN
REALLY FEEL YOUR UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT IS NEEDED IN THE
COMMUNITY, WHICH IS WHY I URGE
YOU TO REJECT THE PROPOSALS THAT
WE CAN'T PLAY WITH MATTERS OF
HEALTH AND CREATE INSTABILITY
WITH VITAL HEALTH NEEDS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO. MONICA
KIRKLAND, STATE POLICY DIRECTOR
FOR SENIOR SERVICES COALITION OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY. WE URGE YOU TO
REJECT THE, ELIMINATION OF THE
HOME SAFE FUNDING AND TO PROTECT
THE VULNERABLE OLDER ADULTS THAT
ARE IMPACTED BY IT. A LOT OF
THEM NEED THAT SUPPORT. WE IN
OUR COUNTY HAVE HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
BY THAT. ALSO, TO REJECT THE
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
EXPANSION, AND THAT RESULTS IN
THE IMMEDIATE LOSS OF STAFF. AND
THEN WE ALSO REJECT THE OLDER
CALIFORNIA ACT MODERNIZATION
FUNDING TO PROTECT THE OLDER
ADULTS WHO RELY ON THE SUPPORTS
OF THIS FUNDING. AND ALSO WE
REJECT THE ELIMINATION OF THE
OLDER BEHAVIORAL PROGRAM IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HELLO. MIKAYLA
DUPONT, RESIDENT OF STANISLAUS
COUNTY, REGARDING APS AND THE
RELATED PROPOSALS, APS NEEDS
INVESTMENT IN STAFF AND SKILLS
TO CONTINUE RESPONDING TO THE
EVER SHIFTING NEEDS OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION TO ADDRESS
A RELATED BUDGET ITEM WITH
HOUSING AND SECURITY BECOMING AN
INCREASING CONCERN FOR THE
GENERAL POPULATION, THIS IS EVEN
MORE MAGNIFIED FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES WHO ARE
ALREADY EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. THE HOUSING AND
DISABILITY ADVOCACY PROGRAM, OR
ADAP, PROVIDES CRITICAL,
COMMUNITY BASED RESOURCES THAT
SUPPORT THE PERSON WHERE THEY
ARE AND HELP ESTABLISH
SUSTAINABLE INCOME THAT HELPS
ENSURE SUCCESS OF LONG TERM
HOUSING RELATED. THE HOME SAFE
PROGRAM SIMILARLY PROVIDES
CRITICAL COMMUNITY SUPPORTS
TARGETING, CASE MANAGEMENT,
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE, AND MORE.
FOR THOSE REASONS, I URGE THAT
WE REJECT THOSE PROPOSALS. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, NINA
WHEELER WITH AARP CALIFORNIA. ON
BEHALF OF OUR 3.2 MILLION
MEMBERS, I WANT TO TEE UP A
COUPLE OF THINGS. 2021 OUR VITAL
VOICES SURVEY FOUND THAT 87% OF
VOTERS OVER 45 WANT TO REMAIN IN
THEIR HOMES AND COMMUNITIES AS
THEY AGE. THE STATE IS TALKING A
LOT ABOUT CALIFORNIA FOR ALL,
BUT THE CUTS I'M GOING TO
ADDRESS ACTUALLY RUN COUNTER TO
THAT. SO AARP IS DEEPLY
DISAPPOINTED IN THE CUTS TO
NUTRITION PROGRAMS AT CDA, TO
THE CUTS TO APS AND THE CUTS TO
HOME SAFE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. KATHY SONDERLING
MCDONNELL FOR ALAMEDA COUNTY.
REGARDING THE ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES CUTS, WE DO URGE YOU TO
REJECT THESE CUTS REGARDING THE
EXPANSION. THIS WASN'T JUST FOR
THE AGE. IT WAS ALSO FOR
ADDITIONAL CASE MANAGEMENT.
ALAMEDA COUNTY WAS ABLE TO HIRE
TEN ADDITIONAL STAFF. THEY WERE
ALREADY LOSING GROUND BECAUSE OF
THE INCREASE IN DEMAND AND
COMPLEXITY, AND THIS WOULD
FURTHER SET THEM BEHIND. THEY
CURRENTLY HAVE 73 CASES PER
WORKER AND THIS WOULD ONLY
INCREASE THAT TO AN UNTENABLE
LEVEL. ADDITIONALLY IMPLEMENTING
SB 43, THE CONSERVATORSHIP
REFORM ACT, AS WELL AS THE CARE
ACT WILL BE IMPOSSIBLE IF THE
TRAINING SERVICES ARE CUT AS
PROPOSED. AND FINALLY, HOME
SAFE. IT'S A HUGE DISRUPTION TO
STOP THOSE SERVICES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AMY WESTLING,
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES, WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE TO THE CHAIR MEMBERS
AND ESPECIALLY YOUR STAFF, FOR
DIGGING THROUGH THE COUCH
CUSHIONS AND LOOKING FOR EVERY
DIME. AND WE ENCOURAGE THAT. IF
ANY DIME IS FOUND THAT IT IS
RETAINED IN THE SYSTEM WHERE
IT'S FOUND, PARTICULARLY IN THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM
RELATED TO THE PROVIDER RATE
DELAYS. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. TARA GAMBOA EASTMAN WITH
THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE,
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING YOU TO
REJECT THE CUTS TO THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
INVESTMENTS. WE ARE IN A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CRISIS AND
ALSO FACE A BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE. THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE ESTIMATES WE
NEED 370,000 WORKERS. I DON'T
THINK WE'RE DOING ANY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKER. WE'RE ON THE
HUMAN SERVICES SIDE. WE HAVEN'T
DONE THE HEALTH SIDE. APOLOGIES.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
RONALD COLMAN BALLEZA HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK, CAN JUST
URGE YOU TO REJECT THE DELAY OF
THE CFAB BENEFITS TO
UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE WILL NEED TO TAKE
A RECESS, THAT'S A ROUGH
SCHEDULE FOR US RIGHT NOW, WE
HAVE TO GO TO SESSION AND
PREPARE, SO WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
A RECESS AND COME BACK AFTER
SESSION TO FINISH THE HEALTH
SIDE. SO IT'S GOING TO BE A LONG
DAY. SO BUDGET'S UP THREE NUMBER
HEALTH ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES HAS ADJOURNED HAS TAKEN
A RECESS. ADJOURNED FOR NOW
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY. HERE WE GO
. LET'S CLOSE THIS OUT, SO THE
ASSEMBLY'S HAVING THEIR HEARING
AT THE SAME TIME, SO WE'RE GOING
TO MAYBE GO OUT OF ORDER. WE'RE
JUST GOING TO TAKE PEOPLE AS
THEY COME HERE AND THEN MOVE
THAT WAY. SO I'M NOT SURE IF FOR
THE FIRST ISSUE ON CENSUS, WE
HAVE SOMEONE HERE. PERFECT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LEO JOINED
THE PARTY
.
PLEASE BEGIN. SIR GOOD EVENING,
MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS CRAIG
JOHNSON, AND I REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES AUTHORITY. AND AS
LISTED IN THE AGENDA, WE'RE HERE
TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
CENTRAL REGISTRY REPLACEMENT AND
THE CALIFORNIA EMS INFORMATION
SYSTEM. REPROCUREMENT ALSO,
WE'RE HERE WITH OUR PARTNERS AT
OTS, CI, SO EMS, A PARTNER WITH
OT, CI TO MANAGE THE PLANNING
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
CENTRAL REGISTRY PROJECT AND
CONDUCT THE CMSIS REPROCUREMENT.
SO THIS PROPOSAL REQUESTS
REAPPROPRIATION OF 3.0 MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE AUTHORIZING ENCUMBRANCE
OR EXPENDITURE UNTIL JUNE 30TH
OF 2026 FOR REPROCUREMENT
ACTIVITIES OF THE CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
INFORMATION SYSTEM AND PLANNING
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES CENTRAL REGISTRY
REPLACEMENT PROJECT. EMSA HAS
STATUTORY AND REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO THE
COLLECTION AND EVALUATION OF EMS
DATA LICENSING, CERTIFICATION,
INVESTIGATORY AND LEGAL
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS AS
DESCRIBED IN THE CALIFORNIA CODE
OF REGULATIONS, TITLE 22,
DIVISION NINE REGULATIONS AND
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE. THE
REQUEST SUPPORTS TWO KEY
ACTIVITIES ONE. CONTINUED
PLANNING EFFORTS OF THE CENTRAL
REGISTRY PROJECT, WHICH WILL
REPLACE THE CURRENT LEGACY
REGISTRY SYSTEM AND HELP ENSURE
EMS MEETS ITS STATUTORY AND
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS RELATED
TO THE COLLECTION AND EVALUATION
OF EMS PERSONNEL. CERTIFICATION
LICENSURE AND TRAINING DATA, AND
TWO REPROCUREMENT ACTIVITIES OF
THE CALIFORNIA EMS INFORMATION
SYSTEM CMS, WHICH IS A CRITICAL
SYSTEM OF PATIENT CARE DATA,
NEED TO BEGIN IN JULY 2024 DUE
TO THE LENGTH OF THE STATE'S
PROCUREMENT CYCLE. SO THIS
PROPOSAL REQUESTS THESE
RESOURCES SO THAT EMS CONTINUES
TO MEET THEIR STATUTORY AND
REGULATORY RESPONSE ABILITIES TO
PROVIDE THE TOOLS NECESSARY FOR
EMERGENCY SERVICES PROVIDERS TO
CARE FOR PATIENTS AT THEIR MOST
VULNERABLE MOMENTS IN LIFE, AND
THEN IF THERE ARE QUESTIONS,
HAPPY TO TAKE THEM, OR I CAN
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
MICHAEL MUTH HERE, WHO'S FROM
THE OFFICE OF TECHNOLOGY
SOLUTIONS AND INTEGRATION, TO
PROVIDE MORE DETAILS. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. SENATOR EGGMAN, I'M
HAPPY TO BE HERE TONIGHT. AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. I KNOW YOU'VE HAD A VERY
LONG DAY, SO I JUST WANTED TO
ADD A LITTLE BIT TO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM MSA STATED. SO
YOU HAD ASKED THE OTHER DAY, YOU
KNOW, WHY NOW? WHY ARE THESE
RESOURCES IMPORTANT NOW? AND SO
LET ME JUST EMPHASIZE A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE CENTRAL REGISTRY
ITSELF. SO THIS IS THE ONLY
SYSTEM THE STATE HAS TO TRACK
AND MAINTAIN EMS PERSONNEL DATA
AND ASSOCIATED RECORDS FROM A
SAFETY STANDARDS AND COMPLIANCE
PERSPECTIVE. AND THE CURRENT
SYSTEM IS, ESSENTIALLY IT'S ON
ITS LAST LEG SO IT NO LONGER
MEETS THE STATE'S TECHNICAL AND
DATA INTEGRATION STANDARDS. IT
REQUIRES MANY MANUAL WORKAROUNDS
AND, AND ESSENTIALLY, THIS
SYSTEM IS NOT ONLY CRITICAL FOR
EMS AT THE STATE LEVEL, BUT ALSO
FOR THOSE LOCAL GOVERNMENTAL
ENTITIES IN CALIFORNIANS THAT
RELY SO HEAVILY ON THE SOLUTION.
AND I'LL JUST GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE OF WHAT I MEAN BY THAT.
SO THERE'S 69 CERTIFYING
ENTITIES EMS, EMPLOYERS, LOCAL
AND STATE AUTHORITIES, AND THE
PUBLIC THAT LEVERAGE THAT
SOLUTION TO VERIFY EMS PERSONNEL
CERTIFICATION AND LICENSURE,
BASICALLY, EMPLOYMENT HISTORY,
BOTH CURRENT STATUS AS WELL AS
HISTORICAL STATUS. AND THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF EMS
PERSONNEL RECORDS AND ASSOCIATED
INFORMATION AND DATA WITHIN THAT
SOLUTION THAT ARE MAINTAINED AND
ACCESSIBLE AS STATUTORILY
REQUIRED, SO THAT'S ON THE
LICENSURE AND CERTIFICATION
PIECE. BUT ON THE TRAINING
PROGRAM SIDE, BECAUSE THE
SOLUTION IS ALSO MEANT FOR
AUTHORIZED AND REQUIRED TRAINING
AROUND PUBLIC SAFETY, THERE'S
90,000, DAYCARE PROVIDERS IS
135,000 SCHOOL BUS DRIVERS.
THERE'S ALMOST 14,000 PEACE
OFFICERS THAT LEVERAGE OR, USE
THAT SOLUTION TO IDENTIFY WHAT
TRAINING PROGRAMS ARE REQUIRED
TO AUTHORIZE AROUND PUBLIC
SAFETY, CPR, AND SO ON. AND SO
THIS SOLUTION IS CRITICAL. AND
THESE RESOURCES ARE CRITICAL FOR
THE CONTINUED PLANNING AND
PROJECT EFFORTS, NOT ONLY FOR
THE CENTRAL REGISTRY, BUT AS WE
MENTIONED, THE CMS REPROCUREMENT
ACTIVITIES, THAT BASELINE
CONTRACT DOES EXPIRE. WE NEED
TIME TO RE PROCURE AND BOTH GET
A CONTRACT IN PLACE BEFORE THE
CURRENT ONE EXPIRES. WHEN DOES
IT EXPIRE? SO THE CMS, THE
CURRENT BASELINE CONTRACT
ACTUALLY EXPIRES? I THINK IT'S,
SEPTEMBER OF 2024. WE HAVE A
BASELINE CONTRACT, BUT WE HAVE
TWO OPTIONAL EXTENSIONS WITHIN
THERE OF ONE YEAR EACH. AND MSA
HAS FUNDING AND REQUEST IN THEIR
FALL BCP FOR THOSE TWO OPTIONAL
YEARS TO TAKE IT OUT TO 2026.
THAT'S THAT'S THE TIME PERIOD IN
WHICH WE'RE GOING TO NEED IN
ORDER TO EXECUTE A NEW, CONTRACT
, BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THE
STATE'S PROCUREMENT PROCESS
TAKES SOME TIME. WHAT DO YOU
MEAN? YOUR FOR BCP, SORRY.
EMSA'S, BCP THAT THEY PUT
FORWARD IN THE FALL. I'LL DEFER
TO MY COLLEAGUES AT DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE OR TO PROVIDE MORE.
YOU MEAN BETTER VERBIAGE.
JANUARY BUDGET. YEAH. THERE
THERE WAS A BCP APPROVED IN THE
FALL FOR THAT CONTRACT OR TO
FUND THE TWO OPTIONAL YEARS. NÓ.
IN THE FALL FOR BUDGET YEAR 24,
25. BUT FOR GOVERNOR'S BUDGET,
IT WAS ALREADY APPROVED
.
OKAY. AND SO THE SYSTEMS RIGHT
NOW ARE DOING IT. THE CONTRACT
IS GOING TO EXPIRE. THE FUNDING
IS TO EXTEND THE CONTRACT TO GET
INTO A NEW SYSTEM, SO IN THE
FALL, WE APPROVED A SEPARATE BCP
TO FUND THOSE TWO OPTIONAL YEARS
OF THE CONTRACT. SO THAT'S DONE.
AND PART OF THIS REAPPROPRIATION
IS TO FUND THE REPROCUREMENT
PROCESS FOR ONCE. THOSE TWO
OPTIONAL YEARS ARE DONE, THEN
THERE WILL BE A NEW VENDOR OR A
NEW AGREEMENT IN PLACE. IF IT'S
THE SAME VENDOR, BECAUSE THAT
PROCUREMENT PROCESS DOES TAKE SO
LONG, WE WANT THERE TO BE A
SEAMLESS TRANSITION. SO THERE'S
NO GAP IN SERVICE IN BETWEEN. SO
THIS IS FOR A CONTRACT THAT WILL
EXPIRE IN TWO YEARS. YES THAT'S
CORRECT. AND YOU AND THE FUNDING
NOW TO BEGIN THE PROCUREMENT
PROCESS BECAUSE IT WOULD TAKE
POTENTIALLY TWO YEARS. YES DO
YOU GUYS WANT TO SPEAK TO THAT.
YEAH. SO REPROCUREMENT EFFORTS
WITHIN THE STATE THROUGH, THEY
TYPICALLY TAKE ANYWHERE FROM A
YEAR TO TWO YEARS. AND WE WOULD
LIKE SOME TIME TO TRANSITION
BETWEEN THE TWO, WELL, IF THERE
IS A NEW VENDOR, WE WOULD LIKE
TIME FOR TRANSITION BETWEEN
THOSE JUST GIVEN HOW CRITICAL
THIS SOLUTION IS. AND THAT'S
PRETTY STANDARD WITH ANY TYPE OF
REPROCUREMENT AND TRANSITION.
THE FUNDING THAT WAS ALLOCATED
IN 2021 WAS FOR A DIFFERENT
PROGRAM, AND NOW WE'RE
REAPPROPRIATING FOR ANOTHER ONE,
YOU'RE REFERRING TO THE BUDGET
ACT OF 2021. CORRECT. SO THAT,
SO IF WE GO BACK TO 2021, THAT
WAS ORIGINALLY AROUND THE
CALIFORNIA EMS DATA RESOURCE
SYSTEM, SO THERE'S $10 MILLION
ORIGINALLY APPROPRIATED TO THAT.
THAT WAS ABOUT DATA INTEGRATION.
AND THAT IT, BASICALLY AND
BUDGET ACT OF 2022, WE WERE
AUTHORIZED TO EXPEND THROUGH
JUNE OF 2024 SO THAT THAT'S NOW,
AND IN 2023, THERE WAS NEW
LEGISLATION AROUND THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY'S DATA EXCHANGE
FRAMEWORK, ESSENTIALLY NEGATING
THE NEED FOR THE ORIGINAL INTENT
OF THE CEDARS PROJECT, BECAUSE
THAT WAS ENVISIONED AS A
SEPARATE HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE. AND WITH THE DATA
EXCHANGE FRAMEWORK NEGATING THAT
NEED THAT WAS WITHDRAWN FROM THE
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFE CYCLE FROM
AN IT, PERSPECTIVE. BUT THE NEED
TO INTEGRATE DATA, ACROSS ALL OF
THESE PLANNED CURRENT AND FUTURE
IT SOLUTIONS STILL EXISTS. SO
FROM THE TIME PERIOD OF THE
BUDGET ACT 2023 AND BEYOND, OR I
SHOULD SAY 2023 WHEN THAT WAS
DECIDED TO PULL IT FROM THE
PROCESS, THAT BECAME THE DATA
INFRASTRUCTURE SOLUTION
INITIATIVE. AND SO THAT IS A
SEPARATE ACTIVITY, THAT THAT
RELATES DIRECTLY TO THESE
EFFORTS BECAUSE THAT WILL PULL
AND, AND USE DATA FROM THESE TWO
SOLUTIONS AS WELL AS OTHER
PLANNED AND CURRENT SOLUTIONS IN
THE SPACE. I DO WANT TO ADD THAT
IT IS A REAPPROPRIATION AND NOT
A NEW BCP, BECAUSE IS THAT CEDAS
SYSTEM THAT KIND OF EVOLVED INTO
THE DATA INFRASTRUCTURE SOLUTION
IT WAS ENVISIONED AS A SYSTEM
TO, KIND OF BE A, SINGLE,
INFORMATION HUB THAT CONNECTS
THESE OTHER THREE SYSTEMS
THROUGH THE CENTRAL REGISTRY.
JIMSY'S IPOST, BUT IT NEVER CAME
OFF THE GROUND. RIGHT? CEDARS.
WELL, IT EVOLVED INTO THE DATA
INFRASTRUCTURE SOLUTION, AND NSA
WAS ABLE TO ACTUALLY PROCURE, A
DATA PLATFORM IN CURRENT YEARS.
SO THIS YEAR TO, KIND OF
ESTABLISH THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
THAT. AND KIND OF ENVISIONED A,
YOU KNOW, I THINK IT KIND OF
EVOLVED WHAT IN TERMS OF WHAT
THEY LANDED ON IN TERMS OF THE
TYPE OF DATA INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WAS NEEDED. AND SO THEY'VE
PROCURED THAT. IT'S A SMALLER
SYSTEM THAN WHAT WAS ORIGINALLY
ENVISIONED, AND BUT IT'S STILL,
YOU KNOW, ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT
DATA SYSTEMS ARE KIND OF
INTEGRATED. AND SO THIS IS
HELPING TO CONTINUE THAT, YOU
KNOW, WHAT WAS ORIGINALLY
ENVISIONED IN 2021 WITH THAT $10
MILLION TO CONNECT ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS. AND SO THAT'S
WHY, YOU KNOW, WE'RE, CONTINUING
THOSE PIECES OF IT. SO THERE'S
THE, THE AND ALSO JUST TO
DISTINGUISH, THIS 3 MILLION OR
THE 2.96, 4 MILLION, IT'S
DIVIDED BETWEEN, THE CHEMISTRY
PROCUREMENT THAT WE WERE JUST
DISCUSSING. AND, THE UPDATING OR
REPLACEMENT OF THE CENTRAL
REGISTRY. SO THOSE ARE TWO
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS. AGAIN, IT'S
ALL PART OF THIS KIND OF
INTEGRATED WEB OF, YOU KNOW,
DATA, A DATA PLATFORM AND KIND
OF, YEAH, AND MICHAEL HAD
EXPLAINED, YOU KNOW, HOW THE
CENTRAL REGISTRY IS OUTDATED, SO
THAT'S, THAT'S WHAT THAT PROJECT
IS TO UPDATE IT, SO THAT IT CAN
ACTUALLY BE FUNCTIONAL AND HAVE
ACCURATE DATA. AND THEN THE
CMSIS IS THE PROCUREMENT SIDE.
OKAY. ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENT ON
THIS, WILL OWENS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE,
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD, BUT
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MADAM CHAIR,
IF I COULD, IF I COULD JUST SAY
MAYBE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, WHY DOES IT TAKE TWO
YEARS TO DO PROCUREMENT FOR WHO?
CAN ANYBODY ANSWER THAT FOR ME?
NO THAT'S HOW GOVERNMENT WORKS.
I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE THAT OFF
AND FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR STAFF.
OKAY. WE. I WAS JUST AT A PRESS
CONFERENCE THE OTHER DAY WITH
THE WITH THE GOVERNOR WHERE HE
WAS TALKING ABOUT I THINK IT WAS
A NO PLACE LIKE HOME, ACT. THAT
WAS PASSED BY VOTERS. AND IT
TOOK US THREE YEARS TO GET OUT
THE RFPS, THREE YEARS TO GET OUT
THE RFP. THAT'S WITHOUT A CENT
GOING OUT. THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
VOTERS VOTED ON. AND WE WERE
ABLE TO STREAMLINE THAT PROCESS.
SO WITH PROP ONE, GOT OUR FIRST
3 BILLION GOING OUT NEXT MONTH,
I THINK. SO I'M JUST THINKING IF
WE CAN DO THAT WITH ONE THING,
IT SEEMS TO ME WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO DO IT WITH OTHER THINGS. I
MEAN, 10 MILLION IS TIME IS
MONEY, TIME IS MONEY, AND WE'RE
AT A TIME WHEN WE DON'T HAVE
MUCH MONEY. SO WE SHOULD WORK AS
BEST WE CAN TO COMPRESS THE TIME
. THANK YOU, SENATOR, THANK YOU.
SO DO WE HAVE ANYBODY HCAI
ANYONE HERE FROM HCAI IN THE
ASSEMBLY? I THINK HE IS IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE'RE GOING TO SKIP.
HI. THE HCS IS IN THE ASSEMBLY.
DPH IS HERE, SO WE CAN SO WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO DPH. YES. I
JUST GOT HERE. WELL I AGREE
.
DOCTOR ARAGON, WERE YOU IN THE
NAVY, NO. MY NOT ME. I WAS A
MARINE. I WAS A MARINE RESERVIST
. MY SON IS A NAVAL OFFICER.
YOU'RE IN THE MARINES.
RESERVISTS RESERVE. NICE TO YOU.
NOW OH, MY GOODNESS, THAT WAS
MANY, MANY YEARS AGO. THEY
ALWAYS MARINES. SO WE'RE GOING
TO FIX THIS, RIGHT? MARINES GET
ABSOLUTELY STUFF DONE. THAT'S
THE PLAN. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH, DOCTOR, FOR COMING. WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH ISSUE ONE ON
A. MYRIAD. WE'RE GOING TO START
ON ISSUE. THE OTHER ISSUE, ONE
ON THE FUTURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND HAVE A MORE IN DEPTH
CONVERSATION. DO WE HAVE ALL THE
PANELISTS UP HERE? MY TWO
PANELISTS, MY TWO. CHAIRS YES.
ONE FOR. MYSELF. AND.
WE'RE ALL HERE. I THINK SO, HOPE
SO. OKAY DOCTOR, I'M GOING TO
HAVE YOU KICK US OFF ON FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND THEN WE'LL
TURN TO TWO REPRESENTATIVES FROM
TWO DIFFERENT COUNTIES JUST TO
TALK ABOUT THAT, I WOULD ALSO,
ADD IN THE AGENDA, THERE'S A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT THERE'S A
BREAKDOWN OF HOW DIFFERENT
COUNTIES ARE UTILIZING THE
FUNDING, THE FLEXIBILITY
ASSOCIATED TO THAT, IF YOU'RE
AWAKE AT 1 OR 2:00 IN THE
MORNING LOOKING FOR SOMETHING TO
READ AND CONTINUE READING, THIS
DOCTOR, THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
FIRST OF ALL, I DO WANT TO THANK
THE SENATE FOR ITS VISION,
VISIONARY LEADERSHIP AND
FORESIGHT AND COMMITMENT TO
PUBLIC HEALTH. SO SO CALIFORNIA
IS A LARGE, COMPLEX AND DIVERSE
STATE. WE ARE LARGER THAN MOST
COUNTRIES WITH A POPULATION
CLOSE TO 40 MILLION. WE'RE AN
INTERNATIONAL DESTINATION AND
HUB FOR TRAVELERS. SO WHAT
HAPPENS GLOBALLY AFFECTS US IN
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE EXISTING,
EMERGING AND REEMERGING PUBLIC
HEALTH THREATS. YOU KNOW ABOUT
THEM STDS. WE HAD HIV, SARS,
ONE, H1, H1, N1 PANDEMIC IN
2009, COVID AND POX,
ANTIMICROBIAL RESISTANCE AND NOW
WE'RE CURRENTLY DEALING WITH
H5N1 HIGHLY PATHOGENIC AVIAN
INFLUENZA IN CATTLE. WE HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS WITH MENTAL
HEALTH, SUBSTANCE USE, OBESITY
AND CHRONIC DISEASES, AND THE
NEED TO SUPPORT MATERNAL, CHILD,
ADOLESCENT AND FAMILY HEALTH. SO
WE KNOW THAT PUBLIC HEALTH HAS
STRUGGLED IN THE PAST AROUND THE
AROUND THE COUNTRY, HAVING
FUNDING FOR CORE PUBLIC HEALTH
SERVICES. WHEN WE DEVELOP THE
FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH INITIATIVE,
WE MET WITH STAKEHOLDERS, WE MET
WITH EXPERTS, WE MET WITH THE
LOCALS. WE WORKED WITH NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
CONDUCTING DECADES OF RESEARCH
ON WHAT IS CORE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS NEEDED
FOR HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES IS, IS THAT WE
RESPOND, AND SO WE END UP
FOCUSING ON CATEGORICAL
SOLUTIONS AND THEN WE HAVE ALL
THESE GAPS THAT WE HAVE TO FILL.
SO THE WAY THE EXPERTS ORGANIZE
THIS FRAMEWORK IS VERY BASIC.
AND THEY TALKED ABOUT
FOUNDATIONAL CAPABILITIES. AND I
WANT YOU TO THINK OF
FOUNDATIONAL CAPABILITIES AS
REALLY THE ROOTS OF A TREE. YOU
CAN'T SEE IT. BUT THOSE
FOUNDATIONAL CAPABILITIES IS
WHAT MAKES THE TREE STRONG. IT'S
WHAT ALLOWS IT TO RESPOND, TO BE
RESILIENT TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
THREATS THAT IT FACES. THE CORE
FOUNDATIONAL CAPABILITIES THAT
WE USE TO DESIGN THE FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH INCLUDED
ASSESSMENT AND SURVEILLANCE,
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT, EQUITY AND HEALTH
EQUITY. ORGANIZATIONAL
COMPETENCIES LIKE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT, IT, DATA SCIENCE,
DATA MODERNIZATION, AND OTHER
OPERATIONAL US POLICY
DEVELOPMENT AND SUPPORT. AND ONE
THING I DO WANT TO POINT OUT IS
FOR THE BIGGEST STATE IN THE
COUNTRY, FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH
INITIATIVE ALLOWED US TO STAND
UP OUR FIRST OFFICE OF POLICY
AND PLANNING EVER, WHICH IS
INCREDIBLY, INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
. THE SIXTH ONE IS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND PERFORMANCE
MANAGEMENT. SEVEN EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE. AND
THEN, OF COURSE, COMMUNICATE AND
PUBLIC EDUCATION. SO THOSE
FOUNDATIONAL CAPABILITIES AGAIN
ARE ARE THE ROOTS OF A TREE. WE
DON'T SEE IT. I THINK PEOPLE
SHOULD REALLY THINK OF PUBLIC
HEALTH MORE LIKE CORE
INFRASTRUCTURE. IN SOME WAYS
WE'RE MORE LIKE PUBLIC SAFETY
BECAUSE WE RESPOND TO WHATEVER
THREAT HAPPENS. WE DON'T GET TO
CHOOSE. WE CAN'T SAY, OH, NO, WE
DON'T DO THAT, YOU KNOW, WE
RESPOND TO EVERY WE RESPOND TO
EVERYTHING. AND THEN, OF COURSE,
THERE ARE THE FOUNDATIONAL AREAS
THAT YOU KNOW ABOUT COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE CONTROL, CHRONIC CHRONIC
DISEASE AND INJURY PREVENTION,
ENVIRONMENTAL, PUBLIC HEALTH,
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE,
MATERNAL, CHILD AND FAMILY
HEALTH. SO THAT'S WHAT THE
FUTURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH
INITIATIVE IS. IT IS CORE PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE TO MAKE US
WHOLE SO THAT WE CAN BE
RESPONSIVE CURRENTLY EVERY DAY.
BUT ALSO TO EMERGING THREATS.
AND IN SOME WAYS, WHEN WE
STARTED, YOU ASKED ME ABOUT, MY
MILITARY BACKGROUND. IN SOME
WAYS WE ARE THERE IS AN ANALOGY
TO THE MILITARY. THE MILITARY IS
CONSTANTLY EXERCISING AND
PRACTICING AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
DOING EVERY DAY WHEN WE'RE
RESPONDING TO DAILY PUBLIC
HEALTH THREATS. AND WE'RE WE'RE
FINE TUNING OUR SYSTEMS OR OUR
SURVEILLANCE, WORKING WITH
HOSPITALS, WORKING WITH
COMMUNITIES, WORKING WITH LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS. SO WHEN
BIGGER ISSUES HAPPEN, WE'RE
PREPARED TO RESPOND IN AN
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT WAY. AND
THAT CAN ONLY HAPPEN WHEN WE'RE
WHEN WE'RE WHEN WE HAVE OUR
STAFF WERE WHOLE AND WE'RE
TRAINING AND WE HAVE THE KIND OF
FUNDING THAT GIVES US THE
FLEXIBILITY TO RESPOND TO
WHATEVER HAPPENS. MOST OF THE
FUNDING THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE
IS CATEGORICAL, AND IT COMES
FROM OTHER, OTHER SOURCES. I'M
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND, END THERE
AND JUST END OFF END OFF BY
SAYING THAT IN PUBLIC HEALTH,
WE, WE PROMOTE A CULTURE OF
HEALTH. WELL BEING AND THRIVING
FOR ALL. IN CALIFORNIA. WE FOCUS
ON PROTECTION, PREVENTION AND
PROMOTION OF HEALTH COMMUNITIES
BEING RESILIENT, US RESPONDING
AND THEN COMMUNITIES RECOVERING.
AND THEN WE'RE ALSO FOCUSED ON
BEING EFFECTIVE, EFFICIENT,
ETHICAL AND EQUITABLE. SO I'M
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND END THERE
AND LET THE REST OF THE PANEL
CONTINUE. THANK YOU. DOCTOR. DO
YOU THINK WE'LL STILL BE ABLE TO
MEET THOSE THOSE CATEGORIES YOU
MENTIONED WITH THE DRASTIC CUTS?
IT WILL IT WILL HINDER US AND SO
THE ONE CONCRETE EXAMPLE FOR ME
IS, IS JUST, FOR EXAMPLE, ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT REALLY EXCITED
ME ABOUT THE FUNDING WAS TO HAVE
, FOR THE FIRST TIME, AN OFFICE
OF POLICY AND PLANNING TO
PROVIDE FOR YOU THE FIRST STATE
OF PUBLIC HEALTH REPORT AND
WE'RE JUST GETTING STARTED. WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO BE UP ON THE
LATEST SCIENCE, TO BE ABLE TO
FIND THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INTERVENTIONS THAT ARE NOT JUST
GOING TO BE THE MOST EFFECTIVE,
BUT WHICH ARE GOING TO BE THE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE, AND IT
ENABLES US TO DEVELOP THESE
STRONG PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR
ACADEMICS SO THAT WE CAN REALLY
PROMOTE BETTER PUBLIC HEALTH FOR
ALL OF CALIFORNIA. AND SO POLICY
AND PLANNING IS SORT OF A
CONCRETE ONE, BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
RUN, IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT TO
RUN AN ORGANIZATION WITH WITHOUT
HAVING A STRATEGIC APPROACH FOR
A STATE THAT'S AS BIG AND AS
DIVERSE AS AS WE ARE. AND THEN,
OF COURSE, OUR EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE REALLY
CRITICAL. WE'RE TAKING REGIONAL
APPROACHES TO HOW WE DO PUBLIC
HEALTH. WE'RE DEVELOPING 24 OVER
SEVEN CAPABILITY TO ALWAYS TO
ALWAYS BE TO ALWAYS BE READY,
AND SO THERE ARE THERE AND OUR
STAFF WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL EXAMPLES, BUT IT WILL
IMPACT US BECAUSE THOSE THINGS,
IF OUR OFFICE OF POLICY AND
PLANNING GOES AWAY, THAT'S A BIG
THAT'S GOING TO BE A BIG A BIG
LOSS FOR US AND IT WILL BE A LOT
A LOSS FOR CALIFORNIA. DO WE
KNOW WHAT THE PROPOSED CUTS, IF
THAT OFFICE WOULD GO AWAY.
PARDON. WOULD THAT NEW OFFICE
WOULD THAT IS THAT AT RISK OF
BEING OF GOING. THAT'S ALL PART
OF THE FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH FOR
THE FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH IS WE
FOCUSED ON FOUNDATIONAL
CAPABILITIES AND PLANNING. AND
POLICY DEVELOPMENT IS A CORE
FOUNDATIONAL CAPABILITY. AND IT
WAS A GAP AREA, GAP AREA FOR US.
THE LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS
DID THE SAME THING. THEY LOOKED
AT WHAT WHAT WHAT IS CORE PUBLIC
HEALTH CAPABILITIES THAT EVERY
COUNTY SHOULD HAVE. THEY LOOKED
AT THEIR GAPS, AND THAT'S WHAT
THEY THAT'S WHAT THEY FILLED.
AND THEN WE WON'T BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO MEET THAT GAP AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND ALSO AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. OKAY SENATOR,
SENATOR EGGMAN AND THEN SENATOR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DOCTOR
OREGON, SO, YOU KNOW, WE'RE WE
ALL HAVE TO MAKE SOME VERY HARD
CUTS. I THINK THIS IS A LOT FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH, ESPECIALLY JUST
COMING OUT OF A PANDEMIC. AND I
THINK THE YEAR AFTER, WE THOUGHT
WE WERE GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET
SOME RELIEF AND WE'RE PUT OFF A
LITTLE WHILE AND, AND WE FINALLY
GOT SOME. AND THEN NOW IT'S NOW
IT'S GOING AWAY. BUT I BUT I'M
CONCERNED IF SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE ALREADY INVESTED IN,
WE END UP WASTING MONEY WALKING
AWAY FROM MONEY INTO THINGS
WE'VE ALREADY BEGUN, IF WE JUST
IF WE CAN IDENTIFY THINGS THAT
WILL, THAT WE'VE ALREADY
INVESTED IN, THAT'S GOING TO
COST US. AND JUST LIKE MONEY
GONE OR THINGS THAT WE CAN THAT
HAVE NOT STARTED YET, THAT
PERHAPS MAKES MORE SENSE IN THE
REDUCTIONS. YES, I AGREE WITH
YOUR ASSESSMENT. IT DOES TAKE A
LONG TIME TO BUILD UP THE
SYSTEMS AND TO DEVELOP THE
PROFICIENCIES IN OPERATING THEM,
AND LEARNING LEARNING HOW TO DO
IT, SO THAT THAT WOULD
DEFINITELY IMPACT US. YES.
SENATOR ROTH. YOU KNOW, I, I
ASKED THIS QUESTION WHEN WE LAST
VISITED THIS SUBJECT. AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE REFERENCED, 27 PLUS
BILLION DOLLARS IS A LOT OF CUTS
. AND WHEN YOU CUT $27 BILLION
OUT OF ANY OPERATION, YOU'RE
PROBABLY GOING TO CUT SOME OF
THE NICE TO HAVE STUFF, SOME OF
THE POLICY AND ANALYSIS TEAMS
THAT ARE REALLY, WE ARGUE, ARE
CRITICAL TO HAVE. BUT NOT BOOTS
ON THE GROUND. IF YOU HAVE A
PANDEMIC OR SOME OTHER NATURAL
DISASTER THAT WOULD INVOLVE
PUBLIC HEALTH, I DON'T THINK.
AND THE QUESTION I ASKED LAST
TIME WAS WHAT? WHAT LEVEL OF
CUTS IS THE IS THE PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEM ABLE TO SUSTAIN OR TAKE
AND STILL HAVE ENOUGH? GAS IN
THE TANK TO RAMP UP QUICKLY IN
THE EVENT OF ANOTHER PANDEMIC OR
SOME OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS?
YES. AND I THAT MAY BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO ANSWER, BUT THOSE
OF YOU WHO ARE IN THE BUSINESS
CAN PROBABLY ANSWER IT BETTER
THAN WE CAN. YEAH SO THERE'S A
COUPLE OF ANSWERS. THAT ONE IS
THE FIRST ONE, SO PART OF OUR
POLICY AND PLANNING IS THAT
ANALYTICAL CAPABILITY BECAUSE WE
HAVE WE HAVE THERE'S ALWAYS NEW
SCIENCE, NEW DATA THAT'S COMING
IN. AND WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT IS THE BEST SCIENCE TO
USE, WHAT IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE
INTERVENTION, WHAT IS THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE APPROACH. AND SO
WE WANT TO FOCUS ON IMPLEMENTING
THOSE THINGS THAT WE THINK ARE
GOING TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE. AND
SO THAT DOES HELP US. THAT'S
THAT'S BIG. I'LL GIVE YOU
ANOTHER WE'LL GIVE YOU A
CONCRETE EXAMPLE THAT HAPPENED
AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL. SO WHEN
SORRY, WHEN SARS-COV-2, THE
COVID PANDEMIC HAPPENED, WE HAD
A VACCINE WITHIN ONE YEAR. WHY
WERE WE ABLE TO GET A VACCINE IN
ONE YEAR? BECAUSE WE HAD MORE
THAN TEN YEARS OF INVESTMENT IN
VACCINE RESEARCH. THAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE IT MAKES. THERE'S NO
WAY WE WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
DEPLOY A VACCINE THAT FAST IF WE
HAD NOT BEEN INVESTING IN
DEVELOPING THAT, THAT SCIENCE
AND KNOWLEDGE. THAT'S THE WAY
WHAT I HEAR FROM YOU IS JUST WHY
WE SHOULDN'T CUT THIS. IT'S WHAT
I KEEP HEARING, LIKE THE
IMPORTANCE OF INVESTING IN ALL
THIS. SO WHAT I WANT TO KNOW IS
GIVEN, GIVEN EVERYTHING YOU'RE
SAYING, GIVEN EVERYTHING WE'RE
SAYING, THEN WHY ARE WE CUTTING
THIS? YOU'RE SHARING ALL THE
WONDERFUL THINGS THAT THIS
FUTURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH DOES.
WHAT? IT HELPS US PREVENT THE
CAPACITY FOUNDATION FOR IT. SO
THEN WHY ARE WE CUTTING IT? SO
THEN WE CAN BE IN THAT SITUATION
AGAIN IN A COUPLE OF YEARS. IF
SOMETHING ELSE HAPPENS, LIKE
WHAT DO WE WHAT IS LEFT IN PLACE
TO DO ALL THE BEAUTIFUL THINGS
THAT YOU MENTIONED PUBLIC HEALTH
DOES? WE WOULD, WE WOULD, WE
WOULD LOSE, WE WOULD, WE WOULD
ALMOST COME BACK TO WHERE WE
WERE PRIOR TO THE, PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC. MADAM CHAIR, MAY I ASK
YOU A QUESTION, SENATOR? OF
COURSE. I DIDN'T MEAN TO. SO I
GUESS THE WHEN YOU HAVE TO CUT.
AND I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
DOUBT THAT WE HAVE TO CUT. AND
SO WE'RE HAVING TO MEASURE YOU
AGAINST CHILD CARE, AGAINST THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED,
AGAINST HEARING AIDS FOR KIDS.
WE'RE HAVING TO MEASURE YOU
AGAINST A WHOLE VARIETY OF OTHER
THINGS. AND YOU OBVIOUSLY ARE A
VALUED PARTNER IN KEEPING
CALIFORNIANS HEALTHY ALL UP AND
DOWN THE STATE. BUT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT YOUR ENTIRE OPERATION
AND WE'RE TRYING TO PLAN FOR
SOME RESIDUAL KEEP, SOME
RESIDUAL CAPABILITY IN PLACE SO
WE CAN RESPOND AT SOME LEVEL PANDEMIC RATHER
QUICKLY, IS SOME OF THIS ABILITY
THAT CAN BE CONTRACTED OUT
RATHER QUICKLY, AS OPPOSED TO
HOW DO YOU TRAIN AND HIRE TRACK
AND TRACE PEOPLE, FOLKS, TO DO
VACCINES. SOME OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT YOU DO IN THE I
THINK YOU DO IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH SECTOR IS THERE NOT A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE MANPOWER
THAT YOU NEED IN THE FIELD AND
SOME OF THE ANALYSIS WORK THAT
OTHERS DO? SO, YEAH. SO THIS
THIS FUNDS REALLY CORE THIS
FUNDING CORE MINIMAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND SO FOR
EXAMPLE, WE KNOW RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE AN EPIDEMIC OF SYPHILIS AND
GONORRHEA. AND EVEN WITH OUR
CURRENT WORKFORCE, EVEN WITH
THESE INVESTMENTS, WE'RE STILL
NOT ABLE TO KEEP UP. IF A
PANDEMIC WERE TO HAPPEN AGAIN,
WE IT WOULD BE LIKE, WHAT
HAPPENED WITH COVID? IT'S AN ALL
STATE RESPONSE. WE WOULD HAVE TO
HAVE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AT
THAT TIME AND MOBILIZE BEYOND
PUBLIC HEALTH BECAUSE WE
MOBILIZE, WE MOBILIZE, WE
MOBILIZE. IT WAS AN ALL OF
GOVERNMENT, ALL OF SOCIETY
RESPONSE TO THE COVID PANDEMIC.
I'LL TELL YOU, ONE OF THE WAYS
THAT I THINK ABOUT IT, BECAUSE I
KNOW THIS IS A CHALLENGE, HAVING
BEEN THROUGH, CUTS BEFORE IN THE
PAST, NOT NOT HERE, BUT AT A
DIFFERENT INSTITUTION, AT A
DIFFERENT AT LOCAL LEVEL. AND
THAT ONE, I TRY TO ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO LOOK AT PUBLIC HEALTH
AS CORE INFRASTRUCTURE AND MORE
LIKE PUBLIC SAFETY, BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT PROVIDING DIRECT
SERVICES. MOSTLY, WE'RE IN THE
BACKGROUND PROVIDING CORE PUBLIC
HEALTH SERVICES. SO THINK OF IT
LIKE INFRASTRUCTURE, WHERE WE
THINK ABOUT, FOR EXAMPLE, IT
IT'S YOU DON'T YOU DON'T
GENERALLY COMPARE IT TO THE
DIRECT SERVICE DIRECT SERVICES
BECAUSE THERE'S TWO VERY
DIFFERENT FUNCTIONS. AND WE
CAN'T SAY WE DON'T USUALLY SAY,
OH, WE'RE JUST GOING TO CUT IT
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T PROVIDE. BUT
I'LL TELL YOU THIS, IF YOU IF
YOU'RE IN A CITY AND YOU HAVE TO
CUT, YOU MIGHT CUT COMMUNITY,
WHATEVER, YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
CUT THE BLACK AND WHITES ON THE
STREET AND. CORRECT. AND I GUESS
THAT'S WHAT I'M ASKING YOU. YES.
WHAT ARE YOUR BLACK AND WHITES
THAT ARE VERY DIFFICULT TO
TRAIN, VERY DIFFICULT TO
RECRUIT, VERY DIFFICULT TO HIRE
THAT YOU NEED TO KEEP IN THE
FACE OF SOME DRACONIAN CUTS THAT
ARE PROBABLY GOING TO TOUCH JUST
ABOUT EVERY DEPARTMENT AGENCY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. YEAH,
WE WOULD RIGHT NOW, THE PROPOSED
CUT WOULD ELIMINATE THE FUTURE
OF PUBLIC HEALTH INITIATIVE,
WHICH FUNDS CORE CORE
INFRASTRUCTURE OPERATIONS AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AS WELL. AND, SENATOR, IF
I MIGHT ADD, RITA NHIÀU NGUYEN
ASSISTANT PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER,
THIS GETS AT ONE OF YOUR
QUESTIONS FROM LAST WEEK AS
WELL. I THINK YOU HAD ASKED A
LOT ABOUT THE LOCAL BOOTS ON THE
GROUND IMPACT, AND TO MAKE IT
CLEAR, PART OF THE FUTURE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH INVESTMENT, 100
MILLION IS FOR STATE OPERATIONS,
BUT 200 MILLION GOES TO OUR
LOCAL COLLEAGUES. THE BOOTS ON
THE GROUND, INCLUDING THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS, THE
FOLKS WHO ARE OUT THERE FORMING
TRUST AND BONDING RELATIONSHIPS
WITH COMMUNITY, AT THE STATE
LEVEL. IT ALSO FUNDS OUR NEW,
NEWLY FORMED REGIONAL PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICE. AND SO THAT
OFFICE PROVIDES TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE VARIOUS
REGIONS TO SUPPORT THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN WHATEVER
THEY MAY WANT TO DO, WHETHER IT
BE EPI WITH DATA OR SUPPORT
THEIR COMMUNICATIONS CAMPAIGN.
SO THEY ARE THEY ARE CLOSELY
LINKED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. MADAM CHAIR, IF I
COULD FOLLOW UP ON THAT
QUESTION. THANK YOU, SO, SO IN
THIS. SO WOULDN'T IT MAKE MORE
SENSE? AND I'M ASKING BECAUSE
YOU I MEAN, THIS IS YOUR
DOCUMENT, YOUR I MEAN, I KNOW
IT'S COMING FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE, BUT WOULD IT MAKE
SENSE THEN TO TRY TO MAINTAIN
THE FUNDING THAT GOES TO THE
LOCALS THEN WHERE THAT'S WHERE
THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND ARE,
WHERE WE HAVE THE SYPHILIS
OUTBREAK. WE WANT TO STOP THE
SYPHILIS OUTBREAK. THAT MAKES
SENSE, VERSUS SOME OF THE STATE
PLANNING PART. RIGHT? IF IT'S
ALL YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT, ALL
BEING LUMPED INTO ONE. BUT CAN
WE SEPARATE THOSE OUT TO BE ABLE
TO MAINTAIN THE SERVICES ON THE
GROUND VERSUS THE PLANNING FOR
LATER? YEAH, YOU'RE ASKING A
REALLY A REALLY GOOD QUESTION, I
THINK I THINK THE, THE ROLE OF
THE STATE OPERATIONS PLAYS IS
REALLY VITAL BECAUSE MANY THINGS
THAT HAPPEN ARE CROSS
JURISDICTIONAL. I'M NOT SAYING
THEY'RE NOT VITAL, BUT YOU'RE
YOU'RE ARGUING TO US TO CUT
EVERYTHING. I MEAN, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT DOING A LOT OF
CUTS AND WE'RE SAYING, HELP US.
YEAH, NO, PRIORITIZE YOUR CUTS.
YEAH. SO WE YES, WE BECAME WE
PUT DOCUMENTS TOGETHER TO TALK
ABOUT THE IMPACT. WE DIDN'T WE
DIDN'T GET INTO SORT OF
COMPARING WITHIN WHAT FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH, WHAT WE WOULD
WHAT WE, WHAT WE WOULD CUT OUT.
AND I DON'T WANT TO I DON'T WANT
TO, I, I DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT BOTH THE STATE ROLE AND THE
LOCAL ROLE ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT, AND THEY COMPLEMENT
EACH OTHER, AND WE WORK REALLY
CLOSELY TOGETHER. AND WE, YOU
KNOW, LIKE THE STATE WORKS WITH
THE CDC AND WE WORK WITH LOCALS
AND WE'RE THAT THAT LINKAGE THAT
ENABLES US TO TAKE REGIONAL
APPROACHES TO TAKE CARE OF
THINGS THAT HAPPEN ACROSS
JURISDICTIONAL LINES, DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE, NHIÀU NÂNG. I DO
WANT TO LIKE NOTE THAT THESE
INVESTMENTS WERE MADE DURING
RELATIVELY BETTER FISCAL YEARS.
SO DUE TO THE BUDGET SITUATION,
WE'RE PROPOSING TO REDUCE THE
FUNDING ON THIS. AND WE DO WANT
TO ALSO NOTE THAT THE MAY
REVISION DOES MAINTAIN $4.8
BILLION IN TOTAL FUNDS FOR PH.
AND THESE FUNDS WILL HELP THE
ENTITIES TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICES TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE BASE FUNDING
ALLOWS FOR. AND WE ALSO DO
MAINTAIN OTHER FUNDING SUCH AS,
SUCH AS THE SAPPHIRE SYSTEM,
26.9 MILLION TO CONTINUE, LAB
DATA FOR REPORTABLE HEALTH
CONDITIONS AND 1.4 BILLION IN
BUDGET YEAR FOR THE CENTER FOR
INFECTIOUS DISEASES. LET'S HEAR
FROM OUR TWO, GUESTS WHO CAME IN
TODAY. FIRST, PUBLIC HEALTH
DIRECTOR FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
I THINK THEY DO IT. THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING. CHAIR AND MEMBERS
KIM SARUWATARI, DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC HEALTH FOR RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND THE IMMEDIATE PAST
PRESIDENT OF CHIAC. THANK YOU
FOR HAVING THIS DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE IMPACTS OF ELIMINATING
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING ON OUR
DEPARTMENTS AND COMMUNITIES AND
ALLOWING ME TO SHARE THE IMPACTS
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY. FUTURE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING HAS
ALLOWED US THE MUCH NEEDED
FLEXIBILITY TO HIRE STAFF IN
AREAS OF HIGHEST PRIORITY, AND
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. IN MY
COUNTY, WE FILLED 104 OUT OF 107
POSITIONS LAST WEEK. YOU ASKED
CDPH LEADERSHIP IF THESE
POSITIONS WOULD GO AWAY AND IF
CALIFORNIA'S PREPAREDNESS WOULD
BE IMPACTED IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY,
WE WOULD LIKELY LAY OFF AT LEAST
90 STAFF AND OUR ABILITY TO
PERFORM CORE PUBLIC HEALTH
FUNCTIONS WILL BE GREATLY
DIMINISHED IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE BENEFITING
GREATLY WITH THESE FUNDS. WE
HIRED NURSES FOR OUR MOBILE
IMMUNIZATION TEAMS IN THE LAST
FOUR MONTHS, WE'VE ADMINISTERED
OVER 1100 VACCINATIONS AT
SCHOOLS, COMMUNITY CENTERS,
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
WITHOUT THESE FUNDS, THIS
FUNDING, THESE TEAMS WOULD BE
ELIMINATED AND ARE ALREADY LOW.
VACCINATION RATES WOULD FALL
EVEN MORE GIVEN THE SURGE OF
VACCINE PREVENTABLE DISEASES
SUCH AS MEASLES. THESE
VACCINATION CLINICS ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IN
PROTECTING OUR RESIDENTS. THE
DISEASE INVESTIGATORS SUPPORTED
BY THIS FUNDING HAVE
INVESTIGATED POTENTIAL CONTACTS
TO CONFIRMED CASES OF MEASLES,
EACH OF WHICH REQUIRES
MONITORING FOR UP TO 21 DAYS. WE
ALSO FUND OUR ENHANCED DISEASE
DETECTION AND INVESTIGATION
TEAM, WHO IDENTIFIED AN OUTBREAK
OF LEGIONELLOSIS IN A SENIOR
APARTMENT COMPLEX BEFORE
TRADITIONAL SURVEILLANCE
METHODS, ALLOWING US TO
INTERVENE EARLIER AND PROTECT
THIS HIGHLY VULNERABLE
POPULATION. WHEN THESE FUNDS
SUPPORT HALF OF OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH LAB TEAM. WITHOUT THESE
STAFF TURNAROUND TIMES FOR
CRITICAL TESTING SUCH AS
TUBERCULOSIS AND BACTERIOLOGY
WOULD TAKE SIGNIFICANTLY LONGER.
INFECTIOUS DISEASES CAN EASILY
AND QUICKLY CAUSE OUTBREAKS IN
THE COMMUNITY. IF TESTING IS NOT
PERFORMED TIMELY, PARTICULARLY
IN HIGH DENSITY POPULATION
SETTINGS LIKE DAYCARES,
DETENTION FACILITIES, SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AND SCHOOL
SETTINGS. IN 2019, I CAME BEFORE
THE SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE AND
SOUNDED THE ALARM THAT OUR LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WERE WOEFULLY
UNDERSTAFFED AND UNPREPARED TO
RESPOND TO A LONG TERM, LARGE
SCALE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY,
LET ALONE MEET THE DAY TO DAY
NEEDS OF OUR POPULATION.
UNFORTUNATELY, OUR WORST FEARS
CAME TRUE DURING AND AFTER THE
PANDEMIC. OUR DEPARTMENT HAS
RESPONDED TO MONKEYPOX, A
RESURGENCE IN MEASLES, HIGH
RATES OF CONGENITAL SYPHILIS,
AND WERE ACTIVELY PREPARING FOR
H5N1 AVIAN INFLUENZA IN LIGHT OF
LAST WEEK'S EVACUATION DUE TO A
POTENTIAL ANTHRAX THREAT. I
WOULD HIGHLIGHT THAT QUALIFIED
PUBLIC HEALTH LABS TEST FOR THIS
AGENT AND IF POSITIVE, PUBLIC
HEALTH WOULD ALSO PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN TREATING THOSE
EXPOSED. THIS IS YET ANOTHER
REASON WHY PUBLIC HEALTH NEEDS
TO BE PREPARED. PLEASE DO NOT
REPEAT THE SAME MISTAKE THAT WE
MADE IN 2019 AND DECADES BEFORE.
IF WE DEVASTATE OUR WORKFORCE
AGAIN, WE WILL STIFLE OUR
ABILITY TO HIRE AND THE PROGRESS
THAT WE'VE MADE. OUR COMMUNITIES
WILL SUFFER AND LIVES WILL BE
LOST. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NOW TURN OVER TO YOLO
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER.
YEAH, GOOD EVENING. I'M DOCTOR
AMY SISSON, PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER FOR YOLO COUNTY AND
PRESIDENT ELECT OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE OF LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS. SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE HEALTH OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS THE DEVASTATING IMPACT
THE PROPOSED CUTS TO FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING WOULD HAVE
ON CALIFORNIA'S 61 LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. WHILE THESE FUNDS
MAY BE CALLED THE FUTURE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH, THEY DRIVE PUBLIC
HEALTH NOW. SINCE 2022,
CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS HAVE HIRED OVER 1100
NEW STAFF USING FUTURE PUBLIC
HEALTH FUNDS BASED ON THE
PROMISE OF ONGOING FUNDING.
WITHOUT THESE MONIES, NEWLY
HIRED STAFF WILL LOSE THEIR JOBS
AND CRITICAL WORK WILL GO UNDONE
. IN YOLO COUNTY, THIS
REPRESENTS 10% OF OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE. FUTURE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH DOLLARS AREN'T
BEING USED TO FUND BELLS AND
WHISTLES. TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION, SENATOR ROTH, THESE
AREN'T NICE TO HAVES. THESE ARE
MUST HAVES FOR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. USE THESE MONIES TO
PROVIDE BASIC PUBLIC HEALTH
SERVICES TO OUR COMMUNITIES. NO
OTHER ENTITY CAN PROVIDE THESE
CORE PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICES. IS
NOT THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM, NOT
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS,
NOT ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS. MUCH
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING
YOLO COUNTY RECEIVES FROM THE
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS IS
EARMARKED FOR A SPECIFIC DISEASE
, LEAVING US WITH LITTLE
FLEXIBLE FUNDING TO MEET THE
NEEDS ACROSS COMMUNITIES. FUTURE
OF PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDS ARE
WONDERFUL BECAUSE THEY ALLOW
YOLO COUNTY TO APPLY THE MONIES.
AS WE SEE FIT TO ACHIEVE OUR
LOCALLY DETERMINED PRIORITIES
AND OBJECTIVES. WITH OUR
ALLOCATION OF THESE FUNDS, YOLO
COUNTY IS CREATING BETTER HEALTH
OUTCOMES FOR THOSE MOST IMPACTED
BY RACIAL, ETHNIC, AND ECONOMIC
DISPARITIES. SLOWING THE SPREAD
OF INFECTIOUS DISEASES AND
INCREASING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
RESIDENTS TO BE HEALTHY WITH
FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDS. YOLO
COUNTY HIRED PERSONNEL TO
ADMINISTER OUR WELLNESS VENDING
MACHINE PROGRAM, WHICH PROVIDES
FREE SUPPLIES LIKE COVID TESTS,
MASKS, MOSQUITO REPELLENT AND
CONDOMS TO PREVENT THE SPREAD OF
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES. WITH
FUTURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDS,
YOLO COUNTY HIRED A FARMWORKER
HEALTH COORDINATOR TO SURVEY
YOLO LARGE POPULATION OF MIGRANT
FARMWORKERS IN ORDER TO IDENTIFY
AND MEET THEIR HEALTH AND SOCIAL
SERVICE NEEDS. WITH FUTURE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDS, YOLO COUNTY
SUPPORTS OUTREACH STAFF AND DATA
SCIENTISTS TO WORK WITH
COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO IDENTIFY
HEALTH NEEDS, AND THEN
COLLABORATE WITH COMMUNITY
PARTNERS TO ADDRESS THESE NEEDS.
NOW IS THE TIME TO STAY
COMMITTED TO FUNDING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS, NOT TO CUT
FUNDING. DECADES OF UNDERFUNDING
LEFT US UNDERSTAFFED AND
UNDERPREPARED FOR A PANDEMIC.
LIMITED TERM FEDERAL FUNDING
BOLSTERED OUR ABILITY TO ADDRESS
COVID 19, BUT THAT FUNDING IS
NEARLY ALL SPENT WITHOUT FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH DOLLARS. LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WON'T HAVE
THE NECESSARY RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS RISING CASES OF MEASLES,
TUBERCULOSIS AND SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS. NOR WILL
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
ADEQUATELY RESPOND TO AVIAN
INFLUENZA A VIRUS. THE CDC
DESCRIBES AS HAVING PANDEMIC
POTENTIAL AVIAN INFLUENZA, ALSO
KNOWN AS BIRD FLU, HAS ALREADY
MADE THE LEAP FROM BIRDS TO
DAIRY COWS IN THE UNITED STATES
AND TO AT LEAST ONE DAIRY WORKER
WITHOUT FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH
FUNDING. LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WILL BE LESS ABLE TO
PROTECT WORKERS IN THE DAIRY
INDUSTRY FROM AVIAN INFLUENZA.
WE WILL BE LIMITED IN OUR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE TESTING,
SYMPTOM CHECKS AND CONTACT
TRACING. WITHOUT SUCH PREVENTIVE
MEASURES, THE VIRUS WILL HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO SPREAD AND
POTENTIALLY MUTATE TO BECOME
TRANSMISSIBLE, NOT JUST FROM COW
TO HUMAN, BUT FROM HUMAN TO
HUMAN. IT HAS BEEN SAID THAT
THOSE WHO DO NOT LEARN FROM THE
PAST ARE CONDEMNED TO REPEAT IT.
LET'S LEARN FROM THE COVID 19
PANDEMIC AND ENSURE THAT OUR
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE
ADEQUATELY FUNDED FOR THE
PRESENT AND THE FUTURE. AND I
WOULD BE REMISS IF I DID NOT
MENTION HOW CLOSELY LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
COLLABORATE TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES. A CUT TO CDF'S
FUNDING NEGATIVELY IMPACTS LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. AS A LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICER, I REGULARLY
CONSULT WITH CDF SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS ABOUT WASTEWATER,
MEASLES EXPOSURES, RABIES
PREVENTION, JUST TO NAME A FEW.
PUBLIC HEALTH IS A TEAM SPORT
AND LOCALS AND CDF ARE ON THE
SAME TEAM. LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS BENEFIT WHEN CDF HAS
THE FUNDING IT NEEDS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. YOU MENTIONED
SOME ITEMS THAT POTENTIALLY GET
SOME FEDERAL FUNDING OR OTHER
SOURCE FUNDING, BUT THIS BRINGS
FLEXIBILITY. ARE THERE CERTAIN
TOPICS YOU CAN THINK OF THAT
PERHAPS DON'T GET REALLY THE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT THAT WOULD BE
AT HIGHER RISK OF, ENDING OR CUT
BEING CUT ALTOGETHER? I MEAN, WE
HAVE SOME AREAS LIKE CHRONIC
DISEASE, FOR EXAMPLE, WHICH ARE
THE LEADING CAUSE OF, OF DEATH
IN CALIFORNIA AND IN THE UNITED
STATES THAT RECEIVE NO
CATEGORICAL FUNDING FROM THE
STATE OR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
SO THESE ARE AREAS THAT WE CAN
FOCUS ON AND ADDRESS WITH OUR
FUTURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDS.
WITHOUT THOSE FLEXIBLE FUNDS, WE
DON'T HAVE ANY, FUNDING TO
ADDRESS CHRONIC DISEASE. FOR
EXAMPLE. SENATOR ROTH WELL, I
GUESS I GET THE ANSWER TO MY
QUESTION, I GUESS IS ON PAGE 27,
IT LOOKS LIKE ABOUT $200 MILLION
FLOWS TO THE LOCAL DEPARTMENTS.
OUT OF THE 300 MILLION THAT'S
BEEN BEING CUT, THAT IS CORRECT.
YOU KNOW, I GUESS YOU DON'T HAVE
TO HELP US MAKE YOU DON'T HAVE
TO MAKE OUR JOB EASIER. BUT IT
CERTAINLY DOESN'T MAKE OUR JOB
EASIER WHEN EVERYBODY COMES IN
AND SAYS, YOU KNOW, WE NEED THE
WHOLE BUCKET BECAUSE EVERYBODY
SAYS THEY WANT THE WHOLE BUCKET.
AND SO THE DANGER IN DOING THAT,
OF COURSE, IS THAT IF IN FACT,
WE HAVE TO MAKE CUTS, WE MAY
MAKE CUTS IN THE WRONG AREA. SO
WHEN YOU ALL LEAVE, YOU'LL HAVE
TO THINK THROUGH THAT AND SEE IF
THAT'S THE RIGHT WAY TO LEAVE
US. IF I MAY RESPOND TO THAT, I
WOULD JUST, YOU KNOW, POINT OUT
THAT MANY OF THE OTHER PROPOSED
CUTS ARE NOT TO ONGOING FUNDING.
THEY'RE TO ONE TIME FUNDING,
WHEREAS THE FUTURE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH, I WOULD SAY THAT'S
TOTALLY INCORRECT. AND MY
SUBCOMMITTEE ALMOST ALL OF THEM
IN MY SUBCOMMITTEE, ARE ONGOING
CUTS. THAT'S THE PROBLEM. THIS
IS ANOTHER ONE THAT IS ONGOING.
CALWORKS FOSTER CARE KIDS. SO
IT'S THE PROBLEM THAT I'M
DEALING WITH HERE. YEAH, WE DO
LOVE PUBLIC HEALTH, DON'T GET ME
WRONG. IT'S ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL.
I HOPE THAT YOU TOOK THAT AWAY
FROM MY QUESTIONS. WE CAN'T
ELIMINATE OUR CAPABILITY. THAT
IS IN OUR LOCAL JURISDICTION TO
RESPOND TO PUBLIC HEALTH CRISES
IMMEDIATELY AND EFFECTIVELY. SO
YOU CAN SAY THAT FOR OTHER
SUBCOMMITTEES OUTSIDE OF THIS
ONE, THEY'RE NOT FAIR TO THE
PRIORITIES FOR THE DEPARTMENT
AND TO THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND,
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO LEAVE
WITH THE SENSE THAT WE AREN'T
BOOTS ON THE GROUND. MANY OF THE
THINGS THAT WE DO ARE BOOTS ON
THE GROUND. WE HAVE A REGIONAL
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICE THAT WORKS
VERY CLOSELY, PROVIDING EPI
SUPPORT TO OUR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS, COMMUNICATIONS
SUPPORT TO THEM. WE ALSO HAVE
OUR DATA AND SURVEILLANCE TEAMS
THAT PROVIDE ONGOING ANALYSIS OF
THE DATA FOR ALL OF THESE
EVENTS. DAY TO DAY AND DURING
EMERGENCIES. WE HAVE OUR, YOU
KNOW, OUR RECOVERY TEAM AND SOME
OF THE OUR CENTER FOR
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE THAT
ARE FUNDED HERE. SO THE OFFICE
OF POLICY AND PLANNING, YOU
KNOW, ISN'T A CRITICAL THING TO
US. IT IS ONLY ONE SMALL PART OF
WHAT WE HAVE FUNDED HERE. AND IT
DOES INCLUDE OUR LAB. YOU KNOW,
LABORATORIANS, IT INCLUDES
ACROSS THE WHOLE GAMUT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH, TRYING TO BACKFILL THOSE
PLACES WHERE WE NHIÀU LIKE
COMMUNICATIONS, WHERE OUR PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC, OUR
COMMUNICATIONS TEAM WAS REALLY
ABOUT RESPONDING TO THE MEDIA,
AND WE FOUND THAT THAT WAS
WHOLLY INADEQUATE IN TERMS OF
THE NEW ROLE OF SOCIAL MEDIA AND
ALL OF THE THINGS WE NEED TO
COMBAT, AS WE MOVE FORWARD. SO I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE AND IF
YOU ASK US WHAT OUR PRIORITY
WOULD BE, IT WOULD BE THE
POSITIONS WE'VE ALREADY FILLED.
SO WE FILLED 317 OUT OF THE 404.
AND SO IF WE HAD TO GIVE
SOMETHING UP, I THINK IT WOULD
BE TO MAINTAIN THE POSITIONS
WE'VE HAD AND THE ADMIN AREA IN
THE DEPARTMENT'S AREA, IN THE
STATE OPERATIONS SIDE. SO WE'VE
WE'VE HIRED WE PROPOSED 404
POSITIONS. WE'VE HIRED 317 OR
ROUGHLY 320, I WOULD SAY,
BECAUSE THOSE WERE ALSO THOSE
POSITIONS WOULD BE CUT. THOSE
ARE 404 POSITIONS WOULD BE CUT
UNDER, WOULD BE ELIMINATED. 317
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
ONBOARDED. OKAY MADAM CHAIR, GO
AHEAD. WELL, WE DON'T WANT TO
DOUBLE IMPACT YOU OR DIDN'T THE
ADMINISTRATION REQUIRE A CERTAIN
LEVEL OF CUT ACROSS THE BOARD?
I'LL LET FINANCE RESPOND, BUT
THERE'S A PROPOSED 8% CUT. AND
THAT'S ON TOP OF THE ALL THESE
THAT WOULD CUT ON. YES NICK
MILLS, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
CONFIRM THAT THERE'S A 8,
ONGOING REDUCTION, BUT WE'RE
STILL WORKING OUT THE DETAILS
AND WORKING WITH DEPARTMENTS ON
WHAT THAT WILL LOOK LIKE, AND I
JUST ALSO WANTED TO FLAG THAT
DIRECTOR FINLEY'S PROPOSAL IS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE MAY REVISION
BUDGET, BUT WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MAY HAVE,
FEEDBACK AND DIFFERENT
PRIORITIES. MAY REVISION IS JUST
A PROPOSAL, RIGHT? THE OTHER
PROGRAMS, MA'AM, I DIDN'T CATCH
YOUR NAME. ALL THE PROGRAMS THAT
YOU MENTIONED, WOULD THEY BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE WITH THESE
CUTS? SO THE EXAMPLES YOU GAVE
AS TO, HEY, WE'RE ALSO BOOTS ON
THE GROUND, WOULD THOSE THOSE
ARE PART OF THE WHAT'S PROPOSED
TO BE ELIMINATED. OKAY OKAY.
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE
YOU UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT. OH,
NO. WE I MEAN, I'M I'M A LITTLE
CONFUSED. THIS IS A VERY
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO WHAT I'M
USED TO HERE. YOU KNOW, MOST OF
THE TIME WE'RE NOT ON THE SAME
PAGE. I AGREE, THIS IS A HUGE
IMPACT. HUGE IMPACT, ON PUBLIC
HEALTH, I SAID LAST WEEK, SO
THIS IS HUGE IN MY DISTRICT AND
THE SPIKES MEN ARE DYING AT THE
AGE OF 26 FOR THIS. I MEAN, YOU
TALKED ABOUT WASTEWATER AND
MOSQUITOES IN MY DISTRICT.
THAT'S A HUGE AREA AND ALWAYS
ALMOST IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
THAT ALREADY HAVE A BUNCH OF
LAYERED ON, HEALTH ISSUES.
RIGHT? DIABETES. YOU CAN'T GET
OVER DIABETES IF ALL THESE OTHER
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES, YOU KNOW,
ARE HAPPENING, YOU GAVE US THE
STATE OF WHAT IS IT, THE STATE
OF PUBLIC HEALTH, THE STATE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH, AND ALL THE
THINGS WE TALKED ABOUT. SENATOR
EGGMAN MENTIONED STIS. I HAVE A
BILL RELATED TO THIS BECAUSE I
KNOW YOUNG PEOPLE ARE INCREASING
IN OUR STI CASES, ALMOST AMOUNT
TO 50% IN CALIFORNIA, AND WE
WERE NOT PREVENTATIVE YOU SOME
ONE OF YOU SHARED A STORY A WHEN
YOUR PROGRAMS GIVES AWAY CONDOMS
AND SO FORTH, WE'RE NOWHERE NEAR
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IN PREVENTING
PREVENTING STIS. HPV IS ON THE
RISE, SO I'M THERE WITH YOU.
MAYBE WE SHOULD ALL TELL
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HOW WE,
HOW WE FEEL ABOUT THIS. YOU KNOW
WHAT'S COMING UP NOW. NO, I
THINK THIS WOULD REALLY, REALLY,
I MEAN, WE SET A FOUNDATION, AND
WE'RE JUST GOING TO WIPE IT AWAY
AND THEN, YOU KNOW, JUST LIKE
YOU WERE HERE IN 2019 ASKING FOR
THIS, 2020 HAPPENED. AND WE KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED AFTER THAT. SO WE
WANT TO BE PREPARED 100. NO ONE
THOUGHT THE PANDEMIC WAS GOING
TO HAPPEN. AND IT HAPPENED.
COVID HAPPENED, CAME OUT OF LEFT
FIELD. SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR STATE IS PREPARED FOR
WHATEVER ELSE COMES NEXT. LEO,
ANY CLOSING REMARKS HERE FOR
THIS TOPIC? YES. WILL OWENS WITH
THE LEO. SO I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
HERE THAT, YOU KNOW, I THINK
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. YOU KNOW, IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY, SENATOR
ROTH MENTIONED HAVE TO BE A FULL
ELIMINATION OF THE PROGRAM OR A
COMPLETELY FUNDING THE PROGRAM,
THE LEGISLATURE DOES HAVE
OPTIONS FOR EXAMPLE, GIVEN, AS
YOU'VE HEARD TODAY HERE, KIND OF
THE BROAD IMPACTS THAT THE
ELIMINATION OF THIS FUNDING
WOULD HAVE ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEM, THIS COULD BE AN
INSTANCE WHERE THE LEGISLATURE
WORKS TO FIND OTHER ONE TIME OR
TEMPORARY SOLUTIONS ELSEWHERE,
WHERE IN THE BUDGET TO MAYBE
GIVE SOME MORE TIME TO FULLY
WORK THROUGH WHAT SOME OF THESE
IMPACTS MIGHT BE TO CONTINUE
FUNDING THIS FOR, SHORT TERM,
YOU KNOW, GIVEN THE ISSUES AND
ONGOING DEFICITS IN THE BUDGET,
UNDERSTANDING THAT ONGOING
REDUCTIONS ACROSS THE BUDGET ARE
NECESSARY, THIS COULD BE AN
INSTANCE WHERE MAYBE A TEMPORARY
, SOLUTION TO UNTIL WE FULLY,
THE LEGISLATURE CAN FULLY KIND
OF WRAP, GET ITS ARMS AROUND THE
IMPACTS OF THIS CUTS COULD BE
WARRANTED. ADDITIONALLY, LIKE I
SAID, THIS DOESN'T NECESSARILY
HAVE TO BE A COMPLETE
ELIMINATION OR A FULLY FUNDING
AS IS, THE LEGISLATURE COULD
WORK TO KIND OF MAINTAIN,
FUNDING FOR CERTAIN PRIORITIES,
SUCH AS REDUCING HEALTH
DISPARITIES WITHIN THIS FUNDING
OR TO KIND OF FOCUS ON ALREADY
HIRED PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE,
AS HAS BEEN DISCUSSED, FROM THE
100 MILLION THAT'S GOING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH, A
LOT OF THAT IS FOR PERSONNEL.
AROUND 80, AS THE DEPARTMENT HAS
SAID, HAS ALREADY BEEN HIRED.
AND THEN AT THE LOCAL LEVEL, 200
MILLION GOING TO LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS, THE SAME THING.
AROUND 80% OF THE PROPOSED HIRES
HAVE BEEN MADE FROM THAT 200
MILLION. SO PRIORITIZING ALREADY
HIRED PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE
FORCE, COULD BE A MIDDLE GROUND
BETWEEN FULL ELIMINATION AND
CONTINUED FUNDING AT CURRENT
LEVELS. HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. WILL THANK
YOU. ANY ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
ON THIS? THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE CONVERSATION.
THE CROSSOVER. WHAT DO YOU SEE
US WHO ISN'T HERE YET? WE'RE
GOING TO DO ISSUE TWO ADAP. SO.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO FOCUS ON THE
FIRST QUESTION. WE WENT OVER THE
OVERVIEW LAST WEEK. JUST ANY
UPDATE NUMBER TWO. AND THEN AN
UPDATE TO THE CONVERSATION WE
HAD LAST WEEK. PLEASE
ABSOLUTELY. GOOD EVENING
EVERYONE. ADRIAN BARRAZA,
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH
THE CENTER FOR INFECTIOUS
DISEASES, SO THE SECOND QUESTION
THAT YOU POSED WAS HOW WILL THE
ADMINISTRATION MONITOR
EXPENDITURES AND CASH FLOW IN
AID APP TO ENSURE THE PROGRAM
DOES NOT SUFFER FROM FUNDING
SHORTFALLS AS A RESULT OF THESE
LOANS, SO WE ACTUALLY OBTAIN A
WEEKLY, FUND BALANCE STATEMENT
FROM OUR ACCOUNTING OFFICE TO
GIVE US REALLY A NEAR REAL TIME
LOOK INTO WHAT THE CURRENT
REBATE FUND BALANCE IS AT ANY
GIVEN TIME, WE'LL NEED TO WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO, ASSESS WHETHER
THE LOAN CAN BE BROKEN UP INTO
SMALLER PIECES AND HOW WE
POTENTIALLY SEQUENCE THAT,
DERIVED ESSENTIALLY BY WHAT THAT
CASH BALANCE SHEET IS SHOWING
US, ONE OTHER THING TO NOTE IS,
IN THE NOVEMBER ESTIMATE, WE HAD
PROJECTED A, A, A FUND BALANCE
AT THE END OF THE FISCAL YEAR OF
APPROXIMATELY 176 MILLION. THE
UPDATED PROJECTIONS AND THE MAY
REVISE IS CLOSER TO 106 MILLION.
SO ABOUT $70 MILLION DIFFERENCE
THERE, SO WE'LL JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO 70 MILLION LESS, 70 MILLION
LESS PROJECTED, PROJECTED AT THE
END OF THE FISCAL YEAR. SO WE'LL
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. TO
ESTABLISH ANY NECESSARY TRIGGERS
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE
FUNDING FOR CONTINUITY OF
SERVICES. WILL WE BE ABLE TO
STILL HAVE THAT FUNDING FOR THE
FURTHER INVESTMENT THAT'S YEAH,
AND I'M ACTUALLY TRACKING 126
MILLION ON MY END. BUT WE CAN WE
CAN WORK THROUGH THAT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT, MAKE SURE WE WERE
LANDING ON THE SAME NUMBER, AND
THAT ACCOUNTS FOR A PRIOR YEAR
ADJUSTMENT THAT WASN'T RECORDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, AS
WELL AS THE 23 MILLION, EARLY
ACTION PACKAGE. SO THAT IS
ALREADY SET ASIDE, AND THEN 26
OUTS AFTER WE DO THE LOAN AND
THE 23 MILLION FOR FUTURE
INVESTMENTS. CORRECT. OKAY.
YEAH, AND THEN THERE'S A FEW
ADJUSTMENTS IN THERE FOR, SMALL
CHANGES IN REVENUES FROM THE,
THE ADAP ESTIMATE. SO THAT'S
WHAT THE DIFFERENCE COMES FROM.
OKAY. CAN WE DO NUMBER THREE.
SURE, SO QUESTION THREE PLEASE
DESCRIBE THE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT SET ASIDE DURING
EARLY ACTION. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ASSESSMENT OF
FUNDING SOURCES FOR THESE
INVESTMENT, SO LET ME FIRST
START WITH A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE FEDERAL AND STATE SPENDING
RESTRICTIONS. SO FEDERAL LAW
ESSENTIALLY PROVIDES THAT
REBATES RECEIVED ON DRUG
PURCHASE FROM FEDERAL FUNDS MUST
BE USED FOR RYAN WHITE SERVICES,
WHICH INCLUDE ACTIVITIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS LIVING WITH HIV, AND
THAT IS THAT THEY HAVE A
PRIORITY FOR SERVICES THAT ARE
ADAP ACTIVITIES. STATE LAW
PROVIDES THAT MONIES INTO ADAP
REBATE FUND MUST BE USED
EXCLUSIVELY TO COVER COSTS
RELATED TO THE PURCHASE OF DRUGS
AND SERVICES PROVIDED THROUGH
ADAP OR PREP ASSISTANCE PROGRAM,
AND PREP AND PEP NAVIGATION AND
RETENTION SERVICES. SO CAN YOU
REPEAT THAT ONE AGAIN, SO OUR
PREP ASSISTANCE PROGRAM, THE
PREP, THE WHOLE STATE THING,
COSTS RELATED TO PRODUCTS.
RELATED TO THE PURCHASE OF DRUGS
AND SERVICES PROVIDED THROUGH
ADAP PREP APP AND PREP AND PEP
RETENTION AND NAVIGATION. AND
I'M HAPPY TO WALK THROUGH EACH
OF THE PROPOSED INITIATIVES, AND
THEN KIND OF GIVE YOU OUR
GENERAL ASSESSMENT OF EACH
PERFECT, SO THE $5 MILLION FOR
THE, THAT WOULD GO TOWARDS SB
954 ESSENTIALLY WOULD REQUIRE AN
AMENDMENT TO HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE FOR US TO IMPLEMENT THE ED
UP AND PREP APP ELIGIBILITY
INCREASE, BECAUSE THE STATE LAW
SAYS ONLY COSTS RELATED TO DRUGS
AND SERVICES, CORRECT. SPECIFIC
TO ADAP ADMINISTRATION, PREP,
APP ADMINISTRATION, OR PREP AND
PREP, NAVIGATION AND RETENTION
ADAP ADMINISTRATION. WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN? SO ADMINISTRATION OF
THE AIDS DRUG ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM, PROCUREMENT OF
MEDICATION, ADMINISTRATING THE
WHOLE PROGRAM. CORRECT. THAT
GOES TO THAT CAN GO TO LIKE CBOS
AND SO FORTH. CORRECT? OKAY.
CORRECT OKAY, THE SECOND
INITIATIVE IS, INCREASE OF THE
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA FROM 500%
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL TO
600% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL. SO THAT WOULD NOT BE
PERMITTED CURRENTLY UNDER HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE, WE WOULD NEED
TO OR TO AMEND HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE TO INCREASE ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA TO 600% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL. THE THIRD
PROPOSAL IS HARM REDUCTION
CLEARINGHOUSE INCREASE, THIS
WOULD NOT BE AN ELIGIBLE USE OF
THE ADAP REBATE FUND UNDER
CURRENT LAW, IMPLEMENTING THIS
CHANGE WOULD REQUIRE MANY HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE TO MODIFY THE
LANGUAGE. ADDITIONALLY, DUE TO
RESTRICTIONS IN FEDERAL LAW,
THIS PROPOSAL COULD ONLY BE
FUNDED WITH THE SUBSET OF REBATE
FUNDS WITHIN THE REBATE FUNDS.
SPECIFICALLY, REBATE THAT'S NOT
GENERATED OFF OF FEDERAL
DOLLARS, AND LASTLY, RELATED TO
THIS ITEM, THE HARM REDUCTION
CLEARINGHOUSE IS HISTORICALLY
BEEN FUNDED BY STATE GENERAL
FUND AND THE ADAP REBATE FUND
ITSELF SHOULD NOT BE USED TO
SUPPLANT OTHER RESOURCES. AND
THAT'S, BOTH THE DESIGNATION AND
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW, WHICH
REQUIRE ADAP TO BE THE PAYER OF
LAST RESORT. HOW DO WE THEN GET
AROUND THAT WITH THE LOAN? SO IN
TERMS OF STRUCTURING THIS AS A
COMPONENT OF THE LOAN, YES. SO
IF IT'S A PAIR OF LAST RESORT,
RIGHT. OR IF IT'S TO USE FEDERAL
LAW TO BE WITHIN THE FEDERAL AND
STATE LAW, HOW DO WE GET AROUND
THAT FOR GENERAL FUND LOANS. SO
SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
ACTIVELY BEEN EXPLORING WITH OUR
LEGAL OFFICE. I'M NOT SURE IF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WANTS
TO, BUT WE'VE DONE IT ALREADY.
THIS WILL BE THE SECOND OR THIRD
TIME. SO I, I DON'T THINK IN THE
PAST WHAT HOW MANY YEARS IT
SEEMS LIKE IT'S LEGAL. I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
REASONS YOU'RE GIVING ME FOR
THESE THINGS, IT SEEMS LIKE THE
LOAN COULD FALL INTO THE SAME
REASON WHY WE CAN'T DO THAT
AMOUNT OF FINANCE, YOU KNOW, SO
THE LOAN IS COMING FROM THE
RESERVE BALANCE, SO IT'S NOT
ACTUALLY SPENDING MONEY OUT OF
THAT ADAP FUND. IT'S JUST
BORROWING. AND THEN WE WILL BE
RETURNING THE MONEY WHEN, THE
GENERAL FUND SITUATION IS EITHER
BETTER OR THE PROGRAM HAS NEEDS
FOR THE FUNDS. SO CAN'T WE DO
THE SAME THING? CAN WE BORROW
FOR THE THINGS THAT THAT YOU
SAID AREN'T ELIGIBLE? IF WE
WOULDN'T THAT BE THE SAME THING?
IT'S NOT PART OF THE PROPOSAL
RIGHT NOW, BUT I GET THAT. BUT
IT WOULDN'T BE VIOLATING STATE
OR FEDERAL RESTRICTIONS. WE
WOULD NEED TO DEFINITELY TAKE
THAT BACK TO OUR LEGAL TEAM TO
ASSESS. OKAY, I THINK IT'S
APPLES TO APPLES. I WOULD REALLY
LIKE TO KNOW IF IT'S NOT.
ABSOLUTELY, BECAUSE WE'RE TAKING
A LOAN THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE STATE AND FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS FUND TO
OFFSET THE GENERAL FUND. THAT
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH WHAT IT'S
INTENDED FOR. BUT THEN THE
FUTURE, THE FURTHER INVESTMENTS
SOME OF YOU ARE, SOME OF THEM
ARE WERE BEING TOLD THEY DON'T
QUALIFY BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
FOLLOWING WHAT THE FUND IS
INTENDED FOR. BUT THE LOAN IS
NOT FOLLOWING WHAT THE FUND IS
INTENDED FOR. YEAH, WE CAN
CERTAINLY TAKE THAT BACK. OKAY
OKAY. I WOULD REALLY LIKE A
RESPONSE IN THERE NEXT TIME THAT
WE CONNECT, WHICH IS I THINK
MONDAY OR SOONER WOULD BE
BETTER, BUT IF NOT, WE'LL COME
BACK ON MONDAY. OKAY. WAS THERE
ANOTHER ITEM ON THAT LIST THAT
DOESN'T QUALIFY THREE MORE
ITEMS, WELL, THE HEALTH
INSURANCE PREMIUM PAYMENT CAP
INCREASE, THAT IS AN ALLOWABLE
USE. THAT ONE. THAT ONE'S FINE,
THE TGI WELLNESS AND EQUITY FUND
, FUNCTIONALLY, THIS IS AN
ACTIVITY THAT FALLS WITHIN OUR
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY, AND IT
WOULD NOT BE AN APPROPRIATE USE
OF THE ADAP REBATE FUND SINCE
THE ACTIVITIES ARE NOT RELATED
TO HIV PREVENTION, CARE OR
TREATMENT, AND THEN THE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT IS AN ALLOWABLE USE.
SO THERE WAS $400,000 ONE TIME
THAT WAS REQUESTED TO DO A GAP
ASSESSMENT OF CLIENT NAVIGATION
AND RETENTION SERVICES. OKAY.
ARE THOSE ALL THE ITEMS? THOSE
ARE ALL THE ITEMS. ANY
QUESTIONS? OKAY. IF WE CAN GET
SOME CLARIFICATION ON THAT
THEY'RE HELPFUL OKAY. LÀ ONLY
COMMENT ON THIS. OKAY. WELL,
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MOVING ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER THREE, CYBER.
THE REASON WHY I'M BRINGING BACK
THIS TOPIC TO BE HONEST,
TRANSPARENCY HERE IS THE PUBLIC
COMMENT WE RECEIVED OFF OF THIS
WAS A LITTLE OVERWHELMING, AND
I'D LIKE TO DIVE INTO MORE OF
THE VALUE OF THESE PROGRAMS, AND
HOW SUCCESSFUL THE
IMPLEMENTATION, HOW MANY, HOW
IT'S BEEN. YOU UTILIZED. GO
AHEAD. OH, SORRY. AM I GONE?
MARIA OCHOA WITH CDF, AND I'LL
COVER THE FIRST ITEM. SO WHICH
GIVES A LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL.
SO AS A COMPONENT OF THE URGENT
NEEDS, URGENT NEEDS AND EMERGENT
ISSUES IN THE CI, PACKAGE, THE
2022 BUDGET ACT INCLUDED 25
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN 22, 23
AND 20,000,000 IN 2324 AND
5,000,000 IN 2425 FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO IMPLEMENT A YOUTH
SUICIDE REPORTING AND CRISIS
RESPONSE RESPONSE PILOT PROGRAM.
OF THE 50 MILLION, 15 MILLION
WAS ALLOCATED TO CDF'S CENTER
FOR INFECTIOUS DISEASES TO
MODIFY STATE SYSTEMS TO MAKE
SUICIDE A REPORTABLE EVENT. CID
STAFF THOROUGHLY EXPLORED THE
FEASIBILITY OF INCLUDING SUICIDE
AS A REPORTABLE CONDITION, AND
EXPLORED USING THE CALIFORNIA
REPORTABLE DISEASE INFORMATION
EXCHANGE FOR DATA REPORTING AND
FOR USING CALCONNECT IN THE
CRISIS RESPONSE PROCESS. CDF
DETERMINED THAT SUICIDE AND
SUICIDE ATTEMPTS DO NOT MEET
DEFINITIONS OF REPORTABLE
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE OR
CONDITION BECAUSE SUICIDE AND
SUICIDE ATTEMPTS FALL UNDER
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH RATHER THAN
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE, THIS
EFFORT HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD. THEREFORE, THERE'S 15
MILLION IN UNSPENT FUNDS. SO OF
IMPORTANCE OF THE 50 MILLION, 35
MILLION WAS ALLOCATED TO CDF'S
OFFICE OF SUICIDE PREVENTION TO
DEVELOP LOCAL REPORTING AND
RESPONSE SYSTEMS. IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIS LOCAL PILOT IS UNDERWAY
IN TEN COUNTIES ALAMEDA, EL
DORADO, HUMBOLDT, KERN, LOS
ANGELES, RIVERSIDE, SACRAMENTO,
SAN DIEGO, SAN JOAQUIN AND
SOLANO COUNTIES. THE FUNDING WAS
NOT REDUCED OR ELIMINATED FROM
THE MAY REVISION. LEARNINGS FROM
THIS LOCAL PILOT PROGRAM WILL BE
USED BY THE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT FOR LOCAL
SYSTEMS. CHANGES. CHANGE EFFORTS
IN THE FUTURE. COUNTIES ARE
DEVELOPING A TESTING MODELS FOR
MAKING YOUTH SUICIDE AND
ATTEMPTED SUICIDE REPORTABLE
EVENTS THAT INITIATE RAPID AND
COMPREHENSIVE RESPONSES WITHIN
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY SETTINGS.
THE GOAL OF THE PILOT PROGRAM IS
TO STRENGTHEN REPORTING AND
CRISIS RESPONSE SYSTEMS SO THAT
HEALING CAN BEGIN, AND FURTHER
SUICIDES AND ATTEMPTS CAN BE
PREVENTED. SO TEN COUNTIES WERE
GOING TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PILOT. THEY GOT FUNDING, BUT
THEN WE WEREN'T ABLE TO COLLECT
THIS DATA. AND WHAT ARE THEY
USING THE FUNDING NOW I
MISUNDERSTOOD. YEAH. SO THERE
WAS 15 MILLION AND UNSPENT FUNDS
THAT WAS GOING TO GO TO MODIFY
STATE SYSTEMS. SO THAT WAS
SEPARATE, SEPARATE, THAT WAS
GOING TO OUR CENTER FOR
INFECTIOUS DISEASE, OUR OFFICE
OF SUICIDE PREVENTION HAS
RECEIVED 35 MILLION. AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE WORKING WITH THE LOCALS
TO COLLECT DATA ON SUICIDE
REPORTING. SO THEY'RE GOING TO
BE DOING THAT. YES. THIS IS
SEPARATE MONIES. THE 15 MILLION
WAS UNSPENT FOR SOMETHING ELSE.
SO THIS IS STILL GOING TO GET
REPORTED. YES. WE'RE GOING TO
GET SOME DATA. YES OKAY. I DON'T
THINK I GOT THAT LAST. YES. I
WAS NOT CLEAR LAST TIME. SORRY.
THAT'S WHY I WANTED TO BRING
THAT UP THIS TIME. SO WE'RE
STILL GOING TO BE ABLE TO
COLLECT THIS INFORMATION FROM A
DIFFERENT OFFICE. WE'RE JUST NOT
GOING TO DO IT UNDER THIS
BECAUSE THAT IT FALLS BETTER ON
THAT OFFICE. BECAUSE IT'S
BECAUSE BECAUSE WE'RE COLLECTING
IT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. THE MONEY
THAT OF THE 15 MILLION THAT WAS
UNSPENT WAS GOING TO BE, TO
MODIFY A STATE SYSTEM TO COLLECT
THE DATA. BUT WE'RE STILL
COLLECTING IT AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. WHEN ARE WHEN WERE THE
PILOT END FOR US TO SEE THIS
DATA, THAT I WILL HAVE TO GET
BACK TO YOU. OKAY, BUT WE'RE
GETTING BETTER NEWS. OKAY. THIS
TIME. OKAY COLLEAGUES, ANY
QUESTION ON THE FIRST PART? NO.
OKAY. YOU CAN GO INTO THE SECOND
POINT. OKAY CAN YOU HEAR ME?
OKAY. THE CYBER PUBLIC EDUCATION
CHANGE CAMPAIGN, THE PROPOSED
REDUCTION IS 73.8 MILLION FROM
100 MILLION CAMPAIGN TO ADDRESS
STIGMA AND IMPROVE MENTAL HEALTH
LITERACY. WAIT. I'M SORRY. IS
THAT NUMBER CORRECT? WAIT. HOW
MUCH IS A REDUCTION? THE
PROPOSED REDUCTION OF 73.8
MILLION FROM THE 100 MILLION
CAMPAIGN TO ADDRESS STIGMA AND
IMPROVE MENTAL HEALTH LITERACY.
THIS IS THE OHE PORTION. COULD
YOU BREAK DOWN THOSE NUMBERS?
BECAUSE I MIGHT ONLY HAVE. YEAH.
CAN YOU JUST BREAK IT OUT PER
WHAT YEAR WE'RE PULLING FOR THE
OUT OF THE 73 YOU MENTIONED THAT
WAS A THE TOTAL, CAMPAIGN OR I
SHOULD SAY THE TOTAL THAT WAS A
FIVE YEAR FROM, 2021 TO 2026.
OKAY. AND WHAT YEARS ARE YOU
PULLING THAT FROM? SO THE
REDUCTION WAS FROM YEAR BUDGET.
YEAR 2425. AND THE 2526, NICK
MILLS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, SO
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
REVERT 28.8 MILLION FROM FISCAL
YEAR 2324, 40 MILLION FROM
FISCAL YEAR 2425 AND 5 MILLION
FROM 2526, AND MAINTAINS 26.2
MILLION. THANK YOU. I THINK I
WAS MISSING THE, THE 28.8.
THAT'S CURRENT SAVINGS IN THIS
YEAR. YES. CORRECT. LACK OF
UTILIZATION, WE WORKED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO IDENTIFY THESE,
UNSPENT FUNDS, SO. THAT'S
CORRECT. OKAY AND WE'RE LEAVING
2.8 MILLION ANNUALLY FOR THE FOR
THE REMAINING THREE YEARS. WE
ARE REMAINING. WE ARE LEAVING,
$26.2 MILLION. THAT'S, AVAILABLE
UNTIL THE END OF THIS FISCAL
YEAR FOR ENCUMBRANCE OR
EXPENDITURE. Ó. SO THIS IT
WON'T BE ONGOING. IT'S JUST TO
CLOSE OUT THE PROGRAM. 26.2.
THAT'S CORRECT. OKAY, SENATOR,
BUT WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO GET
OUT AS MUCH AS WE CAN BEFORE. IS
THAT WHAT WE'RE SAYING? YES.
BEFORE THE END OF THE JUNE, THE
CLOSE OF THE FISCAL, BECAUSE AS
I UNDERSTAND, THIS MONEY HAS
BEEN SLOW TO MOVE. IS THAT
CORRECT? AFFIRMATIVE,
AFFIRMATIVE. OKAY. SO IT'S BEEN
SLOW TO MOVE. SO AND I AS
SPEAKER, AS THE CHAIR OF THE
LGBTQ CAUCUS, WE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT THIS, RIGHT? THIS, THIS IS
THE ONE REDUCING DISPARITIES. NO
WE'RE NOT THERE. OKAY. YES. WE
ARE. THAT IT HAS BEEN SLOW TO
GET OUT. AND SO THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS IT'S BEEN
UNDERUTILIZED. YES. WE ARE WE
HAVE A VENDOR AND WE SHOULD
SPEND UP THE 26.2 BEFORE THE END
OF THE FISCAL YEAR. OKAY SO
WE'RE GOING TO PRIORITIZE
GETTING IT OUT RIGHT. BUT THAT
WOULD BE THAT WOULD COME AT WITH
THE LOCAL LEVEL CAMPAIGNS. THERE
WOULD BE I GUESS $10 MILLION
THAT WERE PROMISED TO LOCAL
LEVEL CBOS THAT WILL NOT BE
COVERED BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
BUDGETED. OKAY, OKAY, SO 26.2
MILLION TO BE SPENT IN THE NEXT
MONTH AND A HALF? YES DOING WHAT
? WORKING WELL, THE LOCAL LEVEL
CAMPAIGNS, THEY'VE ALREADY
RECEIVED OR WILL RECEIVE TWO
PAYMENTS. SO FOR WORK THEY
ALREADY DID FOR THESE ARE GRANTS
LOCAL LEVEL GRANTS. SO WORK THEY
ALREADY DID WORK THAT THEY WILL
DO OR THEY WILL DO IN THE MONTH
AND A HALF. OR THEY CAN USE THAT
FUND PASS OUR FISCAL YEAR. YES.
OKAY WE JUST HAVE TO GET THAT
OUT BEFORE OUR FISCAL YEAR. BUT
THESE CBOS CAN UTILIZE THAT FUND
TO CONTINUE THE CAMPAIGN AS BEST
THEY CAN, BUT THEY WILL BE
LOSING OUT THERE. WOULD BE $10
MILLION THAT WE PUBLICLY
ANNOUNCED AT THE BEGINNING OF, I
THINK, MARCH, THEY WILL NOT
RECEIVE THE ENTIRE FUNDING
AMOUNT. THEY WON'T RECEIVE THE
FULL 26.2. THEY WON'T RECEIVE
THE LOCAL LEVELS WERE PROMISED
25,000,020 TO 25 MILLION, I
BELIEVE 15. THIS YEAR. OKAY. AND
AN ADDITIONAL 10 MILLION WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE AWARDED AFTER
JULY 1ST. OKAY AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE CUTTING OUT. YES WE'RE
CUTTING OUT THAT 10 MILLION THAT
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO GO OUT ON JULY
1ST. AFFIRMATIVE OKAY. THE 25 IS
GOING, BUT THE 26.2 IS STILL THE
26.2 IS WHAT WE ARE BUDGETED FOR
THIS YEAR. OKAY. SO WE'RE JUST
CUTTING THE 10 MILLION. YES. THE
AWARDS THAT WOULD HAPPEN JULY
1ST OKAY. NICK MILLS, DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THERE ARE, SEVERAL
COMPONENTS OF THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND CHANGE CAMPAIGN,
THE DIRECTOR IS RESPONDING AS
TALKING ABOUT THE LOCAL LEVEL
CAMPAIGNS THAT ARE GOING TO 28
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
BUT THERE'S ALSO A STATEWIDE
CAMPAIGN AND SOME OF THAT 26.2
MILLION IS GOING TO SUPPORT THAT
AS WELL. OKAY. SO THIS FUNDING
GOES INTO A STATEWIDE CAMPAIGN
AND A LOCAL WIDE CAMPAIGN. THERE
ARE SEVERAL COMPONENTS OF THIS,
PROGRAM. SO THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
DIFFERENT NUMBERS BECAUSE I'M
GETTING, I GUESS, A LITTLE LOST
ON THE NUMBERS. SURE SO 25
MILLION WAS ANNOUNCED FOR THE 28
CBOS. A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO, 15
MILLION WAS SUPPOSED TO GO OUT
IN 23, 24 AND STILL IS, BUT THEN
10 MILLION WAS SUPPOSED TO GO
OUT IN 2425, AND THAT WILL NOT
BE RECEIVED. GOT IT. SO WE
ANNOUNCED THIS A COUPLE OF
MONTHS AGO THAT WE'RE DOING IT
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE IN THE MIDST
OF THIS BUDGET DISCUSSION. AND
NOW WE'RE SAYING NEVER MIND AT
THE TIME OF REVISION, THIS WAS
THE BEST INFORMATION WE HAD.
OKAY, OKAY. SO BOTTOM LINE, SOME
OF CBO OR CBOS WILL GET SOME
FUNDING TO CONTINUE AS BEST AS
THEY CAN. THIS CAMPAIGN AND THE
STATEWIDE CAMPAIGN, THE MEDIA
WILL BE ELIMINATED. THE
STATEWIDE CAMPAIGN WOULD BE
ELIMINATED. YES. DID IT EVER GET
OFF THE GROUND? WE HAVE A VENDOR
WHO'S WORKING. YES. AND WE'RE
WE'RE CUTTING THAT VENDOR
COMPLETELY. THERE WILL BE NO
STATEWIDE CAMPAIGN. IS IT
BECAUSE IT'S EXPIRING OR WE HAVE
TO SEVER THAT CONTRACT EARLIER?
WE ARE CUTTING THE BECAUSE THERE
WAS NO FUNDING FOR THE REMAINING
YEAR. OKAY. IS IT SO WE'RE
CUTTING WE'RE GETTING OUT
EARLIER THAN OUR CONTRACT
BECAUSE OF THE FUNDING OKAY.
WE'RE GETTING OUT EARLIER OKAY.
AND WHAT WAS THE SUCCESS RATE OR
LIKE HOW ANY DATA THAT YOU'RE
ABLE TO SHARE WITH US ON IN THE
PAST FROM 21, HOW THIS CAMPAIGN
WENT, HOW MANY PEOPLE DID WE
REACH FOR THE LOCAL LEVEL
CAMPAIGNS OR OUR LEVEL OR THE
STATE LEVEL? NO, THEY WE HAVE
NOT STARTED THE STATE LEVEL
CAMPAIGN. WE HAVEN'T STARTED ON.
WE NEVER STARTED. AND WE'RE
CUTTING IT. YES OKAY. BUT WE
HIRED A VENDOR. YES TO DO WHAT?
TO START WORKING ON IT. AND IT
WAS SUPPOSED TO LAUNCH IN
OCTOBER OF THIS YEAR. OF THIS
YEAR? YES AND WE SO WE PAID A
VENDOR TO DO NOTHING BECAUSE WE
WON'T BE ABLE TO START IT. WE
STARTED THE CAMPAIGN. IT STARTED
FORMATIVE RESEARCH ON THE
CAMPAIGN. GOT IT. AND WE'RE
ESSENTIALLY YEAH. YES. OKAY. HOW
MUCH OF WAS ALREADY SPENT. YEAH
I HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. I'LL HAVE TO
GET BACK TO YOU TOO. I DON'T
HAVE THE EXACT AMOUNT FOR THE
STATE LEVEL CAMPAIGN, BUT THIS
IS WHERE MY CONCERN IS. AND A
LOT OF THESE THINGS, WE WANT ALL
THESE DIFFERENT MONEY. AND I'M
LIKE, CAN WE JUST HOLD OFF? CAN
WE JUST FUND IT FOR A YEAR? CAN
WE DO LESS THAT MONEY, LESS OF
THAT MONEY REQUEST BECAUSE IT
TAKES US A LONG TIME TO START
OFF CAMPAIGNS AND SO FORTH.
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR US
TO CUT CONTRACTS RIGHT NOW,
BECAUSE WE'RE DOING IT IN SOME
WAY IN SOME PROGRAMS. WE'RE
CUTTING CONTRACTS. AND THEN
OTHER CONTRACTS WERE NOT. IT
JUST SEEMS LIKE WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SOME CENSUS, I
BELIEVE, LIKE WE ALLOCATED
FUNDING FOR, THE LEGACY SYSTEM
CEDAR THAT DIDN'T PAN OUT. SO
WE'RE COMING BACK TO A DIFFERENT
ONE. SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
AT LEAST THIS YEAR, EVERYTHING
WE'RE REQUESTING FOR, IS
APPROPRIATE IN A WAY THAT WE
KNOW IT'S GOING TO BE ALLOCATED
ALL THE WAY, KNOWING OUR 1 TO 2
YEAR PROCUREMENT, PROCESS,
KNOWING HOW LONG IT TAKES US TO
GET MONEY OUT THE DOOR, KNOWING
HOW LONG IT TAKES US TO STAND
UP, A PROGRAM LIKE US BEING VERY
SENSITIVE OF THE DOLLAR AMOUNT
WE'RE REQUESTING FOR EVERY
SINGLE PROGRAM. BECAUSE THEN
THIS HAPPENS WHERE WE CUT
PROGRAMS BEFORE THEY EVEN START.
YES. CAN I CIRCLE BACK TO ONE
THING? YOU ASKED WHEN THE PILOT
PROGRAM WOULD END, AND IT'S JUNE
OF 2025. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OKAY. AND THEN ON THE LOCAL
LEVEL PROGRAMS, ARE WE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE ANY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE? IT'S NOT BUDGETED.
IT'S NOT BUDGETED. OKAY YEAH
OKAY. SO WE'RE JUST GIVING OUT
THE MONEY AND THEY'RE GOING TO
DO WHAT THEY DO. WE'RE NOT
COLLECTING ANY DATA AT THE END.
WE WON'T KNOW IF THIS PROGRAM
WAS SUCCESSFUL. SO I THERE'S NO
FUNDING BEYOND THE OKAY THE
YEAR. SO THAT INCLUDES THE
ENTIRE I GUESS STAFF THAT WOULD
CHECK ON THAT STUFF. OKAY. WELL
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENT? NO.
OKAY. ANY OKAY. THANK YOU. ISSUE
FOR CALIFORNIA CANCER REGISTRY.
MARIA OCHOA CDF. SO THE MAY
REVISION REFLECTS AN INCREASE OF
271,000 AND THE GENERAL FUND AND
ONE POSITION TO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL ACTIVITIES REQUIRED
BY THE CALIFORNIA CANCER
REGISTRY, AS MANDATED BY SENATE
BILL 344, THE ONE POSITION BEING
REQUESTED IS NEEDED TO DEVELOP
AND PROMULGATE REGULATION,
PACKAGE AND SUPPORT OPERATIONAL
FUNCTIONS TO MEET THE STATUTORY
AMENDMENT RESULTING FROM THE
2023 LEGISLATION. SB 344 CHANGE
REQUIREMENTS FOR ELECTRONIC
PATHOLOGY REPORTING OF CANCER
DIAGNOSES RESULTING IN A NEED
FOR A STATEWIDE QUALITY CONTROL
TO AND FOLLOW UP WITH PROVIDERS
THAT HAVE DEFICIENCIES. THIS
WORK IS SEPARATE AND DISTINCT
FROM THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
AND OPERATION OF THE REGISTRY.
THE REGULATIONS PACKAGE WILL
ENHANCE DATA QUALITY AND
TIMELINESS TO OPTIMIZE THE USE
OF CANCER DATA AND PROMOTE
HEALTH EQUITY AND THE POSITION
IS NEEDED ONGOING TO MANAGE THE
DATA. CDF WOULD LIKE TO CLARIFY,
AND THIS CAME UP AGAIN LAST WEEK
, THAT THE CALIFORNIA CANCER
REGISTRY CANNOT BE CLOSED AT IS
MANDATED AS IT IS MANDATED BY
STATUTE. AS OF THE MAY REVISE,
THE REGISTRY IS EXPECTING A
DECLINE IN FUNDING, WHICH WOULD
DIMINISH THE REGISTRY'S UTILITY
TO DETECT DISPARITIES SUCH AS
RACE, RACE AND ETHNICITY, AND
THE TIMELINESS OF GETTING DATA
OUT TO INFORM OVERALL CANCER
CONTROL STATEWIDE. BUT THE
REGISTRY WILL CONTINUE. CDF IS
CONTINUING TO LOOK FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO REDIRECT
FUNDING TO MEET THE 800,000
SHORTFALL IN FISCAL YEAR 2425,
IF REDIRECTION IS NOT POSSIBLE,
THE SHORTFALL WILL BE PASSED TO
CONTRACTORS PERFORMING THE
ESSENTIAL FUNCTION OF THE
ESSENTIAL REGISTRY FUNCTIONS. IN
FISCAL YEAR 2425, CDF IS
PURSUING ADDITIONAL CCR
EFFICIENCIES AND HAS ENGAGED IN
LEAN TRANSFORMATION AND
COLLABORATION WITH THE CDF LEAN
TRANSFORMATION OFFICE AND IS
LOOKING FOR ADMINISTRATIVE
EFFICIENCIES. BASED ON RECENT
ADOPTION OF A FEDERAL DATA
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. AND WE SHOULD
SEE SAVINGS IN FISCAL YEAR 2526.
YOU MENTIONED IF WE DON'T FIND
OR MEET THE 80 $800,000
SHORTFALL, THAT WE'RE GOING TO
FOLLOW THE CONTRACTS TO CONTINUE
IT. SO WE HAVE, WE HAVE
CONTRACTORS THAT PERFORM SOME OF
THE ESSENTIAL FUNCTIONS OF THE
REGISTRY. AND SO WE WOULD BE
CUTTING SOME OF THEIR FUNDING.
OKAY. SO IT'S NOT THAT WE GO TO
THEM TO CONTINUE. CORRECT SO THE
GOAL HERE IS TO 100% TRY TO FIND
A WAY TO MAKE THE REGISTRY WHOLE
SO I CAN CONTINUE. CORRECT. IT
WILL STILL CONTINUE THE QUALITY
OF DATA JUST MIGHT NOT BE AS
GOOD BECAUSE WE CAN POTENTIALLY
JUST STOP COLLECTING SOME KIND
OF DATA IF THERE'S DEFICIENCIES
WITH THE DATA, WE MIGHT NOT HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO CORRECT THE
DEFICIENCIES. HIS AND WOULD THAT
BE THE ONLY THING THAT'S AT RISK
IF WE DON'T FUND OR IS
COLLECTING DATA? ALSO, THE DATA
COLLECTION AND THEN THE
TIMELINESS OF HOW QUICKLY WE'RE
ABLE TO GET THE DATA OUT. OKAY.
BUT THIS POSITION IS TO ADD MORE
DATA TO BE ABLE TO COLLECT
ADDITIONAL DATA. SO THERE WAS,
REQUIREMENTS WITH SB 344 TO
COLLECT FOR ELECTRONIC PATHOLOGY
. AND WE NEED TO FOLLOW UP WITH
THOSE DEFICIENCIES WITH THE DATA
THAT'S SUBMITTED. SO THIS
POSITION WILL HELP WITH THE
REGULATION PACKAGE. AND THEN
THEY'LL ALSO HAVE MANAGE THE
DATA THAT'S COMING IN. ONCE THE
REGULATIONS ARE IN PLACE. OKAY.
SO THIS SPECIFIC, DATA WOULD BE
COLLECTED EVEN IF WE DON'T FUND
THE 800,000 OF. CORRECT. OKAY.
JUST EVERY OTHER TYPE OF DATA IS
AT RISK. MARK, I BROUGHT A
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT TODAY.
THANK YOU. MARK JAMISON, CDF,
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANCER REGISTRY. SORRY CAN YOU
HEAR ME? YES, SO, SO IN
RESPONDING TO YOUR QUESTION,
THE, AS MARIA SAID, THE ISSUE IS
THAT WITH THE CUTS THAT THAT
WOULD HAPPEN WITHOUT, IF WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO FIND ADDITIONAL
FUNDING, WE WILL SEE, LESS
ABILITY TO HAVE A DATA SET TO
BUILD A DATA SET WHICH CAN BE
USED TO PROMOTE HEALTH EQUITY.
THAT'S THE THAT'S SORT OF WHAT
THE END RESULT IS. AND BUT GO
AHEAD. BUT THIS DATA WILL BE
ABLE TO COLLECT ALL OF THIS SB
344 DATA TO ME. ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS SB 344 MERELY IS
LOOKING TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY
OF THE DATA THAT IS ALREADY
COMING IN, AND THE THAT'S WHAT
THIS THE FUNDING THAT IS BEING
REQUESTED IS TO IN ORDER TO
ENSURE ENHANCE THE QUALITY OF
THAT DATA SO THAT THE THOSE MOST
IN NEED REALLY KIND OF THOSE
WITH THE, THE HIGHEST RISK OF
DISPARITIES WILL BE INCLUDED IN
THE DATA. THEY'LL BE REPRESENTED
ACCURATELY AND WILL BE ABLE TO
REALLY SERVE THEM ARE THE BEST
WE CAN FINAL SUMMARIZATION. SEE
IF I UNDERSTAND THIS. IF WE IF
WE DON'T FUND AT $800,000, WE'RE
AT RISK. LIKE YOU SAID, SIR, OF
NOT BEING ABLE TO MEET TO
ADDRESS EQUITY AND X, Y, Z THAT
YES, THAT I THINK, OKAY, WE ARE
WE HAVE LESS ABILITY TO PROMOTE
EQUITY, PROMOTE EQUITY IN OUR,
IN OUR POPULATION. AND WE ARE
REALLY A MODEL FOR THE WHOLE
NATION IN THE WORLD. OKAY. SO AT
RISK OF BEING ABLE TO PROMOTE
EQUITY, EQUITY, OF NOT BEING
ABLE TO NOT BEING ABLE TO
PROMOTE EQUITY, THE FUNDING TO
ADDRESS TO FUND SB 344 IS TO
HELP INCREASE, PROMOTE OR
INCREASE OUR PROMOTION OF EQUITY
AS WELL. YES. AND FOR A SPECIFIC
PART OF THE DATA, AS MARIA
MENTIONED, IT'S THE ELECTRONIC
PATHOLOGY DATA, WHICH REALLY
COMES IN EARLIER THAN THE REST
OF THE DATA. THE THE, THE VALUE
THERE IS THAT WE, WE THAT'S BEEN
IN PLACE SINCE 2019. AND WHAT WE
FOUND IS THAT THE DATA QUALITY
IS NOT WHAT WE NEED IN ORDER TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO USE
THIS, THIS ADVANTAGE TO SERVE
THE, THOSE MOST IN NEED. AND SO
THIS IS WHAT THE THAT SECOND
PART IS FOR THE SB 344 FUNDING.
IS IT CORRECT THEN TO ASSUME
THAT EVEN IF WE PASS THROUGH
THIS FIRST PHASE WHERE WE THE
FUNDING FOR SB 344 PASSES
THROUGH THE FIRST PHASE OF
EQUITY, IT STILL HAS TO GO
THROUGH THE SECOND PART THAT WE
POTENTIALLY WON'T BE ABLE TO
FUND. SO WHAT IS THE POINT OF
DOING PART ONE IF WE WON'T BE
ABLE TO DO PART TWO IF WE DON'T
FUND THE REGISTRY? THE REGISTRY
WILL REMAIN, NO MATTER WHAT, BUT
WE WON'T BE ABLE TO CATCH,
INEQUITIES OR MISS, NOT
MISTAKES, IF I COULD HOP IN
HERE, QUALITY INEQUALITY. AND I
THINK WE'RE LOOKING AT OTHER,
WE'RE LOOKING AT OTHER
ADMINISTRATIVE EFFICIENCIES. SO
THAT'S WHAT I WAS SAYING
EARLIER. SO WE HOPE TO SEE, YOU
KNOW, THERE WE FOUND SOME LIKE
DUPLICATION WITH SOME OF OUR
CONTRACTORS IN THE DATA THAT
THEY COLLECT. SO WE'RE WORKING
WITH THEM. AND, WE HOPE TO SEE
EFFICIENCIES WITHIN FISCAL YEAR
2425. SO HOPEFULLY WE WILL NOT
WE CAN MAKE THE CANCER REGISTRY
WHOLE BY THOSE ADMINISTRATIVE
EFFICIENCIES, ONE, WITHOUT THE
OTHER. THAT'S WHERE BOTTOM LINE,
YOU CAN'T HAVE ONE WITHOUT THE
OTHER. AND IT'S HARD TO APPROVE
A BCP WITHOUT KNOWING IF THE
CANCER REGISTRY IS GOING TO BE
MADE WHOLE. THAT'S THE WHETHER
OR NOT THE CANCER REGISTRY IS
MADE WHOLE, IF I MAY, IF I MAY
ADD, IT WILL CONTINUE. AND IT
REMAINS TO BE A, YOU KNOW, ONE
OF THE BEST, THE BEST REGISTRY,
I WOULD SAY, EVEN WITHOUT IT
GETTING FULLY FUNDED, WE ARE
STILL WE ARE WE ARE STILL A, A,
YES, WE ARE STILL THE MAYBE ONE
OF THE ONLY STATES THAT HAS ALL
THE WHOLE STATE COVERED BY WITH
NCI, THE NCI IS USING OUR DATA,
AND THAT THAT PROVIDES OTHER
DATA QUALITY. SO, SO YES, EVEN
AN EVEN WITH THE, THE LARGER
SHORTFALL THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT,
THE, THE ENHANCEMENT OF OUR
ELECTRONIC PATHOLOGY DATA DOES
PROVIDE AN IMPORTANT VALUE.
OKAY. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS? DID WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ADD SOMETHING, NICK MILLS DID
PART OF FINANCE, I JUST WANTED
TO NOTE TWO THINGS THE STATE
DOES NOT TYPICALLY BACKFILL FOR
DECLINING TOBACCO TAX FUNDS FOR
PROGRAMS SUPPORTED BY TOBACCO
TAXES. AND NUMBER TWO, SOME OF
CALIFORNIA CANCER REGISTRIES,
CONTRACTORS, REGIONAL CANCER
REGISTRIES, THEY USE THESE STATE
FUNDS AS A MATCH TO DRAW DOWN
FEDERAL GRANT FUNDS FROM THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF HEALTH
SURVEILLANCE, EPIDEMIOLOGY, AND
END RESULTS PROGRAM, ALSO KNOWN
AS SEER. HOWEVER THESE MATCHING
FUNDS ARE NOT REQUIRED TO COME
FROM THE STATE AND THE
ORGANIZATIONS WHICH HOUSE THESE
REGIONAL REGISTRIES COULD ALSO
CHOOSE TO PROVIDE MATCHING FUNDS
. WHO CAN CHOOSE TO PROVIDE
MATCHING FUNDS, REGIONAL CANCER
REGISTRIES, I BELIEVE, OF
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA, UCSF, AND I CAN'T
REMEMBER THE THIRD UC DAVIS Þ UC
DAVIS. AND FOR ARE WE ASKING
THEM? ARE WE ASKING THEM TO
SUPPORT. OH, THEY ALREADY THEY
ALREADY DO, AND YES, BUT NØ NICK
MAKES A GOOD POINT, AND YES, I
THINK IT, YOU KNOW, IT STANDS ON
ITS OWN. OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. OKAY. SO NOW
WE'RE GOING TO. FLIP BACK TO THE
FRONT HERE
.
OKAY. NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO HCAI. ISSUES AGAIN. WELCOME
BACK. GOOD EVENING, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. ELIZABETH LANDSBERG
WITH HCAI. THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE. ACCESS AND
INFORMATION. THE AGENDA ASKS US
TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
PROPOSED REVISIONS AND
REDUCTIONS. DID YOU WANT ME TO
GO THROUGH THOSE? NOT ALL
NECESSARILY. I THINK I REALLY
WANT TO FOCUS ON WHAT WE TALKED
ABOUT LAST WEEK, THE CONCERNS OF
THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN ALREADY
AWARDED AND WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE, AND TAKING THEM BACK. WE I
KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT THE
RESIDENCY, BUT ANOTHER THING I
CAN'T REMEMBER IF WE TALKED
ABOUT ARE LOAN REPAYMENTS ON
ANYBODY WHO DECLARED, YES, I'M
GOING TO WORK IN THAT AREA AT
THE PROMISE OF A LOAN REPAYMENT.
AND NOW WE'RE SAYING NEVER MIND.
SO THOSE ARE THE TWO MAJOR
THINGS AND ANY OTHER PROGRAM
THAT IS IN THAT SCENARIO. SO
YES, MADAM CHAIR, HAPPY TO COVER
THE AREAS WHERE FUNDS HAVE BEEN
OBLIGATED AND ARE PROPOSED. FOR
CUTS UNDER THIS VERY DIFFICULT
BUDGET. SO AGAIN, THE COMMITTEE
ASKED HØI WHETHER MEDICAL
STUDENTS WHO HAD JUST MATCHED
EARLIER THIS SPRING WOULD HAVE
THEIR RESIDENCIES PUT AT RISK BY
THESE CUTS. AND SO WE DID CALL
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS TO WHOM
WE HAD MADE AWARDS, AND THEY DID
ADVISE THAT THE FUNDING WE HAD
AWARDED IS FOR RESIDENTS WHO
JUST GOT A MATCH AND ARE SET TO
START THEIR RESIDENCIES THIS
SUMMER. WE WOULD NOTE THAT A
MATCHED RESIDENCY PROGRAM,
THERE'S A YOU KNOW, THEY'RE
CONTRACTUALLY BOUND, TO COMPLETE
THE YEAR, WHICH OFFERS SOME
PROTECTION TO THE RESIDENT WHO
WOULD NOT LIKELY FIND ANOTHER
MATCH IN THE CYCLE. AS WAS
NOTED, HOWEVER, IT IS POSSIBLE
THAT CONTRACTS COULD BE BREACHED
IF THE RESIDENCY PROGRAM
COULDN'T BACKFILL THE LOSS OF
SONG BROWN FUNDING FROM THE
STATE. SO FOR MOST PRIMARY CARE
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS, THE SONG
BROWN FUNDING DOES REPRESENT
CORE SUPPORT TO RETAIN FACULTY
TÊ, WHICH IS REQUIRED TO
MAINTAIN PROGRAM ACCREDITATION
SO. YOU KNOW, I'VE SPENT A LOT
OF TIME WORKING ON THIS AREA IN
THE 12 YEARS I'VE BEEN UP HERE
WITH MY COLLEAGUE TO MY RIGHT
AND WITH DOCTOR RICHARD PAN.
WHEN HE WAS HERE AND TRYING TO
BUILD UP OUR RESIDENCY FUNDING.
AND I HAVE TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION THÀNH FOR DOING
IT, BECAUSE WE DON'T DO THAT.
BUT THE ADMINISTRATION DOES. BUT
IN, IN THE, IN THE COURSE OF
BEING INVOLVED IN AND HAVING
OTHERS SET UP MEDICAL SCHOOLS
AND WATCHING THE IMPACT AND
WATCHING RESIDENCY PROGRAMS BE
SET UP, I DO KNOW THIS. THERE
ARE MORE PHYSICIANS SEEKING
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS THAN THERE
ARE RESIDENCY PROGRAMS TO PUT
THEM INTO. AND SO IF A PHYSICIAN
LOSES A MATCH, FIRST OF ALL,
THEY MATCH. AND IF A PHYSICIAN
DROPS OUT AT THAT POINT, I THINK
THE ODDS OF THE PHYSICIAN
FINDING A RESIDENCY PROGRAM ARE
PRETTY SLIM. AND AS YOU ALL
KNOW, BECAUSE YOU'RE IN THE
BUSINESS, IF THE PHYSICIAN DOES
NOT FIND A RESIDENCY PROGRAM,
THE PHYSICIAN CAN'T PRACTICE
MEDICINE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE A PHYSICIAN
WITHOUT A COMPLETED RESIDENCY
PROGRAM CAN'T GET A CONTRACT TO
PROVIDE SERVICES, IS PROBABLY
NOT GOING TO BE HIRED BY ANYBODY
WHO HAS A CONTRACT TO PROVIDE
SERVICES. AND I GUESS THERE ARE
CLAIMS REPRESENTATIVE FOR SOME
HEALTH PLANS SOMEWHERE, AND WE
JUST CAN'T HAVE THAT. WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH OF THESE PEOPLE.
THEY SAY WE NEED 4100, WHETHER
IT'S 4100 MORE OR 6100 MORE, WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH OF THEM. AND
SO I REALIZE THIS ISN'T YOUR
DECISION, REALLY, BUT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO ELEVATE IT TO
THE PEOPLE THAT CAN FIX THIS
PROBLEM, BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANY MORE RESIDENCY MONEY
OUT THERE. THERE THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF SOURCES FOR RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS, OF COURSE, MEDICARE
FUNDS, RESIDENCY PROGRAMS. AND
PROP $56 FLOWS THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICINE SCHOLARS
PROGRAM. I KNOW ALL I KNOW ALL
OF THAT, MADAM DIRECTOR. WHAT
WHAT I ALSO KNOW IS THERE ARE
MORE PEOPLE PUT PUSHING INTO THE
PIPELINE THAN THERE ARE SLOTS
THAT ARE FUNDED. DULY NOTED.
IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT BUDGET
YEAR, YET. WELL, WE I WILL TELL
YOU THIS. I WILL NOT VOTE FOR A
BUDGET THAT CUTS THE RESIDENCY
PROGRAM OUT OF A POSITION THAT
IS MATCHED, JUST LIKE I WILL NOT
VOTE FOR. AND I WANT THE PEOPLE
UPSTAIRS TO HEAR THIS. I WILL
NOT VOTE FOR A BUDGET THAT CUTS
A PSYCHIATRIST WHO IS RECRUITED
INTO A STATE HOSPITAL ON THE
PREMISE OF LOAN REPAYMENT. OUT
OF THAT LOAN REPAYMENT. THAT IS
SIMPLY NOT THE HONORABLE THING
TO DO. NOT THAT YOU'RE
DISHONORABLE, BUT THE HONOR OF
THE STATE IS AT STAKE HERE, AND
WE'LL HAVE TO FIGURE IT OUT AND
FIND IT SOMEPLACE ELSE, BECAUSE
THAT JUST CAN'T WORK. I DO
APPRECIATE ALL THAT. YOU. THIS
IS TOUGH FOR YOU, JUST AS IT'S
TOUGH FOR US. ALL RIGHT, MADAM
CHAIR, THAT'S JUST. NO, NO, NO
APOLOGIES, SENATOR. I THINK I
THINK THAT'S THE SENTIMENT
ACROSS THE ONES THAT HAVE BEEN.
AND THIS IS LIKE IN THE CHILD
CARE. WE TALKED ABOUT THIS SLOTS
THAT HAVE BEEN AWARDED THE AWARD
LETTERS HAVE GONE OUT ON
PROGRAMS THAT AWARD LETTERS HAVE
GONE OUT LIKE THAT'S THOSE ARE
THE MOST THE EVEN MORE DIFFICULT
ONES BECAUSE YOU'RE RIGHT, I
THEIR RESIDENCY IS TO START IN
LIKE A COUPLE OF MONTHS AND TO
THEN IMMEDIATELY SAY, HEY, NEVER
MIND. THAT'S REALLY DIFFICULT.
I'M AT A TIME WHERE PROP ONE IS
GOING TO NEED SO MANY MORE
PEOPLE TO BE INVOLVED IN THIS.
CAL AIM NEEDS WAY MORE HEALTH
CARE WORKERS INVOLVED IN THIS
AND THOSE KIND OF PROJECTS. SO
YOU NOTICE THAT WE UNDERSTAND
WE'RE NOT HERE SAYING WE WANT
ALL OF THIS BACK. WE'RE VERY
BEING VERY STRATEGIC IN SAYING,
LIKE THESE, THESE TWO IN
PARTICULAR ARE EVEN HARDER TO
SWALLOW, BECAUSE OF THE, THE
IMPACT, BECAUSE IT'S ALREADY
BEEN ALLOCATED. PEOPLE ALREADY
GOT AWARD LETTERS. PEOPLE ARE
ALREADY ACCOUNTING FOR THIS MAY
JUST LIKE DECISIONS BASED ON
THESE OF GOING, HEY, I MIGHT
MOVE AWAY FROM MY FAMILY BECAUSE
I'M GOING TO GO TO A SPECIFIC,
LOCATION JUST SO I CAN GET MY
LOAN REPAYMENT. AND WHAT IF
THEY'RE STUCK THERE? SO I
APPRECIATE YOU CHECKING INTO
THOSE SCHOOLS, BUT I THINK THAT
MADE IT A LITTLE WORSE. GETTING
THE INFORMATION THAT THIS IS
STARTING IN SUMMER, HAVE THESE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE THE SCHOOLS
MADE THESE RESIDENTS? I THINK IT
WAS 19 YOU MENTIONED. SO IN
ADDITION TO THE SONG BROWN
FUNDS, YES, MADAM CHAIR, THERE
ARE 19 FOR WHOM HCAI HAS MADE A
PHYSICIAN LOAN REPAYMENT AWARDS.
AWARD 19 INDIVIDUALS. SO THE
LOAN REPAYMENTS 19 INDIVIDUALS?
YES. WHO WERE TOLD THEIR LOANS
WERE GOING TO BE REPAID.
CORRECT. THE PORTION OF THEIR
LOANS WOULD BE REPAID FOR
WORKING IN A MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREA. AND THEY
ALREADY STARTED WORKING IN THAT
AREA. I BELIEVE, GIVEN THAT WE
JUST MADE AWARDS, THAT THEY'RE
LIKELY FINISHING THEIR RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS. WE DID NOT REACH OUT
TO THE INDIVIDUALS. I DON'T
BELIEVE. OKAY. AND THEN THE
OTHER, HOW MANY PEOPLE IN THE
PSYCHIATRIST NÓ. YES. THE LOAN
REPAYMENT FOR PSYCHIATRIST THE
LOAN REPAYMENT FOR PSYCHIATRY.
BUT WE HAVE NOT MADE NOT MADE
AWARDS. NO AWARDS. SO IT SEEMS
LIKE THE ONLY PROGRAM THAT HAS
MADE AWARDS IS THE RESIDENCY
SONG. BROWN RESIDENCY ONES SONG.
BROWN RESIDENCY SONG. BROWN
NURSING THE INDIVIDUAL. THE LOAN
, THE PHYSICIAN LOAN REPAYMENT.
AND THEN TWO OF OUR PIPELINE AND
PATHWAY PROGRAMS. SO THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICINE SCHOLARS
PROGRAM WAS EXPECTING 2.8
MILLION FOR THE NEXT FOUR YEARS.
AND CMSP HAS ADVISED US THAT THE
PROGRAM WOULD WOULD EFFECTIVELY
BE TERMINATED WITHOUT STATE
SUPPORT. SO THIS IS A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TO MEDICAL SCHOOL
PATHWAY PROGRAM THAT'S ALREADY
BEGUN. YES YES, IT HAS BEGUN. SO
THEY HAVE TWO COHORTS, YES. WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN TO THE COHORTS, SO
THIS WE TALKED BRIEFLY ABOUT
THIS PROGRAM LAST WEEK. SO THIS
PROGRAM PROVIDES SUPPORT FOR
FOLKS WHO'VE COME FROM COMMUNITY
COLLEGES INTO MEDICAL SCHOOLS.
SO THEY RECEIVE PERSONALIZED
TRANSFER GUIDANCE, MCAT SUPPORT
APPLICATION ASSISTANCE, RESEARCH
AND CLINICAL INTERNSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES, TARGETED ADVISING
FROM COMMUNITY COLLEGE
COUNSELORS, MANY GET GET
INTERNSHIPS IN CLINICAL RESEARCH
SO IT SUPPORT TO HELP THOSE
STUDENTS SUCCEED IN MEDICAL
SCHOOL. SO THIS IS THE GETTING
INTO THE MEDICAL SCHOOL PIECE
FROM COMMUNITY COLLEGE. YES.
ABOUT THE MCAT. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. YES. HAVING INTERNSHIPS
AND LABS. SO THEY GET EXPERIENCE
THAT LOOKS GOOD ON MEDICAL
SCHOOL APPLICATIONS AND ALL THAT
. RIGHT? CORRECT. BUT MADAM
CHAIR, MAY I ASK ONE MORE? YEAH,
OF COURSE. ON THE SONG BROWN
NURSE PROGRAM, I'M LESS FAMILIAR
WITH THAT, OBVIOUSLY. WHAT DOES
THAT DO? DOES THAT PROVIDE LOAN
MONEY TO THE NURSES OR. NO,
THAT'S ALSO TO THE ORGANIZATION.
SO IT'S A FUND NURSING NURSING
TRAINING PROGRAM. OH I SEE YES.
EVEN THOUGH THEY DON'T HAVE
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS, IT'S TO
PROVIDE THE BASIC TRAINING
PROGRAM. CORRECT. MANY IS FOR
ADN NURSING PROGRAMS. GOTCHA.
DOES IT GO TO PUBLIC PROGRAMS OR
PRIVATE PROGRAMS? THE SONG BROWN
NURSING, SOME OF EACH. OKAY YES,
MADAM CHAIR, IF I MIGHT ADD,
JOSEPH DONALDSON, DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. SO TALKING ABOUT BOTH,
SONG BROWN AS WELL AS TALKING
ABOUT THE SONG BROWN NURSING
COMPONENT, WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
BASED WITH BASED WITHIN THE
PROPOSAL WITHIN THE MAY REVISE
THAT SONG. BROWN RESIDENCIES.
WHILE THERE ARE REDUCTIONS TO
THESE CURRENT YEAR AND PRIOR
YEAR DOLLARS THAT HAVE HAVE BEEN
OBLIGATED AT THIS TIME, THE
PROGRAM IS NOT COMPLETELY
ELIMINATED. THE PROGRAM STILL
MAINTAINS 31.3 MILLION IN 24,
25, AND ONGOING. SO WHILE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE,
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS MONEY, THIS
PROGRAM IS NOT COMPLETELY
ELIMINATED BASED ON THE
PROPOSAL. ALSO, IN REGARDS TO
NURSING, I KNOW, WITHIN THIS
PROPOSAL, THERE ARE VARIOUS
NURSING REDUCTIONS, BUT I JUST
REALLY WANTED TO REITERATE THAT
EVEN WITHIN THE STATE BUDGET AS
A WHOLE, UNDER PROP 98, UNDER
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROGRAM,
UNDERSTANDABLY, THAT IT'S NOT
UNDER BUDGET, THERE ARE STILL
$300 MILLION BEGINNING IN 24, 25
AND ALLOTMENTS OF 60 MILLION PER
YEAR. SO JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT WHILE THERE ARE SOME
DIFFICULT, SOLUTIONS BUILT
WITHIN MAY REVISE, THERE ARE
DOLLARS STILL MAINTAIN AND
CONTINUE WITHIN THE STATE BUDGET
AS WELL AS SOME OTHER
INVESTMENTS WE TALKED ABOUT IN
THE PREVIOUS HEARINGS. CONNECTED
TO PROP ONE. SO JUST JUST REALLY
WANT TO REITERATE THAT WHILE
THERE ARE REALLY TOUGH
REDUCTIONS WITHIN THIS MAY
REVISE, THERE ARE OTHER FUNDS
WITHIN THE STATE BUDGET THAT ARE
STILL TRYING TO MAINTAIN THAT
COMMITMENT. BUT THE 31.3 FOR THE
RESIDENCY, THAT'S FOR 25, 26.
IT'S SORRY, IT'S IT STARTS IN 20
WOULD CONTINUE IN 2526 NÓ THE
FUNDING WOULD REDUCE THE FUNDING
SLOTTED FOR 2425 AND ONGOING.
THAT FUNDING IS NOT IMPACTED BY
THE SOLUTION. IT'S JUST THE
FUNDING FROM THESE PRIOR AND
CURRENT YEAR DOLLARS THAT WHILE
THEY HAD BEEN OBLIGATED, THEY
WERE NOT ENCUMBERED AT THE TIME
OF DEVELOPING, WE HAVE THIS
INCORRECT BECAUSE IT SAYS I
DON'T UNDERSTAND 10 MILLION. SO
REDUCTION OF GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE, AUTHORITY OF
10,000,024 25. SORRY. REPEAT
THAT ONE MORE TIME. REDUCTION OF
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY IN 2425 OF
10 MILLION. SO THIS IS WHERE
THERE'S VARIOUS FUNDINGS FOR
SONG BROWN. SO THERE IS THE
ONGOING FUNDING OF THIS 31.3
MILLION THAT I KNOW THAT IT'S
NOT TOUCHED WITHIN THE 22 BUDGET
ACT. THERE ARE AUGMENTATIONS
MADE TO SONG BROWN. THERE WAS
ONE FOR, I BELIEVE IT WAS FOR
NURSING AND DIRECTOR. CORRECT ME
IF I'M WRONG. IT WAS FOR PRIMARY
RESIDENCES AS WELL. SO THERE'S
TWO AMOUNTS. THERE WAS A TOTAL
OF 25 MILLION IN TOTAL FOR THESE
TWO PROGRAMS. SO THE 10 MILLION
YOU'RE REFERRING TO WAS A ONE
TIME AUGMENTATION THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE 22 BUDGET ACT,
NOT THIS 31 ONGOING, FOR SONG
BROWN, BUT WHAT'S THE 31 MILLION
FOR IF WE'RE NOT GOING TO KEEP
OUR WORD TO THE 19? YEAH.
RESIDENCY SLOTS AND THE AND THE
AND THE AND THE LOAN PAYBACK
UNDER THE MAY REVISE THAT WAS
THAT WAS NOT IDENTIFIED AS PART
OF THE SOLUTION. WE ONLY
IDENTIFIED TIED OBLIGATED BUT
UNENCUMBERED DOLLARS. SO THE 31
WELL I UNDERSTAND THAT CONCERN
OF KIND OF AN ONGOING COMMITMENT
THAT FUNDING IS NOT, CURRENTLY
INCLUDED WITHIN THE MAY REVISE.
SO WE MIGHT NEED SOME
CLARIFICATION BECAUSE OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN AWARDED, AND WE'RE
CLAWING THE AWARDS BACK. ARE YOU
SAYING THAT'S NOT TRUE? I'M
SORRY. YOU'RE SAYING THAT'S NOT
TRUE? NO. I'M SORRY, I'M TRYING
TO CLARIFY THAT THERE'S FUNDING,
THERE'S FUNDING THAT WAS
OBLIGATED. THAT IS PROPOSED AS A
REDUCTION. HOWEVER, THERE'S
STILL FUNDING WITHIN HIS BUDGET
RELATED TO SONG BROWN. SO YOU
HAVE EXTRA MONEY IN SONG BROWN I
WANT TO LET ME JUST TELL YOU
WHAT I NEED TO SEE, BECAUSE I'M
NOT A FINANCE PERSON. WHEN I
NEED TO SEE IS THE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE BEEN MATCHED. IN THE CASE
OF RESIDENCIES, AND NORMALLY
THEY DON'T MATCH THEM UNLESS
THERE'S ENOUGH MONEY IN THE
PIPELINE TO COVER WHATEVER THE
LENGTH OF THE RESIDENCY PROGRAM
IS. THREE YEARS FOR, YOU KNOW,
FOR A OF INTERNAL MEDICINE OR
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN, YOU
KNOW, WHATEVER IT IS. SEVEN
YEARS FOR PSYCHIATRY, I DON'T
REMEMBER, BUT THERE'S A LENGTH
OF TIME ATTACHED TO EACH OF
THEM, AND THEY DON'T TAKE PEOPLE
IN UNLESS THERE'S MONEY TO COVER
THEM. SO IF WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
IS THERE'S EXTRA MONEY IN THE
POT, NOTWITHSTANDING THESE CUTS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
COVER THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
MATCHED. I THINK OUR COLLEAGUE,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
REFERRING TO ONGOING FUNDING FOR
SONG BROWN, WHICH DOES EXIST,
AND I WAS HAPPY TO COVER ALL THE
REMAINING FUNDS, THAT'S BUT
THAT'S BUT HERE'S MY I MEAN, I
THEN I'M REALLY I DON'T I DON'T
UNDERSTAND IT. SO NOT THAT WE
NEED TO BELABOR IT TONIGHT, BUT
I THINK YOU CAN SOMEBODY CAN
TELL ME WHO'S WHO'S MATCHED IT.
AND IF THERE ARE 50 OF THEM, HOW
MUCH MONEY IS BLOCKED AGAINST
THAT? REGARDLESS OF WHO HAS IT.
AND THEN I GUESS THEY'LL STOP
MATCHING PHYSICIANS. IF YOU CUT
THE BUDGET AND DON'T AWARD ANY
MORE MONEY. SO THERE ARE $90
MILLION IN SONG BROWN FUNDS FOR
BOTH PRIMARY CARE RESIDENCY
NURSING AND NURSE PRACTITIONER
PAS THAT HCAI HAS OBLIGATED THAT
ARE PROPOSED UNDER THIS
DIFFICULT BUDGET FOR TO BE CUT
AND IN ADDITION THERE IS ONGOING
FUNDING FOR FUTURE YEARS TO
MAINTAIN A BASE LEVEL OF FUNDING
FOR SONG BROWN. SO THAT AND I'VE
HEARD THE SENATOR'S CONCERNS.
THAT MEANS PEOPLE WILL BE OUT OF
A SLOT. YES. RIGHT. CORRECT
CORRECT. 31 MILLION TO READ.
JUST A LOOK OVER HERE, I WILL, I
WILL HAVE TO WE'LL HAVE TO WORK
THIS OUT. I MEAN, YOU UNDERSTAND
OUR CONCERNS, MADAM DIRECTOR,
AND IT'S NOT YOU. I MEAN,
SOMEBODY UPSTAIRS, SO WE'LL HAVE
TO FIGURE IT OUT. I JUST DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANY CIRCUMSTANCE
WHERE THE STATE SHOULD GO BACK
ON ITS WORD. YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE BREAKING CONTRACTS,
AND WE'RE PROPOSING TO DO THE
SAME THING. RIGHT? BUT I FEEL
LIKE WE'RE GETTING TWO DIFFERENT
31 MILLION RESPONSES HERE. OKAY.
WE'RE LÀ JASON CONSTANDUROS. BUT
MAYBE JUST TO HELP SORT OF
CLARIFY THIS A LITTLE BIT MORE.
SO THE SONG BROWN PROGRAM HAS
ONGOING AND ONE TIME FUNDING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSING TO
RESCIND MOST OF THAT ONE TIME
FUNDING THAT WAS FOR SONG BROWN.
THEY'RE ALSO PROPOSING TO
REVERT, IN THE ONGOING AMOUNT
THE AMOUNTS THAT WERE FOR PRIOR
YEAR AND CURRENT YEAR, BUT NOT
THE BUDGET YEAR AND ONGOING. SO
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU HEAR ABOUT, SO
MANY OF THE FUNDS ARE OBLIGATED,
IT'S BECAUSE THEY WERE
APPROPRIATED IN PREVIOUS BUDGETS
AND THEY'RE PROPOSING TO REVERT
THOSE. THE BUDGET ASSUMES,
THOUGH, THAT BEGINNING IN 2425,
THERE WOULD STILL BE THAT
ONGOING AMOUNT FOR SONG BROWN.
SO THAT'S WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING TO
CONVEY IN THAT, IN THAT ANSWER.
SO THE KEY ISSUE REALLY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE HERE IS, IS THAT
SORT OF AMOUNTS THAT WERE IN THE
CURRENT YEAR AND SORT OF
PREVIOUS YEARS BEFORE THAT, YOU
KNOW, OUR, YOU
KNOW, SORT OF THE PREVIOUS
HEARING, YOU KNOW, WE THINK IT'S
REASONABLE FOR TO, YOU KNOW,
REVISIT LIMITED TERM SPENDING.
THAT'S A KEY STRATEGY. WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE PURSUE
THIS IS THIS DOES RAISE A MORE
SPECIFIC TRADE OFF AS, AS YOU'VE
ALL NOTED, BECAUSE, SOME OF
THESE FUNDS IN THAT WERE IN
PREVIOUS YEARS AND IN THE
CURRENT YEAR WERE OBLIGATED. AND
ACCORDING TO, YOU KNOW,
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT, THAT THAT AMOUNT IS
ABOUT 125 MILLION. AND THIS
SOLUTION IN THE BUDGET YEAR IS
ABOUT 600 MILLION. SO IT IS IT
IS A KEY PART OF THE SOLUTION.
THAT'S ASSUMED THAT MAY
REVISION, SO THIS IS SOMETHING,
YOU KNOW, THE LEGISLATURE COULD,
COULD TREAT AS A HIGHER PRIORITY
FOR FINDING ALTERNATIVES. WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
TO IDENTIFY ALTERNATIVES TO, BUT
IT IS A KEY PART OF THE SOLUTION
TOO. SO IT IS ONE OF THOSE AREAS
THAT THAT COULD REQUIRE A MORE
ONE FOR ONE, 125 MILLION OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS PART OF THE IS OF THE
OF THE PROPOSED REDUCTION.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT, 125
MILLION HAS BEEN OBLIGATED. SO
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE AMOUNT
THAT WE'RE 125 HAS BEEN
OBLIGATED. THAT'S THAT'S MY READ
OF THEIR THE INFORMATION THEY
PROVIDED OVER THE WEEKEND WHERE
PEOPLE ALREADY GOT AN AWARD
LETTER. CONGRATULATIONS. YOU'VE
BEEN SELECTED. YES I SEE MY
POINT. I MEAN, WE'RE OUR JOB IN
THIS COMMITTEE AND IN THE OTHER
SUBCOMMITTEES THAT I'VE BEEN ON.
AND THE BIG BUDGET COMMITTEE IS
TO DEAL WITH THE NUMBERS, BUT
WHAT I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE DEAL
WITH HERE IS THE ARE THE PEOPLE.
AND I UNDERSTAND CUTTING A
PROGRAM BEFORE SOMEBODY IN IT. I
GET THAT I UNDERSTAND CUTTING
NURSING SLOTS BEFORE SOME NURSE
CANDIDATE IS SITTING IN ONE, BUT
I DON'T UNDERSTAND CUTTING A
SLOT THAT SOMEBODY IS IN UNLESS
WE HAVE EXPLORED EVERY OTHER
ALTERNATIVE. AND YOU'VE HEARD, I
DON'T THINK I'M WRONG. WE CAN
GET THE EXPERTS IN HERE, BUT I'M
FAIRLY CERTAIN THAT WHEN A NURSE
WILL PROBABLY FIND ANOTHER SLOT.
BUT IF AN MD PHYSICIAN WHO NEEDS
A RESIDENCY PROGRAM WILL
PROBABLY NOT FIND ANOTHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAM IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. SO I THINK AT
SOME POINT WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT
THE PEOPLE, AND YOU CAN HELP US
UNDERSTAND THE NUMBERS, BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY I'M I GATHER THE
ONGOING FUNDING IS NOT
SUFFICIENT TO SUPPLANT THE MONEY
THAT WE'RE GOING TO, THE ONE
TIME MONEY THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CHOP OUT OF THE BUDGET. LEO I
THINK I'D HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
THAT ONE A LITTLE BIT, BUT BUT
BUT GENERALLY IT'S, MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE PROPOSED
REDUCTION HERE IS, IS GREATER
THAN THAT ONGOING AMOUNT IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. AND THERE'S A BIT
OF A TIMING ISSUE WHEN, WHEN
MONEY IS APPROPRIATED AND, THERE
ARE THERE IS OTHER IS THE
ADMINISTRATION NOTED THERE IS
OTHER FUNDING FOR GMI, BUT IT IS
OF A LESSER AMOUNT THAN, THAN IN
PREVIOUS YEARS. THERE THE ACROSS
YOU KNOW THE SONG BROWN AND ALSO
THE èC PROGRAM. SO THERE THERE
IS FUNDING THERE'S ONGOING
FUNDING STILL APPLY. BUT UNLESS
IT'S CHANGED YOU SEE USES THAT
MONEY INSIDE ITS OWN MEDICAL
CENTERS. RIGHT. THE $75 MILLION.
NO. IT'S BROADLY DISTRIBUTED.
IT'S THROUGH AN APPLICATION
PROCESS. IT'S A COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROGRAM SIMILAR TO SONG
BROWN, BUT ALSO INCLUDES
EMERGENCY CARE. AND THAT'S A
THAT THAT AMOUNT IS A HAS BEEN
40 MILLION. BUT THE REVISION
JUST TO UNDERSTAND SO I KNOW YOU
UNDERSTAND THERE MEDICAL SCHOOLS
THAT GRADUATE UNDERGRADUATE
PHYSICIANS EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
AND WHEN THEY GRADUATE THEY ALL
PILE THE DIRECTOR KNOWS BECAUSE
SHE, YOU KNOW RUNS THIS, THEY
ALL PILE INTO THE PIPELINE. AND
IF YOU HAVE SOMEBODY WHO'S
ALREADY MADE IT OUT OF THE
PIPELINE INTO A MATCH PROGRAM,
THAT PERSON OR THOSE PEOPLE ARE
OUTLIERS, HOW DO THEY GET BACK
IN TO COMPETE WITH THE FOLKS
THAT JUST CAME OUT OF MEDICAL
SCHOOL? AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS
IT IS VERY, VERY DIFFICULT. SO
I'M GOING TO SHUT MY LIPS RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE IT'S GETTING LATE
AND WE CAN TALK ABOUT THIS SOME
OTHER TIME, BUT WE'LL HAVE TO
GET TOGETHER ON THIS ONE. 125
MILLION THAT I'VE BEEN
OBLIGATED. HOW MANY SOULS IS
THAT? HOW MANY PEOPLE WE'RE
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH? WITH
THE EXACT NUMBER. MADAM CHAIR,
WOULD YOU PLEASE, SIR? AND THEN,
ONE LAST QUESTION ON THE SONG.
BROWN NURSING. IS THAT FOR
CLINICAL SPOTS? BECAUSE I KNOW
NURSES AND STUDENT NURSES ARE
HAVING DIFFICULTY PLACING IN
HOSPITALS FOR THEIR CLINICAL IS
THAT FOR THAT? SO WE HAVE A
SEPARATE INITIATIVES AROUND THE
CLINICAL PLACEMENT. THIS IS THIS
IS FOR THE TRAINING PROGRAMS
JUST TO CONFIRM. YEAH. OKAY. ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS JASON. KNOW
THAT THOSE THOSE ARE MY COMMENTS
. SO THE AGENDA ALSO ASKS WHAT
PROGRAMS WOULD REMAIN AFTER MAY
REVISION REDUCTIONS. DID YOU
STILL WANT ME TO COVER THAT?
MADAM CHAIR? OKAY. SO IF THE MAY
REVISION REDUCTIONS WERE ADOPTED
, HCAI WOULD STILL HAVE A 26.7
MILLION REMAINING IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND. THE BULK OF THAT
208 MILLION IS FROM SAIBAI, AND
WILL BE USED TO FUND EMPLOYER
SUPPORT GRANTS, CONTRACTS WITH
CSU AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
START THE NEW PROGRAM.
SCHOLARSHIPS AND APPRENTICESHIPS
FOR OUR FOR OUR CERTIFIED
WELLNESS COACHES. MOST OF THESE
FUNDS ARE CURRENTLY AVAILABLE,
AND WE INTEND TO SPEND THEM IN
THE BUDGET YEAR OR SHORTLY
THEREAFTER, THERE IS ALSO
FUNDING FOR REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
FOR SOME OF OUR PIPELINE
PROGRAMS 15 MILLION THIS YEAR
FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS.
PROMOTORAS AND TRIBAL
REPRESENTATIVES, AND SOME
ADDITIONAL ADDITIONAL FUNDS. WE
WERE THE WELLNESS COACHES.
START. THE WELLNESS WE DO IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE, AS OF LAST
MONDAY, 133 CERTIFIED WELLNESS
COACHES. SO, SCHOOLS, THEY,
THERE IS AN IF THEY GET A
ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE IN SOCIAL
WORK OR PSYCHOLOGY, THERE ARE A
FEW PROGRAMS THAT THEY CAN GET
NOW. AND THEN DO THEIR CLINICAL
HOURS TO BECOME CERTIFIED
WELLNESS COACHES. SO WE DO HAVE
AND WE HAVE A COUPLE THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN THE PIPELINE. AND THEN
WE'RE POISED TO GRANT EMPLOYER
SUPPORT GRANTS AND SCHOLARSHIPS.
OKAY, OKAY. AND WHERE CAN THEY
WORK? THEY CAN WORK IN SCHOOLS
OR COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
. OKAY. YEAH, ADDITIONALLY, IN
ADDITION TO THAT, 267,000,000 IN
1 TIME FUNDS, HCAI WOULD
MAINTAIN ROUGHLY 50 MILLION PER
YEAR IN ONGOING LOCAL ASSISTANCE
FUNDS FROM BUDGET YEAR FORWARD.
SO THAT INCLUDES THE 31 OR 33
MILLION ANNUALLY FOR SONG BROWN
PRIMARY CARE RESIDENCY FEES AND
THEN A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS WHERE
THE EXISTING WORKFORCE PAYS
LICENSURE FEES. AND WE THAT THAT
HELPS FUND LOAN REPAYMENT AND
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS FOR A WIDE
RANGE OF PRIMARY CARE AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROFESSIONS.
SO THOSE ARE THE BULK OF THE, OF
THE FUNDS THAT WE WOULD MAINTAIN
UNDER THE MAY REVISION. OKAY.
SO, OKAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT. THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO DCS. WE'RE NOT GOING
TO MOVE ON TO DCS. GET OUT OF
HERE OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO DO THE
ISSUE WHERE IT'S BOTH DCS AND DF
. CDF. OKAY. IS THAT ALL. THERE
WE GO. IF YOU'RE FOLLOWING ALONG
IN THE AGENDA WE'RE ON PAGE 22.
FIRST ISSUE.
WHICH I JUST HAVE IN FRONT OF
AND DCS. QUESTION TWO. SO I
BROUGHT THIS ISSUE BACK BECAUSE
YOU, YOU KNOW, FROM LAST WEEK,
YOU HEARD SOME OF MY CONCERNS
JUST BECAUSE THIS, THIS
COMMITTEE COUPLE A COUPLE
MONTHS, A COUPLE MONTHS AGO, WE
HEARD REGARDING THE DIFFICULTY
OF COLLECTING DATA FROM A BILL
THAT CAME OUT IN LIKE 2020,
2021, SENATOR WIENER'S BILL. AND
IT TOOK US SUCH A LONG TIME TO
FIGURE OUT, TO FIND OUT THAT THE
DATA WASN'T BEING COLLECTED. WE
HAD APPROPRIATED FUNDS FOR THAT.
WE WERE THEN TOLD THAT
APPROXIMATELY 7 TO 9 FORMS OUT
OF THE 200 AND SOMETHING FORMS
WERE THE ONLY ONES COLLECTING
THIS DATA. DUE TO PRIVACY
ISSUES, WE NOW HAVE AB 1163 THAT
IS VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT THAT
BILL WAS LOOKING TO DO.
COLLECTING ALL THIS DATA. I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL THESE
ALLOCATION OF FUNDS, BECAUSE
IT'S NOT JUST YOUR TWO
DEPARTMENTS. I THINK TWO OTHER
DEPARTMENTS ARE GETTING FUNDING
JUST FOR THIS BILL. WHAT I DON'T
WANT IS THAT WE ALLOCATE THE
FUNDING. YOU COME TO US NEXT
YEAR OR TWO YEARS AND SAY WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO COLLECT THIS
DATA BECAUSE OF PRIVACY ISSUES.
SO THAT'S JUST FORMING THIS
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIRPERSON RITA NGUYEN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. I'M THE ASSISTANT HEALTH
OFFICER. I'M HAPPY TO JUMP IN TO
ADDRESS YOUR CONCERNS HEAD ON,
AND THANK YOU FOR THAT FEEDBACK
FROM THE LAST HEARING. WE REALLY
WELCOME THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
ENGAGE WITH YOU FURTHER ON THOSE
CONCERNS, WE HAVE REACHED OUT TO
THE LGBT LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS TO
HAVE MORE IN DEPTH REGULAR
CONVERSATIONS. SO ONE POINT OF
CLARITY. I JUST WANT TO REALLY
EMPHASIZE IS THAT SOMETIMES THE
PHRASING OF PRIVACY CONCERNS IS
USED AS A SHORTHAND TO REALLY,
CAPTURE ALL THE COMPLEXITY
RELATED TO COLLECTING,
ANALYZING, AND DISPLAYING SOGI
DATA. BUT TO BE VERY DIRECT AND
CLEAR, THE CHALLENGES WITH
SHARING SOGI DATA, COLLECTING
AND SHARING IS PRIMARILY DRIVEN
BY, THE LACK OF DATA COMING TO
US. SO TO YOUR POINT, WE'LL
FOLLOW UP WITH THIS IN NUMBERS
AS WELL. BUT OF THE FORMS THAT
WE DID EVALUATE AT OUR
DEPARTMENT, 65 OF THEM WERE
ALREADY COLLECTING SOGI DATA.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE REASONS
WHY WE AREN'T ABLE TO GET THE
FORMS. SO ABOUT 50% OF OUR
FORMS, ARE ACTUALLY FROM THIRD
PARTY FORMS THAT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE NO CONTROL OVER. IF YOU ADD
THAT WITH THE FEDERAL FORMS,
THAT'S CLOSER TO 60% OF OUR
FORMS. ARE ACTUALLY EITHER FROM
THE FEDS OR FROM OTHER SOME
OTHER THIRD PARTY ENTITY THAT WE
DON'T HAVE CONTROL OVER HOW THEY
COLLECT THEIR SOGI DATA. AND SO
ACTUALLY, PER THE STATUTE, AB
959, THE ORIGINAL BILL THAT YOU
REFERENCED, THOSE ARE ACTUALLY
EXEMPT FOR THAT REASON BECAUSE
WE CAN'T CONTROL IT. AND SO
AGAIN, I'M HAPPY TO DIVE IN
FURTHER, AT THE LGBT CAUCUS
MEETINGS, I RECOGNIZE THAT
TODAY'S HEARING IS FOCUSED ON
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR 1163.
HAPPY TO DISCUSS THAT, THERE SO
THAT YOU MAY FOCUS YOUR TIME,
BUT JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT
IT'S NOT PRIVACY THAT THE STATE
AND LOCAL LAWS AROUND PRIVACY
AREN'T PARTICULARLY UNIQUE TO
SOGI, FOR THE MOST PART. AND
AGAIN, IT'S DUE TO THE LIMITED
DATA WE CAN COLLECT, AND THERE'S
GREAT RISK OF US THEN ANALYZING
DATA ON SUCH A LIMITED SCALE AND
MAKING POLICY AND PROGRAM
DECISIONS ON POOR DATA. AND WE
HAVE FOUND THAT TO BE THE CASE,
SO I APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE I
THINK WE FOR A LONG TIME WE WERE
JUST BEING TOLD PRIVACY ISSUES.
YEAH. FURTHER EXPLANATION DOES
HELP. I THINK. I THINK PART OF
THE PROBLEM IS THE SHORTHAND TO
EXPLAIN THE COMPLEXITY OF IT.
BUT, BUT AGAIN, HAPPY TO EXPLAIN
THAT FURTHER. SO HOW DO HOW DO
SOME OF THOSE BARRIERS, HOW ARE
THOSE GOING TO ARE THOSE GOING
TO BLEED INTO THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIS BILL. SO THE CHALLENGES
WITH OUR INABILITY TO CONTROL
FORMS THAT ARE NOT OURS WILL
CONTINUE TO BE A PROBLEM. WHAT
WE'VE EVEN SEEN WHEN IT COMES TO
RACE AND ETHNICITY DATA. SO
THERE'S, A LOT OF EXISTING RULES
AND LAWS THAT MANDATE THE
REPORTING OF RACE AND ETHNICITY
DATA, FOR EXAMPLE. BUT WE STILL
IN SOME CASES, RANGING FROM STDS
TO HEP C, ARE ONLY REALLY ABLE
TO REPORT RACE AND ETHNICITY.
AND, SOMEWHERE BETWEEN 80 TO 70%
OF THE TIME, SO THE SHORT ANSWER
IS YES, IN THE DOMAINS THAT WE
CAN'T CONTROL, THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO BE A PROBLEM IN
TERMS OF THE DATA THAT WE DO
RECEIVE. OKAY ARE WE ADJUSTING
ARE TWO THINGS. ARE WE ADJUSTING
BOTH OUR EXPECTATIONS TO MEET
THOSE TO MEET THAT FRAMEWORK?
AND TWO, ARE WE ADJUSTING ALSO,
THE REQUEST FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS KNOWING THAT PERHAPS
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
COLLECT THE DATA FROM EVERY
SINGLE ENTITY FORM AND SO FORTH.
SO C  OF THE FORMS WE HAVE, I'M
TRYING TO I DON'T HAVE THE EXACT
NUMBERS IN FRONT OF ME. THE
THERE'S A SMALLER SUBSET THAT WE
DO CONTROL. ACTUALLY 21 OF THEM
DO HAVE THIS IN FRONT OF ME. 21
ARE FORMS THAT WE CAN CONTROL.
AND SO IT WILL BE EASIER FOR US
TO, PURSUE THE SYSTEMS CHANGES,
WHICH IS WHAT THE CCP IS ABOUT,
IS FIXING NOT JUST THE FORMS,
BUT THE SYSTEM. MORE IDEALLY, WE
HAVE SEAMLESS INTEGRATED DATA
SYSTEMS THAT CAN ACTUALLY ENABLE
US TO BE AGILE AND REALLY ADAPT
AS WE CHANGE THE WAYS THAT WE
COLLECT ANY NUMBER OF DATA
RELATED TO SOGI OR RELATED TO
OTHER DEMOGRAPHICS LIKE RACE AND
ETHNICITY AND DISAGGREGATION,
BUT YES, WE ARE WELL POSITIONED
TO AT LEAST CHANGE THE THINGS
WITHIN OUR CONTROL AND THE
SYSTEMS THAT ARE WITHIN OUR
CONTROL WITH THIS CCP. OKAY DO
WE NEED TO DO ANY SYSTEM CHANGES
FOR THE PREVIOUS DATA COLLECTION
? HI, MADAM CHAIR ROMEO AMIN,
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
THE CENTER FOR HEALTH STATISTICS
AND INFORMATICS, YES, WE DID SO
WE DID MAKE THOSE CHANGES. AND
WE ARE WE DO HAVE THE ANALYSIS
OF THESE FORMS AND ARE LOOKING
TO MAKE THOSE CHANGES WITH THIS,
BILL THAT'S COMING. OKAY. SO
THOSE DATA CHANGES, THOSE SYSTEM
CHANGES WE MADE STILL DOESN'T
MEET THE NEEDS TO MEET THIS BILL
IN SOME AREAS. CORRECT GOT IT.
OKAY. AND ARE OUR EXPECTATIONS
ARE WE CAN CONTROL 21 FORMS AT
LEAST FROM YOUR DEPARTMENT. SO
AS WE LATER ON COME BACK AND
LOOK AT THIS DATA, WE SHOULD
HAVE SOME WE SHOULD HAVE A GOOD
UNDERSTANDING. WE SHOULD HAVE
GOOD DATA AT LEAST FROM 21
FORMS. THE CHALLENGE VOLUNTEER.
RIGHT. SO IT'S BASED OFF OF
SELF-IDENTIFICATION. AND THEN
THE TRAINING AND THE ENVIRONMENT
IN WHICH IT'S ASKED WILL THEN
INFLUENCE WHETHER OR NOT
INDIVIDUALS ARE WANTING TO
VOLUNTEER THAT INFORMATION. AND
YOU KNOW, WE'RE VERY THOUGHTFUL
AND PURPOSEFUL ABOUT THE WAY
THAT WE COLLECT, ANALYZE AND
DISPLAY DATA AS NOT TO LEAVE
PEOPLE TO MAKE ERRONEOUS
CONCLUSIONS BASED ON LIMITED
DATA. SO, I WILL PREFACE IT WITH
, WE CAN'T CONTROL HOW MUCH DATA
WE WILL GET TO THEN BE ABLE TO
DISPLAY AND HAVE POLICYMAKERS
MAKE SOUND DECISIONS OFF OF
THAT. BUT THIS IS SORT OF THE
ARC OF PROGRESS FOR SOGI, EQUITY
AND JUSTICE IS THAT WE ARE
SLOWLY IMPROVING OUR SYSTEMS TO
GET TO A PLACE WHERE WE CAN
COLLECT IT. AND WITH TIME AND
WITH EFFORT AND EDUCATION OF
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS AND OF
COMMUNITY MEMBERS OF HOW DO WE
ASK THESE QUESTIONS IN TRAUMA
INFORMED WAYS WILL THEN GET US
TO A PLACE WHERE WE WILL HAVE
BETTER DATA. IS ALWAYS THE HOPE
THAT WE HAVE TO START SOMEWHERE,
OKAY. AND THEN I SEE I'M JUST
READING YOUR PCP FURTHER. OKAY,
OKAY. LINDY HARRINGTON,
ASSISTANT STATE MEDICAID
DIRECTOR, SIMILAR TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH, OUR
CONCERN IS NOT AROUND PRIVACY,
BUT WE DO CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONCERNS AROUND THE FEDERAL
PERMISSIBILITY OF THIS ADDITION,
AS FEDERAL RULES REQUIRE THAT
THE APPLICATION BE STREAMED,
SIGNED, AND ONLY INCLUDE
QUESTIONS NECESSARY TO DETERMINE
PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY. TODAY, DCS
ALREADY COLLECTS A LIMITED SET
OF OPTIONAL GENDER IDENTITY AND
SEXUAL ORIENTATION RESPONSES
APPROVED PREVIOUSLY BY THE
CENTERS FOR MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID SERVICES ON THE
MEDI-CAL APPLICATION AND THE
ENACTMENT OF THIS BILL WILL ADD
INTERSEXUALITY TO THE MEDI-CAL
APPLICATION, WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
US TO GO BACK TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, FOR REVIEW AND
APPROVAL TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE TO
FEDERAL MEDICAID LAW, THE ADDING
THOSE ADDITIONAL GENDER IDENTITY
CATEGORIES BEYOND THE MINIMUM
APPROVED BY CMS COULD LEAD TO AN
APPLICATION THAT IS CONSIDERED
NO LONGER STREAMLINED, WHICH
WOULD THEN JEOPARDIZE FEDERAL
FUNDING IF WE WERE TO ADD THOSE
TO OUR APPLICATION, SO WE WILL
NEED TO WE WILL ALSO NEED TO
SEEK FEDERAL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AS IT RELATES TO
COLLECTING, INTERSEXUALITY DATA,
STORING AND EXCHANGING THAT
HEALTH CARE DATA, BECAUSE THE
CURRENT CATEGORIES DO NOT ALIGN
WITH GENDER IDENTITY, SUB
CATEGORIES IN THE UNITED STATES,
CORE DATA FOR INTEROPERABLE
ABILITY CODE SET, WHICH IS THE
PRIMARY FEDERAL STANDARD FOR
STORING AND EXCHANGING HEALTH
CARE DATA. SO WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS, THAT WOULD NOT, BE
ELIMINATED WITH THIS FUNDING,
BUT THAT FUNDING IS WHAT WOULD
BE REQUIRED IN ORDER TO ADD THEM
TO THE APPLICATION. OKAY. THANK
YOU. I APPRECIATE THAT, DETAILED
INSIGHT INTO THIS. AND WE DON'T
HAVE A PCP YET FOR THIS. IS THAT
CORRECT? I BELIEVE IT IS COMING
AS PART OF A GROUP OF, ENACTED
LEGISLATION T I THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. YEAH, THAT PCP IS
PENDING AND SHOULD BE POSTED
SHORTLY. THE FUNDING. DO YOU
NEED THAT TO SO THE FUNDING IS
REQUIRED TO SUPPORT, THE TO FUND
THE SYSTEMS COSTS THROUGH CAL
SAU BENEFITS. CAL AND CAL.
HERE'S TO ADD AND COLLECT THAT
DATA AS PART OF THE MEDI-CAL
APPLICATION. AND AN IT
CONTRACTING RESOURCE WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT TO SUPPORT THAT WORK.
OKAY. AND THEN WE DON'T KNOW
WHEN THAT WORK WILL START,
BECAUSE WE STILL HAVE TO GO TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
APPROVAL AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. CORRECT. GOT IT.
OKAY AND THAT MIGHT TAKE A
WHILE. IT COULD IT COULD. OKAY.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS OKAY.
OKAY, LÀ Þ ANY WILL ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENT ON THIS, WILL
OWENS WITH THE LAO, NOTHING
FURTHER TO ADD, BUT AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT.
THOSE RESPONSES GIVE INSIGHT
.
YES. DCS.
ALL RIGHT. FIRST ISSUE MCO,
BEFORE I THINK YOU MENTIONED OR
THE GENTLEMAN THAT LEFT, ARE WE
GETTING ALL THE BCC FOR DCS ALL
AT ONCE? BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
WE HAVE A SINGLE ONE UPLOADED
YET. WE'RE GOING TO CRAM IT ALL
IN BEFORE WE VOTE. YEAH, WE'LL
GO READ IT RIGHT AFTER THIS
HEARING. BUT THEY'RE COMING.
WE'RE WORKING ON THEM. OKAY.
THEY'RE COMING SHORTLY. WE'RE
VOTING NEXT WEEK. OH, BOY. OKAY,
MCO TALKS, WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THIS LAST WEEK, THE THEME HERE
AND PULLING THINGS BACK TO
FURTHER HAVE FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS ON SOME THE
STICKIER ISSUES THAT ARE
PROPOSED IN THE MAY REVISE, I
AGAIN GOING BACK YOU KNOW, I'VE
BEEN OBVIOUSLY YOU'VE YOU'VE
SEEN YOU'VE SEEN ME UP HERE TALK
ABOUT THE MCO TAGS FOR A YEAR
AND A HALF. NOW FROM THE
EXCITEMENT, TO THE FRUSTRATION
TO THE EXCITEMENT, TO THE
FRUSTRATION, TO NOW CONFUSION,
HONESTLY, CONFUSION. BECAUSE OF
ALL THE THINGS WE TALKED ABOUT
IN THE REALM OF MCO TAX. AND
MAYBE I SHOULD ASK MY
COUNTERPART ON THE ASSEMBLY.
MAYBE THAT'S WHERE THEY TALKED
ABOUT THE CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
DIRECTED PAYMENT. JUST THIS JUST
NEVER CAME UP. IT JUST WASN'T
PART OF THE CONVERSATION THEN I
DON'T KNOW. NO, I NEVER HEARD A
SINGLE THING FROM PUBLIC COMMENT
THAT THIS WAS THE THING THAT WE
NEEDED TO DIVE INTO. SO THAT'S
WHERE I'M AT. CONFUSION AS TO
WHERE WE GOT TO THIS, YOU KNOW,
YOU, DIRECTOR, YOU KNOW, I WAS
LIKE 200 MILLION FOR ALL THESE
THINGS. THIS IS WHAT I. THIS IS
WHAT I'M. I WANT WAS A BIG FAN
OF HOSPITALS GETTING INCREASES,
PROVIDERS GETTING INCREASES.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD, OUR
REPRODUCTIVE CLINICS GETTING
INCREASES, LIKE ALL OF THOSE
WERE FOR NOMINAL INVESTMENTS.
AND THEN INCLUDING THE ONES THAT
I WANTED FROM NEW FRIENDS.
RIGHT. SO THIS IS WHERE WE'RE
AT, WHERE IF YOU COULD JUST
AGAIN WALK US THROUGH WHERE WE
GOT TO THAT POINT, WHY
EVERYTHING WAS JUST COMPLETELY
DISMANTLED, PROBABLY PROBABLY
GOING TO HEAR US BECAUSE WE NEED
TO BALANCE THE BUDGET. BUT LET'S
GET INTO IT AGAIN. SURE. SO AS
PART OF THE MAY REVISION, THE
BUDGET PROPOSES TO PRESERVE THE
TARGETED RATE INCREASES THAT
WENT INTO EFFECT JANUARY ONE,
2024. THAT IS, FOR PRIMARY CARE,
MATERNITY CARE, AND NON
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH TO 87.5%
OF MEDICARE. AND THEN IT
PROPOSES AND PRESERVES ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS OF THE 200 MILLION
FOR THE DISTRESSED HOSPITAL LOAN
AND THE SMALL RURAL HOSPITAL
FUND AS WELL. PROPOSES TO
ELIMINATE THE 2025 RATE
INCREASES. WE WENT THROUGH KIND
OF THE DISCUSSION OF ALL OF
THOSE CATEGORIES AND THEN
PROPOSES TO ESSENTIALLY USE
THOSE DOLLARS AND THE REMAINING
RESERVES FROM THE MEDI-CAL
PROVIDER PAYMENT PROVIDER
RESERVE FUND TO SUPPORT THE
GENERAL FUND AS PART OF THE 2025
TERM SHEET OR THE 2025 RATE
INCREASES, THERE WERE
INVESTMENTS FOR OUR HOSPITALS IN
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS WERE PART
OF THE OUTPATIENT AND COMMUNITY,
COMMUNITY PROCEDURES AND ALSO
THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT BUCKETS
AS WELL. BUT AS PART OF MAY
REVISION, PROPOSING 115 MILLION
DIRECTED PAYMENT FUNDED BY THE
MANAGED CARE TAX FOR CHILDREN'S
HOSPITALS, RECOGNIZING THAT THEY
PROVIDE HIGHLY SPECIALIZED, HIGH
ACUITY CARE TO THE VULNERABLE
CHILDREN IN THE STATE AND
RECOGNIZING KIND OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED TO SUPPORT
THAT HIGH ACUITY IS EXCEPTIONAL.
IT'S ABOVE KIND OF THE NORMAL,
COST OF THE WAY OUR RATES ARE
FUNDED. SO PROPOSING TO DO A
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT FOR OUR
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL, IT'S A
DIRECTED PAYMENT THROUGH OUR
MANAGED CARE PLANS FOR THESE
HOSPITALS. WHICH PROVIDERS WOULD
GET THE INCREASES? THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS? NO. WHICH
IS IT? ALL YES, AND IT WOULD BE
BASED ON UTILIZATION. SO THAT'S
HOW THE DIRECTED PAYMENT PROGRAM
WOULD WORK. OKAY, THIS IS FIRST
TIME I'M HEARING THIS PHRASE.
COULD YOU JUST WALK ME THROUGH
LIKE WHAT? THE DIRECTED PAYMENT.
WHAT IS THAT. SURE. SO IT'S KIND
OF A TERM OF ART, UNDER FEDERAL
REGULATION, WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
DIRECT MANAGED CARE PLANS
PAYMENTS UNDER A SET OF SPECIFIC
EXEMPTIONS, AND ONE OF THOSE IS
TO DO A DIRECTED PAYMENT TO, A
SET OF PROVIDERS WITH CERTAIN
CRITERIA. AND SO WE, WE JUST
SPEAK ABOUT THOSE AS DIRECTED
PAYMENTS BECAUSE THAT'S KIND OF
HOW THEY'RE, THEY'RE LISTED IN
THE FEDERAL REG, SO WE HAVE A
SET OF THOSE. SO IF YOU THINK
ABOUT, IF YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH
LIKE THE ENHANCED PAYMENT
PROGRAM FOR DESIGNATED PUBLIC
HOSPITALS OR THE QUALITY AND
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM OR INCENTIVE
PROGRAM FOR PUBLIC HOSPITALS,
THE PRIVATE HOSPITAL DIRECTED
PAYMENT PROGRAM UNDER THOSE ARE
ALL VARIOUS DIRECTED PAYMENTS
THAT WE DO, WHICH ARE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS TO
HOSPITALS UNDER THE MANAGED CARE
PROGRAM. SO THIS WOULD BE
CREATING ONE FOR THE CHILDREN'S
HOSPITALS. OKAY. SENATOR ROTH, I
SHOULD KNOW THIS, BUT I DON'T.
IF I KNEW IT, I DON'T REMEMBER
IT. DO OUR CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS
EMPLOY PHYSICIANS OR ARE THOSE
IS IT LIKE A NORMAL HOSPITAL
WHERE THEIR PRACTICE GROUPS
CONTRACT? I BELIEVE THEY DO NOT.
IT'S LIKE A NORMAL HOSPITAL.
THEY'RE LIKE NORMAL. AND SO IS
THE MONEY THIS MONEY THE UNDER.
I GUESS THERE'S 115 MILLION IN
FEDERAL FUNDS, BUT THE OTHER 115
MILLION. WHAT'S IT GO TO DO WITH
THE HOSPITAL? IS IT IS IT PAYING
THE HOSPITAL FOR INPATIENT
SERVICES, OR IS IT GOING TO PAY
PROVIDERS, THE SPECIALTY
PEDIATRICIANS THAT ARE PROVIDING
SERVICES IN THE HOSPITALS? THESE
DOLLARS GO TO SUPPORT THE
HOSPITAL, THE FACILITY ITSELF.
SO IT'S THE INFRASTRUCTURE, THE
BUILDING, THE TOOLS, THE
TECHNOLOGY EQUIPMENT. EXACTLY.
NOT THE PAYMENT TO THE
SPECIALTY. EXACTLY OKAY. AND THE
CONVERSATIONS WHERE WE TALKED
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THE MCO TO
INCREASE RATES, YOU KNOW, GET AS
CLOSE AS POSSIBLE TO MEDICARE
AND SO FORTH. WAS THIS THE AREA
THAT MOST, MOST NEEDED A JOLT UP
AND RATE INCREASES? AND
REIMBURSEMENT RATE INCREASES? I
WOULD SAY OUR COMMUNITY
OUTPATIENT RATES ARE PRETTY LOW
WITH REGARD TO THE OUTPATIENT
PROCEDURES ARE PRETTY LOW
COMPARED TO WHERE WE WERE AT
WITH MEDICARE, IN TERMS OF THE
BUCKETS OF DOLLARS, IT WAS ONE
OF THE LOWEST AREAS CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL OR COMMUNITY
OUTPATIENT. SO JUST THAT'S JUST
A HOSPITAL LINE ITEM THAT WAS IN
THE PREVIOUS TERM SHEET. OKAY.
SO WHY THEN I GUESS THE FOCUS
THEN ON THIS IN SPECIFIC. SO
JUST AGAIN RECOGNIZING THAT KIND
OF THEIR EXCEPTIONAL KIND OF,
YOU KNOW, OUTLIER COSTS FOR
CARING FOR SOME OF THE SICKEST
AND MOST VULNERABLE, TO BE ABLE
TO MAINTAIN THAT NETWORK AND
THAT POSSIBILITY IN THE STATE
FOR HOSPITALS TO MAINTAIN THE
ABILITY TO SERVE CHILDREN WITH
REALLY HIGH NEEDS, HIGH ACUITY.
OKAY. WE DIDN'T HEAR. WE DIDN'T
HEAR A LOT OF IT THROUGHOUT THIS
TIME. BUT THE HIGH THE HIGH COST
OF ASSOCIATE THAT'S ASSOCIATED
WITH THE CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IS
THE COST ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CAPITAL FACILITY ITSELF. AND NOT
THE COST OF SOMEBODY PAYING
PEDIATRIC SPECIALTY PHYSICIANS
AND SOMEBODY PAYING THE HIGHLY
SKILLED PEDIATRIC NURSING STAFF
FOR ALL THE OTHER ALLIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH THE COMPLICATED, NEEDS OF
THIS PARTICULAR POPULATION. SO
IT'S THE CAPITAL FACILITY WHERE
WE'RE PUTTING OUR MONEY. I WOULD
SAY IT'S PROBABLY A COMBINATION
OF BOTH, BUT THIS PROPOSAL IS
RELATED TO THE FACILITY. THE
FACILITY COST AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. HOW MANY
PROVIDER CODES ARE WE INCREASING
WITH THIS PROPOSED? I, I DON'T
HAVE THAT. WE WOULD BE LOOKING,
TO ESTABLISH AGAIN SOME
ADDITIONAL DETAILS TO WORK OUT
WITH WITH OUR VARIOUS PUBLIC,
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL PARTNERS,
BUT IT WOULD BE MORE SPECIFIC
TO, LIKE, PER VISIT, INCREASES
THAT WE WOULD BE PROVIDING, SO
IT WOULDN'T NECESSARILY I DON'T
HAVE THE NUMBER OF SPECIFIC
CODES THAT WOULD BE UNDER THAT
UTILIZATION. OKAY AND. I CAN'T
REMEMBER IF I ASKED THIS
QUESTION. IN TRYING TO SEE HOW I
KNOW THIS IS PART OF THE
ORIGINAL, SHEET, THERE WERE
GOING TO BE THERE EMBEDDED
BECAUSE THEY HAD THE ERS. AND SO
FORTH, HOW WE'RE LOOKING TO
BALANCE SUPPORTING RURAL
HOSPITALS AND HELPING BRING
ACCESS TO AREAS THAT DON'T HAVE
ACCESS. IS THIS FUNDING GOING TO
BE ALLOCATED IN A WAY THAT IS
DEPENDENT ON WHERE EACH HOSPITAL
IS LIKE GEOGRAPHICALLY? SO I
THINK THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
DETAILS THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE WITH THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS TO FINALIZE
THAT, THAT DISTRIBUTION
METHODOLOGY. BUT IT WOULD GO TO
ALL OF THE HOSPITALS BASED ON
UTILIZATION AND OTHER FACTORS
COULD BE TAKEN IN. I MEAN, ARE
WE I MEAN, WE'RE WE'RE TRIAGING
EVERYTHING, RIGHT? AND WE'RE
ALWAYS HEARING ANOTHER FOR,
WHERE ARE THEY CALLED? MATERNITY
WARDS. YEAH, RIGHT. MATERNITY
WARDS, LABOR AND DELIVERY. YEAH.
LABOR AND DELIVERY. CONTINUE TO
CLOSE. ANOTHER ONE, ANOTHER ONE
CLOSING, ANOTHER ONE CLOSING.
AND WE'RE SEEING HOSPITALS FALL
UNDER MORE AND MORE AND MORE,
YOU KNOW, WE'RE OPENING OUR
DOORS TO SO MANY AS WE SHOULD TO
SO MANY PEOPLE COMING FROM OTHER
STATES FOR REPRODUCTIVE CARE.
AND HERE IN CALIFORNIA, WHERE
THE NEED IS GOING TO BE GREATER
AND GREATER, YOU JUST HEARD THAT
THE HIS PROPOSED OR DEPARTMENTS
DEPARTMENT FINANCE IS PROPOSING
CUTTING SLOTS FOR RESIDENTS AND
SO FORTH, IF WE KEEP ADDING ALL
OF IT UP, WE'RE GOING TO BE
DEEPER AND DEEPER IN THE HOLE.
THIS IS SO SPECIFIC TO ONE THING
THAT I'M HAVING TROUBLE
UNDERSTANDING HOW THIS IS REALLY
GOING TO MEET THE EQUITY. THIS
IS ME SAYING, I MEAN, I'M ALWAYS
HERE TALKING ABOUT DEFENDING OUR
CHILDREN AND KIDS, RIGHT? I'M
ALWAYS AT THE FRONT LINE OF
THAT. BUT IN THIS SPECIFIC, I
DON'T THINK WE'RE MEETING THE
PART OF THE GOAL OF THE MCO TAX
ON MEETING THE EQUITY OR
REACHING EQUITY, I'M REALLY
INTERESTED IN HAVING KIDS IN
RURAL AREAS, HAVING PLACES TO
GO, PREGNANT PEOPLE IN RURAL
AREAS, HAVING PLACES TO GO,
PEOPLE FROM EVERYWHERE, HAVING
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND
INCREASING THAT, I DON'T I DON'T
KNOW IF I'VE GOTTEN TO A POINT
WHERE THIS MAKES SENSE TO ME,
WHERE THIS AREA, FOR WHAT WE'RE
ALLOCATING OF THE MCO TAX AFTER
IT WAS PROPOSED TO BE COMPLETELY
DISMANTLED, MAKES SENSE, I WOULD
ALSO POINT TO ONE OF THE OTHER,
ACTIVE CITIES THAT ARE THAT WE
HAVE PROPOSED AS PART OF MAY
REVISION IS REMIND ME OF THAT.
ONE IS AN INCREASE TO OUR PUBLIC
HOSPITALS, INCLUDING IN OUR
DISTRICT AND MUNICIPAL PUBLIC
HOSPITALS, WHICH WOULD ALLOW
INCREASES TO PROGRAMS WHERE THEY
PROVIDE AN INTERGOVERNMENTAL
TRANSFER. SO THEY PROVIDE THE
NONFEDERAL SHARE, WHICH WE THEN
MATCH WITH FEDERAL DOLLARS AND
INCREASE PAYMENTS UNDER THOSE
OTHER DIRECTED PAYMENTS. I WAS
TALKING ABOUT, INCREASE PAYMENTS
TO THOSE HOSPITALS, TO, TO HELP
WITH BRINGING IN ADDITIONAL
REVENUE AND FUNDING TO THOSE
HOSPITALS. PUBLIC HOSPITALS WERE
HERE LAST WEEK AND COMMENTING
THAT, YOU KNOW, THEY WERE TAKEN
OUT OF THE MCO TAX. SO THEY ARE
GETTING SOME SUPPORT. SO IT'S
NOT AS IT'S NOT THROUGH THE MCO
TAX, BUT IT'S UTILIZING,
FINANCING MECHANISMS THAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE FOR THOSE PUBLIC
HOSPITALS WHERE THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE FUNDING TO US
THAT WE CAN THEN MATCH WITH
FEDERAL MONEY TO BRING IN
ADDITIONAL REVENUE TO THE
SYSTEM. SO BASICALLY BRINGING IN
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL REVENUE TO
THE SYSTEM. SO WE'D BE
INCREASING THOSE PROGRAMS
RAIMES, ABOVE THE BASELINE THAT
WE HAVE IN ORDER TO BRING IN
ADDITIONAL REVENUE THAT DOES NOT
REQUIRE THE MCO TAX. SO BY THE
WAY, IS THIS, IS THIS ONGOING
FUNDING FOR THE CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL? YES, IT IS TO BE
ONGOING. YOU KNOW, I WE HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF, A YEAR. WE HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF, OF CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL BEDS. I MEAN, WE DON'T
HAVE ANY PEDIATRIC BEDS FOR THE
MOST PART, IN ANY OF OUR ACUTE
CARE GENERAL HOSPITAL HOSPITALS
FOR FINANCIAL REASONS, DECISIONS
THAT THOSE HOSPITALS AND THE
HOSPITAL ADMINISTRATORS MAKE. SO
IT IS IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN OUR
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS. I'M JUST,
AND WITHOUT KNOWING WHERE THE
MONEY IS GOING TO GO ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS, I'M JUST WONDERING
WHAT I ALSO KNOW HAVING JUST HAD
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT MEDICAL
RESIDENCIES, IS THERE IS THERE
IS A DIRE SHORTAGE OF SPECIALTY
PEDIATRICIANS OF ALL KINDS UP
AND DOWN THE STATE. AND I'M JUST
WONDERING, IN SOME COORDINATED
WAY WITH THE CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
FOLKS IF THEY COULD HELP YOU,
HELP US FIGURE OUT WHAT'S THE
BEST MIX OF THE USE OF THIS
MONEY, BECAUSE IT'S ONE THING TO
KEEP A FACILITY AND HAVE IT TO
BE A GREAT FACILITY, BUT NOT
HAVE ENOUGH SPECIALTY
PEDIATRICIANS TO STAFF IT, SO
THAT'S JUST MY COMMENT ON IT.
SORT OF HARD FOR ME TO TELL
SENATOR HICKMAN. YEAH, I WOULD
JUST ALONG THE SAME LINES, LIKE,
I DON'T KNOW THAT I'M EVEN SURE
HOW MANY HOW MANY CHILDREN'S
HOSPITALS ARE THERE IN
CALIFORNIA? I BELIEVE THERE ARE
TEN. AND THE MONEY IS GOING TO
BE EQUALLY DISTRIBUTED BETWEEN
ALL OF THEM WILL BE BASED ON
UTILIZATION AS WELL, MEDI-CAL
LIVES, MEDI-CAL UTILIZATION.
OKAY. IT IT FEELS LIKE THIS HAS
BEEN DROPPED ON US OUT OF THE
BLUE. IT HASN'T BEEN PART OF OUR
DIALOGS AND CONVERSATION. I JUST
I MEAN, I LOVE KIDS, I HAVE A
KID, BUT I DON'T KNOW HOW IT IT
GETS ELEVATED TO 100 MILLION
ONGOING EVERY YEAR OUT OF THIS
WHEN WE'RE I MEAN, I THINK YOU
WERE HERE FOR PART OF THIS
MORNING WHEN THE CUTS ARE UGLY,
AFFECTS PEOPLE'S LIVES. CHILD
CARE. I MEAN, REAL STUFF. SO I
DON'T LIKE IT. LARA DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I JUST WANTED TO FLAG
THAT THE MIC THE MAY REVISION
DOES MAINTAIN THE 300 MILLION
FOR GENERAL HOSPITALS FOR, A
DISTRESSED HOSPITAL LOAN PROGRAM
. YEAH, IN THE CURRENT YEAR. SO
THAT HAS ALMOST ALL BEEN, SPENT.
AND THEN GOING BACK TO ALSO
PROVIDERS, GENERAL MEDI-CAL
PROVIDERS, WE SEE. YES, THE
INVESTMENT FOR THE CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL IS 115 MILLION MCO TAX,
BUT WE STILL HAVE THE PROP 56
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS TO
PHYSICIANS AND OTHER PROVIDERS,
WHICH IS A BILLION IN CURRENT
YEAR AND 800 MILLION. WE'RE
OFFSETTING SOME OF THOSE FUNDS
WITH MCO TAX. RIGHT. THAT'S
CORRECT. YES, BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
FUNDING, WE'RE BACKFILLING AND
WE'RE OFFSETTING THE LACK OF
FUND. YEAH, YEAH. WE'RE
MAINTAINING PROP 56 SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS. SO YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW
THAT'S LIKE A SLAP IN THE FACE
FOR AT LEAST PHYSICIANS. RIGHT.
THE PROP $56 IS THERE TO
INCREASE RATES. AND WHEN IT DIPS
INSTEAD OF GETTING MORE FROM THE
MCO TAX, WE'RE GOING TO PULL IT
INTO OFFSETTING THE LACK OF
FUNDS. AND PROP 56 JUST SEEMS
LIKE A STAB. STAB. YEAH. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I REMEMBER
NOTING WHEN I SPOKE TO A I DON'T
KNOW, THERE WERE 150 OR 200
PEDIATRICIANS THE OTHER DAY UP
HERE. WAS THAT THE SPECIAL? AS I
RECALL NOW, THE SPECIALTY PTA,
PEDIATRICIAN, REIMBURSEMENT
RATES AND RESULTING INCOME, IS
LESS THAN WHAT THE PEDIATRICIAN
THÀNH IN NORMAL NON SPECIALTY
PEDIATRICIAN MAKES IN PRACTICE,
I DON'T KNOW, YOU ALL WOULD KNOW
THE RATES BETTER THAN I, BUT IF
THAT'S THE CASE THEN, YOU KNOW,
MAYBE THAT REQUIRES A LITTLE
ATTENTION TOO, BECAUSE WE
CLEARLY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH OF
THEM. WE FIND SPECIALISTS TO
ACTUALLY BE PAID HIGHER THAN,
THAN GENERAL. AND IN THE 87.5,
INCREASE THAT WE ARE MAINTAINING
, WHILE IT IS FOCUSED ON PRIMARY
CARE, SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
AND MATERNITY CARE, THOSE CODES
THAT CAN BE ALSO BILLED BY
SPECIALISTS, THE SPECIALISTS ARE
GETTING THAT 87.5% FOR THOSE
CODES AS WELL. WE, THEY IT WAS
IT WOULD JUST BE THE ADDITIONAL,
SPECIALTY SPECIFIC CODE. SO
SPECIALIST ARE ABLE TO RECEIVE
FOR THINGS LIKE THEIR ENM VISITS
AND THOSE. SO WHEN THEY'RE
BILLING THOSE CODES, THEY WILL
BE GETTING THE 87.5. IT'S NOT
ONLY, PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS. SO
FOR THAT FOR THAT LIST OF CODES
THAT WENT LIVE WITH ON JANUARY
1ST, 2020 FOR, SPECIALTY
PROVIDERS THAT ALSO BILL THOSE
CODES ARE RECEIVING THAT
INCREASE. SO I DO I DO JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE FOLKS ARE TRACKING
THAT AS WELL AND WILL PERHAPS I
WAS WRONG IN MY READING ON THE
SPECIALTY PEDIATRICIANS, BUT THE
115 MILLION OR THE WHATEVER IT
IS, 230 MILLION, IS THAT CAPABLE
OF BEING UTILIZED TO BACKFILL
HOSPITALS FOR REIMBURSEMENT RATE
DEFICIENCIES FOR INPATIENT CARE?
SO WE WILL BE LOOKING TO DO, IT
WILL LIKELY BE A DIRECTED
PAYMENT THAT WILL BE ACROSS
THEIR INPATIENT AND OUTPATIENT
SERVICES. Þ. SO YOU'LL TELL THEM
HOW TO USE THE MONEY. CORRECT?
WE WILL WE WILL STOP. WE WON'T
TELL THEM HOW TO USE THE MONEY.
WE WILL. THAT IS HOW WE WILL SET
THE REIMBURSEMENT STRUCTURE WILL
BE ACROSS FOR BOTH INPATIENT AND
OUTPATIENT. THE 115 WILL GO TO
BOTH INPATIENT AND OUTPATIENT.
IT GOES DIRECTLY. IT WILL GO
THROUGH THE MANAGED CARE PLANS
TO THE HOSPITALS. BUT WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DIRECT THE
MANAGED CARE PLANS, HOW THEY PAY
THE HOSPITALS UTILIZING THOSE
FUNDS. AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
SPECIALTIES UNDER BEING A DIRECT
PAYMENT, RIGHT? CORRECT. BECAUSE
YOU'RE ABLE TO DIRECTLY SAY THAT
. SO, DIRECTOR, YOU KNOW, BOTTOM
LINE IS LIKE THIS WAS LIKE A
CURVE BALL FOR US. THIS JUST
CAME OUT OF LEFT FIELD. AND I
LITERALLY WAS GOING TO SAY WHAT
SENATOR EGGMAN SAID IN THE PAST
YEAR AND A HALF. EVEN MORE SO IN
THE PAST SIX, FIVE MONTHS, FIVE
MONTHS, WE'VE HAD VARIOUS
CONVERSATIONS, GREAT PANELS ON
THIS. AND IT'S OUT OF ALL THAT,
THIS WAS A TAKEAWAY FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION, I THINK THAT'S
WHERE WE FEEL LIKE WE, YOU KNOW,
WE PUT SO MUCH ENERGY INTO
DISCUSSING BRINGING THE NEEDS OF
WHAT WE THOUGHT WAS A REALLY
ROBUST COALITION, BOTH ON THOSE
WERE ALREADY INCLUDED VERSUS WHO
WANTED JUST FEEL LIKE NOTHING
CAME ACROSS IN APPEARS. AND A
WHOLE OTHER THING WAS PROPOSED
TO US. SO THAT'S THE SENTIMENT I
THINK WE'RE WE'RE FEELING HERE,
LÀ Ó ANY ADDITIONAL JASON, ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS? CAN YOU
HEAR ME? GREAT, JASON SEYARTO
CEO, SO JUST AS A REMINDER, YOU
HAVE TWO SOLUTIONS IN THIS
ISSUE. YOU HAVE THE THEIR
INCREASE IN THE TAX AND THEN
THE, PULLING BACK OF THE OF THE
PREVIOUS PACKAGE FOR THE TAX
INCREASE. YOU KNOW, OUR MESSAGE
IS SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU'VE HEARD
US SAY IN THE PAST. YOU KNOW, IN
CONCEPT IT'S REASONABLE. THERE
IS STILL SOME INFORMATION THAT
THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS, INCLUDING
THE PROPOSED TRAILER BILL, BUT
ALSO THE WHAT THE TAX RATES
WOULD BE. AND ADDITIONAL
ANALYSIS FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
DEMONSTRATING THAT INCREASE IN
TAX WOULD MEET FEDERAL RULES.
THE ADMINISTRATION INDICATES
THAT IT IS INTENDING TO GET THAT
PART OF IT PASSED AND TIME TO
SUBMIT TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SO IT COULD START IN APRIL. SO
THAT'S ALL THE MORE REASON WHY
THIS INFORMATION WOULD BE GOOD
TO HAVE SOON, SO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN FULLY ASSESS
THAT PART OF IT IN TERMS OF THE
OF THE SECOND PART OF THE
SOLUTION, WHICH IS THE, YOU
KNOW, PULLING BACK THE MCO TAX
PACKAGE, YOU KNOW, GENERALLY,
YOU KNOW, WE THINK IT'S, IT'S A
REASONABLE PLACE TO LOOK AT, YOU
KNOW, GIVEN THAT THE PACKAGE
THAT WAS ENACTED IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET AT THE TIME THAT WAS
ENACTED, IT WAS NOT, YOU KNOW,
THE MAGNITUDE OF THE BUDGET
PROBLEM WAS NOT FULLY KNOWN TO
THE LEGISLATURE AT THE TIME. AND
THAT SAID, WE ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS AN
INTEREST IN THIS AREA, YOU KNOW,
GENERALLY, YOU KNOW, MEDI-CAL
BENEFICIARIES DO FACE, A GREATER
BARRIERS FACING ACCESS AND,
QUALITY IN HEALTH CARE, RELATIVE
TO THE GENERAL POPULATION. AND
RATE INCREASES GENERALLY ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH IMPROVEMENTS TO
ACCESS TO CARE. SO IT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE STILL WANT TO PURSUE
CERTAIN AUGMENTATIONS HERE. IF
THAT IS THE CASE, WE RECOMMEND
KEEPING A COUPLE OF PRINCIPLES
IN MIND. FIRST, WE RECOMMEND
FOCUSING ON ON, YOU KNOW,
AUGMENTATIONS THAT ARE
RELATIVELY SIMPLE THAT THAT
EXPAND EXISTING PROGRAMS OR, YOU
KNOW, WHERE THE EFFECTS ARE
RELATIVELY KNOWN, YOU KNOW, FOR
EXAMPLE, INCREASING RATES AS A
PERCENT OF MEDICARE OR APPLYING
AN INFLATIONARY ADJUSTMENT, WE
CAUTION AGAINST TRYING TO DO
NOTABLY NEW PROGRAMS OR SORT OF
MAJOR NEW THINGS WHERE THE AND
THAT'S BECAUSE WHEN THAT WHEN
THAT HAPPENS, TYPICALLY THE
EFFECTS OF THAT ARE LESS
CERTAIN. AND IN AN ENVIRONMENT
OF CONSTRAINED BUDGETING THAT
THAT'S SORT OF A KEY ISSUE FOR
THE LEGISLATURE. WE ALSO THINK
THAT'S A GOOD WAY TO THINK ABOUT
THE PROPOSED DIRECTED PAYMENT
FOR CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS. THIS
IS A NEW PROPOSAL. WE'RE STILL
GETTING MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
IT. SO THIS IS THIS IS AN AREA
THE LEGISLATURE WOULD WANT TO
SERIOUSLY CONSIDER AS IT'S SORT
OF WEIGHING ITS FINAL PACKAGE. I
ALSO WANT TO JUST AS A TECHNICAL
POINT, THERE WAS SOME QUESTION
ABOUT WHAT IS A DIRECTED
PAYMENT. SO A DIRECTED PAYMENT
IS JUST A PAYMENT THAT'S
DIRECTED THROUGH THE MANAGED
CARE SYSTEM. NORMALLY WHEN THE
STATE INCREASES RATES, IT
INCREASES RATES FOR, FOR AND THE
FEE FOR SERVICE SYSTEM. BUT IN
THE MANAGED CARE SYSTEM THINGS
WORK A LITTLE DIFFERENTLY. AND
SO TYPICALLY THE WAY A DIRECTED
PAYMENT WOULD WORK, AS I MY
UNDERSTANDING HOW THIS MIGHT
WORK IN THIS CASE IS IT'S LIKE A
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT. IT WOULD
IT WOULD BE AN ADDITIONAL
PAYMENT BEYOND WHAT MANAGED CARE
PLANS NORMALLY PAY IN THEIR SORT
OF BASE RATES. OTHER
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT PROGRAMS
LIKE PROP 56 THERE ARE THAT ALSO
HAS A DIRECTED PAYMENT
COMPONENT. SO THAT THERE ARE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS IN THE
MANAGED CARE SYSTEM TO. AND THEN
FINALLY, WE ALSO JUST WANT TO
KEEP IN MIND THAT YOU KNOW, THAT
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
KEEP THE BUDGET PROBLEM IN MIND.
THIS IS A MAJOR PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
SOLUTION. SO THIS WOULD BE AN
AREA WHERE IF THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERS PURSUING MORE
AUGMENTATIONS THAN WHAT'S
PROPOSED, IT WOULD NECESSITATE,
A DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR REDUCTION
ELSEWHERE IN THE BUDGET. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU, WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO
TAKE MCO PUBLIC COMMENT NOW.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS, STUART
THOMPSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
WHILE WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
THIS IS A VERY TOUGH BUDGET
SITUATION, WE ARE VERY
DISAPPOINTED. AND THE MAY
REVISION TO THE MCO PROPOSAL. I
KNOW IT'S LATE, SO I'M JUST
GOING TO TOUCH UPON A FEW
HIGHLIGHTS. A FEW POINTS BROUGHT
UP DURING THIS HEARING. JUST SAY
THE AVERAGE RESIDENCY SLOT COSTS
ABOUT 150,000. THAT'S A KIND OF
ROUGH BACK OF THE KIND OF NAPKIN
MATH, BUT DEPENDS ON THE OTHER
PROGRAM AND THE REGION. AND SO
IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT JUST PROP
56 REDUCTIONS, WHICH IS 13.5
MILLION, THAT IS NOT BEING
PROPOSED TO BE BACKFILLED BY THE
MCO, JUST THE RATES ARE
PROPOSED. WE BACKFILL ON THE
PROP 56 SIDE. THAT'S ABOUT 90
SLOTS. THE 75 MILLION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED LAST YEAR
REPRESENTS ABOUT 500 NEW SLOTS.
SO THAT GIVES YOU KIND OF AN
IDEA OF THE NUMBERS AS FAR AS
KIND OF RESIDENT PHYSICIANS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT. I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT WHEN THE
AGREEMENT THAT WAS REACHED LAST
YEAR, THE BUDGET WAS DEFINITELY
KEPT IN MIND, 60% OF THE MCO
REVENUE IN THAT PROPOSAL WENT TO
THE GENERAL FUND. AND ACTUALLY
ON A YEAR OVER YEAR INCREASE WAS
ACTUALLY THE MOST RAPID UP THAT
THE WAS EVER DEVOTED TO THE
GENERAL FUND. SO WE ASK THAT WE
RESTORE THE CUTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. IF YOU COULD KEEP IT
TO A MINUTE, PLEASE. MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS, MARK
FAROOQ, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION,
ECHOING MANY OF THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM CMA WHO SPOKE
BEFORE ME, JUST QUICKLY, YOU ALL
KNOW IN THE HEARINGS THAT YOU'VE
HAD HOW FOUNDATIONAL THE
TARGETED RATE INCREASES ARE TO
MAINTAIN ACCESS AND IMPROVE
EQUITY IN THE MEDI-CAL SPACE. WE
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
REJECT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL RELATED TO THE MCO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, VANESSA KAHINA, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS, WOULD
CONCUR. REMARKS WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN THAT
FAMILY MEDICINE IS THE BEST WAY
TO GET TO PRIMARY CARE. AND BY
GOING BACK ON THESE RATE
PROMISES, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
SOME PROBLEMS GOING INTO THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING. MOLLY ROBSON WITH
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA AT PLANNED PARENTHOOD
HEALTH CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA.
OVER 85% OF OUR PATIENTS ARE
MEDI-CAL PATIENTS. AND SO THE
MCO TAX AND THE INVESTMENTS IN
THE MEDI-CAL SYSTEM WERE A
REALLY BIG DEAL FOR PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AND FOR IMPROVING
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY ACROSS THE
SYSTEM. SO WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT YOU REJECT THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS AND REINSTATE
THE FUNDS FOR THE MCO AS
ORIGINALLY AGREED TO. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR, DARBY KERNAN ON
BEHALF OF THE LOCAL HEALTH
PLANS, WE'RE VERY CONCERNED WITH
THE MCO PROPOSAL USING ALL THE
FUNDS FOR GENERAL FUND BACKFILL.
THE LOSS OF THIS MUCH NEEDED
FUNDING FOR PROVIDER RATES THAT
WOULD IMPROVE BOTH THE QUALITY
AND ACCESS TO MEDI-CAL PROGRAM
WILL BE PROFOUND. WE ASK YOU TO
REJECT THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. CONNIE
DELGADO, ON BEHALF OF THE
DISTRICT HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP
FORUM. THESE ARE THE 33 DISTRICT
AND MUNICIPAL HOSPITALS IN THE
STATE. OFFER, CARE IN SOME OF
THE MOST RURAL AND REMOTE
LOCATIONS IN CALIFORNIA, SERVING
THE UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS OF
THE STATE, DEEPLY DISAPPOINTED
TO SEE THE SWEEP OF THE MCO
FUNDS AT A TIME WHERE HOSPITALS
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE MORE
SERVICES TO MEDI-CAL
BENEFICIARIES AND SEE THIS AS A
AS A VERY DIFFICULT DECISION. WE
KNOW IT'S A TOUGH BUDGET YEAR.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
REJECT THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS
TIM MADDEN, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOU TO REJECT THE MCO
PROPOSAL, EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS
AND EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS HAVE
WILL HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT AS A RESULT OF NOT ONLY
THIS CUT, BUT MANY OF THE OTHER
CUTS THAT YOU'VE BEEN DISCUSSING
AS A RESULT OF THOSE PEOPLE WILL
END UP IN THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT, AND ONCE AGAIN, THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT TREATS ALL
PEOPLE COMING IN, NOT JUST
MEDI-CAL ENROLLEES. SO WE'D ASK,
TO THE EXTENT THERE'S ANY
COMPROMISE, YOU KEEP THAT IN
MIND IN TERMS OF, BUTTRESSING UP
THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT TO
ENSURE THEY CAN HANDLE THE FLOW
OF PEOPLE THAT WILL COME. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY, MOVING ON
TO ISSUE TWO ON THIS ONE, I KNOW
WHAT I'D LIKE TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT IS THE UTILIZATION OF THIS
, YEAH, WE CAN START THERE. SO,
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
ELIMINATE THE OPTIONAL ADULT
ACUPUNCTURE BENEFIT IN MEDI-CAL
EFFECTIVE JANUARY 1ST, 2025,
WITH THIS ESTIMATED REDUCED
GENERAL FUND COST OF 5.4 MILLION
IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND 13.1
MILLION ONGOING IN 2023,
APPROXIMATELY 66,000 MEDI-CAL
MEMBERS HAD APPROXIMATELY
416,000 VISITS THAT RESULTED IN
ABOUT 650 CLAIMS. SO MULTIPLE
VISITS CAN BE, MANY MULTIPLE
CLAIMS CAN, OCCUR DURING ONE
VISIT. SO THAT WAS THE
UTILIZATION IN 2023. IF SO, WE
TOOK OUT CAIRO A COUPLE YEARS
AGO AND WE'RE TAKING OUT
ACUPUNCTURE. AND WE WANT
EVERYONE TO BE ON DRUGS BECAUSE
THIS IS VERY IT'S PREVENTATIVE
IN NATURE. I MEAN, I'VE USED
ACUPUNCTURE AND, CAIRO FOR MY
BACK ISSUES FOR YEARS. ONE,
BECAUSE THEY SAY I'M TOO YOUNG
FOR SURGERY, BUT TWO, SO I CAN
GET STAY OUT OF SURGERY. RIGHT.
SO AGAIN, GOING BACK TO THE SAME
THING THEME OF, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
CUTTING SO MANY PREVENTATIVE
THINGS THAT WE MIGHT SEE
INCREASES IN OTHER THINGS,
RIGHT? BECAUSE THEY'RE START
GOING MORE LONGER STAYS XYZZY.
BUT BUT ONE OF MY MAIN CONCERNS
HERE IS THAT COVERED CALIFORNIA
HAS THIS AS A BENEFIT. RIGHT.
LIKE THIS IS IT IS PART OF THEIR
ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFIT. SO
WE'RE CUTTING IT JUST FROM THE
MOST POOR. SO MEDI-CAL
RECIPIENTS WON'T HAVE
ACUPUNCTURE BUT THOSE BECAUSE
IT'S PART OF OUR BENCHMARK
RIGHT. COVER CALIFORNIA
COMMERCIAL PAY WILL HAVE
ACUPUNCTURE. SO IT'S JUST
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF LIKE WE'RE
REALLY GOING AFTER LIKE THE
POOREST OF THE POOR. SO OUTSIDE
OF YOU TELLING ME BECAUSE TO
BALANCE OUR BUDGET, I'M
WONDERING IF THERE'S ANOTHER
REASON WHY WE'RE CUTTING
ACUPUNCTURE. THERE IS. YES
POLYPHONICA TANG WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO AS YOU
HAVE STATED, THE OVERALL GOAL
WAS TO MAINTAIN CERTAIN CORE
PROGRAMS AND BENEFITS, SUCH AS
MEDI-CAL ELIGIBILITY AND
BENEFITS, I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE
SPECIFICS OF THE OF THE
DELIBERATIVE PROCESS AS TO WHY
THIS BENEFIT WAS CHOSEN OVER
OTHERS, BUT AGAIN, THIS IS
REPRESENTS ADMINISTRATION'S
RECOMMENDATIONS. THESE ARE
PROPOSALS THAT REFLECT THE GOAL
OF PRESERVING THOSE CORE
BENEFITS. AND, THE ELIMINATION
OF THIS BENEFIT IS JUST A
PROPOSAL TO HELP SOLVE FOR THE,
GENERAL FUND SHORTFALL WITH
CAIRO. YOU KNOW, IT STILL HASN'T
GONE BACK. I DON'T KNOW IF THIS
IS CUT, IF WE WILL EVER BRING
THIS BACK, AS A BENEFIT TO
MEDI-CAL, DON'T SEEM TO HAVE A
GOOD TREND ON BRINGING THIS BACK
. I'M TRYING TO SEE ALL THE
OTHER SERVICES IS HERE NOW. I
MEAN, YEAH, SO THIS WAS ONE OF
THE BENEFITS THAT WAS CUT IN
2009, AS PART OF AND THEN WAS
BROUGHT BACK. SO IT WAS BROUGHT
BACK. IT WAS BROUGHT UP BACK IN
2016. OKAY. ACUPUNCTURE IT IS AN
OPTIONAL BENEFIT UNDER MEDICAID,
RULES. AND SO THAT IS AGAIN,
LOOKING TO PRESERVE THOSE CORE.
YEAH, BENEFITS. I WOULDN'T WANT
TO. SOPHIE'S CHOICE OVER HERE.
WHERE DO YOU CUT. I BROUGHT THIS
BACK JUST BECAUSE THIS WAS ONE
OF THE MORE HARDER ONES ON THE
ON THE MAY REVISE JUST TO SAY
WE'RE STILL TRACKING THIS ONE.
THIS IS STILL A VERY HARD ONE
FOR US TO, ACCEPT AGAIN, JUST
BECAUSE IT'S PREVENTATIVE IN
NATURE AND REALLY JUST HELPS
ALLEVIATE BEFORE IT GETS WORSE.
RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTION ON
THIS, JASON, DO YOU HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD ON THIS? OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE
THREE BECAUSE IT'S LATE. IT IS
LATE. SO THE, THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES TO ELIMINATE THE INDIAN
HEALTH PROGRAM, REDUCE GENERAL
FUND COSTS OF 23 MILLION
ANNUALLY, THE INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAM GRANT RECIPIENTS INCLUDE
27 INDIAN HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS.
SO 20 TRIBAL AND SEVEN URBAN
INDIAN ORGANIZATIONS. THE FUNDS
ALSO SUPPORT FOR TRADITIONAL
INDIAN HEALTH GRANT RECIPIENTS
LOCATED THROUGHOUT THE STATE. TO
DATE, GRANT RECIPIENTS HAVE USED
THE AWARDS TO SUPPORT CLINIC
INFRASTRUCTURE AND IMPROVE
ACCESS TO CARE THROUGH HIRING
NEW PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS,
RIGHT SIZING PROVIDERS, SALARIES
TO COMPETITIVE LEVELS,
SUPPORTING RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION EFFORTS, HIRING
CONSULTANTS TO ASSIST WITH
FINDING CANDIDATES FOR HARD TO
FILL PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER
POSITIONS. TRAINING FOR EXISTING
PROVIDERS AND STAFF TO IMPROVE
QUALITY CARE AND INCREASING
ACCESS. TRADITIONAL HEALING
SERVICES. THIS ONE'S WAY HARDER
THAN THE PREVIOUS ONE. THIS
ONE'S A REALLY, REALLY HARD ONE.
THERE'S ABOUT LIKE 20. IT'S A
LONG LIST OF THINGS THAT ARE
KEEPING ME UP, DURING THIS
BUDGET PROCESS AND THIS ONE'S A
REALLY ROUGH ONE. I JUST FEEL
LIKE, YOU KNOW, WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT CUTTING THINGS. LIKE IHS
FOR UNDOCUMENTED. YOU KNOW,
WE'RE CUTTING ALL OF THESE
SERVICES FOR INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAM, WHERE WE HAD CUT IT
YEARS AGO. RIGHT WE BROUGHT IT
BACK FOR JUST A COUPLE OF YEARS,
SAYING AND PEOPLE PROBABLY WERE
REALLY EXCITED. AND NOW WE'RE
CUTTING IT AGAIN. THESE ARE
LIKE, REALLY THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WE KNOW. THE DATA
AROUND, OUR TRIBAL FAMILIES AND
SIBLINGS OUT THERE. YOU KNOW,
WE'RE ALWAYS LOOKING TO CLOSE
THE GAP, AND THIS IS GOING TO
PUT US EVEN FURTHER, FURTHER,
FURTHER BACK. WHAT, IF ANY,
DIRECTOR LIKE WHAT OTHER
PROGRAMS CAN SUPPLEMENT, CAN
ADDRESS, CAN MEET SOME OF THESE
NEEDS THAT EXIST? IS THERE
ANYTHING MAYBE NOT AT THE SAME
LEVEL, IN TERMS OF AN
ALTERNATIVE FUNDING SOURCE FOR
THESE TYPES OF SERVICES, I CAN'T
THINK OF ANYTHING THAT WE HAVE
UNDERWAY TODAY, JUST DO NOTE
THAT, REDUCING DISPARITIES FOR
THIS POPULATION IS KIND OF PART
OF OUR COMPREHENSIVE QUALITY
STRATEGY. SO WE ARE VERY
CAREFULLY WATCHING THE DATA. I
WOULD ALSO SAY WE HAVE JUST
JANUARY WENT LIVE WITH OUR
ENHANCED CARE MANAGEMENT FOR
BIRTHING, EQUITY AND KIND OF
REALLY A FOCUS ON THIS
POPULATION. AND SO TRYING TO
THINK OF OTHER WAYS IN THE
MEDI-CAL, THE GLOBAL MEDI-CAL
SYSTEM TO, TO, TO SUPPORT,
REALLY ADDRESSING THE
DISPARITIES OF HEALTH OUTCOMES.
CAN WE MEET THAT? AND BY CUTTING
THIS, WILL WE FALL SHORT OF THAT
OF THAT GOAL? I WILL SAY THIS IS
DEFINITELY HELPFUL IN ADDRESSING
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF THESE
COMMUNITIES AND REALLY THE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO ACHIEVE
BETTER HEALTH OUTCOMES.
YEAH. NO, I MEAN. BIG SIGH.
BECAUSE JUST. I MEAN, THESE ARE
THINGS THAT ARE JUST SO CHRONIC
AND GENERATIONAL. IF WE DON'T
HELP ONE GENERATION, IT GETS
TRANSFERRED OVER TO THE NEXT.
AND WE'RE IN THIS NEVER ENDING
VICIOUS CYCLE OF NEVER STOPPING
IT IN ONE GENERATION BECAUSE
IT'S NOT ONGOING. IT'S NOT.
YEAH. IT'S JUST NOT CONSISTENT.
AND THE OVERALL THEME HERE IS
THAT WHENEVER WE HAVE A BUDGET
PROBLEM, WE GO AFTER OUR MOST
VULNERABLE AND THEN WE PAY IN IN
THE OUT YEARS. IT'S JUST A
REALLY HORRIBLE MESSAGE WE SENT
TO CALIFORNIANS THAT YOU WILL
ALWAYS BE ON THE CHOPPING BLOCK
IF YOU ARE CONSIDERED MOST
VULNERABLE, YOU'RE ALWAYS FIRST
TO GO. NOTHING ELSE. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO ADD ANYTHING? WELL
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD.
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS.
EMOTIONALLY. PHYSICALLY. TIRED.
YOU WONDER HOW THE ELIMINATION
OF A WHOLE PROGRAM RISES RIGHT
TO THE LIKE. OH, HERE'S 23
MILLION, AND I KNOW IT'S TOUGH.
I KNOW WE'RE LOOKING EVERYWHERE,
BUT IT JUST SEEMS LIKE THE WHOLE
ELIMINATION IS A SEVERE. IS IT
WHEN OTHER YEARS WE TALK ABOUT
23 MILLION AS BUDGET DUST.
RIGHT. BUT FOR THIS PROGRAM,
IT'S THE WAY IT'S THE PROGRAM.
IS IT BECAUSE FOR THE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS, CALIFORNIA HAS
REALLY, REALLY DOVE INTO HUMAN
SERVICES, HEALTH SERVICES AND
SAID, WE'RE GOING TO REALLY
INVEST. THAT'S WHY THERE'S ALL
THESE CUTS, BECAUSE ALL THE
MONEY FOR THE PAST COUPLE OF
YEARS WERE INVESTED IN THIS
AREA. IS THAT. LARA LÀ
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I WOULD
SAY THAT, A GOOD WAY TO FRAME
IT, THE MEDI-CAL BUDGET IS, THE
LARGEST GENERAL FUND BUDGET
OUTSIDE OF PROP 98. THERE WERE
SIGNIFICANT, UNPRECEDENTED
INVESTMENTS, WHEN WE HAD FUNDING
. AND NOW WE'RE FACING, YOU
KNOW, OBVIOUSLY, THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS PREVIOUSLY
COMMITTED TO MAKING THESE
INVESTMENTS. WE MADE A LOT. AND
UNFORTUNATELY, NOW WE'RE HAVING
TO MAKE THESE REALLY TOUGH
DECISIONS AND SEARCHING UNDER
THE COUCH CUSHIONS. AND IT IT IS
A LARGE BUDGET AND, HAS A LOT OF
ONE TIME FUNDING AND
DISCRETIONARY FUNDING TO THAT
POINT, I WOULD SAY THAT WE WORK
TO RESTORE THE CUTS THAT WE HAD
MADE PREVIOUSLY IN THESE LAST
FEW YEARS WITH SOME
AUGMENTATION. AND NOW WE'RE
GOING TO GO RIGHT BACK TO WHERE
WE FOUND OURSELVES. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION REMAINS COMMITTED
TO, YOU KNOW, THESE SERVICES AND
THESE INVESTMENTS AND, TO
HELPING WITH ACCESS AND
COVERAGE. BUT, YEAH, IT'S NOT A
POSITION WE WANT TO BE IN. I
THINK IT'S I THINK IT'S HARD TO
BE COMMITTED TO SOMETHING AND
LETTING IT GO. I THINK ANYONE
WHO ENCOUNTERED A BREAKUP
DOESN'T HEAR LIKE, I'M STILL
COMMITTED TO YOU, BUT I'M
BREAKING UP WITH YOU. THAT'S
WHAT I'M TAKING FROM THIS. LIKE,
WE CAN'T BE COMMITTED TO THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE CUTTING
BECAUSE WE'RE LETTING THEM GO.
OKAY. ISSUE FOR, THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
REDUCE A $2 MILLION AUGMENTATION
THAT WAS MADE IN THE 2021 BUDGET
ACT RELATED TO FREE AND
CHARITABLE CLINICS. THIS
SUPPORTS FREE CLINICS THAT ARE,
THERE ARE ABOUT 33 IN THE STATE,
AND THESE DOLLARS ARE ALLOCATED
TO THE ASSOCIATION. WHO THEN
ALLOCATES THESE DOLLARS TO THE
CLINICS WHO ARE THE ASSOCIATION?
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FREE AND CHARITABLE CLINICS. DO
WE HAVE ANY ANY REPORTS ON. WE
DON'T HAVE ANY REPORTS. WE DON'T
KNOW HOW THIS NUMBER, HOW THIS
FUNDING IS BEING UTILIZED. IF
IT'S SUCCESSFUL OR NO, IT'S PART
OF THE 21 BUDGET ACT. IT WAS A
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL TO JUST
AWARD THE DOLLARS TO THE
ASSOCIATION, WHO THEN
DISTRIBUTED THE DOLLARS TO THE
TO THE CLINICS. WE SHOULD
DEFINITELY COLLECT DATA ON EVERY
SINGLE DOLLAR WE SEND OUT. BUT I
CAN ONLY SPEAK TO ONE PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE. WELL, PERSONAL
EXAMPLE, BECAUSE OF MY DISTRICT
AND I'VE BEEN I VISITED THEM AND
THESE TWO PHYSICIANS AS
VOLUNTEER AND PUT ON A FREE
CLINIC, AND THEY'RE LIKE, WE'RE
SWAMPED. WE ARE SWAMPED EVERY
SINGLE TIME WE'RE OPEN, THERE'S
ENDLESS AMOUNT OF PEOPLE THAT
COME IN. I KNOW WE'RE EACH Â
EACH COUPLE YEARS. WE INCH
TOWARDS, YOU KNOW, HEALTH CARE
FOR ALL. AND VARIETY OF WAYS.
BUT THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE IT RIGHT.
$2 MILLION, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, $2 MILLION. THAT'S I
THINK THIS IS THE SMALLEST ONE.
LARA DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WELL, I CAN'T GIVE YOU DETAILS
ABOUT THE PROPOSALS IN OTHER
AREAS. I'LL TELL YOU THAT THIS
IS NOT THE SMALLEST. OH, BOY.
IT'S A GREAT PROBLEM. WE'RE JUST
. SO THAT'S WHY, YOU KNOW, WITH
THE PCP'S. I'M GETTING ON, ON ON
SOME, EXTRA STAFFING AND SO
FORTH, IT'S GOING TO BE REALLY
HARD FOR ME TO APPROVE THOSE
WHEN LIKE, THESE ARE THESE CUTS
ARE HAPPENING BECAUSE AS IF
WE'RE, WE'RE TRYING TO BE LIKE,
SLIM EVERYTHING. RIGHT. TRY TO
PROTECT AS MUCH AND I'M HERE,
OKAY, THAT NOT EVERYONE'S GOING
TO GET THE SAME AMOUNT AS
THEY'RE USED TO. EVERYONE'S
GOING TO HAVE TO TRIM DOWN, BUT
I CAN'T TRIM BUT THEN ASK FOR
MORE IN OTHER AREAS. THAT'S
WHERE IT'S HARD. IT DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE EVERYONE'S HAVING AN EQUAL
TRIM, LIKE IF WE REALLY WANT TO
DO AN EQUAL TRIM, THEN I CAN'T
SEE PROPOSALS FOR MORE STAFF
THAT THAT'S THE PART I CAN'T. IF
SOME STAFF IS MORE THAN THAN
THIS, LIKE, YOU KNOW, IN THE
200, 100 MILLION FOR THIS AND SO
FORTH, SOMEWHERE IN THE
THOUSANDS. BUT THAT'S THE PART
BRING THESE ISSUES BACK JUST TO
KNOW THAT THESE ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE ON THE TARGET LIST FOR
MOST DIFFICULTY, INSIGHT INTO
WHAT WE'RE, WE'RE, WE'RE, WE'RE
LOOKING AT AND JUST TO SAY IT'S
GOING TO BE REALLY HARD TO VOTE
FOR BCP'S THAT ARE ASKING FOR
MORE FUNDING WHEN WE'RE CUTTING.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENT? ELIO?
GREAT ISSUE NUMBER FIVE, THE
DEPARTMENT CREATED THE NALOXONE
DISTRIBUTION PROJECT IN 2018 TO
COMBAT OPIOID OVERDOSE RELATED
DEATHS IN CALIFORNIA. VÀ THROUGH
THE PROVISION OF FREE NALOXONE
TO ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIA ENTITIES.
TO DATE, NDP HAS DISTRIBUTED
MORE THAN 4 MILLION NALOXONE
KITS AND HAS RECEIVED MORE THAN
268,000 REPORTED OVERDOSE
REVERSALS. WE'VE SPENT
APPROXIMATELY 206 MILLION TO
PURCHASE THE NALOXONE FOR
DISTRIBUTION THROUGH THIS
PROGRAM, FOR FISCAL YEAR 2425,
WE PROJECT ABOUT 54 MILLION,
UTILIZING OPIOID SETTLEMENT
DOLLARS, AND WE BASED ON KIND OF
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSAL OF A
REDUCTION OF 35 MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND, AN AUGMENTATION OF
8 MILLION, OPIOID SETTLEMENT
FUNDS IN SOME CURRENT YEAR
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY. WE FEEL
LIKE WE WILL BE FULLY FUNDED TO
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. DO WE KNOW HOW MUCH
IS IN THE FUND? WE SHOULD KNOW
WHICH, ARE YOU LOOKING FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR ENDING BALANCE OR
ARE YOU LOOKING FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR, 2324 BUDGET YEAR? OKAY.
YEAH, WELL, CURRENT YEAR. YEAH.
TYPICALLY, TYPICALLY WHAT WE DO
WITH THE OSF. SORRY. NATE
WILLIAMS, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
WE ARE, WE ESSENTIALLY TRY AND
SPEND ABOUT THE MAXIMUM THAT WE
CAN. SO TYPICALLY WE DON'T LEAVE
MUCH OF A RESERVE BALANCE IN THE
OSF. I WILL SAY THAT, I THINK WE
HAVE APPROXIMATELY $2 MILLION
THAT WOULD BE NOT ACCOUNTED FOR
IN THE, IN THE OSF EXPENDITURE
PLAN. GOOD. YEAH SO THE REASON
WHY I BROUGHT THIS ONE BACK IS
BECAUSE I STILL HAVE I DON'T
FULLY UNDERSTAND WHY WE'RE
FUNDING THAT AND NOT MAKING HÌ.
AND I DON'T THINK IT'S UNDER
YOUR DEPARTMENT. IT'S NOT WOMEN
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. IT IS. SO
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON WHY I'M
BRINGING THIS ONE, JUST TO SHARE
THAT I STILL AM TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHY WE CAN'T REMOVE SOME
WORK. WELL, THIS IS A PROPOSAL.
I GET IT, WE'RE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS, BUT JUST SHARING
THAT. I STILL THINK WE SHOULD
DECREASE THIS AMOUNT AND PROVIDE
SOME FUNDING FOR THE, THE HARM
REDUCTION. HARM REDUCTION,
PORTION NHIÀU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SO I THINK WHAT WE WERE
TRYING TO DO WITH THIS IS, BOTH
THE CDF PROGRAM THAT YOU'RE
REFERENCING AND NDP TOOK A, A
REDUCTION AT, AT GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, AND THEN THE NDP
ACTUALLY TOOK AN ADDITIONAL
REDUCTION AT MAY REVISION OF
GENERAL FUND OF 35.5 MILLION. SO
US RIGHT NOW. YEAH. SO THE NDP
IS TAKING A $35.5 MILLION
REDUCTION IN GENERAL FUND
ONGOING. AND SO THIS
AUGMENTATION OF APPROXIMATELY 8
MILLION IS REALLY TO TRY AND,
RIGHTSIZE THE BUDGET YEAR'S
APPROPRIATION TO APPROXIMATE THE
SAME NUMBER OF UNITS THAT WE
WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO SUPPLY.
VÌ, WITH OUR GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
CALCULATION, GIVEN THAT THE
DECREASE IN PRICE SO WE DON'T
HAVE TO FULLY, GAIN BACK THE
FULL 35.5 MILLION, NOW THAT
THERE'S A DECREASED COST. OKAY,
YEAH, I UNDERSTAND WE'RE GOING
CHEAPER COSTS WITH FENOMENO. SO
SO WE'RE THERE'S A PROPOSAL. I
THINK I MISSED THAT. MAYBE I'M
JUST TIRED. 35 MILLION. YES. SO
IT'S ACTUALLY TIED UP. SO
THERE'S A $61 MILLION REDUCTION
FOR MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENT, PROGRAMS. AND THEN
ALSO INCLUDED IN THAT IS 35.5
MILLION. SO IN THAT 6130 5.5.
AND THE 8.3 ARE JUST TO OFFSET.
THAT'S TO TRY AND GET US BACK TO
OUR GOVERNOR'S BUDGET NUMBERS.
CORRECT GOT IT. WHY WOULD WE
REDUCE. AND THEN ADD. AND THE
SAME MAY REVISE. I MEAN, I GUESS
YOU COULD KIND OF THINK OF IT AS
A FUND SHIFT. WE DIDN'T
NECESSARILY CALL IT THAT, BUT
THAT'S KIND OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
IS WE'RE REDUCING THE 35.5
BECAUSE IT WAS TIED UP WITH THE
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT.
IT WAS KIND OF ITS OWN PCP. SO I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE NECESSARILY
TALK ABOUT IT THAT WAY, BUT
THAT'S ESSENTIALLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING. OKAY THANK YOU. LÀ
GREAT. THANK YOU. I THINK YOU
JUST HAVE ONE LAST. WE'RE DONE.
YEAH, WE'RE DONE HERE. THANK
YOU. DIRECTORS, ONE LAST THING
COVERED CALIFORNIA. FOR.
WE DON'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
WHOLE THING AGAIN. JUST WANTED
TO KNOW IF THERE IS ANY
ADDITIONAL THOUGHTS ON WHAT WE
TALKED ABOUT LAST WEEK. JOSEPH
DONALDSON, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
. SO, SPECIFICALLY TO YOUR FIRST
QUESTION ON THIS RATIONALE, ALL
OF THE ONGOING, TRANSFER THAT WE
PROPOSE, THE MAY REVISE OF 109
MILLION BEGINNING IN 2526. SO
IT'S MORE CONNECTED TO THE
OVERALL STRUCTURE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO THE
BUDGET. SO WHILE MAY REVISE IS
PROPOSING A BALANCED BUDGET FOR
BOTH BUDGET YEAR AND BUDGET YEAR
ONE, WE'RE ALSO ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT THERE ARE STRUCTURAL
PROBLEMS AND OUT YEARS AS WELL.
SO WHILE THE MAY REVISE IS,
ADDRESSING THE BUDGET YEAR AND
BUDGET YEAR ONE, THIS ONGOING
TRANSFER ALLOWS THE STATE TO BE
HOPEFULLY IN, GOOD FINANCIAL
FOOTING GOING FORWARD SO THAT
POTENTIALLY MORE SOLUTIONS MAY
NOT BE NEEDED IN THE FUTURE. IF
YOU KNOW, WHEN WE CROSS THAT
BRIDGE, SO TO SPEAK, BUT NOTING
THAT WHICH WE NOTED IN PREVIOUS
HEARINGS THAT NOT ONLY WITH THIS
PROPOSED SOLUTION, AS WELL AS
THE OTHER TWO SOLUTIONS, IS
THESE DON'T IMPACT OR REDUCE
CURRENT SERVICE PROGRAMS THROUGH
COVERED CALIFORNIA. SO JUST
WANTED TO REITERATE THAT EVEN
WITH THESE SOLUTIONS, WE'RE NOT
REDUCING OR IMPACTING THE
AFFORDABILITY PROGRAMS OFFERED
BY COVERED CALIFORNIA. RIGHT.
WE'RE JUST NOT INCREASING IF
MORE PEOPLE COME IN WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE, WE WON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY. TO. I, I MIGHT DEFER TO
MY COLLEAGUE AT COVERED
CALIFORNIA FOR JUST KIND OF THE
PROGRAM DESIGN ON THIS, I, I
WILL KIND OF FIRST BEGIN THAT. I
KNOW WHEN WE DEVELOPED SOME OF
THESE FOR SPECIFICALLY THE COST
SHARING AFFORDABILITY PROGRAM
THAT HAS 165 MILLION OR, YES,
165 MILLION STILL MAINTAIN THAT
WHEN THIS WAS DEVELOPED, THE
COVER CALIFORNIA USED A VERY
CONSERVATIVE MODEL TO ENSURE
THAT IT WAS STAYING WITHIN THE
CONFINES OF THIS APPROPRIATION.
MY COLLEAGUE COULD PROBABLY GO
INTO MORE DEPTH ON THIS, BUT
WHEN WE DEVELOPED IT, THAT WAS
THE INTENT. HI THERE. KATIE
RAVEL, DIRECTOR OF POLICY
ELIGIBILITY AND RESEARCH AT
COVER CALIFORNIA. WE ARE IN THE
FIRST YEAR OF RUNNING THE
PROGRAM THIS YEAR WITH 82.5
MILLION, AND IT WILL DOUBLE FOR
NEXT YEAR. SO WE WILL HAVE MORE
EXPERIENCE IN THE COMING MONTHS
ABOUT OUR CONSERVATIVE APPROACH.
WE DID BUILD IN SOME CUSHION FOR
ENROLLMENT ABOVE AND BEYOND EVEN
OUR HIGHEST PROJECTIONS, WHICH
POTENTIALLY ALSO GIVES US SOME
CUSHION AS BENEFIT COSTS
INCREASE. SO THOSE ARE TWO
FACTORS THAT WE'RE NOT USING.
ALL OF THIS 165 WE ARE PROJECTED
FOR OUR 2025 YEAR TO BE ABLE TO
SERVICE UP TO 1.3 MILLION
ENROLLEES IN THOSE PLANS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO PUT ON THE SHELF
IN 2025. WE CURRENTLY HAVE 1.1
MILLION IN OUR SILVER PLAN. SO
WE COULD GROW BY 200,000 AS WE
DO OUR ADVERTISING. IF WE DON'T
GROW BY THAT AMOUNT, THEN
THERE'S SOME CUSHION GOING
FORWARD AS BENEFIT COSTS
INCREASE. SO WE'RE RIGHT NOW
WE'RE SERVING A 1.1 MILLION
RIGHT NOW AT OUR 82.5. WE'RE
SERVING A LITTLE OVER 700,000.
THAT WILL DOUBLE AS WE GO
FORWARD WHEN THE FUNDING
DOUBLES. YES. AND THEN WE STILL
HAVE APPROXIMATELY ROOM TO GROW
200,000. WE DO? YES. PAST THAT.
THAT'S RIGHT. OKAY. OKAY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT. YOU'RE
WELCOME. BECAUSE WE STILL
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF UNKNOWN.
I'M STILL WITH THE MINDSET THAT
I KNOW WE NEED IT FOR NEXT YEAR.
I'M NOT DISPUTING THAT, BUT JUST
THE INDEFINITE ONGOING PART IS
I'M STILL STUCK ON AND CONCERNED
ABOUT IT. IT DOESN'T REMOVE YOUR
ABILITY TO COME BACK TO THE
TABLE AND ASK FOR IT AGAIN AND
AGAIN, THAT'S WHERE I'M AT. I
KNOW THERE'S A STRUCTURAL ISSUE.
CAN STILL COME BACK NEXT YEAR
AND ASK FOR IT FOR THE FOLLOWING
FOLLOWING YEAR, BUT STILL
HAVEN'T CHANGED MY MIND ON THAT
PART. YES. UNDERSTOOD WELL, THAT
THAT IS A CONCERN. AND
OBVIOUSLY, AS WE'VE NOTED, WITH
ALL THESE SOLUTIONS, THESE ARE
PROPOSALS WE'RE WILLING TO WORK
ON ALTERNATIVES. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT, AND WE
NOTED THIS IN PREVIOUS HEARING
THAT FOR 2425, THERE IS A FUND
BALANCE FOR THE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY FUND, HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY RESERVE FUND OF
ABOUT 14.5 MILLION, AND IT'S
ABOUT 30 MILLION IN BUDGET YEAR
ONE. WHEN WE START LOOKING AT
THESE OUTYEAR PROJECTIONS BASED
ON WHERE WE SEE REVENUES AND
WHERE WE START SEEING SOME OF
THESE LOAN REPAYMENTS START
GETTING FACTORED IN, EVEN WITH,
THE PROPOSED ONGOING SHIFT, THE
FUND STILL WOULD HAVE A RATHER
ROBUST, FUND RESERVE, SO EVEN
WITH THE PROPOSALS THAT WE HAVE
IN PLACE OF NOT ONLY THE 62
MILLION, LOAN, THE DELAYED
REPAYMENT OF THE 600 MILLION
LOAN, AS WELL AS THE ONGOING
REVENUE TRANSFER, WE SEE THAT
BASED ON CURRENT REVENUE
PROJECTIONS, THE AVAILABLE FUND
BALANCES FOR THE AGE CURVE IS
STILL RATHER, RATHER SIZABLE. SO
WE'RE NOT IF THE CONCERN IS THAT
WE'RE SHORT CHANGING OURSELVES
IN THE FUTURE FOR TO ADDRESS THE
NOW I DON'T KNOW IF THAT WOULD
BE THE CORRECT KIND OF
REPRESENTATION OF THE FUND, BUT
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT, YOU KNOW,
THERE COULD BE A DIFFERENCE OF
OPINIONS BETWEEN ONGOING AND BUT
WE WOULD STILL FALL SHORT,
WHETHER IT'S ROBUST OR NOT, WE
WOULD STILL FALL SHORT IF FOR
SOME REASON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT GETS UNFRIENDLY WITH
US, WE STILL WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
MEET OUR OBLIGATION TO COVER ALL
THOSE BENEFITS BENEFICIARIES. I
THINK BASED ON I WOULD, WANT TO
MY COLLEAGUE FROM COVER
CALIFORNIA BASED ON THE CURRENT
LEVEL OF SUBSIDIES OFFERED BY,
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, PART OF
THESE ENHANCED BENEFITS, IT IS A
RATHER SIZABLE AMOUNT. THAT
WOULD BE A RATHER BIG COST
PRESSURE ON THE STATE, WHETHER
THROUGH THE HALF OR THROUGH THE
GENERAL FUND, YOU KNOW, THAT
WOULD HAVE TO BE A DISCUSSION
OF, YOU KNOW, IF WE WOULD
CONSIDER DOING A BACKFILL TO
WHAT DEGREE AND WHAT LEVEL, BUT,
YOU KNOW, BASED ON THIS PROPOSAL
, WE DID ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IT WAS
ASSUMING THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WOULD WOULD EXPAND BEYOND 25,
26. WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS
UNCERTAINTY AND TO A DEGREE,
POTENTIALLY RISK. BUT IN ORDER
TO KIND OF REALIZE SAVINGS
AVAILABLE TO ADDRESS THE GENERAL
FUND SHORTFALL, WHILE ALSO NOT
IMPACTING CURRENT PROGRAMS
OFFERED BY COVER CALIFORNIA,
THAT WAS THE PROPOSAL PUT
FORWARD AT THE MAY REVISE. OKAY
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS, YEAH.
RYAN MILLER I'LL TRY TO KEEP IT
BRIEF AND JUST ACKNOWLEDGING THE
HOUR AND WHERE WE ARE. TO YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT YOU KNOW,
BACKFILLING THE POTENTIAL LOSS
OF THE ENHANCED SUBSIDY, I THINK
THAT WOULD BE PRETTY DIFFICULT.
AND ESPECIALLY IN THE CURRENT
BUDGET CLIMATE THAT WE FIND
OURSELVES IN, YOU KNOW, ONE
ADDITIONAL THOUGHT I WANTED TO
OFFER, YOU KNOW, WE HAD SAID IN
LAST IN THE HEARING LAST TIME ON
THIS MATTER THAT, YOU KNOW, WE
THOUGHT THAT IT COULD BE
PREMATURE BECAUSE IT WOULD PUT
THE LEGISLATURE IN A DIFFICULT
POSITION IF THAT, PROBLEM DID
MATERIALIZE. I, YOU KNOW, JUST
TO OFFER WITH REGARD TO A LOT OF
THESE, ESPECIALLY THE ONGOING
KIND OF ACTIONS THAT WE'RE
CONSIDERING, I THINK THAT THERE
ARE A LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS TO
THINK ABOUT THE NATURE OF THOSE,
YOU KNOW, WITH REGARD TO THE
ENHANCED FEDERAL SUBSIDIES ON
THE EXCHANGE, ONE WAY TO THINK
ABOUT THE POTENTIAL LOSS OF
THAT, WHILE IT WOULD HAVE
DEFINITELY SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES
FOR THOSE WHO GET FOR
AFFORDABILITY ON THE EXCHANGE,
IT WOULD RETURN THAT TO SORT OF
A 2019 SERVICE LEVEL. I THINK
THERE HAVE BEEN OTHER ISSUES
DISCUSSED IN THE COMMITTEE
WHERE, YOU KNOW, ARGUABLY AN
ONGOING REDUCTION THAT'S BEEN
PROPOSED IN THE MAY REVISION MAY
ACTUALLY CUT SOMETHING, YOU
KNOW, EITHER DEEPER THAN THAT OR
SAY, IN THE CASE OF THE LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE, YOU KNOW,
WOULD WOULD GO BACK ON SOMETHING
THAT SEEMS TO HAVE BROUGHT A
SERVICE LEVEL UP TO WHERE IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN AT THAT TIME.
SO, YEAH, I'LL JUST I GUESS I'LL
JUST LEAVE IT WITH THAT. BUT
WE'RE AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS TO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. APPRECIATE
IT. THAT CONCLUDES OUR ISSUES.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE INTO
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR ALL ISSUES.
WE TALKED ON HEALTH OUTSIDE OF
MCO TAX. OKAY. SO 30S NOT A LOT
30S MADAM CHAIR, SENATOR BRANDON
TATE WITH THE YOUTH HEALTH
EQUITY COALITION, I WANTED TO
TRY TO FILL IN SOME OF THE GAPS
OF INFORMATION. YOU DID NOT GET
TO YOUR QUESTIONS TONIGHT. SO
THERE ARE FOUR ASPECTS TO THE
PUBLIC EDUCATION CAMPAIGN THE
STATEWIDE, THE LOCAL, THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR THE
LOCAL AND A DEDICATED LGBT
EFFORT. WHAT'S HAPPENING IS THAT
WE'RE GETTING CONFUSED THAT EVEN
THOUGH SOME OF THE CBOS MIGHT
RECEIVE SOME OF THE FUNDING, THE
STATEWIDE CAMPAIGN WAS ACTUALLY
CREATING THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
ENSURE THAT THE MESSAGES WERE
EFFECTIVE AND EVIDENCE BASED.
YOU ASK WHAT HAS HAPPENED ON THE
STATEWIDE CAMPAIGN? SO FAR?
CONTRACT DIDN'T START UNTIL
JANUARY, SO IN ONLY FOUR MONTHS
THEY'VE ENGAGED 1645 YOUTH AND
PARENTS ACROSS THE STATE, AND
THEY THEY'VE STOOD UP A
COMMUNITY ADVISORY BOARDS WITH
86 YOUTH AND PARENTS WHO'VE BEEN
HIRED TO SERVE ON THOSE. SOME OF
THOSE ARE THE ONES YOU SAW LAST
WEEK. THOSE ARE THE YOUTH THAT
WOULD BE DISMISSED. THANK YOU,
YEAH. THERE'S A LOT MORE TO SAY.
LET'S SEE. OH, MY NAME IS EMMA
SNUGGS. I'M A CITIZEN OF THE
CHEROKEE NATION AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE TRIBAL PEOPLE'S
EMPOWERMENT PROJECT, MY PROJECT
IS ACTUALLY A PART OF DC'S
NALOXONE DISTRIBUTION PROJECT, I
GOT INTO THIS WORK AFTER MY
BROTHER PASSED AWAY OF A
FENTANYL OVERDOSE, TWO YEARS AGO
, YOU KNOW, JUST FOR THE RECORD,
YOU KNOW, OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE
THE HIGHEST RATE OF OPIOID
RELATED OVERDOSE, THE LOWEST
LIFE EXPECTANCY, 2.3 TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO DIE OF DIABETES THAN
WHITE COUNTERPARTS HAVE THE
HIGHEST RATE OF SUICIDE, AND 1
IN 3 NATIVE WOMEN REPORT BEING
RAPED IN THEIR LIFETIMES, I KNOW
THAT PEOPLE HAVE SHARED, YOU
KNOW, CRUCIAL LOSSES. LAST
THOUGHT, A CUT OF THIS MAGNITUDE
WILL RESULT IN THE LOSS OF A
LIFE IN MY COMMUNITY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
VANESSA KAHINA, ON BEHALF OF
COMPROMISO, IN OPPOSITION TO THE
CUTS TO THE HCAI WORKFORCE
REDUCTIONS FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS, PROMOTORAS AND
REPRESENTATIVES, THAT WAS AN
EQUITY INVESTMENT IN A
HISTORICALLY UNDERREPRESENTED,
EXCLUDED POPULATION. ALSO, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS, IN
OPPOSITION TO THE $10 MILLION
CUT TO SÐNG BROWN LOAN
REPAYMENTS, SONG BROWN RESIDENCY
PLACEMENT. EXCUSE ME AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON THAT. WE DO BELIEVE
THAT THAT CUT COULD LEAD TO
PEOPLE BEING ENROLLED AND HAVING
TO LEAVE THEIR RESIDENCY. THANK
YOU. HI, I'M LILY CORTEZ. I'M
WITH THE LGBTQ CENTER, I'M THE
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, TO HERE, TODAY, I'M
HERE TO ADVOCATE AGAINST THE
PROPOSED BUDGET CUTS FOR THE
YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS AT
THE SPECIFICALLY AT THE OFFICE
OF HEALTH EQUITY. EARLY EARLIER
TODAY, YOU SPOKE ABOUT THE NEED
TO ADVOCATE AND FIGHT FOR OUR
CHILDREN. YOU ALSO MENTIONED
THAT YOU ADVOCATED FOR CHILDREN
TO HAVE A PLACE TO GO. THE
PROPOSED BUDGET CUTS, IN
PARTICULAR THE ONES FOR THE
YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS AT
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY,
WILL ELIMINATE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR LGBTQ YOUTH TO HAVE A PLACE
TO LAND, GET RESOURCES,
AFFIRMATION, MENTAL HEALTH CARE,
AND LEARN HOW TO ACCEPT
THEMSELVES. THESE CUTS WILL
FORCE US TO CLOSE OUR OUTREACH
PROGRAM AND OUR NEWLY LAUNCHED
SATELLITE LOCATION IN EL DORADO,
PLACER AND YOLO COUNTIES. WE
RECEIVE CALLS DAILY ASKING FOR
HELP AND RESOURCES. THESE KIDS
HAVE NOWHERE ELSE TO GO. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. GOOD EVENING EVERYONE.
EMILY MCCLINTOCK WITH THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE HERE TO VOICE
MY CONCERNS ABOUT THE PROPOSED
CUTS TO THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE
PUBLIC EDUCATION CHANGE
CAMPAIGN. AS WAS MENTIONED, 28
CBOS WERE ALREADY PROMISED $25
MILLION OF FUNDING FOR THEIR
WORK IN LOCAL LEVEL CAMPAIGNS
AND WILL NOW RECEIVE A PORTION
OF THAT WITH NO TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE NOR OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE STATE TO EVALUATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS WORK.
CUTTING OFF THE FUNDS AND
SUPPORT TO CBOS ON JUNE 30TH,
2024 WILL JEOPARDIZE THIS
CRITICAL WORK. SO WE'RE ASKING
YOU TO HELP US FOLLOW THROUGH ON
THESE LOCAL LEVEL PROJECTS AND
MAINTAIN. ORIGINALLY PROMISED
FUNDS AND SUPPORT TO THESE CBOS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WELCOME
BACK. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR,
DOCTOR MARK LOBO, CEO OF CRIB.
WE WORK WITH 68 FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND 20 TRIBAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS HERE TODAY TO RECOMMEND
SUBCOMMITTEE REJECT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE
THE INDIAN HEALTH PROGRAM, WHICH
WAS ESTABLISHED IN 1975. TRIBAL
AND ADDITIONAL AMERICAN INDIAN
COMMUNITIES ENDURE SIGNIFICANT
HEALTH DISPARITIES AND COMPRISE
ONE OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS IN THE STATE, WHERE
RECOVERING FROM
MULTIGENERATIONAL TRAUMA,
POST-TRAUMATIC STRESS IMPOSED ON
US BY COLONIAL FORCES, OUR
CLINICS ARE CHRONICALLY
UNDERFUNDED BY THE FEDERAL
INDIAN HEALTH SERVICE, AND WE'RE
RELIANT UPON THE STATE FOR
RESOURCES. IN LIGHT OF THIS,
TRIBES AGAIN URGE SUBCOMMITTEE
TO REJECT DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES PROPOSAL TO
TERMINATE THE INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. HELLO.
STEPHANIE WELDON WITH UNITED
INDIAN HEALTH SERVICES. I AM
ALSO A YUROK TRIBAL MEMBER AND
CUTS TO THE INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAM WILL IMPACT ME AND MY
COMMUNITY, CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN. THIS FUNDING
FUNDS TRADITIONAL HEALERS AS
WELL AS THE RECRUITMENT OF OUR
PROVIDERS. SO MUCH NEEDED AND
ALSO IMPORTANT PART HERE IS THAT
OUR PEOPLE ARE NOT GETTING
ADEQUATE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES THROUGH COUNTIES, BOTH
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE AND
ACCESSIBLE FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE. AS THIS NATION'S
FIRST PEOPLE. AND IF THE
DEPARTMENT HAD CONCERNS OR WAS
WORRIED ABOUT THIS PROGRAM, THEY
DID NOT ENGAGE IN TRUE
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
CONSULTATION AS THEY'RE EXPECTED
AND REQUIRED TO DO SO WITH
TRIBES TO TALK ABOUT THE PROGRAM
NEEDS. WE FOUGHT REALLY HARD TO
GET THIS PROGRAM REFUNDED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. STACY HIRAMOTO
WITH REMCO. THE RACIAL AND
ETHNIC MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES
COALITION, ALSO REPRESENTING
PARTNERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT. I
WANT TO, SUPPORT AND COMMEND THE
REMARKS OF MARK LEBEAU AND
STEPHANIE WELDON. WE ARE VERY
UPSET ABOUT THESE CUTS TO THE
INDIAN HEALTH PROGRAM. WE THINK
IT'S VERY UNFAIR. BUT ON THE
OTHER HAND, IN A WAY, WE'RE NOT
SURPRISED WHEN IT COMES TO THE
SAIBAI CHILDREN, YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE,
YOU YOU WERE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND ALL THE PEOPLE LAST
WEEK. YOU LOOK AT IT LIKE PEOPLE
LAST HIRED, FIRST FIRED. THAT'S
WHAT PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE USED
TO. AND THESE CYBER Kò, THE
GRANTS THAT ARE GETTING CUT ARE
THE ONES THAT WOULD SERVE THE
BIPOC AND LGBTQ COMMUNITIES BEST
, IT'S THE ONE OF THE, PUBLIC
EDUCATION CHANGE CAMPAIGN. DID
YOU NOTICE THEY WERE ALL PEOPLE
OF COLOR? AND ANYWAY, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING. KIARA
ROSS, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
PASADENA HEALTH PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT, ONE OF THREE CITY
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN THE STATE.
I'M IN OPPOSITION OR I GUESS,
ASKING YOU TO REJECT THE
PROPOSED CUTS TO THE LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING FOR THE
CITY OF PASADENA. THIS WOULD BE
DEVASTATING. WE'D LOSE EIGHT
STAFF. AND THESE ARE SOME OF OUR
VERY TOP STAFF WHO LAST YEAR
WERE ABLE TO STOP TRANSMISSION
OF DENGUE FEVER. BUT ALSO FOR
OUR HOMELESS, WE HAVE NAVIGATION
SERVICES THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO
CUT THAT HAVE ACTUALLY GOTTEN
DOZENS OF PEOPLE OFF THE STREET
AND INTO SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. KATHY.
SENATOR MCDONNELL, FOR THE
COUNTY OF ALAMEDA, ALSO URGING
REJECTION OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
FUNDING FOR THE LOCAL LEVEL, AS
I NOTED LAST WEEK AT THE
HEARING, 39 STAFF ARE HIRED WITH
THIS FUNDING. AND ALAMEDA
COUNTY, IF THE PANDEMIC SHOWED
US ANYTHING, IT'S THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH IS VALUABLE, CRITICAL,
AND IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE NOT
TURN BACK THE CLOCK AND GO BACK
TO WHERE WE WERE BEFORE, BARELY
MAKING ENDS MEET. AND BARELY
KEEPING ABOVE WATER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. DYLAN
ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTIES OF KERN, FRESNO,
MADERA, NAPA, HUMBOLDT, SOLANO,
SAN JOAQUIN AND TULARE, ALL
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE FUTURE
OF PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDS URGE YOUR
REJECTION. THOSE ARE IMPORTANT.
FIRST LINE PUBLIC HEALTH,
DEFENSE MONIES. THANK YOU.
CHRISTINE SMITH, HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PUSH BACK ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO SWEEP
$109 MILLION ONGOING FROM THE
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY
RESERVE FUND, STARTING NEXT
YEAR, THIS FUND COLLECTS REVENUE
FROM CALIFORNIA'S UNINSURED AND
HAS BEEN PRESERVED FOR COVER.
CALIFORNIA TO MAKE INSURANCE
MORE AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE.
OUR UNDERSTANDING WHEN PENALTY
FUNDS WERE SECURED LAST YEAR WAS
THAT ANY FUNDS TAKEN WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE LOANS, AND ONLY
WHEN ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY, AND
THEN RETURNED FOR ITS ORIGINAL
PURPOSE. SO WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO INSTEAD SUPPORT
HEALTH FOR ALL COALITION REQUEST
TO USE A SMALL PORTION OF THESE
FUNDS TO OPEN COVERED CALIFORNIA
TO CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED AND EARN TOO MUCH
TO QUALIFY FOR MEDI-CAL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING.
CHLOE STECK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER. I WANT
TO ECHO ALL OF THE COMMENTS MADE
BY MY COLLEAGUE AT HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA, ULTIMATELY, WE WANT
TO URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROTECT FUNDING THAT WILL, IN
TURN PROTECT THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES IN OUR STATE. WE IN
THIS ROOM ARE THEIR VOICES,
PRESERVING THE FUNDING WILL BE
CRUCIAL
AND DIGNITY OF EVERY CALIFORNIAN
, REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. THANK YOU. I'M SORRY.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS KATHY MOSSBERG
, ON BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE, WANT TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES REGARDING OUR
EXPRESSING OUR OPPOSITION TO THE
FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH CUTS, AND
ALSO APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
ON THE CANCER REGISTRY. WE
REALLY DO WANT TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS HERE. I THINK
WITHOUT MINIMAL FUNDING, WE'RE
WE'RE ARE AT RISK OF LOSING OUR
FEDERAL DOLLARS. AND SO WE
REALLY HOPE TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE, AS WE'VE DONE FOR
THE LAST DECADE, TO MINIMALLY
FUND THE CALIFORNIA REGISTRY. SO
WE DON'T LOSE THOSE FUNDS. AND
WE WOULD SAY REJECT THE
POSITIONS UNLESS WE DO GET THAT
MINIMAL FUNDING. I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING, ADRIAN SHELTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES. WE CONTINUE TO
BE CONCERNED WITH THE WALKING
BACK OF INVESTMENTS ON
CHILDREN'S BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
THE INFRASTRUCTURE, SPECIFICALLY
THAT'S NEEDED TO SUPPORT THESE
PROGRAMS. OUR WORKFORCE. SO
WE'RE OPPOSED TO THE PROPOSED
CUTS UNDER OUR DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND
INFORMATION FOR THE HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE INITIATIVES. AS WAS
STATED, WE NEED MORE WORKERS,
NOT LESS. WE HAVE A CRISIS OF
CARE IN OUR STATE. WE DO NOT
HAVE ENOUGH PROVIDERS NOW, AND
WE HAVE CAL-AIM. WE HAVE
PROPOSITION ONE, AS WAS STATED.
SO WE URGE YOU TO REJECT THOSE
CUTS. AND WE ALSO CONTINUE TO BE
OPPOSED TO THE PROPOSED
ELIMINATION OF THE $15 MILLION
PROGRAM AT DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH FOR YOUTH SUICIDE
REPORTING AND CRISIS RESPONSE.
THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING, MADAM
CHAIR. JULIE ONODERA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES, REPRESENTING ALL 58
COUNTIES. ALSO HERE, ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE RURAL COUNTY,
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION ON THE
PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE FUNDING
FOR THE FUTURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
DIRECTOR AND THE YOLO COUNTY
HEALTH OFFICER REGARDING THE
SERIOUS IMPACTS OF THOSE OF
THOSE CUTS ON WORKFORCE
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH, ON
BEHALF OF JEFF NEEL, ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTIES OF LAKE CONTRA
COSTA AND SAN DIEGO, ALSO URGING
YOU TO REJECT THE CUTS TO THE
FUTURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH IN LAKE
COUNTY. JUST THE PROPOSAL HAS
ALREADY HAD AN EFFECT. THEY
PULLED THE LISTING FOR AN
EPIDEMIOLOGIST. THEY'LL LOSE
FIVE OTHER POSITIONS AS WELL, IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY, THEY'LL LOSE
91 POSITIONS. 57 OF THOSE
POSITIONS ARE REPRESENTED. ASIDE
FROM ALL THE CATASTROPHIC, YOU
KNOW, RESULTING LOSSES TO
PANDEMICS, IT'S EVERYTHING FROM
THE PERSON WHOSE JOB IT IS TO DO
BRAIN REMOVAL FOR ANIMALS IN
RABIES INVESTIGATIONS IS DOING
THE BEACH WATER TESTING RIGHT
NOW. OBVIOUSLY, THE PROBLEM WITH
THE TIJUANA RIVER, AND, AND
NARCAN PROGRAM FOR THE COMMUNITY
, ALL WOULD BE AFFECTED. THANK
YOU. TARA EASTMAN WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THE
$500 MILLION IN WORKFORCE
INVESTMENTS. THANK THANKS. GOOD
EVENING. RONALD COLMAN HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PANASONIC HEALTH NETWORK KHN,
WE URGE YOU TO REJECT THE CUTS
AT HCAI TO CHAU. THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME THIS POPULATION HAS
BEEN ALLOCATED FUNDING FOR
TRAINING AND CERTIFICATION. NOW,
THIS PROMISE AND RECOGNITION OF
THEIR WORK IS AT THREAT. MOSTLY
WOMEN, MOSTLY PEOPLE OF COLOR,
MOSTLY LATINAS, WONDERING HOW
WILL ACTUALLY MEET THE STATE'S
GOALS OF GETTING 15,000 CHAU IN
PLACE BY 2028? AND SO JUST URGE
YOU TO REJECT IT ON THE INDIAN
HEALTH PROGRAM, THIS THIS
POPULATION HAS BEEN COLONIZED,
MARGINALIZED AND ISOLATED. IT'S
CONTRIBUTED TO DEEP DISPARITIES.
WE MUST HAVE THE INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAM IN PLACE MOVING FORWARD,
PUBLIC HEALTH CUTS. WE'RE VERY
DISAPPOINTED ABOUT THESE CUTS.
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO ALSO
REJECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH CUTS.
THIS IS ALSO A CUT TO LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR FOR THE
FIRST TIME EVER, WE SAW PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS LOCALLY GO
AND WORK AND BUILD BRIDGES WITH
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING. GOOD EVENING. LINDA WEI
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. CONSIDERING THE EQUITY
IMPLICATIONS, WE OPPOSE THE CUTS
TO THE INDIAN HEALTH GRANTS IN
MEDI-CAL, WHICH IS VITAL TO
ADDRESSING DISPARITIES THAT
PERSIST DUE TO A HISTORY OF
COLONIZATION AS WELL AS THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER CUTS
WITHIN HCAI, AND PUBLIC HEALTH
CUTS RELATED TO COVERED
CALIFORNIA. WE ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH HEALTH FOR ALL
COALITION TO NOT SWEEP THE FUNDS
AND INSTEAD FUND A MERE EXCHANGE
FOR UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS,
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING, RYAN SOUZA, ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO AIDS
FOUNDATION AND APLA HEALTH,
SPEAKING TO THE ADAP FUND ISSUE.
WE JUST WANT TO APPRECIATE THE
COMMITMENT AND ATTENTION TO
ADDRESSING BOTH THE FUND BALANCE
AND THE PROGRAM MODERNIZATIONS.
WE BELIEVE THAT ALL THE
MODERNIZATIONS USING THE ADAP
FUND ARE APPROPRIATE AND CAN BE
ACHIEVED WITH TYPICAL AND MINOR
STATUTORY CHANGES. AS SECOND, AS
IT RELATES TO THE TGI WELLNESS
AND EQUITY FUND, THERE WAS A
SLIGHT CLARIFICATION THERE THAT
IT'S ACTUALLY FOR PEOPLE LIVING
WITH HIV AND AIDS ON THE TGI
INDIVIDUALS. AND THEN SO ON
BEHALF OF SAN FRANCISCO AIDS
FOUNDATION, APLA HEALTH AND IN
THE EPIDEMICS COALITION, WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER TO
FINALIZE THIS ACTION. THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING. MICHELLE GIBBONS
WITH THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE, URGING YOUR REJECTION OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH CUTS PROPOSED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE.
THANK YOU FOR INCLUDING THE
EXAMPLES IN THE AGENDA. I HAVE A
TON MORE THAT I CAN SHARE AROUND
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES AND
INFECTION PREVENTION AROUND
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES GOING INTO
OUTBREAK OR COMMUNITIES WITH
OUTBREAKS AND REALLY ADDRESSING
DISPARITIES. I WILL SPARE YOU
ALL OF THE DETAILS AND JUST
WOULD ASK THAT YOU ALL REJECT
THOSE CUTS. THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING, CHAIR BETH MALINOWSKI,
SEIU CALIFORNIA, ALIGNING MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF Kò AND
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
CAN'T WAIT COALITION THAT HAVE
BEEN HERE THIS EVENING. REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL DIALOG
ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH CUTS TODAY.
I WANT TO REALLY ACKNOWLEDGE
SOME OF THE WORDS OF DOCTOR
ARAGON EARLIER. RIGHT. HE'S
REFERENCED HOW THESE FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING CUTS ARE
THE ROOTS OF OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEM. WE THINK OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AS A CORE SERVICE. WE
THINK ABOUT HOW TO ACTUALLY HELP
STAND UP. OUR WHOLE ECONOMY
KEEPS OUR SCHOOLS OPEN AND JUST
REALLY ASK THAT. WE CONSIDER
THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN THIS
BUDGET PROCESS AND THE DIFFICULT
CONVERSATIONS WE HAVE, WE HOPE
YOU CAN REJECT THIS CUT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING,
MADAM CHAIR. JONATHAN CLAY HERE
ON BEHALF OF USC KECK SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE, SCHOOL. THAT'S LATE
TONIGHT, WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE CANCER REGISTRY AND
TRYING TO FIND THAT BASE LEVEL
FUNDING, AS MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED EARLIER, WITHOUT THAT
BASE LEVEL FUNDING, WE DO
ACTUALLY RISK LOSING FEDERAL
DOLLARS. I ALSO WANT TO JUST
RAISE LIKE IF WHY ARE WE EVEN
LOOKING AT A P Y WHEN WE CAN'T
EVEN FUND THE BASE LEVEL
FUNDING? SO FOR THAT, WE URGE
THAT YOU GUYS TRY AND FIND THAT
BASE LEVEL FUNDING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I Kò KNOCK NOW.
VIRGINIA HEDRICK, I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM FOR URBAN
INDIAN HEALTH, AND WE WORK ON
BEHALF OF PROGRAMS LIKE THE
SACRAMENTO NATIVE AMERICAN
HEALTH CENTER. AND WE URGE YOU
TO SUSTAIN THE 23 MILLION FOR
THE STATE INDIAN HEALTH PROGRAM.
SNACK IS AN FQHC THAT PROVIDES
PRIMARY CARE, DENTAL, BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH, IN A MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREA OFTEN REFERRED
TO AS A HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
SHORTAGE AREA. CHAIRMAN, TO YOUR
EARLIER POINT, SNACK AND OTHER
TRIBAL HEALTH PROGRAMS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN ISSUED AWARD
LETTERS FOR THE 2425 FISCAL YEAR
, YOU'VE ALREADY HIGHLIGHTED
MANY OF THE DISPARITIES, AND I
JUST WANT TO NOTE, IN 2021, THE
LIFE EXPECTANCY FOR AMERICAN
INDIANS WAS JUST OVER JUST 65
YEARS. THAT MEANS AT MY AGE OF
NEARLY 40, MY FIVE CHILDREN
WOULD HAVE JUST OVER 20 YEARS
LEFT WITH ME. AGAIN, I URGE YOU
TO SUSTAIN THE STATE INDIAN
HEALTH PROGRAM. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. HAS ALSO GOTTEN A KI¾M
KHN CALVIN HEDRICK I AM
MOUNTAIN MAIDU AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF ORGANIZING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE HOPE PROJECT,
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE INDIAN HEALTH PROGRAM.
I'VE WORKED WITH YOUTH FOR OVER
20 OVER 20 YEARS AND WORKED IN
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES FOR OVER 25
YEARS, AND WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE IS AN ALREADY UNDER
UNDERFUNDED INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THIS MONEY
FILLED GAPS, BUT NOT ALL OF THE
GAPS. AND SO WHAT THAT MEANS
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SOME OF
THESE STATISTICS IS THAT, SOME
OF OUR, OUR STUDENTS THAT I WORK
WITH WILL NO LONGER GET THOSE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OR WON'T
GET THEM. THE, AND THEY ARE
ALREADY A COMMUNITY, YOUNG
NATIVE PEOPLE WHO ARE THE
HIGHEST, WHO HAVE THE HIGHEST
SUICIDE RATES OF ANYBODY IN THE
COUNTRY. SO I STRONGLY URGE YOU
TO PRESERVE THIS CRUCIAL
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
JOSEPH CROSS I'M A MEMBER OF THE
SEMINOLE NATION OF OKLAHOMA AND
MUSKOGEE CREEK, AND I'M A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE VOTE PROJECT.
I STRONGLY URGE THE DECISION TO
RECONSIDER ELIMINATING THE 23
MILLION IN FUNDING FROM THE
STATE INDIAN HEALTH PROGRAM. THE
FUNDING PROVIDES SO MANY VITAL
SERVICES, INCLUDING MEDICAL
CARE, BEHAVIORAL HEALTH, AND
CULTURALLY SPECIFIC PROGRAMS AT
MYSELF, MY FAMILY, AND A LARGE
MAJORITY OF AMERICAN INDIAN
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ACROSS THE
STATE POSITIVELY BENEFIT FROM.
WITH OUR POPULATION HAVING
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER LIFE
EXPECTANCY, OUR YOUTH HAVING THE
HIGHEST RATES OF SUICIDES, AND
MANY OTHER HEALTH DISPARITIES.
THIS CUT WILL LEAVE SUCH A
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON THE HEALTH
SERVICES THAT ARE AVAILABLE FOR
THE COMMUNITY, AND WILL CAUSE
THOUSANDS OF PATIENTS TO LOSE
ACCESS TO ESSENTIAL CARE THAT
WOULD NOT BE AVAILABLE IF NOT
FOR THE PROVIDED FUNDING MODEL.
THANK YOU. A YOUNG KUMIKO, ALSO
JULIETTE, MY NAME IS KUMIKO
HOSSLER. I COME FROM THE VILLAGE
OF MELDON ON THE HOOPA VALLEY
RESERVATION. CURRENTLY, I WORK
FOR THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE VOTE
PROJECT AS A YOUTH ORGANIZER.
I'M HERE TO ADDRESS THE PROPOSED
ELIMINATION OF $23 MILLION IN
FUNDING FOR STATE INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAM. THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAS PROMISED SUPPORT FOR NATIVE
AMERICANS THROUGH INITIATIVES
LIKE THE TRUTH AND HEALING
COUNCIL. HOWEVER, ELIMINATING ÁP
FUNDING BLATANTLY CONTRADICTS
THESE COMMITMENTS, TURNING
PROMISES INTO EMPTY WORDS. AS WE
CALIFORNIA INDIANS HAVE
HISTORICALLY EXPERIENCED FROM
THE STATE GOVERNMENT. AHP IS NOT
JUST A BUDGET LINE ITEM, IT IS A
LIFELINE. IT PROVIDES ESSENTIAL
MEDICAL CARE, BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES, AND CULTURALLY
SPECIFIC PROGRAMING. WITH THE
NATIVE AMERICAN YOUTH FACING
SUICIDE RATES OVER TWICE THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE, AHP'S ROLE IS
INDISPENSABLE. IT DIRECTLY
ADDRESSES THE SEVERE MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES, OFFERING
CRITICAL SUPPORT THAT SAVES
LIFE. CUTTING. THIS FUNDING IS
NOT JUST A FINANCIAL DECISION,
IT IS A DIRECT ASSAULT ON THE
HEALTH AND WELL-BEING OF
THOUSANDS OF NATIVE AMERICANS.
IT EXACERBATES EXISTING HEALTH
DISPARITIES, UNDERMINES ANY
CLAIMED COMMITMENT TO TRUTH AND
HEALING. I CHALLENGE YOU TO
UPHOLD YOUR PROMISES AND
COMMITMENTS AND REJECT THE
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
BRIANNA CLARK, AND I'M A MEMBER
OF THE HOPLAND BAND OF POMO
INDIANS. AND I'M URGING THE
REJECTION TO CUTS FOR THE INDIAN
HEALTH SERVICES, YOUTH SUICIDE
RATES ARE AT CRISIS LEVELS AND
ARE HIGHER THAN ANY OTHER
ETHNICITY WITHIN THE COUNTRY.
ELIMINATING THE FUNDING DIRECTLY
CONTRIBUTES TO BARRIERS WITHIN
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AND
PROVIDING ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH AND BEHAVIORAL SERVICES.
THE LEADING CAUSES OF DEATH
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES ARE HEART
DISEASE, CANCER AND DIABETES,
ALL OF WHICH CAN BE MAINTAINED
IF CAUGHT EARLY AND USE
PREVENTATIVE CARE. IHS PROVIDES
HEALTH CARE IN A WAY THAT IS
DIFFERENT THAN GENERAL AND
PRIVATIZED HEALTH CARE, AND
WHERE THEY OFTEN FAIL, IT
PROVIDES HEALTH CARE THAT IS
PERSONALIZED, CULTURALLY
SENSITIVE, AND ASSISTS IN
FOSTERING SELF-DETERMINATION
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES. TODAY,
QUESTIONS WERE RAISED ABOUT HOW
TO CUT FUNDING SELECTIVELY AS WE
CAN'T HAVE THE WHOLE BUCKET.
HOWEVER, FOR OUR COMMUNITIES,
CUTTING THE PREEXISTING FUNDING
FOR IHS WOULD BE EXTREMELY
DETRIMENTAL TO THE OVERALL
BASELINE OF OUR HEALTH. THANK
YOU. NICOLE WATERMAN, ON BEHALF
OF THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP,
DEEPLY DISAPPOINTED IN THE LACK
OF FUNDING FOR 0 TO 5 CONTINUOUS
MEDICAL COVERAGE, URGING FUNDING
OF THAT, BUT ALSO URGING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE DIRECT DHS TO
SUBMIT THE FEDERAL WAIVER WITH
OR WITHOUT THE FUNDING. IN
ADDITION, WE'RE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE PUBLIC HEALTH CUTS, AS IS
ORANGE COUNTY AND SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY AND THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP IS ALSO OPPOSING THE
HEALTH CARE, NAVIGATION CUTS.
THANKS. THANK YOU. I'M DOCTOR
DONALD LYMAN, WHO, REPRESENTS
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
PREVENTIVE MEDICINE, WHERE THE
DOCS WHO TRY AND KEEP PEOPLE
AWAY FROM DOCTORS AND HOSPITALS.
AND I'M WAS ALSO THE SENIOR
CIVIL SERVICE PHYSICIAN AND WHAT
IS NOW THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH FOR ABOUT 40 YEARS, WE'RE
HERE TO SUPPORT THE FUTURE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING AND
FUNDING FOR THE CANCER REGISTRY.
WHILE I WAS IN THE DEPARTMENT,
WE HAD AN ENDLESS SERIES OF
ISSUES WHICH WERE ASSIGNED TO ME
THAT HAD NO OTHER PARKING PLACE
INSIDE THE ADMINISTRATION. SO WE
HAD HAZARDOUS WASTE DUMP SITES,
WE HAD AIDS, WE HAD TOBACCO
CONTROL, WE HAD OPIATES. AND
WHEN COVID ARRIVED, THERE WAS
REALLY NO CAPACITY TO DEAL WITH
SOMETHING THAT BIG, THAT AWFUL.
I HAD RETIRED AT THAT POINT, BUT
I WATCHED THE SYSTEM BREAK. THIS
FUTURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS THE
FUNDING TO. THANK YOU, SIR.
SUPPLY THAT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR BRUCE. MADAM
CHAIR BRUCE PALMER, REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HEALTH LAB DIRECTORS,
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THESE CUTS.
THE SCIENTIFIC CAPABILITY TO
IDENTIFY AND CONTROL THE SPREAD
OF DISEASE IS MAINTAINED BY
THESE 28 PUBLIC HEALTH LABS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THE CUTS
ARE GOING TO TAKE AWAY A GREAT
DEAL OF THE ADVANTAGE OF THAT
SCIENTIFIC EXPERTISE THAT'S
EFFICIENT. AND IS SO ESSENTIAL
TO CONTROLLING THE SPREAD OF
DISEASE. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
HEARING. I THINK YOU ASKED SOME
GREAT QUESTIONS, AND WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT SOME KIND OF
RESOLUTION TO THIS ISSUE CAN BE
DEVELOPED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. HALF A DAY. MY NAME IS
GABRIELA CAJANDIG. I'M A YOUTH
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR THE NATIVE
AMERICAN HEALTH CENTER IN SAN
FRANCISCO, I DEEPLY OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION OF THE STATE INDIAN
HEALTH PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM HAS
BEEN IMPERATIVE TO THE SUPPORT
OF URBAN INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES
AND HELPING THEM THRIVE AND
FIGHT AGAINST MASSIVE HEALTH
DISPARITIES AND COLONIZATION
IMPACTS ACROSS GENERATIONS, AND
CULTIVATED LIFE SAVING
PREVENTATIVE MEASURES AGAINST
SYSTEMIC SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
DISCRIMINATIONS. NOW UPHOLDING
THE LEGAL OBLIGATIONS TO NATIVE
POPULATIONS WILL AFFECT PRESENT
AND FUTURE GENERATIONS. THIS
PROGRAM ELIMINATION WOULD BE
DEVASTATING TO NATIVE
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HELLO. MY NAME IS TERESA LOBO,
ENROLLED MEMBER OF THE PIT RIVER
TRIBE. I HAVE WORKED IN INDIAN
HEALTH CARE FOR 33 YEARS. RURAL
INDIAN HEALTH CARE. I HAVE SEEN
MANY, MANY CHANGES THROUGHOUT
THE YEARS. MADAM CHAIR, YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER ABOUT BEING
EXCITED WHEN WE GOT THE MONEY.
NOW YOU READY TO TAKE IT AWAY? I
HAVE SEEN WHERE OUR FAMILIES
HAVE TRAVELED MANY, MANY MILES
JUST TO SEE, JUST TO GET
PROVIDE, QUALITY HEALTH CARE
OUTSIDE OF OUR SERVICE AREA, I
ASKED NOT TO CUT THE INDIAN
HEALTH CARE. WE NEED FUNDING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR CLOSING US OUT.
SEEING NO OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR SEVEN HOUR
AND 25 MINUTE SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
TODAY. BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER THREE AND HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES HAS CONCLUDED.